in this video we'll be covering
everything you need to know about
digital marketing we'll do this with the
help of our instructor rob sanders so
let's start with an introduction to
digital marketing a digital marketing
course video and some of the best
digital marketing tools we'll also have
a look at what is seo an seo tutorial
seven tips and tricks for seo how to
perform keyword research how to rank
number one on google and google tag
manager greetings everyone this is rob
sanders and today we're going to talk
about what is digital marketing so
thanks for joining us here at simply
learn and let's get started let's start
talking about why digital marketing is
important so let's start there on the
why so we're just a fly on the wall and
we're in an office environment we're
looking at two friends having a
conversation about digital marketing so
really if we're listening in
everybody every marketer is using
digital marketing for his or her
business now digital marketing has
become more popular than traditional
marketing that's not a surprise
so in response hey over the past few
decades digital marketing has evolved at
a rapid pace these days a lot of people
spend most their time on the internet so
what happens in the internet every 60
seconds well a lot happens every 60
seconds so according to social media
today i mean there's a lot of snaps
there's a lot of clicks there's a lot of
text there's a lot of videos watched
there's a lot of pictures being taken
there's a lot of
voice activated activity going on a lot
of tweets emails swipes there's a lot
going on here in 60 seconds so there's a
lot of activity on the internet a lot
and so the one gentleman says hey can
you also mention a few differences
between digital and traditional
marketing systems and then the expert
responds of course i can
certainly clarify a few differences
between digital and traditional and so
he goes on to say what the differences
are between traditional and digital and
let's look at that okay so on
traditional marketing we're talking
about print radio billboard newspaper tv
anything that's not on your mobile or
laptop so we know with traditional
marketing reach is limited
with digital marketing reaches maximum
and what we mean by that is hey when you
print something you're printing it for x
amount of people if you're trying to
promote an event and you
basically create a thousand flyers okay
you figure it's going to a thousand
people maybe they'll share it so you're
looking at about 2 000 people maybe just
to be generous well digital marketing
we're promoting an event we can promote
it to a whole lot of people depending on
the platform so 2000 is nothing when
you're targeting an audience on facebook
or google search traditional marketing
non-versatile
and with digital marketing very
versatile so again going back to our
flyer printing an eight and a half by
eleven okay that's it you know with with
digital marketing running display
banners 468 by 60 200 by 200 250 by 250
300 by 300 i mean the list goes on on
the types of different display sizes not
to mention text ads not to mention video
or multimedia
so there's a lot you can do
to get your message out there okay with
traditional it's always delayed
communication okay so
meaning if you're trying to get that tv
spot there might not be a spot open
until one in the morning okay well with
digital marketing there is no hours okay
you can certainly get your point out
there and have people see it
instantaneously so with traditional
marketing there's a lack of real-time
results i mean this seems like uh it's
obvious but you know digital marketing
that's one of the biggest benefits
instant real-time results instant okay
nowadays
go to analytics you can look at
real-time reporting okay so we could see
real-time results okay traditional
marketing can be very costly i mean if
you're not only doing postcards and
printing postcards but you have to mail
those postcards so there's postage fees
where with digital marketing it's very
very very cost efficient i mean meaning
you could pick and choose who you want
to target when you want to target where
you want to target what you want to
target and if you're doing search you
can put your bidding in place you can
put your hours in place you can really
control how much you actually spend so
that to me is one of the biggest
advantages to digital marketing not only
do you get real-time results but you can
control costs and then obviously
optimize based on the amount of cost
you're spending based on those real-time
results with traditional marketing it's
difficult to reach a target audience you
know with digital marketing it's easy to
reach a target audience i mean you know
i don't want to bash traditional
marketing too much i mean if you're
gonna put a tv ad in place you know
you're gonna do it on a tv show that
tends to
gear more towards your target audience
but that doesn't guarantee anything here
we can simply go to facebook or twitter
or linkedin and just pick and choose
specifically who we want to target when
we want to target them so it just
becomes a lot easier to reach a targeted
audience on a digital marketing platform
and then with traditional marketing poor
campaign measurement with digital you
have easy to measure and optimize
campaigns and what we really mean by
that is because you get instant time
results because you can control cost
because you can reach your target
audience more easily all those a result
of okay you can measure and optimize
based on what our audience is seeing and
how much they're spending to see it we
can quickly make adjustments in order to
optimize the campaign for better
performance so that's generally that
means that's a culmination of pretty
much everything that we've listed as a
benefit for digital marketing okay so
now
why digital marketing has been answered
with all the benefits that
it carries let's talk about the what is
digital marketing so
you know that
you know you want to do digital
marketing so
how do we go about that what what is it
exactly well let's just define it
digital marketing it's just the act of
promoting a company's product or an
individual's product or service with the
help of a device or technology and so
obviously when we talk about device
we're talking about maybe a laptop we're
talking about a mobile device and when
we talk about technology it could be an
app it could be
you know a cloud-based platform okay it
could be a piece of software okay so
a lot going on on the digital side in
terms of variations and what you can do
but that's in a nutshell what digital
marketing is you're really just using
technology to promote your product or
service so we know because of the
benefits in digital marketing you can
promote your campaign on different
platforms okay so all the benefits we
mentioned about instant real-time
results cost efficiency
optimizing campaigns you could do that
on search you could do it on social via
email on mobile apps etc so that's what
we mean by with the help of digital
devices and technology well these
digital devices and technology come in
the form of search engines and emails
and mobile apps etc so
when we want to go
and promote our product or service using
a campaign we have different options so
there are different types of digital
marketing channels that we can choose
from and let's just go through that list
of digital marketing channels and the
first one is what i consider the king of
them all and that's seo so seo stands
for search engine optimization there's
search engine marketing there's email
marketing affiliate marketing social
content mobile and then we can get into
subsets of each of these digital
marketing channels but really we'll
start with seo because that's the king
and to me that's basically increasing
the quality and quantity of relevant
organic traffic
on the search engines including google
so depending on where you're located in
the u.s market google tends
has a large market share so you want
your
pages on your website to be found and
clicked on organically and so that means
that somebody types in a keyword you
want that relevant page to show up first
on google so somebody can click on that
link okay and we know that millions of
people
specifically in the us but worldwide you
search on a daily basis so if you're
ranking for those relevant keywords you
can imagine how much traffic you can get
okay so that's seo okay and here's an
example so you type in online shopping
well you can see the first listing here
is a paid search ad and we're gonna get
to that in a minute the second
organically is amazon okay so online
shopping you think maybe walmart you
think maybe
alibaba or you're thinking probably
amazon okay so no surprise amazon's
ranking for the keyword online shopping
and so if somebody clicked on their
listing that's traffic for amazon let's
move on to search engine marketing you
know known as sem or pay per click or
cost per click or ppc or cpc or
sponsored search or google ads i mean
there's a lot of different names
synonymous with sem so search engine
marketing is really just using paid ads
on search engines just as we saw the
previous example if you want to be found
for keyword you don't have to worry
about organic if you're willing to pay
for it you just bid on that keyword and
voila you have the opportunity to appear
number one in the search results at the
top of the page for that keyword now
when somebody clicks on it you have to
pay google if it's google you're
advertising on but that's the beauty of
search engine marketing you can bid on
keywords and appear at the top of the
search results for that keyword example
here if we go back to online shopping
well
myus.com
is bidding on that keyword online
shopping so they're actually appearing
above amazon's organic listing but
that's what they want to do they want to
be found for that keyword so if they're
not ranking for it organically well
they're bidding on it and if somebody
happened to click on that listing then
myus.com is going to pay google
something
depending on what the cost per click is
and so that could be anywhere from one
penny to a hundred dollars it depends
depends on the keyword depends on who
else is bidding on the keyword depends
on the location depends on the time of
day
depends on quality score there's a lot
of factors involved and regarding what
you pay however
the benefit of sem is visibility and
getting traffic to your website for
keywords you're not found for so that's
why sem such a popular choice for a lot
of companies okay let's talk about
digital marketing that's a traditional
type of digital marketing channel it's
been around a long time
you know we all send emails on a daily
basis and we probably all receive emails
on a daily basis this is an effective
way to capture leads and convert them to
customers because with email you can
personalize your emails and you could
send your emails to a segmented audience
okay so if you have emails from
females who are 35 years of age to 44
that live and say this southern part of
the united states you can segment that
and send them an email and cater that
email directly to that audience and of
course you can put some nice call to
action in there you could design it
really snazzy and you could track it
just like you can any other digital
marketing channel so email is a very
effective way to really reach a target
audience because everybody for the most
part has a functioning email account so
basically here's an example of an email
that could go out you're selling a
product and the products promotion is
about to end well you know get that
email out to your target audience let
them know hey you have until tonight to
purchase a product and if you purchase
it you're going to get 30 off and you
can put the coupon code right in there
with a nice call to action and you can
measure how many people click on that
email go to that web page and purchase
the product using that coupon code so
that's an example of email marketing
okay we have affiliate marketing so
affiliate marketing is an effective way
for digital marketers to
basically create a sales force of people
so basically what you're doing is you're
getting
merchants to promote your products and
services and you're using usually a
third-party broker like commission
junction or cg.com as an example to
introduce you the the person selling the
product the merchant with the affiliate
so that affiliate could likely be a
merchant him or himself and they can
basically be a good partner of yours by
publishing your product or service on
their website so
that they can sell in order to get
commissions so it's all based on a
commission so you basically are going to
use a third-party affiliate like cj get
all these affiliates to work for you
they're going to promote your product or
service if they do sell your product or
service you're going to pay them a
commission that's more or less how it
works with affiliate marketing and you
know with affiliate marketing to me it's
a good way to you know really promote
your product or service and you can pick
and choose the affiliates or the
publishers of whom you want to work with
so here's an example
of affiliate marketing at work okay you
basically see a banner basically you can
see earn up to 12
advertising fees with a trusted
e-commerce leader okay so if somebody
clicked on that purchase for example or
joined you could pay off that commission
okay let's turn our attention to social
media marketing so social media
marketing you know i would say it's
fairly new i mean if i think about it
we're in 2019
and i remember talking about facebook
back in 2006 so you're talking about 13
14 15 years of social media it's
definitely evolved over the years and
but the concept remains the same it
involves creating different types of
content depending on the platform okay
so you could be on pinterest or
instagram and be dealing with photos or
you could be on twitter tweeting out
certain characters up to a limit okay so
it really depends on the social media
platform uh that really drives the type
of content you're gonna promote but we
know social media can be effective
because people use social media i mean
facebook is one of the more popular
platforms and if you want to get your
product or service out there you could
certainly pay to have an ad on facebook
or you could just post your content
organically okay that's the beauty of
social most of your social platforms
like linkedin and twitter and facebook
and pinterest and instagram they'll have
a paid form of advertising that you can
use to promote your product or service
or you can go the organic route and
you know post content organically in
hopes of driving traffic back to your
website so with social you do have two
options here but social is interesting
because a lot of different social media
platforms out there really depends on
your product or service okay so an
example of social media marketing
especially on facebook with facebook you
got mobile and desktop and you obviously
have the opportunity to post something
organically and have that liked or
commented on or shared or you could post
an app and get that liked commented or
shared or clicked and have people go
back to your website and fulfill the
goal of what you want them to do so
moving on to content marketing so
content marketing is really an effective
way of really distributing valuable
content online and when we talk about
content marketing you know we're talking
about different types of assets so it
could be simply text in the form of a
blog post or it could be a video or it
could be an an infographic or it could
be an image okay there are lots of ways
to create content these days especially
in digital marketing and the great thing
about content marketing is you're
writing content for a targeted audience
so
if you're trying a targeted audience on
say
instagram then you know who your
audience is and you know what the type
of content you're going to post on there
so it could be in the form of a video or
infographic or just a graphic and so
that's the beauty of content marketing
really putting yourself out there
and
depending on the platform putting
yourself out there with various types of
content so for example if we look at
youtube
you can see this video here about
digital marketing certified associate
well hey you don't need to always write
the content you can produce the content
in the form of a video and post it on
youtube this is a form of content
marketing so that's content marketing
and then let's talk about mobile
marketing so content marketing again
different types but if we go now to
mobile marketing you can kind of segue
from content to mobile because the only
difference here is with mobile it's
strictly on mobile phone it's not
desktop so
mobile marketing is really a strategy on
its own that helps
you the company promoting your product
or service to reach your target audience
through a mobile device and that
includes tablets and how you could do
that is via messaging you could do it
via email or you could be do it via an
app okay so you have different ways of
getting your content out there to people
okay so as an example you can use
basically sms or instant messaging via
mobile devices to promote your product
or service here's another example
of a mobile marketing via app install
and so you can even compound that by
running a say google ad as an example
and running your google ad on say just
mobile you could do a bid adjustment
just for mobile and the goal could be
app installs okay so and you can even do
a mobile or app extension so there's
lots of ways to
really promote your app or your product
or your service via mobile marketing
okay let's talk about the customer life
cycle
so we know why we want to do digital
marketing we want to know we want we
know
what the digital marketing channels are
because we just talked about them from
seo to social to affiliate to mobile to
content to sem okay you have a lot of
different digital marketing channels at
your disposal so now how do we go ahead
and approach our customers so that's
what we're going to talk about first so
we're going to talk about different
stages of the customer life cycle okay
and the first one is the awareness stage
so we need to get our customers aware of
what we're selling or what we're
promoting okay so the awareness stage is
really
what product does your brand offer
that's a question we want to get out
there and we want to answer okay what
does a customer need your product or
excuse me why does a customer need your
product that's a question we want to
answer with digital marketing okay what
solution does your product provide okay
that's an answer to a question we want
to make sure people understand so these
are questions that we want to be able to
answer in the form of digital marketing
whether that be mobile or content
okay so getting our information out
there that answers these essential
questions and if we could do that then
somebody's gonna become aware of our
product or service okay so what product
does our brand offer why does a customer
need it and what solution does it
provide okay those are some key
questions that people tend to ask
themselves when they look at a brand
okay and when they look at a product hey
do i really need this is gonna help me
in my life okay and who who is selling
this i mean who is this brand i mean
that's those are just things that run
through people's mind intuitively that
with the right messaging
the right channel the right type of
asset the right targeted audience
you can quickly make somebody aware of
your brand's product or service in this
stage it's help potential customers
discover your brand with the help of
these different marketing channels so in
the awareness stage you know content is
key so it's to me if we have a website
we need a blog because if somebody does
come to our blog from say organic search
seo then we can write about that product
or service via blog and talk to our
customer talk directly to our targeted
audience through that blog and if we're
not ranking organically we can use paid
search to promote it because paid search
on google for example basically we can
be right at the top of the search
results and so somebody can actually see
it when they do a search because we know
millions of people you search on a daily
basis you could do
social media marketing okay so you can
publish that product or service on
facebook while you're building your
community and you can use affiliate
marketing to help get the word out by
using cg.com as an example build up a
sales force of people these publishers
that are going to put your product or
service out there so to me in the
awareness stage these are the
digital marketing channels you could
focus on now i will say one thing about
display ads display is part of search
engine marketing you could use display
because you can reach a large number of
people so even though it's listed here
low priority in the awareness stage
display
ads mean that if you're on google's
display number you could pick and choose
your sites your demographics keywords
topics an audience you could focus on
all those different demographics to
really attract a large number of people
so low priority but it's probably also
good to focus on in the awareness stage
okay so content marketing you must
create a high quality content that
people are searching for without content
it's hard to get found
and so to me this is you know where the
blog comes in seo take that content get
it optimized okay sem if we're not
ranking organically we can make sure
we're at the top of the paid search
results or the the search results for a
particular keyword we want to be found
for and then social media marketing
using different channels depending on
the channel if we're selling you know
training like simply learn does you know
linkedin is a good platform for us okay
and then affiliate
you know basically building up a nice
network of publishers to get the word
out so these are all good channels that
we can focus in on so traffic sources
may include paid unpaid social referral
display email or direct so they they
could come in the awareness stage from
all different types of channels even
though you're focused on content i mean
you could still get traffic from mobile
or email so now that we got the word out
via all these different marketing
channels there's that consideration
stage so
you know people are aware of us now
they're considering us and that's kind
of the next stage in the process okay so
a few essential questions to address on
the consideration stage hey what
features make your product valuable to
others and how will i increase customer
engagement towards my product so those
are answers to questions you want to ask
okay what features make your product
valuable you want to basically separate
yourself from the competition basically
that's what you're trying to answer okay
so if you're promoting your product or
service on paid search and other people
are bidding on the same keyword how are
you going to stand out and then how will
i increase customer engagement towards
my product so for example if you're on
facebook okay and you're trying to get
people over to your site to purchase
your product then how are you going to
improve that engagement you got to
create something really snazzy or really
it's going to be attention grabbing or
something that's going to get them to
become aware of it that's going to
separate your post from all the other
posts that are in somebody's facebook
news feed okay so you really have to
work hard to really convince somebody to
get their consideration towards your
product or service so in this stage your
customer considers your product so help
them understand how your product is
valuable okay to me email works really
good here because if you have a targeted
audience this gives you the opportunity
to really answer these questions in that
particular channel email you can support
that with a promotion and display i
think display is a good option here too
because even though you know people are
trying to become aware
you know you can really hone in
and really
get them to take that next step okay
with display you can even do remarketing
so if somebody's been to your site
because they're aware of your product
they're curious you can cookie them and
remarket to them via display so display
to me is a good a good channel to use
here okay so you have email mobile
display you know sem these are all you
know good channels to use on the
consideration stage especially on search
because somebody's looking for something
and they're aware of your brand then you
have the good opportunity to get them to
click on your ad especially if you're
offering a promotion and get them to
convert the goal here is to increase our
engagement so
people are aware we're moving them
further along the funnel with email
marketing we have the opportunity to
promote the product by sending an email
directly to our audience so with this
stage plan your campaigns around
welcoming emails newsletters we can talk
about product descriptions add ratings
and reviews in the email you know we
really just want to encourage people to
purchase the product that's we're trying
to sway them over so email is a good
source to allow us to do that because
with mobile marketing we can promote the
products by sending relevant messages to
our target audience display again
retargeting because we can retarget an
audience that has been to our website
already did some research about our
brand our product or service and now
we're going to reach back out to them to
sway them so remember we want to
encourage customers to buy a product by
creating detailed articles about the
product that always helps and that's
content okay we want to opt for a
customer testimonial okay that helps
sway people and add some guest blogging
okay we can have ambassadors blog on our
behalf or we can go out and blog on
somebody else's
site okay so blogging works both ways
it's ways of of showing yourself and
telling people hey
we know you're looking for this product
here's why you want to choose us okay
moving on from the consideration to the
purchase stage so they're aware of you
they're considering you
and now we're on to the purchase stage
so the questions we want to really make
sure we address here are how are my
prices compared to my competitors and is
my brand more credible than others okay
so they're considering you but
that price point and it may not even be
the price it could be the shipping for
example the price could be good but the
shipping cost could be high so you
really want to do some due diligence and
research on what your competitors are
doing credibility that goes back to the
consideration stage and testimonials you
want to make sure you have reviews and
testimonials to really elevate what
you're trying to tell customers and that
that is hey i have a good brand i have a
good product i have a good service come
buy my stuff come buy my product and
service but you really need to support
that claim you just can't go out and say
it and so supporting that comes in the
form of what other people say and that
could be reviews that could be comments
on a social media platform it could be
you know stars on say yelp or google my
business you know make sure you do your
due diligence and make sure
you get people to you know review you or
provide testimonials because people are
going to do their due diligence before
they purchase especially if it's on
google my business or yelp or
tripadvisor or whatever it is you're
trying to sell they're going to be able
to see those reviews and so do your due
diligence to get the reviews and if it
is a negative review hey that's okay you
can't please everyone you're gonna get
them that's the world we live in just
make sure you show your upper hand and
respond even to the negative as well as
the positive reviews that you get that
actually bodes well to some people
because hey it shows that i made a
mistake and you're willing to correct it
and so people actually see that that
could be the tipping point to getting
them to purchase hey look hey this brand
really cares because they're really
responding to people they're not
ignoring negativity okay just those
small things that can get people to
change their mind now with the purchase
stage according to e-consultancy 83 of
the online audience require
encouragement to complete a purchase
encouragement what does that mean well
it could mean providing a promo giving
them that extra incentive you know if
you don't offer promo consider it
especially on the email and the example
we looked at earlier sending in an email
means that if the promo is going to end
at midnight send that email out and tell
people they have until midnight and if
they purchase today you'll even increase
it to 20
and email is a good channel for that
mobile can reach a lot of people through
sms okay social media reaching people
instantaneously
and then you know really with the
purchase stage it gives prop prospects
an offer to help them make that purchase
so you have plenty of channels to choose
from in fact most of these channels the
only one really that doesn't fit the
instantaneous mode is seo but you can
really focus on affiliate even though
that's a low priority here you can
really you know coordinate with your
publishers who especially those
publishers that have proven their worth
and have sold your products in the past
you get them to help promote it and
incentivize their audience so let's move
on from the purchase to the purse post
purchase stage so this is after somebody
purchases
okay so some essential questions we want
to be able to address here so what
additional product could my customer buy
now that they're my customer what else
could i sell them what you know without
being too pushy could if they buy a coat
well a hat work or a pair of gloves or
you know blouse you know you want to be
able to not push a product on your
customer but think about how you can
complement that purchases that
purchasers or customers product and then
how to improve the customer buying
experience
so again this goes back to you know what
we just said about reviews get somebody
to offer a review and if they don't give
you
a full compliment of five stars they
only give you three and a half stars
then you know what that's great feedback
because then you can learn from that and
then the other question is will the
customer refers to others and if so why
so that's
definitely something you want to be able
to address in the post purchase stage so
let's take a look here so with post
purchasing stage you know to me emails
at the top of this list because if
somebody purchases something you can
send a nice thank you email because if
they purchase they're giving you their
email in return because you're likely
going to be sending them the receipt via
email so email to me is a nice
channel you send in a nice message even
you know social media you know you can
thank your community for supporting you
on this recent campaign that you ran you
know even throwing an extra five or ten
percent on a future purchase is a thank
you and that's easily done on social
media
you know you could even post a blog you
know promoting you know the success of a
product and then offering a promotion
okay so there's a lot of things you
could be doing here on the post
purchasing stage so to me even looking
at content again you could even you know
put a survey together you could even put
a survey together for your affiliates
okay you could even post a poll on
facebook so it's just working in with
these different channels to get some
feedback about your product and service
so with email mobile you can engage
customers with follow-up emails or
customer care content you know with
mobile if you have somebody's mobile
number hey text them a simple thank you
goes a long way you know you could say
hey look if you're satisfied let us know
give us a call you can even in the ee
mobile text message you can put a link
to a survey send emails to active
subscribers give rewards for customer
feedback so if somebody does provide
feedback give them an extra 10 off you
know you want to be able to reward
loyalty loyalty comes in the form of a
partnership if you're giving somebody
discounts and you have a good product or
service then they're going to recognize
that they're going to say hey look i
really like this product and they're
giving me 10 i'm going to go ahead and
purchase from these guys again so give
those discounts to those active
customers or on the affiliate network
give referral opportunities to your
customers so
if it's an affiliate publisher hey if
they're getting people to your site you
know reward them or if it's an email and
you put a four to a friend get an extra
10 off it doesn't hurt because you're
incentivizing people to help you sell
your product so with social display and
content use those banner ads or
use that content that you display on
social or the blog you're going to write
to give customers advice in order to
maximize the value of the purchase so
again you can use these platforms to
also enhance
what they purchased so hey you just
purchased this product thank you very
much did you know you could do this this
and this with it and so that's the idea
of a post-purchase stage is to maximize
these channels to be able to answer
those essential questions about what
else could they purchase you know do
they like how do i get these people to
become loyal customers okay so with the
first purchase stage if a customer has
bought a pair of sports shoes for
example running shoes you can recommend
cross product sale or cross sale it
could be a pair of shorts or a water
bottle or an accessory with an exclusive
discount so that's another example what
you can do on the post purchase stage so
in today's world everywhere you go it's
all about digital so today this lecture
is going to be about all the different
marketing channels available piece them
together kind of put together a little
digital marketing course for you so
first off before we get started we're
going to talk about what is digital
marketing and really digital marketing
covers a lot of areas it's very broad
and really what it refers to just
marketing
that
a company does a person does an
individual a group an organization
and they do it in the form of an
electronic device or with the aid of the
internet that's really what digital
marketing is it's just having something
digitally not something tangible like a
billboard or newspaper or tv and with
that there are lots of places where you
can apply digital marketing and so
electronic devices we think of mobile
devices and so you could certainly use
mobile as a form of digital marketing or
to help you with your marketing efforts
digitally okay you can create apps you
can run advertising on mobile you can
communicate with different people your
target audience
via different devices like whatsapp and
messaging okay uh there's also search
engines search engines is where a lot of
people get their information from at
least start to do their research to get
information you got social media lots of
different social media platforms all the
way from you know tweeting to blogging
to
a social sharing to social content okay
so a lot of of platforms under the
bucket social media you also have
traditional forms of digital marketing
like email you can use different email
platforms to send out emails so
lots of different ways to communicate
your product your service your message
to a large number of people that are
really targeted to your efforts how is
digital marketing useful well we know
provides different metrics why do we
know it provides different metrics
because it's all digital okay so anytime
you send out an email or post something
on facebook you're going to get data
back when you get data back you could
take that data to determine how well
that posed or that email performed and
if it didn't perform up to expectation
you can make changes to improve
performance that's called optimization
okay so that's the great thing about
digital marketing it's useful in that we
get data in some cases instantaneously
and we're able to make changes in order
to optimize that campaign we can also
you know provide personalized user
experience so meaning if we know who our
target audience is on say twitter or
linkedin or facebook we can really cater
our messaging to that group probably
most importantly is that digital
marketing compared to traditional forms
of marketing allow us to really reach a
global audience very easily very easily
at a very low cost that's the key so if
i want to target people in india or or
nepal or pakistan i can certainly do
that and i can do that with the snap of
a campaign and i get data back and based
on the data i can tailor that experience
even better really just allows us to
really hone in on a particular audience
anywhere in the world very quickly so
these are just three of the main reasons
why digital marketing is useful some
other experiences or uses for digital
marketing again it provides a
cost-effective alternative to
traditional marketing so you know for
those that are familiar with purchasing
advertising on say tv or radio you have
to pick a spot you have to pick a
program and then pick a time slot
associated with that program so
somebody's watching a program and and
that program tends to draw on a specific
target audience then you want to show
your ad around the time when that
program is slotted to air on tv uh
because you know you're likely going to
reach your audience however to purchase
that time slot could be competitive and
could be very costly where there are
forms of of advertising and paying for
advertising digitally and those forms
are cost per click or cost per
impression and so using a cost per click
or cost compression model allows you to
really go head to head in kind of an
auction style format where
you can control how much you pay and
potentially get that prime spot in front
of your target audience so it really
does become cost effective and it allows
you to make small investments to get a
really substantial return on roi so
let's just say your cost per click is
only 10 cents but you're selling a
product for 10
well all you need is one click and one
sale to generate a very substantial
return on investment and so knowing that
you get metrics back on a campaign you
could slowly or quickly optimize that
campaign towards a very positive roi
then another use for digital marketing
just enables targeting users based on
their actions and preferences so again
we can really hone in on who we want to
target it really depends on the platform
but if you take google ads for example
and you want to target the display
network well we know we have
demographics we know we have topics we
know we have interest we know we have
retarget audiences in segment audiences
we have age we have gender so you have a
lot of options available to choose from
to really hone in
on who you want to target and we talk
about remarketing is another form of
digital marketing so you can set up a
marketing campaign so if somebody comes
to your website and does not purchase
the product or service that you're
offering you could take action on that
behavior so i can re-target a group of
people who didn't purchase that's
retargeting or you could do it via
remarketing and
basically that's the beauty of digital
marketing allows you to really target
users based on their actions some other
uses for digital marketing it helps
build brand awareness and reputation of
your business so we say brand awareness
if you're just launching a company and
nobody knows who you are if we use
google ads as our preferred method of
digital marketing and establishing
campaigns we can choose that display
network that display network on google
ads reaches a large amount of people so
you can really get your name out there
and really target your attended audience
and allow that targeted intended
audience to really understand who you
are because they're going to see your ad
in the form of a banner or in the form
of a video or in the form of text and so
that's the beauty of digital marketing
you can really reach a lot of people and
a lot of people who might be interested
in your product or service and then
digital marketing provides a platform
for you to be interactive with your
audience helping you stay relevant and
competitive and the best example i can
give here is youtube and so youtube's a
really it's a search engine for videos
but it's a video sharing platform and so
if i upload a video
then i can entice people to comment on
that video or like the video or share
the video and i can really interact with
that audience by responding to their
comments
or
you know putting together a playlist or
giving them more videos okay so i can
really interact with my audience and i
could do that on multiple platforms not
just youtube and video i can blog
and and interact based on somebody's
comments i can have a website and have
live chat and interact with my audience
so there's lots of different ways to
interact with an audience and that's
what digital marketing provides so i
already mentioned a few examples based
on the uses of digital marketing i
mentioned google's display network i
mentioned youtube and blogging and
social media platforms like facebook
well there are lots of different types
of digital marketing channels out there
and we're going to talk about a few of
them today we're going to start with
search engine optimization and so search
engine optimization
as you probably know from the name
involves search engine and it involves
really making your site relevant in the
eyes of that search engine so if you're
in the united states you know that
google has a large market share meaning
a lot of people use google on a daily
basis so we want to make sure we do
everything we can to optimize our site
in order to make our site relevant for
those coveted keywords now why do we
want to make ourselves relevant for
those coveted keywords that we want to
be found for on search well because a
lot of people use search and when a lot
of people you search and you're found
for those keyword queries then it's
going to increase the flow of organic
traffic to your website so the higher
you rank in theory the more traffic
you're going to get and so when we
talked about optimization okay how do we
optimize our site in order to be
relevant in the eyes of google well it
really comes down to a two-pronged
approach you have on-page seo you have
off-page seo on-page has everything to
do with your website in order to make it
relevant off-page has everything to do
with your website but not on your
website it means that how can we become
relevant by linking to other websites
for example how can we become relevant
by getting our content on other
platforms so we become relevant in the
eyes of google so that's off page seo so
seo is always going to be two prong what
you do on your website and what you do
off the website to make sure your
website your domain whatever that domain
is dot com or dot org is relevant in the
eyes of google and so let's take a look
at on-page seo first so like i mentioned
it involves optimizing your website and
when we say optimizing your website
there's a lot of things you can do on
your website to make it relevant in the
eyes of google and we can look at the
content okay we can look at the source
code and so there are a lot of different
components to be looked at here so you
have the header tag you have the meta
description you have the alt tag you
have how fast your page loads you have
internal linking you have a site map you
have a lots of different things going on
here and so for me
one of the first things you should do
when you create a page on your website
is to make sure the title tag is unique
and includes those key words so if we
look here at this example the title tag
is important because that's what shows
up in search results here you can see
the title tag on google is up to 65
characters so you always want to include
that keyword in the title tag then you
have your url and then you have what you
call a meta description so that's
underneath the url underneath the title
tag and again this is in search results
so organic search results somebody types
in a keyword you want to be found and
you want your title tag to stick out and
you want your meta description to
specifically describe what it is you're
offering okay so again if somebody's
looking for stock imagery then you want
to make sure that you know that person
who's looking for stock imagery can come
to your website and they can in this
case search for millions of royalty free
stock images photos videos and music and
so you want your description to really
get that person to click on your listing
an organic search that's the whole point
so that's the point of a title tag and a
meta description is you really want to
be found for what somebody's searching
for and you want to be able to show them
that you have what they're looking for
you have something here underneath your
organic search results called site links
and site links are just other are links
to pages on your website and so
unfortunately this is not necessarily in
your control this is in the control of
google so if google wants to offer up
site links underneath your title tag
meta description they will add them and
it's based really on the amount of
content you have and that goes with site
search so you can see also their site
search there underneath the meta
description all of that is contingent
upon your website do you have a lot of
content and if you have a lot of
relevant content then google will
naturally add in site links underneath
your organic listing to links to other
pages on your site so that's on page seo
and now we're going to look at off-page
seo okay so off-page seo involves using
promotional methods beyond just
optimizing your site for example
optimizing your title tag meta
description might not be enough to get
you to rank for that coveted keyword
query so we need to do
some link building we need to get our
name out there on other websites okay so
we need to be able to establish some
external links or backlinks from high
quality relevant sites to our site and
it may not just necessarily have to be a
link because google recognizes linkless
backlinks so just having a reference on
a high quality site may be good enough
to get you in the eyes of google to
become more relevant okay so that's
off-page seo in definition so really
what we want to do is we want to
establish a way to get links from other
websites to our own or references on
other websites to our website we want to
build those links to help us gain in
ranking so there's lots of ways to do
that you have social media again you
have social content sites like reddit
medium quora you have blogging okay
there's lots of ways to establish
yourself out there on the internet you
just need to make sure they're quality
sites and you need to make sure they're
relevant and so when you do get a link
on an external site pointing back to
yours you want to make sure it's a
follow so you want to make sure that
google knows to follow that link from
that site to yours so if you're out
there establishing content on a
third-party website or another website
and they're gonna link back to you just
make sure that it's a follow do follow
not a nofollow okay and i'm gonna show
you an example of what that looks like
here so if you're not sure what the
difference is here i'm on backlinko.com
and
really a no-follow versus they do follow
is simply in the href so
in the href if you don't have anything
in there other than the link then
the search engines are going to follow
that link from that external site to
yours and
if you have a no follow in that link
then the search engines are going to
ignore the link so you're not going to
pick up the backlink or external link to
your site and that's simply that site
just adding the rel equals nofollow okay
so if you see that in the link pointing
to your site from that external site
then that means you're not going to get
credit for that backlink so you always
want to shoot for
a do follow link because that means
you're going to get credit for the
backlink okay so again do follow links
allow searching engine crawlers to
follow the link and if they can follow
it you're going to get what they call
link juice and that's going to establish
some reputation to your domain a no
follow link basically doesn't allow the
search engines to follow that link so
it doesn't pass on the link juice now
again search engines like google are
smart enough to pick up the association
between
a website that talks about your website
and your website so meaning if you don't
have a link and you don't have a if you
have a nofollow link on that site don't
fret because you know google has come a
long way they're not necessarily focused
on links though it does help so for
example if you are on a very prominent
site and there's no link then you still
may get credit because google does
recognize linkless backlinks and that's
what they call a linkless backlink it's
just having a reference on that site but
you always want to try and get that
follow not the do not follow okay so
here you can see an example of off-page
seo okay like tripadvisor
would be a good example a link that
redirects from tripadvisor to
you know the oprah magazine as an
example so the oprah magazine is going
to get a
back link from tripadvisor to the site
so if google crawls tripadvisor then
they're going to be able to see this
link and if it's a follow link they're
going to give the oprah magazine that
domain credit from tripadvisor so for
seo because there's a two-pronged
approach involved you have on-page and
off-page and a lot of tools here a lot
of tools so let's take a look at some of
these tools we're gonna look at google
keyword planner we're going to look at
moz ahrefs we'll get some tools that
will help you with both on-page and
off-page seo so let's start with
google's keyword planner so why are we
using google's keyword planner because
we want to find keywords okay so we
can't do on-page seo we can't optimize
our title tag and meta description
without a good keyword that we want to
be found for so what we want to do is we
want to go into google ads now that's a
pay-per-click platform okay so if you
want to be found via paid search you're
going to use google ads but from an
organic search perspective we can use
google's keyword planner so we need a
google ads account we have a google ads
account then all we need to do is go to
tools then we need to go to keyword
planner and the keyword planner is a
good tool because it allows us to find
those coveted keywords so we can
discover new keywords and that's exactly
what we're going to do so for example
we're going to find you know use the
keyword mail delivery if we have a
business that delivers mails to people
what keywords do we want to optimize for
so we're going to be in google ads we're
going to go to tools we're going to go
to keyword planner we're going to
discover new keywords and we're simply
just going to type in a keyword so we're
going to click get results and google's
keyword planner is basically going to
give us some information so the keyword
we chose was mail delivery and they're
telling us that on average over the last
12 months there's 22
200 search queries on average over the
last 12 months okay so i could see if i
click hover over the graph here i'm
going to be able to see
the average over 12 months okay so here
i can see the average over 12 months
from july to june 2019 so here what do i
want to do i want to look for trends
because here i can see the averages go
up and down a little bit but 22 200 is
the average over 12 months and then
google's keyword planner also tells me
how competitive that keyword is so
if it's highly competitive but it's got
a lot of search volume it could be a
keyword i may want to covet but the
beauty of the keyword planner is that
they also give you other keywords to
look at okay so mail delivery service
that's 49 500. okay so here you got some
other ones best food delivery service 9
900. again some of these are very
competitive but some of them aren't and
so you want to be able to
do your due diligence do some analysis
and figure out
what keywords work best for you that
aren't going to be competitive but at
the same time
give you some search volume so if you do
rank for that keyword you should expect
x amount of clicks on that keyword based
on the volume so that's google's keyword
planner alternatively you can use a tool
like moz.com so if i log into moz they
have a tool called keyword explorer and
so here i can just type in that same
keyword mail delivery
targeting the united states in english
and moz is going to give me some
information on the keyword so here
they're going to give me a range in
terms of the monthly volume and they're
going to give me a difficulty score so
they're going to tell me how difficult
this keyword is so out of a score of 100
it's 53 and they're going to tell me
what my expected click-through rate
could be if i'm ranking for that keyword
more importantly they're going to
give me some other keyword suggestions
just like google's keyword planner so
here i can see prepared mail delivery
mail delivery service mail delivery
companies so there are a lot of
different suggestions of keywords that i
can choose from and if we scroll down we
could see
basically some mentions we could see the
analysis who's ranking for these
keywords so we can really get some
insight as to who's ranking how much
volume how difficult it is what my
estimates could be if i'm ranking et
cetera so a lot of information built
into moz's keyword explorer tool so
moz's keyword explorer tool could be a
good option for you if you don't have
access to google ads and google's
keyword planner so if you're working on
seo for a website and you curious is
about what the off-page seo situation
looks like well you can use a tool like
age reps it's a free tool you can go
here if you're working on a specific
domain and you're focused on off page
you can simply type in that domain here
and then you can check the back links
for that domain okay so i'm gonna go
ahead and type in my my domain and now
i'm gonna get a sense of what my
backlink profile is for my domain so
here i can see the number of backlinks
the total backlinks and notice 85
percent of them are do follow links so
google is able to recognize those links
and then i could see
referring domains so i have a 124
different domains pointing to my website
and so here i can get a snapshot of the
top 100 backlinks pointing to my website
and so this just gives me a snapshot of
what's going on with my off-page seo
performance again it's a free tool it's
good to use because it gives you an idea
of what your off-page seo situation
looks like okay another tool you could
use is pingdom okay you can set up a
free trial here it's good for 14 days
and it allows you to
you know look at page speed it allows
you to monitor the site itself in terms
of you know visitors maintenance etc so
you can use pingdom as well uh however
it's only a 14 day free trial but it
does give you some good insights into
seo now page load time is one of those
on-page seo factors and so if you're
doing on-page seo for domain you
certainly want to go into google
analytics and you want to measure the
page load performance of the pages on
your website and so here if i go to
google analytics and then i go to
behavior and i go to site speed and i go
to speed suggestions here i can see the
pages how many pages i've received over
a period of time and the average page
load time now if you see the average
page load time is slow
and in my opinion anything over two to
three seconds is going to be slow
you need to be able to
take action and so the great thing about
google analytics the page load time
reporting is it actually gives you some
suggestions so page speed suggestions so
all you need to do is click on the link
here in this case this particular link
or url on my website has seven
suggestions if i click on that then page
speed insights is gonna open up and
what's gonna happen is google analytics
slash page speed insights is going to
analyze this page and give me some
feedback on how the page is performing
not only on desktop but on mobile as
well and so here i can see if i analyze
this page i can see
some of the opportunities to improve the
page load time on desktop and again on
mobile here so here you can see a lot of
the opportunities and a lot of the
issues i have that i can address now if
you're going to manage seo for a website
then you're going to need an seo
platform so again moz is a good example
because we showed you the keyword
explorer but they also have many other
tools available built right into the
platform for example rankings okay you
can get crawl information so when the
bots crawl aside what kind of errors are
coming up here i can get some page
optimization so i can choose a keyword
and
i can choose a page and moz is going to
be able to give me feedback to see what
more i could do to improve my on-page
seo performance okay we mentioned
keyword explorer in terms of looking for
keywords okay you also have something
called link explorer as well so if i go
back and choose link explorer from my
list here then i'm going to go to a link
explorer and i could type in any domain
again just like on the hrefs except mods
goes a little bit deeper here okay so
they're telling me how many linking
domains and what my keywords are ranking
okay and then i have some other reports
that i can leverage for off-page seo i
can look at spam scores for certain
websites that are linking to me because
you can disavow yourself from us being
associated with those sites here you got
a link intersect tool so you can compare
one domain against another
to what links are pointing to that other
website so a lot of different
reports and tools available to you for
off-page seo under moz's link explorer
so moz has a lot of different tools
available and again my recommendation if
you don't use moz there's sem rush
there's bright edge there's a lot of seo
platforms out there to use but if you're
gonna focus on seo you are going to need
an seo platform now if you have any more
questions on seo you feel free to go to
simply learns youtube account you'll be
able to find a video there for seo
tutorial for beginners you know take a
look at the video it goes really in
depth about everything we just covered
about on-page and off-page seo so take a
look at the video
and if you have any comments about
everything we covered with seo feel free
to comment underneath this video here
and we'll be sure to respond accordingly
especially if you have any tips and
tricks that you do for seo so let's move
from search engine optimization to
content marketing and so content
marketing is a form of marketing that
involves
simulating interest in a brand's
products or services by creating and
sharing online material so we talk about
online material that can come in many
forms or assets so some examples are
blogs videos
infographics case studies white papers
ebooks all of this is content generated
it's just in different forms and so you
want to be able to take any one of these
forms of content and be able to
distribute that in some form or fashion
okay so for example blog can be part of
your
website a video could be something you
upload to youtube an infographic could
be something you actually share on
linkedin so all these other assets could
be integrated throughout they could be
shared or used on your website okay for
people to grab and share and use and
comment on okay so that's what content
marketing is you need to be able to
push out content so that people have a
better understanding of your product or
service the process of content marketing
is you really want to decide what goal
you want to achieve with your content
marketing campaign you want to define
your buyer personas to determine the
audience best suited for your content
okay so what are you creating who is it
for and then you want to run content on
it to determine the best type of content
that can be used and when we talk about
content audits we're talking about you
know content that's already been posted
are people sharing it are people
downloading or people viewing it and so
you want to be able to understand over
time what people are reacting to so that
you can reuse or continue to use that
content that seems to resonate with your
target audience so you want to choose an
appropriate content management system so
if it's a blog you want to use wordpress
maybe so you want to start brainstorming
for ideas for new content ideas so in my
opinion maybe put together a content
calendar and jot some ideas on that
content calendar then you want to settle
on a particular type of content you want
to create and then you want to be able
to publish and manage your content so
some top popular tools used for content
marketing you have buffer you have
buzzsumo followerwonk hootsuite so let's
go ahead and take a look at an example
of a content marketing management system
and
we're going to use wordpress and so if
we go into wordpress here on the back
end we're logging a login and so the
reason why we use wordpress is because
we can post blogs so in wordpress if i
go to post here i'm going to be able to
see all the different posts that have
been posted over a period of time and
the great thing about wordpress is you
can optimize it for seo so if i go in
here and look at this recent blog post
that has been posted i can go ahead and
edit it and when i edit it okay i'm
going to be able to look at this blog
post in a visual format and i can also
look at it in html form so notice i the
great thing about wordpress is i can use
imagery i can insert videos i can insert
infographics
i can attach a white paper case study to
it and then again we have something
called yoast seo plug-in so we've
installed a plug-in here so that'll help
us
with optimizing that particular blog
post for that particular keyword we're
trying to target and so here you can see
our focus keyword is remarketing and
retargeting okay so we have that in the
title tag okay we also want to make sure
it's in the meta description and so here
we have an internal link we have it in
the introduction okay we have it you
know spread throughout the content so
yoast does a good job of allowing us to
make sure we're integrating that keyword
into our blog post but the key to blog
posting is we want to again follow the
process we want to be able to choose
content for our intended audience
in this case with a blog post we can
write up to
you know 500 to 3 000 keywords and the
whole point is we're trying to introduce
our audience to a particular topic that
resonates with our product or service
and so that's the great thing about
blogging that's the great thing about
wordpress is that you know very easy to
use
you can integrate it with seo
you obviously have commenting you have
different plugins that you can add in
there uh very easy to edit and so a lot
you can do here with wordpress and
blogging so another example of content
marketing is video
so with video you have the ability to
upload this video to
popular video sites like youtube or
video and you can optimize that
particular video with title tags and and
hashtags and descriptions and you can
see the interaction here so you can see
how many views how many likes shares the
ability to share the ability people for
saving it and there's just a lot of
interactivity when you have video you
can also use video as i mentioned on
your blogging platform if it's wordpress
you can also use video and social media
platforms like twitter linkedin and
facebook so video is a very popular form
of content marketing lots of good video
tools out there to create a video a high
quality video is what you want to put
your product and service in the best
forefront okay so that people can react
they can share they can comment they can
follow they can like okay so that's what
you want to do is think about video
because video is very versatile and
powerful in terms of getting your
message out there so let's move from
content marketing to social media
marketing and
social media marketing really involves
creating content if it's that blog if
it's that video that you created for
content marketing and really using
different platforms to increase your
visibility whether that be traffic
whether it be engagement whether it be
brand awareness or any other marketing
goals that you have that's what social
media is good for because social media
will take that content take what you're
trying to get out there and really allow
you to hone your marketing goals against
that okay so if it's facebook and you
got some videos that you want to post up
there okay what's your goal is your goal
to then post the video to get traffic to
your website or to build brand awareness
or to just get people to react by
sharing or liking and so that's what
social media is good for it's really
good for taking content and really
distributing it to your target audience
okay so
uh sharing content allows you to you
know generate user generated content or
it allows you to create interactive
content and again you can use
infographics or you can apply content
with imagery or post videos or do things
that are interactive like polling and
contest so a lot of flexibility in terms
of the content that you could share on
social media and so you want to
establish a process for social media
marketing so this is the digital
marketing course of it so you want to be
able to have a process and you want to
be able to set up goals that you want to
achieve with your social media campaign
because just posting content for content
sake is really not going to generate
anything for you so you want to set up
those goals ahead of time then you want
to understand what content would be best
suited for your target audience so if
our goal is to generate brand awareness
then maybe
an infographic is what we want to do
okay maybe that's the best choice of
asset for
our target audience based on the
platform with social media we also want
to research what the competition is and
find out what works for them so it's
very easy to do on social so if you
already have a competitor on facebook
you can always go to your competitors
website and you can always see
you know what they're posting and what
kind of reaction engagement they're
getting for a particular post so it
doesn't help before you go live to do
some due diligence about your
competition you can also conduct a
social media audit again what we mean by
audio just like on the content side we
want to be able to see what's worked and
what's not worked in the past and with
digital marketing recall you can get
instant metrics back so if you posted
something last year and you're thinking
about posting it again you probably want
to do an audit to see
over the past year what posts have
worked and have not worked for you then
you want to pick and choose the social
media channels or platforms and to find
a strategy for each of them because if
you have a video then the video may work
on say youtube or instagram but may not
necessarily work for linkedin and
twitter and so you want to be able to
pick and choose the asset the strategy
and align it with the appropriate
platform then you want to take
inspiration from case studies and other
famous brands so again continue to learn
i mean that's the beauty of social media
marketing most big companies
medium-sized companies even smaller
companies that have performed well are
out on social media so take a look at
some other companies that inspire you or
some other companies in your industry or
even again your competitors and see what
they're doing and what they're posting
and what kind of engagement they're
getting so you should always you know be
able to seek out what others are doing
on social and to me this is important
create a social media content calendar
and this isn't necessarily
the very end of the process this goes
back to the beginning of the process so
when you're establishing goals and
you're establishing what kind of type of
content you want to use that should all
be part of a social media content
calendar and i'm going to show you an
example of one here shortly and then
again you want to be able to
test evaluate and adjust your strategy
because again you're getting metrics and
if you post a video on facebook and it's
taking off then
meaning in terms of likes and shares you
probably want to consider maybe doing
another one that complements that so
here's a broad example of a content
calendar again it's in a spreadsheet
again by no means there's one size fits
all but just to give you an idea if
we're blogging what we want to do is we
want to pick our target audience maybe
that be country or particular
demographic and you want to come up with
some topics ahead of time here
and you want to maybe put the status up
there of you know it's just a draft or
an idea when it actually does go live
you want to turn it on live you want to
pick your date add some comments okay
create your content and you know what's
good about a content calendar is you can
also work in seo so you can assign
keywords and then you could add those
keywords to moz for ranking uh you can
create your title and meta description
then you can carry that content forward
and choose a particular social media
platform to post to so
that's the beauty of a social or excuse
me a content calendar is it allows you
to think about things up front and then
prepare the content accordingly so you
can optimize it for organic search and
post it on social media for off page seo
and for social media marketing and so
you just want to get organized ahead of
time using a spreadsheet in this case
google sheets to lay out the topics
ahead of time so you can write the
content for your intended audience that
to me is the way to go now remember
there's lots of different forms of
content that you can use with social
media marketing here we have video so
you can see this video could be posted
on youtube or linkedin or wherever and
the whole point is you want to be able
to measure engagement here you can see
this is just an image it's just a file
and this has been posted on facebook so
here we can see many likes and comments
and then shares and so you want to be
able to leverage different forms and
different assets across social media to
see actually what works and what doesn't
work and again look at what other
companies have done whether they be
competitors or not see what type of
assets they're posting and what's
working for them now when it comes to
social media marketing there are lots of
tools available okay you got buffer
hootsuite sprinkler post planner later
sprout social i mean the list of social
media marketing tools is endless and
just like seo you will need a platform
to work with so with seo we showed you
moz as the seo platform with social
we're gonna show you sprout social
because with sprout social if you have a
content calendar if you have a lot of
different assets you want to be able to
organize those assets and content across
multiple channels and the great thing
about using a social media calendar is
yes you can publish and organize your
post accordingly you also have most
social media platform tools have
listening so you can listen in on
keywords and audiences different brands
and industries and conversations that
are being had about a specific topic
okay and again most social media
platforms if not all have reporting and
so this is important because you can
actually see
you know what how your post or different
assets are performing in terms of
engagement and so to me that's important
if you're going to focus on social media
as a platform as a channel you want to
have a social media platform tool that
will help you organize your content
publish it accordingly listen in and and
get that report to help you figure out
what's engaging and what's not engaging
again so that you can
you know react to the content that
you're using and sharing so that's
sprout social as an example but you will
need a social media platform now the
other benefit to
social media is in some cases you could
actually pay to have your post out there
and so for example on facebook we could
set up a paid campaign to target our
intended audience and so with facebook
facebook owns instagram so you have the
ability to really put your content out
in front of your target audience on
facebook and instagram and so
what you need to do is go to facebook
ads manager and simply just create an
account or campaign um you want to be
able to create a campaign and by
creating a campaign that means you're
going to have to go
through a particular process here so
if we first we want to do is choose our
objective okay so you always want to
have an objective for your campaign so
is it going to be brand awareness is it
going to be to drive you know traffic is
it going to be to drive conversions so
you want to choose a goal or objective
if you're advertising really on any
platform then you want to be able to
choose your audience so who are we
trying to target so with facebook you
know you can target any specific age
gender demographic based on interest and
behavior so you can choose specific
placements and you can assign a budget
okay and then on the ad side you have
different types of ads that you can use
you can do a single image or video you
can do a carousel okay meaning you can
rotate different images as a collage or
different videos as a collage and again
you can choose exactly where you want
your ad to be shown for example desktop
or mobile news feed
facebook in-stream video
you got instagram feed you got even
messenger so you have a lot of options
available to you on where your ad or
video is going to be shown and then you
can support that with a headline
description and you can send that
traffic back to your website you can
even test call to action buttons okay so
you can append your ad with a call to
action button and so you can do a lot
here this is just facebook you can
really do a lot of specific targeting
now with facebook advertising it's a
cost per click model so anytime somebody
does click on that ad you're going to
pay but it allows you to really
get your content out there in front of
your intended audience if you're not
doing it organically meaning you're not
posting on facebook on a regular basis
or maybe you want to supplement those
organic posts then
doing this is a good way to really get
your brand out there if it's awareness
if it's to drive traffic or to convert
facebook is a good option linkedin
twitter all these social media platforms
offer that up that option up to do paid
advertising now if you want more
information about social media we have a
great video on youtube already how to
start social media marketing it really
goes into the details about organic
social and what i just covered with paid
social specifically on facebook so take
a look at that video and again if i
missed anything on the social media side
feel free to comment or add in your best
practice whether that be part of the
process or a different platform that you
use for social media okay let's switch
to our next digital marketing channel in
search engine marketing so search engine
marketing is an advertising model
that is good for driving traffic to your
site because you're paying each time
someone clicks on your advertisement now
how is that an equal trade well because
you can advertise on channels like or
search engines like google or bing or
adroll which has a
a big network that includes google you
can actually pay your way to the top of
search engine rankings and so if you're
at the top for paid search
and somebody searches something like
shoes or something to that effect your
ad can appear at the very top even above
local search even above organic search
and so the visibility is there it's a
good way for you to then get that
traffic that
that you you'll covet for certain
keywords and because you're getting
traffic or have the potential to get
traffic you're going to pay each time
somebody clicks on these ads so
you have multiple choices on the type of
asset you want to use including text
image video etc so
there's more to it than just google bing
ad role i mean you have linkedin you
have twitter you have facebooks you have
lots of different ways to advertise and
get your ad in a more prominent position
you just have to pay for it and i just
showed you that under social media
marketing facebook you can create an ad
have your ad targeting your audience and
in return you're going to pay facebook
works the same way for most of these
networks okay so when you actually set
up a campaign
like anything you do when you set up a
campaign you want to determine the goal
you want to achieve for the campaign you
want to do that up front especially when
you're talking about pain per click if
you're paying per click then you
definitely want to make sure you
determine what your goals are so you can
measure them accordingly then you want
to choose in this case a relevant list
of keywords you could do it for your
brand meaning you could choose your own
brand keywords you could choose keywords
related to what your brand is trying to
offer whether that be a service or
product and
once you choose a relevant list of
keywords you can finalize those keywords
and then bid on them so
once you start bidding on them then what
you're going to do is align those
keywords with a headline so it's all
done within the framework of any
platform you're advertising on really
the key here that i want to really
emphasize is when you establish a
campaign or set up a campaign you need
to establish what the goal is because
when you actually choose your keywords
and write your ads and launch the
campaign and start paying google or bing
or whomever
it is you're advertising with you want
to be able to measure those goals so
that's really the important part here
because
regardless of where you advertise you're
going to be able to monitor campaign
results and so with google you can even
import conversions into the campaign so
for example if i go to google ads for
example if i go to tools okay you can
see i'm running campaigns what am i
trying to accomplish with these
campaigns well in this case i'm trying
to get donations people click on
donations so i can go to tools click
conversions and then i can see what
conversions are added to my account and
that way i can measure my campaigns
against these conversions okay if i
don't see a conversion error i can
certainly create one or import it from
in this case google analytics so that's
the important thing you want to be able
to measure your campaigns
with your conversions and then just as
important you want to be able to
optimize your campaign because if it's
not performing if you're running a
campaign you're running up costs and
you're not getting conversions you're
probably not going to be continuing to
run those campaigns so you want to
optimize your campaign and retarget
potential customers so retargeting is
always a good option retargeting is
targeting someone who that went to your
website and basically
acted in a certain way meaning they went
to a certain page or abandoned the card
or actually purchased or downloaded
something okay you define what action
you want that audience to take in order
to retarget to them okay so the whole
point is you can configure your
retargeting campaign based on certain
behavior on your website and the whole
point there retargeting is you're
pulling people back to your website so
in addition to optimizing you know
search campaigns you can one of the
benefits of search engine marketing is
you can run retargeting campaigns so
here's an example of an ad okay so here
you could see
it's a good ad in the sense that
it's using everything available to it so
for example
here i could see three headlines so
google in this example allows you to add
in three headlines so here you can see
simply learn official site get certified
get ahead then you can see
simplylearn.com
so they're taking advantage of three
headlines and then here you can see two
description lines and so each
description line you can have up to 90
characters and so you want to be able to
take advantage of what google gives you
the more information you can add the
better well here you can see some other
types of ads here you can see a banner
ad for slack okay here you can see
betterment.com running an ad okay so
this looks like an ad that is on youtube
so because you can see
after a few seconds you can skip the ad
okay so here's a video ad here's an
image ad here's a text ad so depending
on what platform you advertise on you
have an option on what type of asset you
want to use you know the one thing i
like about facebook is they offer up a
multitude of options in terms of assets
so you can run a single image ad you can
run a carousel meaning you get a
multiple images you can run a video you
can run a combination video image you
can obviously run text okay with a
thumbnail so you have a lot of options
in terms of the type of ad you can run
so before we move into our next channel
let me just show you an example of you
know how an ad actually looks on a
particular website so here you can see
i'm on buzzfeednews.com
okay here you can see
uh volkswagen golf is running an
advertisement in spanish on this
particular site so
they're either using google or some
other platform and having that platform
if it's google post their ad on this
particular site so here you can see it's
a banner app and if we're in google ads
and you're setting up a text ad let me
just run through you with that text that
it looks like remember you want to
always take advantage of what's offered
to you because especially text ads you
have very few characters and with very
few characters it's hard to get your
message across so with google you have
your final url which is where people are
going to go to after they click on your
ad but you have one not one not two but
three headlines that you can take
advantage of so we're talking about help
and child hunger help today you know you
can always add in visit our website for
more info i mean you want to take
advantage of what's available to you now
again here you can see in this example
i'm only allotted 30 characters and so
if you go over then your ads not going
to get approved so you really have to be
cognizant of the character counts and
getting your point across because
writing text ads is not the easiest
thing to do when you're limited to
characters now with google you have what
they call display path so after the
domain you can add in a couple of
keywords in there and then you have
description line one and description
line two so again take advantage of
what's available if you're not sure what
copy to write grab some from the website
and paste it in there you want your ads
to be healthy and to have as much
information as possible and then the one
thing i will say about google ads is
they also have extensions so extensions
are exactly that they're extensions to
your text ad so here you can see i have
four extensions these are actually site
links so google ads offers up something
called ad extensions so it could be call
outs site links can be location
extensions app extensions they have a
number of different extensions that they
can append to your ad so take advantage
of that as well remember the whole point
of ads is to make a compelling case for
your product or service so that somebody
can click on the ad and go to your
website and then perform the action you
want them to perform now if you have any
more questions about google ads feel
free to check out our in-depth video
about google ads it covers everything a
to z on google ads you know we also have
videos on our simply learn youtube
playlist for facebook uh twitter social
media marketing so if you're curious to
know a little bit more about search
engine marketing you know check out any
one of these videos that we have listed
on our youtube channel okay so let's
move over to affiliate marketing now and
so with affiliate marketing
really it's interesting and unique and
that affiliate marketing involves paying
out commissions and who are you paying
commissions to while you're paying
commissions to website owners or
publishers or people who have websites
with lots of content or people who have
websites that attract a lot of users and
so the whole point is you want to be
able to find those websites to advertise
your product or service okay these
people who are selling your product or
service on your behalf are going to get
commissioned or incentivized based on
whatever action you put out there so
it could be registrations just getting
your affiliates to help you with
getting people registered or signing up
for your email or
you know for a lot of you conversions
you're trying to sell a product so you
want help in selling that product or it
could be subscriptions okay signing up
to something okay so
you determine
what it is you want to incentivize your
affiliates for you also determine how
much you're going to incentivize them
and that's the great thing about
affiliate marketing it's it's no
different than having a sales team um to
support you what are the steps for
affiliate marketing well you need to
find a platform there are lots of
different affiliate platforms out there
you know commission junction or cj.com
comes to mind because these platforms
are going to help you find
these affiliates or partners okay so
they're the broker and all this and
so once you set up your platform you're
going to establish rules guidelines post
images and banners and assets for those
affiliates to use on their websites and
more importantly again you're going to
establish the commission so the
commission doesn't have to be the same
for all affiliates it could simply be
you know your top affiliates get a
higher commission as opposed to just
some other affiliates who get a starting
commission you establish everything on
the platform the affiliate platform that
you choose now affiliates apply to
advertise on your behalf so they're
going to say hey i'm interested in
selling your product or service so
you're going to use that platform if
it's commission junction to approve or
disapprove the re affiliates request to
advertise on your behalf and really what
you want to try and do is leverage the
platform as best as you can a lot of
these affiliates are out to make money
and some of them are really good you
need to be able to choose the affiliate
that is going to represent your brand
product or service the best so it's
simple customer clicks on an ad or link
okay on that affiliate website and they
go to your website and they perform an
action so that could be a purchase or
registration a subscription a download
an email sign up you determine that and
the great thing is these affiliate
networks the cj's commission junctions
of the world will record everything
they're tracking not only traffic from
the affiliate website to your website
but they're also tracking the
conversions the transaction is validated
and credited to the affiliate by the
broker and then the affiliate has paid
his or her commission so that's how it
works so the more the affiliate sells or
converts on your behalf the more they're
going to make and that's the beauty of
the affiliate network so here's an
example of affiliate marketing okay here
you can see uh an advertisement here
okay so you can see profit from our
experience earn up to 12 advertising
fees with a trusted e-commerce list
leader so somebody clicks on that link
joins and then this person is going to
get a commission based on somebody
joining for free again i mentioned
commission junction there are also some
other affiliate marketing tools out
there
uh
amazon associates a win trade doubler
max bounty i mean there's a there's
there's a lot out there
cj.com is the one i've used in the past
but you know give some of these other
platforms a chance okay it doesn't hurt
to even be on multiple platforms you
have nothing to lose okay when you're on
a platform basically the platform again
is acting as the middle person they're
introducing you to affiliates and so
every time you actually pay an affiliate
a commission they're gonna get their cut
of it so they're gonna get a small
percentage as well so just keep that in
mind but you know give it a try try one
or two of these affiliates if you find
you're getting quality affiliates that
are selling your product or service
great if you don't then you know feel
free to change you know affiliate
networks it's that simple but the key
here is
find the affiliates you think are going
to best represent your brand product or
service because those affiliates are
likely going to be the ones to convert
for you and if your small business
starting out and you need some help
affiliate marketing is the way to go
okay let's move over to native
advertising okay so native advertising
so neighbor advertisements means that
your ad is showing up next to content
that basically
naturally fits so these are advertisers
that are featured on a platform
alongside the content okay that isn't
paid for okay so for example here you
can see a paid post okay this is by
spotify okay this paid post okay was on
buzzfeed this particular post was
probably on a news article related to
music because they're talking about your
bands that probably won't exist without
led zeppelin okay so for spotify
you're using native advertising allows
them to put their ad next to content
related to their ad here you can see
another buzzfeed article okay 11 great
amazon deals that will be music to your
ears if you're an audiophile here you
can see
an advertisement next to the article so
you can see the ad about led zeppelin
and here you can see the actual article
is about music so the whole point about
native advertising is making sure
there's a connection between the ad and
the article so spotify is advertising
okay their product and service on an
article on buzzfeed which happens to be
about music so a good example we used
buzzfeed just a second ago so if we go
to buzzfeed here you can see i'm on tv
and movies and here you can see
got an ad here if we scroll down
uh keep scrolling down we can see
another ad here for hbo and so this ad
makes sense because
it's placed on tvs and movies so people
who go and read the content are going to
see an ad related to that content so
that's generally what native advertising
is you need to be able to be able to
place the ad on the right pages okay so
you're going to need it and network for
that so we talked about paid search
advertising we talked about google ads
so google ads has the ability to place
your ad natively on particular pages
that are relevant to that ad so that's
really what native advertising is all
about making sure that your ad is placed
next to content that's naturally
relevant so if you need more information
about affiliate marketing feel free to
visit simplylearn's youtube channel we
have a nice uh in-depth video about
affiliate marketing to get more
information about the platforms how it
works and all the tips and best
practices about how to run a successful
affiliate marketing campaign so let's
turn our attention to email marketing
now so email marketing very traditional
form of digital marketing it's been
around the longest it's kind of the
grandfather of all digital marketing
channels so email marketing really is
used to personalize emails in order to
convert that recipient or that
perspective user into a customer and so
like all the other digital marketing
channels we want to follow some type of
flow or process or methodology and the
first step in email marketing is you
have to identify your target audience
okay when you identify your target
audience you're gonna create a segment
okay so in other words you don't want to
send one email to everyone because not
everyone is going to be interested in
that email so in order to get somebody
interested you need to be able to send
an email tailored to that audience okay
so that audience can respond and react
accordingly so once you target that
audience and create segments email
segments you're going to create the
campaign and set up an appropriate call
to action one note here is when you
create the campaign and set up that
appropriate call to action that call to
action is going to be aligned with your
goal so what is the goal of the email
campaign is it simply to get people to
click on something and purchase or is it
simply to get people to click on
something and sign up or watch something
or submit some information or download
or whatever the case you need to
establish that up front just like you
would with a search engine marketing
campaign or any other type of campaign
you want to run so
there are lots of tools out there just
like with affiliate marketing you want
to choose an appropriate email marketing
tool there are plenty to be had each
work in a very similar nature
some offer different pricing models
meaning you know you can send an email
to ex recipients for flat fee or you pay
a small amount per email address each
one is slightly different in terms of
how they price but in terms of the
features they all work in a very similar
fashion and we're going to show you an
example of one here shortly so when you
choose that email marketing tool you're
gonna test your emails before you send
them out and then when you test your
emails you're gonna use that email
marketing tool to actually send the
campaign after it's been tested okay so
you want to send the campaign you can
immediately send them out or you can
schedule them now a best practice with
an email is when you actually send one
out you're sending an email out to your
target audience you want to create
probably two emails per segment audience
why because you want to add an
attractive subject line and copy to the
email but if you send two emails to the
same target audience then you want to
test the subject lines you want to be
able to see what subject line's going to
entice somebody to open the email okay
that's the beauty of email marketing is
you can do that okay so you can set up
your a design based on your target
audience but it's always the subject
line that people see first so you want
to write an attractive subject line and
copy that's going to entice somebody to
open the email so why not send two
emails to each target audience that way
you can see what email subject line
works best so that's the whole idea
about performing a b test to test out
different ideas it doesn't necessarily
have to be a subject line it can be the
same subject line
two emails but the difference being the
body of the email it's totally up to you
but the idea here is to always split out
your emails per target audience and just
like any other channel whether it be
affiliate or search engine marketing
organic search you want to analyze
performance and in the case of emails
it's always about open rates how many
people are opening then how many people
are clicking and then how many people
are actually responding are they
converting or downloading or whatever it
is you want them to do you need to be
able to monitor the behavior because for
example if your open rates don't work or
they're low then you know something's
wrong with your subject line so you want
to be able to make an adjustment so
here's an example of an email from
airbnb it's a simple email okay they're
just simply trying to get somebody to
click on that call to action to take the
survey okay that's really all it's about
here with this particular email so who's
their target audience well their target
audience could be somebody who's already
stayed at
a airbnb property or it could be
somebody who used the app probably
airbnb has already targeted this
audience and they're sending this survey
to a particular audience so that they
can get the best results okay so that's
a good example of a targeted email with
a good call to action that's getting
somebody to take the survey so they're
probably measuring how many people
opened it how many people clicked on the
cta the call to action and then how many
people actually filled out the survey so
you need to follow each step and track
each step accordingly okay so again some
popular tools used in email marketing
let's take a look at mailchimp here uh
but i will mention like marcato is a
good marketing automation tool
now owned by adobe marketo allows you to
send those drip campaigns so if somebody
doesn't purchase right away you could
send up follow-up emails like say one
day out or seven days out or 14 days out
so hubspot works in a very similar
fashion you want to be able to
methodically plan out your emails that's
the point i'm trying to make here so
let's take a look at mailchimp so if we
go over into mailchimp a very easy
interface okay here if we go under
audience we can actually see who our
audience is and we can break out our
audience into different groups you can
have a simple test list you can have
people who purchase people who subscribe
to something okay so you can break out
your audience into different groups okay
when it comes to campaigns you can see
campaigns that are already been built or
you can create your own campaign okay so
in the case of mailchimp we can actually
see
what campaigns have been dropped or sent
out already and then we can see
the opens the clicks and then the
conversions so mailchimp has some nice
reporting so you want to be able to
measure
the reports or how well the campaign
performed so here we could see
specifically how many people open
clicked how many people bounced or email
addresses bounced and how many people
unsubscribed from the list and here we
can see you know the top links that have
been clicked okay the subscribers with
the most opens did anybody perform any
social media activity okay what
locations open the email okay so you can
actually see a lot of good information
here right in mailchimp and you want to
be able to react to the emails you send
out so if an email is not performing
okay you want to learn from that so you
don't make the same mistake again great
thing i like about mailchimp too they
have a lot of nice templates to use so
if you're trying to create a template
here you got some templates that you can
leverage so that's mailchimp kind of in
a nutshell mailchimp you could pay
upfront buy credits and with those
credits you could send out emails to a
number of people okay so that's how
mailchimp works they do have a free
trial so you can set up an account using
the free trial now if you need any more
information about mailchimp or email
marketing in general take a look at the
email marketing webinar we have set up
on our simply learn youtube account now
let's finish up with online pr or press
releases so we talked about seo and
social and search and affiliate and
email marketing and content native
advertising let's talk about online pr
here because with online pr
it really does involve
working with digital publications or
blogs or other content related websites
for example
content related websites could be
newspaper digital newspaper sites like
the new york times okay the whole point
of
online pr is you want to try and get
some publicity on those on those
websites publicity means awareness for
the brand it means traffic to the
website and eventually some loyalty
future customers and conversions
channels that can be used to maximize
your online pr efforts for example you
can connect with reporters on social
media to develop a relationship so
you can just follow some reporters see
if they're covering specific
industries or verticals and if they are
similar to what you're offering then
it's probably a good idea to reach out
to them you can use engaging user
reviews to help humanize your brand or
you can respond to comments that help
generate productive conversations so
those are all certain things you can do
to generate awareness and buzz for your
brand so really the one thing i want to
point out about online pr is
basically you can also hire a pr firm
and they can do some of the heavy
lifting for you or like i said you can
reach out to different reporters or
different influencers even to help push
your product or brand now if you're
trying to go at it alone on the online
pr what you could do if you don't reach
out to reporters or influencers or
you're active in trying to build your
brand through a conversation you can
always use a third-party service like
pr.com so pr.com allows you to
you know basically create your own
profile you know submit content to your
own profile or even submit press
releases if you submit press releases
then other news agencies are going to
pick up on those press releases so it's
a good way to get your press releases
out there likes of yahoo and google
might pick up those press releases and
give you some you know much needed
visibility you can also use other tools
like you know pr newswire for example so
it works in a very similar way
again it's a press release distribution
network so you can go ahead and sign up
for an account get that press release
out there and they do the distribution
for you or you can also use aggregation
sites so there are lots of different
aggregate sites out there and so what
aggregate websites do
is they help disseminate and distribute
your content so here you can see
some of the new aggregator websites of
2019 you got feedly
panda tech mimi
metacritic e science news the morning
news so you have a lot of options
available to get your content out there
okay so what these sites do is basically
pick up articles that fit their website
fit their theme fit their target
audience so you do have options in the
form of third party tools as well okay
so if you don't hire a pr firm which
could be expensive you can certainly go
at it alone by signing up for any one of
these particular products or services
today we're going to talk about digital
marketing tools so fasten your seat
belts and let's get started so what
we're going to do is we're going to take
a look at some of the
best digital marketing tools for not
only 2019 but ones that have performed
well in the past that are popular and
ones that we foresee as being the go-to
tools for the future so past and future
digital marketing tools is the way to
look at this uh with a good focus on a
lot of different marketing channels here
so we're gonna focus first on seo talk
about some of the tools related to on
page and off page we're going to switch
over to
paid search talk a little bit about paid
search tools we're going to talk about
email marketing and some of the email
marketing platforms and the tools within
those platforms the center of it all is
web analytics so google analytics is the
tool we'll be taking a closer look at in
today's webinar and all that it has to
offer okay affiliate marketing we'll
talk about some of the
tools available to you and for affiliate
marketing we'd be remiss we didn't talk
about social media and all that it has
to offer and all the metrics and tools
available
all the platforms available so we'll
hone in on a couple of examples there
and then we'll also talk about some
competition tools available for you so
there's a whole suite of tools the one
caveat being hey if you have your
favorite tool continue using it in fact
if there's a tool that we didn't mention
in today's webinar feel free to mention
it in the comment box below this video
we'd love to hear what you're using to
manage your particular digital marketing
channel okay and so the goal for today's
webinar is hey we hope you get something
out of this in terms of using new tools
there's some tools that i use some tools
that my colleagues use everybody uses
different tools so be good to kind of
see what else is out there so if you
have something to share share it by all
means what we're trying to do is share
what we think are
you know best practices and
some of the most
popular or most used tools out there in
the industry so
that's what we're going to do the goal
is to get you to
better understand some of the tools
we're using a little bit more detail and
what we're going to do is start out with
search engine optimization okay so
search engine optimization
or organic search we have a mixture of
paid and free so there's a lot of
different platforms but if you're
focusing on seo you certainly need to
use an seo platform so there's sem rush
okay you also have google search console
which is free so if you don't have a seo
platform you definitely need to be using
google search console and so we'll take
a closer look at that there's google
keyword planner which is actually
situated under google ads and so if
you're running google campaigns on
google search network or even the
display network you have access to a
great tool called keyword planner and if
you know anything about seo you'll know
that using google's keyword planner is a
good tool so we'll take a look at that
moz is a freemium tool meaning they have
a free trial that you can sign up for to
test drive it but it's another seo
platform and it does cost money got a
great tool in screaming frog that's a
paid version again not too expensive
we'll talk a little bit more about that
and then we have you know a tool in
hrefs that help us with all aspects of
seo primarily focusing on off page so
these are just some examples that we're
going to hone in on but this is just a
small subset of what really is available
out there in the market so let's go
ahead and dive a little bit deeper and
understand why we use some of these
tools well the first reason when we talk
about seo is to find relevant keywords
not only do we want to find relevant
keywords we want to find relevant
keywords with high volume and low
competition okay we wouldn't want to
find non-relevant keywords with high
competition low volume that wouldn't
make sense so we need a tool to kind of
help us put it all together and so the
tool of choice for us is google's
keyword planner and google's keyword
planner helps us hone in on keywords we
may be interested in
optimizing for because not only one are
they relevant but two they're going to
have high volume and low competition so
let's take a look at an example in
google's keyword planner so here i am
i'm in google's keyword planner and as i
mentioned before google's keyword
planner is situated under google ads
okay so you have to have a google ads
account to use google's keyword planner
and so when you're in google ads you
simply go to tools and then under tools
you're going to select keyword planner
so what we want to do is look for
keywords we're focusing on organic
search not necessarily paid search so
organic search we want to
hone in on some keywords so let's just
use one of the examples that google's
given us here mail delivery so we're
going to just type in mail delivery and
get some results so notice i can enter a
domain as a filter and so in other words
hey i could say look hone in on keywords
related to this website if i wanted to
but i'm asking google hey just give me
something closely related to mail
delivery because that's my business so
i'm going to click click get results
notice i could add another key to it if
i wanted to but i'm just going to stick
with one keyword but there are certainly
other keywords that i can certainly hone
in on if mail delivery is my business
and so let's just hone in on that one
keyword mail delivery we want to be
found organically for that keyword so
what google keyword planner does is not
only give us the keyword and other
keywords relevant to that but it gives
us the average monthly search volumes
and this is an average over the course
of the last 12 months and notice here i
get a column for competition so
i'm able to see whether that's a very
competitive keyword or not and then just
to give you an extra edge when you're
choosing keywords you can get a sense of
what the keyword may cost if you wanted
to bid on that for paid search so for
mail delivery i can see it's anywhere
between
7.46 and at the top of the page high
range 16.61
so that should alert me to the fact that
hey if i'm gonna try and optimize for
this keyword i know it's competitive
because not only google is telling me
it's competitive by telling me high
competition but i know that the cost per
click seems a little bit high and what
is a little bit high well you know i can
see some other keywords here that you
know a dollar to three dollars okay i
could see some other ones that are even
lower than the seven dollars they're
suggesting so that's a indication that
the keyword is highly competitive so the
idea here using google's keyword planner
is one we want to get an idea of what
other keywords are out there that are
relevant so it helps stimulate some
ideas for relevancy two we can get an
average monthly search volume so we want
to know on average over the past 12
months how many search queries i can
expect from this keyword and then three
i can get a sense of the competition how
competitive is this keyword so if i try
to optimize for this keyword and i want
to rank for it organically
is it competitive if it's competitive
then it's probably going to take me a
bit longer to be found for this keyword
on page one of google so that's the
whole idea behind google's keyword
planner and note that you could change
some of the settings here so if you want
to choose a different language okay you
can hone in on a longer or shorter
period of time you can even choose a
specific location so i chose taxes i can
certainly choose the entire united
states to get a sense of what the volume
would be for the total u.s so you have
settings that you can change and
manipulate to get you the data you need
to choose keywords so that's the whole
idea behind google's keyword planner to
find relevant keywords high volume low
competition now alternatively i can
certainly use another tool to find
keywords so
i have a moz account so i logged into
moz and moz has a tool called keyword
explorer so if i use that same keyword i
used in google's keyword planner mail
delivery i'm going to ask maz to give me
some data on that keyword so this is for
the entire united states and again i can
change that if i wanted to okay so i can
hone in
on a specific country or different
country so what moz is telling me hey
for this keyword in the entire united
states i'm looking at anywhere from
eleven and a half thousand
to thirty thousand on monthly volume now
what moz does is they give you a
difficulty score so a difficulty score
is a score between 1 and 100 and so i
could see this is pretty much right down
the middle in terms of difficulty okay
so if it's zero it's an easy keyword if
it's if it's a hundred it's very
difficult and then that means
you have a lot of competitors who are
optimizing for this keyword that are
ranking for this keyword and so
moz gives us the volume they give us the
competition and they just like google's
keyword planner gives us some other
keywords that we can potentially hone in
on so
here i could see
keyword delivery plans delivery services
etc so i can see a lot more suggestions
than what's listed here so moz delivers
a bunch of other analysis
related to the keyword you know they
also give you some good keyword
suggestions so moz is a good alternative
tool and we'll be coming back to moz
related to seo for some other of its
features but for now
if you don't want to necessarily use
google's keyword planner because maybe
you're not running google ads you can
always use mazda remember moz has
basically a freemium version meaning you
can sign up for a free account and you
could sign up for a free account as a
test trial and you could test it for a
period of days and leverage its tools
during that free trial to get a better
sense of how these tools work so we want
to be able to use mods we want to be
able to use google's keyword planner not
only to search for all those relevant
keywords available to you but we want to
be able to choose keywords with high
volume and low difficulty low
competition we also want to select
primary and second keywords wisely so
remember when you optimize you're
optimizing a page for more than one
keyword so you want to be able to have a
nice portfolio of diverse relevant
keywords with high search volume and low
difficulty and then you want to be able
to identify those keywords that your
competitors are ranking for so moz gives
you that information
and so we want to be able to leverage
the tools available to us to choose the
right keywords so if you need any more
information on this
we got a nice webinar on keyword
research for seo so take a look at that
video on youtube and to get more
specific details about using seo tools
for keyword research and all about
keyword research in general for seo so
let's talk about some other reasons
under seo what we would use some of
these tools available to us well we want
to be able to understand the search
engines and how they crawl and index our
site okay we also want to check the
correct format of the site map and we
want to monitor backlinks okay we also
want to analyze
linking to our web page okay which ones
are good which ones are not good okay we
also want to perform some competitor
analysis so these are some of the
reasons why other than keyword research
why would we use some of these seo tools
so we have tools available to us some
majestic
hrefs again moz let's take a look at
google search console and i want to hone
in on google search console because it
is free and it's a must if you're going
to work on seo you need to be working in
google search console and so the whole
key behind google search console is you
have a website and you need to get that
site verified once it's verified when
school can recognize that you are
associated with this website then you're
going to be able to see some important
information so
here i'm looking at a website and what
am i looking at i'm looking at something
called coverage under index so what does
coverage mean well going back to what we
just said we want to be able to
understand how google's crawling and
indexing our pages and so what google
does is through this platform search
console is they're letting us know once
they go to our website and start
crawling it and they pull these pages
back to their server they're letting us
know
if we actually have any issues so here i
can see
i have some issues with 112 pages and
some of those issues are listed down
here so there could be a crawl issue
a 4-4 you know redirect okay so
you could see there's some five unique
issues across 112 pages so here i can
see submitted url marked new index
there's a hundred of those pages we have
some redirect errors there's seven pages
that you know fall victim to this error
and so we can really hone in
um what the error is and address the
error okay so if google's telling us hey
this is an issue and you want that page
indexed by google
then we should probably address the
error and so that's the great thing here
about going into google search console
is you can under index go to coverage
and get a sense of what google is
indexing and what they're not indexing
okay so these are the errors i could see
they've certainly were able to crawl and
index 9115
pages they were able to crawl okay and
they excluded 54 000 plus pages and then
we also have some pages with some
warnings so this is kind of an overview
of
what google sees when they crawl our
site so when they say crawl they're
coming to our site they're following
links on the site and every link they
follow they're either going to index
that page or they're going to report to
you an error or an issue that they found
if we want these pages indexed we need
to
address the issues the errors and so
that's the beauty of this report here is
google is telling us firsthand what the
issues are so we also want to take a
look at the sitemap so you have an
opportunity to submit a sitemap and a
sitemap is just a formatted file that
includes all your website urls and so
you're going to
have this file sitting in your root
directory and you're probably going to
call it or should call it
sitemap.xml xml being the format so once
you have this file you're just going to
let google know that that file exists so
you're going to enter in the sitemap url
so if it's in the root directory all
you're going to do is type in
sitemap.xml and click submit so once
you've done it just like this site is
done what google's going to do is say
hey look we see you've submitted this
and we last read it a couple days ago
and we could see
that we discovered
1419 urls so i can go back under
coverage and i can see some of the
issues that they found but if i go back
under site maps i can see that these are
the urls they've discovered via the
sitemap and so
the whole point of a sitemap is we want
to be able to get and push the urls to
google not have google come to our site
and discover them so this is a quicker
faster more efficient way to communicate
with google all the urls that you have
on your site that you want google to
index and so that's the beauty of search
console now while we're in search
console we might as well take a look at
some of the other features it has and so
one of the most important features under
search console is this mobile usability
report okay so google is a staunch
believer and mobile first so nowadays
most people start and finish
a lot of their searches a lot of their
behavior on mobile so they begin it on
mobile and they may end it on mobile so
if they don't end it on mobile then you
know perhaps they'll go into a store or
perhaps they'll go via desktop but
google is a staunch believer and
definitely a lot of what's going on
today
starts with mobile so they want you to
understand how your site fares
via mobile and when i say fares via
mobile is it mobile friendly is it
responsive is it loading quick enough
you know is it formatted to google
standards and so if there are any issues
google is going to let you know what
those issues are so here i could see
google's recognized 206 pages before
different issues okay so here i can see
what those issues are just like the
coverage issues we can see specifically
what they are and so here i can see for
206 pages text too small to read click
elements too close together the viewport
not set to device with and then content
wider than the screen so there's 10
pages that fit under this error and if i
actually click on it the error i can see
what those 10 pages are and so when
we're done we can actually when we
address the issues we can actually have
google validate whether the fix has been
made so you can definitely use this as a
means of communicating directly with
google telling google look i see what
the issues are i'm going to fix them and
then i want you to validate them okay so
this is important because if you can
communicate with google and let them
know hey we do recognize the errors we
are fixing the errors please validate
them you know it's going to draw
google's attention google's going to
validate them and get these pages
indexed quicker
so if you ignore the issues and the
errors especially for mobile then you
stand the chance of your pages not
getting indexed so the mobile usability
report to me is an important report
because we want to better understand
whether google's picking up issues on
mobile and if they are we want to
address them get google valid them so
google can index them quicker now
there's another report that
is of interest to you or may be of
interest to you in google search console
and that's the links report so the links
report in google search consoles shows
us what pages have the most links okay
so here we can see the home page has 26
000 plus links if we hone in on interior
pages we can see the links to those
pages okay so we can get a sense of what
are the top link pages from external
links meaning links on other websites
pointing to these pages i can also see
internal links so google is recognizing
links from within my website from one
page to another so external links
internal links both factors for seo when
ranking so then i can see top linking
sites what sites are linking to my site
and then i can see top linking text so
google search console has given me kind
of an overview of what my leaking
structure looks like okay so
externally i want links from other
websites pointing to various pages on my
site and i certainly want my pages
linking to one another on my site and so
i'd be able to better understand what
that structure looks like using google
search consoles links report okay
there's one more report that i think's
of interest in google search console and
that's the performance report so the
performance report is a report that
actually you can link up with google
analytics so you can see the same report
and analytics if you're able to link up
google search console with analytics and
you should be able to do that all you
need to do is make sure you use the same
email address that you use for analytics
and search console so it needs to be the
same email address you could certainly
link up the two and have this data
imported into google analytics so what
is this data that we're talking about
well it's called performance so what we
can actually see is the queries the
actual queries people are typing in to
google so when they're typing them into
google we can actually see how many
impressions the keyword queries received
and how many clicks the keyword queries
received and then i can see click
through rate and average position okay
so here i can see for this particular
keyword on the first line i could see
over the course of the last three months
it received 209
297 impressions so what does that mean
that means this keyword was used or
typed in as a query at least that many
times and that's how many times my
listing appeared in the google search
results pages based on this particular
query and so as a result
of somebody typing in this query 209 000
plus times this site received 120 000
plus clicks so to get a sense of the
click-through rate all you would need to
do and google can obviously do this for
you is you would simply just divide the
209 000 297
into the 120 000 397. okay so that's
really going to give you that's going to
give you a click-through rate and the
click-through rate in this case is 57
so
over half of the clicks occur
when this listing appears for this
keyword okay so we can get a sense of
the click-through rate for each one okay
and you could simply just use the
filtering here now we can also see
average position okay so we could see a
little bit more than that too we can go
from queries to pages we can go from
pages to countries so we get a sense of
how many impressions and clicks i'm
receiving by country and importantly we
can see by device so here i can see a
majority of the people who conduct a
search related to my website primarily
do it on desktop now i mentioned the
beauty of the google search console
performance report is that you can link
it up to google analytics and when you
do that all you need to do then is go to
acquisition google search console and
then from there you could choose landing
pages countries devices or queries so i
could see the same data that i see in
search console but this time i'm looking
at it in google analytics and so here i
can see what my search queries are my
clicks my impressions my click-to-rate
bike search query and then the average
position so that's the great thing about
that performance report is that when i
link up google search console with
analytics i'm able to see that data in
analytics so that's an added bonus so to
speak now let's talk about some other
reasons why we're going to use these seo
tools available to us and so we already
listed a number of different reasons
ranging from
site maps to keyword research but we
also want to hone in on you know what
domains are
driving links to our site so i showed
you an example in search console we also
want to
hey maybe identify and disavow poor
backlinks so search console is a great
tool for that because if we don't want
to be associated with a particular
website we can certainly disavow that
link we could track a number of follow
and no follow links okay we could track
our website's rankings we can measure
click-through rates and impressions just
as we did with search console
we could track keyword ranking for
desktop mobile cross locations just as
we just did with the search console
performance report we can identify top
performing gaining and losing keywords
again the performance report so we could
certainly look at the google search
console report but if you have a
platform like moz you can certainly also
look at a lot of that data available so
for example rankings so if you have a
moz account we can certainly go into
rankings okay and we can see
for the keywords that we've chosen that
we want to optimize for we could
certainly see where they rank the great
thing about moz is it's a great tool not
only for rankings and on page
optimization but for off-page
optimization as well so
if i go ahead and take a look at a
domain for example i'm just going to
type in this domain i'm going to be able
to get what they call a domain authority
so a score out of 1 in 100 i'm able to
see how
authoritative my domain is and how
authoritative a domain is is based on
the quality of links pointing to it so
moz gives me some good insights as to
how many linking domains how many
inbound links i have ranking keywords
and it goes into detail as well so here
if i click on the linking domains i'm
going to be actually able to see
the actual domains
pointing to my site as an external link
and not only can i see the domains i can
actually see the domain authority of
those domains so if there's a domain for
example that
doesn't have a good domain authority and
the site appears a bit scammy per se
then we can disavow that so i can
certainly look at all the domains that
are linking to me and then i can
highlight the ones that have poor domain
authority what mazda even takes it a
step further they also give me a spam
score so moz is able to measure how
spammy a website is so if i have a
combination of say a low domain
authority
and a high spam score then i probably
want to disavow myself from that site
and so i can use this report here you
can see here as i keep going down for
example i can see this particular
website has a domain authority of 26 and
it has a spam score of 16
so not a good combination this should
alert me to the fact that hey
this particular site because it has so
many links pointing to me or it has at
least one link pointing to me that i
probably want to disavow myself because
it's probably hurting my own domain
authority so that's the great thing
about this linking domains report is i'm
able to hone in on not only who's link
linking to me meaning domain but how
many linking domains does that domain
have what's the spam score of that
domain what's the domain authority of
that domain and then i can get into a
little bit more detail and actually see
you know all the links pointing to that
domain so it really goes into detail
about
backlinks domain authority spam etc
everything you need to use in order to
measure off-page seo so that's the great
thing about moz is they have not only
on-page seo tools but off-page seo tools
and moz is a freemium so to speak so
here you can see if you just go to
moz.com
free-seo-tools you'll be able to use
some of these tools available to you not
just for seo but also for local seo as
well so here you like some of these
tools you can start your free 30-day
trial so i use and lean on moz a lot for
all that it has to offer from
choosing keywords to rankings report
to checking issues on my website to even
checking who's linking to me so this
fits in the mold with everything i need
to do for seo so in addition to that
keyword research video you could
certainly lean on some other webinars
that we've done in the past on seo so
we've done a webinar on seo tools and
we've also done a webinar on seo tips
and tricks so if you want any more
information about the tools we covered
or seo in general take a look at those
two videos
and
check them out and that should kind of
complement what we talked about with
using some of the tools google's keyword
planner
moz and google search console okay let's
switch over to email marketing tools and
so with email marketing tools we have a
lot available to us
in the form of
reporting in the form of platforms in
the form of you know tools that really
help us go from a to z on our email
choosing you know what email to send out
to creating a list to measuring how the
email campaign went and so we could
start with mailchimp because mailchimp's
a freemium version when we say freemium
meaning they have a free trial available
then you're expected to upgrade but you
know mailchimp to me is a tool i use i
like the interface very easy for
beginners so we're going to take a look
at mailchimp but there are certainly
many others available you know marcato
is a good tool you know marcato is a
good tool because
if you have a business and you're trying
to funnel people through
your pipeline so to speak meaning
they sign up as a lead and you want to
nurture that lead from the beginning to
the end meaning at the end they're
actually going to turn around and
purchase well marketo is a good tool for
you to use because you can then set up
trip campaigns or also known as email
campaigns you know so that you're
talking and communicating with that
particular prospect through every point
in the funnel so that's the great thing
about marketo it has drip campaigns
available along with some other features
there's a hubspot a very powerful tool
it does a lot
from creating landing pages to a b
testing to social to
you know email so
this is another freemium tool that you
could use you have another freemium and
send in blue
email platform and then you also have
convertkit another email platform
there's more dimension that we can't
even fit on this screen now if you have
a favorite email marketing tool that you
use constant contact vertical response
there are plenty out there emma
you know feel free to to note that in
the comments section below this video
i'm curious as to how many people
actually use you know different tools
because there are so literally so many
email marketing tools out there why
because email marketing has been around
probably the longest amongst all the
other digital marketing channels and a
lot of people use email on a daily basis
so
it's no wonder why there's just so many
tools available and so with these tools
you could certainly send bulk emails now
in the case of marketo you could send
emails to a segmented audience and so
that's
actually what you want to do as a
strategy is always send emails to a
segmented audience you know you want to
use a tool where you're going to be able
to create campaigns then send those
campaigns to again segmented contacts
and then be able to design your email
around that particular audience so you
know you have a good tool when you can
do that when you can really segment for
your audience okay you want to be able
to
use a tool that's going to be able to
segment your users you know use
transactional emails meaning hey look if
somebody go ahead went ahead and
purchased can you follow up with an
email and creating workflows just like i
mentioned with marketo you want a
workflow set up where hey if somebody
does this you're sending email b etc so
you want an email marketing tool that's
flexible enough to handle what your
business strategy and goals are okay so
you want to be able to also use a tool
that you know has various email
templates available okay you don't want
to be stuck with just a vanilla template
again you want to be able to customize
an email for your audience you want to
be able to
manage your list appropriately
meaning
if you have 10 000 users or emails in a
list you want to be able to manage them
accordingly you know break them up or or
have sub lists so to speak and then most
importantly you want to make sure you
have a platform that
not only does its tracking on its own
but will give you some detailed insights
meaning you know what percentage of
users
opened your email what percentage of of
recipients clicked on your email what
links do they click on you know which
which emails bounce so you want some
detailed insights right in the platform
that you're using it just makes it more
simpler and easier and more effective to
manage you certainly want to create
those smart automated campaigns meaning
you don't even have to send out the
email and then you want to be able to
have some flexibility to set up email
delivery based on a specific time of day
so these tools also allow you
your sigma context based on geolocation
you want to be able to use a tool that
allows for multi-variant testing
again you want to analyze performance
and optimize campaigns you want to
trigger automatic responses
somebody purchases something are you
using a tool that will automatically
send that email out so these are all the
reasons why you would use
an email marketing tool so let's dive in
and take a look at an example and we're
going to use mailchimp as our example
today so let's dive in and take a look
at mailchimp so with mailchimp once you
log in you know you're going to be able
to see
some historical campaigns that you've
sent out or you're going to be able to
create your own campaign and so
this is kind of under campaigns you can
kind of see an overview of the ones
you've sent out or if they're in draft
mode you'll be able to see their draft
mode so you can go ahead and edit them
so here we have one that was set up on
august 26th and it's still in draft mode
so we can go ahead and edit that so if
we just click edit you know we have the
flexibility to
you know pick and choose who we're
sending this to who it's from what the
subject line is and then we can
certainly design the email so if we
click design email again this is
important because with email marketing
you want to be able to
cater your email to your intended
audience
so if you're selling men's shoes your
audience should be men okay so you don't
want men to receive an email about
women's shoes it sounds like it's common
sense but the point being you want to be
able to use an email platform that's
going to be able to allow you to put two
and two together the message and the
design with the intended audience and so
here you can see mailchimp allows us to
do that okay you can see
some of the layouts here okay you also
have themes that you can choose from
okay you can search for different themes
or you can even just code your own so
you can just paste
your code in or you can import it so
mailchimp allows that flexibility you're
not stuck with one of their templates
and so if we go back to the dashboard
the one thing i like about mailchimp
though is the reporting okay so
yes it is easy to choose a template and
map that template to your audience but i
really like the reports that they have
to offer so
you know here you can see there's some
lists that we've sent to
and if we choose one of our audience
list
then we can see some really detailed
reporting here and so
here i could see this email that was
sent out in june i could see it was sent
to 95 000 plus subscribers okay of the
subscribers i saw 2 000 plus open it and
157 clicks so i can view this report in
more detail just by clicking on view
report so again we want an email
platform that's going to be able to give
us some detailed information about how
that email campaign performed and so i
can get down really to the nitty gritty
i can actually see
you know on the content what was clicked
and what wasn't clicked so here i sent
two different subject lines so i'm able
to compare the two against one another
okay so i can really go into detail
about one of them here
so if i click view report i can
specifically see what the average for
this list is so here i'm able to compare
against the list average and it's 16
i only had
an open rate of 2.5 percent so the
industry average
is 18
and so here i'm able to see the list
average for the click rate and the
industry average for the click rate as
well so then i can see some specifics
about it how many people unsubscribed
then i could see
a graph i could see the top links that
were clicked okay the top subscribers
with the most opens i can link social to
it if i want to and then i can see
geographic information so the point
being is mailchimp really goes into some
nice detail here
about
the email campaigns and how they
performed so the great thing is too with
the mailchimp you could link it with
google analytics you can link it with
e-commerce okay so if you have an email
and you're you're selling products
and somebody purchased that product
mailchimp is able to integrate in with
your
shopping commerce platform for example
woocommerce so if somebody did purchase
you can send out that thank you email
mailchimp even goes a step further and
if somebody did click on a link go to
your shopping cart add something to the
shopping cart and then abandon the cart
you know mailchimp allows you the
opportunity to retarget them via email
so mailchimp is flexible and that's what
you want in a email marketing platform
you want something that's flexible that
you can cater to your audience you can
manage your audience list and you can
get detailed reporting on your different
campaigns for that audience so that's
mailchimp in summary and so most email
platforms do a lot of similar features
or have some similar features but that's
what you ideally want to look for in an
email marketing platform so here's a
tool that doesn't get talked about
enough when it comes to email marketing
and that's google's url builder and the
reason why we're going to talk about
this tool today is because
most people in the u.s
use google analytics as their web
analytics tool and the one thing about
google analytics is it allows you to
track different campaigns so if you're
doing pay-per-click campaigns outside of
google you can certainly track the
performance right in google analytics
and email is no different so if you're
using google analytics and you're
sending out an email let's just say on
mailchimp or any other email marketing
platform you want to be able to append
your links with what we call utm
tracking so for example
if i have a url that says visit florida
and i'm going to send out an email i
have up to five parameters that i can
use okay so here's my email or url that
i'm using in the email so i have up to
five parameters that i can use to track
this particular email so let's go
through some of those parameters so the
first one is campaign source so what's
the source of the campaign well we could
certainly identify mailchimp if you're
using mailchimp as the source now the
the thing about the url builders you
always want to use lowercase because
google analytics is case sensitive so as
a rule of thumb just stick with a
lowercase so our source is going to be
mailchimp because that's the platform
we're using if you're using you know
constant contact or vertical response or
you know some of these other one
convertkit then go ahead and put in that
platform as the source now for the
medium which is the means in which we're
driving traffic to the site let's go
ahead and put in email because that's
what we're using to drive traffic to
this particular page now what's the
campaign name well we're in summer so
we're going to call this the summer
promo so their summer promo here is
visit florida beaches okay so we're
going to send this email out to the
masses and particularly not only the
masses but the masses in the north
because we're going to say hey look come
to florida for the summer come visit our
beaches that's the point of the campaign
so that's what we're going to use for
the campaign name is whatever the
campaign is it's a summer promo now
notice i got an asterisk next to these
particular parameters so google's asking
us hey these are mandatory so go ahead
and put something in there now for
campaign term and campaign content we
could certainly leave them blank because
they're not mandatory but since we're
talking about email i would certainly
recommend that you use the campaign
content parameter and why do i say that
because if we're sending an email out to
say
you have 10 000 recipients i want to be
able to split out the email into two
segments one segment that's gonna get
subject line one and one segment that's
gonna get subject line two so
in this case i'm going to put whatever
subject line one is in the campaign
content field so now i have four
parameters
and once i've entered in my variables in
those parameter fields i now have a
revised repented url so my original url
was visit florida.com
ian-us
florida-beaches.html
my original url i've now appended that
with some utm parameters
and now i see my original url appended
with the utm parameters based on those
variables so i can copy it just by
clicking the copy url
i can go to my browser
i can paste that url in there and i want
to check to see if it works so here i
could see this particular page loaded
florida beaches with my utm parameters
appended to the url so that's for the
first subject line that's for the
audience that's going to get the first
subject line i want to do another one
for the second subject line so now i'm
going to change my campaign content
parameter to subject line underscore two
i'm going to copy that url i'm going to
check it
okay so i can see that the page loads
with those utm parameters and so now
what am i going to do i'm going to use
the first url and the second url in my
email okay so any link that i have in
this case i'm using subject line two so
for the email with the second subject
line going to that segmented audience
this is the link i'm going to use in the
email so if you have one or two or three
links in the email this is the url
you're going to use because when
somebody clicks on that link you're
going to be able to see that that click
in google analytics so if i jump over to
google analytics after i send out my
email i'm going to go to acquisition i'm
going to go to campaigns i'm going to go
to all campaigns now based on the
variables i put into
my parameters meaning source
medium campaign name content or term
that's what i'm going to look for in
google analytics so we could start with
source and medium
so if i click on source and medium as my
primary dimension
here i can see
mailchimp and the actual date was used
as part of the variable for for source
and then i will can i see the medium
being email so now i can see for this
email that was sent out in mailchimp in
may i could see
how many users how many sessions and
more importantly how many conversions so
we could certainly hone in on that
particular email if we wanted to
if we choose some of the other
parameters available to us so here i
could see the campaign name okay so i
could see exactly what campaign what
source what email
drove in traffic and conversions and if
i'm doing subject line testing i can
choose content as my parameter so here
i'm going to change it to content and
now i can see the subject lines in this
case if i go back to
my source medium i'm going to be able to
see what subject lines from my emails
generated the most traffic and not only
the most traffic but also conversions so
that's the whole point behind using the
url builder again you're taking a url
that you're going to use in email and
then you're going to pan that url with
different parameters campaign source
campaign medium campaign name and then
optionally campaign content or campaign
term okay once you've entered variables
into those parameters you're going to
get an appended url which you can then
use in your email so when the email gets
sent you're going to go back over to
google analytics and you're going to
look at the results of that campaign of
that source of that medium of that
content ie subject line and so that's
why
the url builder is so important because
mailchimp gives us some good insight
as to how the email performed in terms
of open and click rates but
what we really want to see
is how that campaign performed once it
drove traffic to my website so that's
the whole idea behind the url builder if
you're using google analytics you'll be
able to
use the url builder with whatever email
platform you're using so let's move on
to web analytics tools
and this is an important section because
web analytics tools kind of the central
focal point of all digital marketing and
it starts really with google analytics
google analytics is a freemium meaning
that they have a free version that you
can use there is also a paid version of
google analytics but given the advent of
google its popularity especially in the
united states a majority of users are
using the free version of google
analytics so it's a very popular tool
especially for marketers but there are
also other tools available so it's not
just google so we have adobe analytics
which is also freemium you have kiss
metrics you have spring metrics you have
youtube analytics which is part of
google but
youtube has its own separate analytics
insights so
a lot of these as you can see are free
to use they're available
no reason why you should not be using
an analytics tool to measure your
marketing campaigns or website behavior
and why would we want to use these tools
again well
again we want to really measure behavior
we want to measure what's going on with
our website so we want to be able to
identify the location of where our
website visitors are coming from and a
lot of these analytics tools use
ipaddress to identify the location of a
website visitor so if you're trying to
target a specific country then you want
to be able to see that the visitors to
your website are coming from that
specific country or location we also
want to measure the engagement of our
website behavior so
we get traffic to the website what are
they doing how long are they staying
what pages are they visiting so this is
the overall nature of really why we want
to use web analytics to measure how
successful our website is at treating
our website visitors with the same
courtesy you would if you had a brick
and mortar store somebody comes into
your store you want them to find what
they're looking for quickly you want
them to be happy with their experience
you certainly want them to pay for the
products very quickly and easily and
efficiently and you want them to come
back and that's no different than a
website so we want our website to
perform in a manner that's going to suit
our audience and that's why we want to
track engagement so why else well we
want to really look at who's coming are
they returning visitors or new visitors
you know ideally you want a nice mix
between
50 new and 50 returning because you know
returning visitors are loyal there's
some loyalty to that they already know
your brand they're coming back to your
website new visitors are curious and you
want new visitors because that means
more traffic so you want a nice balance
between that analytics tools will help
you measure that you want to be able to
measure organic traffic whether you like
it or not whether you know it or not but
google and other search engines are
indexing your pages and your pages are
being found via the search engines and
so you want to be able to measure how
much traffic you're actually generating
from those search engines we talked
about this with email marketing utm
tracking so if you set up email
campaigns or non google campaigns you
want to use utm tracking and google
analytics and other analytics tools but
specifically google analytics
will help you
see the results of your campaigns if
they're tracked with utm tracking so
that's another good reason why to use a
web analytics tool probably most
importantly amongst all these bullet
points is our goals our website
conversions we want to be able to see
how much traffic is coming to our
website and not only the engagement of
the traffic but how much of that traffic
is actually doing what we want them to
do i.e are they converting and we want
to optimize our sites and channels
performance so the whole idea of
collecting all this information is that
you can turn around and improve
performance so if your bounce rate is
high well how do you lower bounce rate
well we need to do something about that
and analytics tools will help us
identify what's not working from our
site perspective and from a channel
perspective
and we can take action to improve
performance so that's the whole idea
behind optimizing our site's performance
so let's jump into google analytics and
let's take a look at
everything we just talked about in those
bullet points so about improving website
performance measuring engagement looking
at our goals and conversions measuring
campaigns with utm tracking all those
good things that we can get in a good
analytics tool so adobe
mix panel spring metrics you know they
all work in a similar fashion in that
they're really measuring website
behavior and so if we're in google
analytics really what we're doing is
we're measuring the performance of our
website broken down into four components
audience acquisition behavior and
conversions so
what do we want to do well we want to
look into each one of these sections so
let's start with audience and so
audience and google analytics tells us
who is coming to our website now they're
not going to specifically tell us hey
rob sanders came to your website but
they are going to say that somebody from
san francisco california came to the
website and these are the pages they
looked at and this is the language and
they came from this device
and
they're a returning user so they're
painting a picture for you okay so
they're not giving you a list of names
that would not be legal but
they are
providing you with a good picture of who
is coming and when i say picture we have
to paint that picture and so if we look
at say demographics for example and i go
to demographics overview here's a
picture i'm painting well i can see that
25 to 34 year olds are the majority of
the age group that is coming to my
website okay i can see on the gender
side of it i can see that
63 of my traffic and again this is
year-to-date that i'm looking at is
coming to my website so two-thirds of my
traffic is female one-third male and
they're between the ages of 25 and 34.
so
i'm painting a picture about you know
gender and age coming to my website well
i can also look at geo so where
specifically might these people be
coming from so if i go to location under
geo i'm going to be able to see a
breakdown of country or i can even hone
it down to city
or specific location and here i can see
the united states is the primary driver
but not by much so we have 16 almost 17
percent from the u.s
and then 16 from argentina 13 from
mexico 10 from india so we have a nice
mix of traffic from different locations
in the world coming to our website so
that's geo but more importantly let's
take a look at mobile so if we go to
mobile overview how are people coming to
our website are they on a desktop or
laptop are they using their mobile
device are they using a tablet and so
google analytics breaks it down very
nice for you and so we could see
percentages and actual numbers by device
category and so in this case i can see
year to date i can see 62
are coming from desktop 35
are coming from mobile and so that's
important because most people start
their journey from mobile and that is
growing and that's going to continue to
grow so you want to keep an eye on
mobile so to me this is one of the more
important reports under audience because
people who come from mobile have a
different not only experience because
the website should be responsive to the
mobile device but their mindset is going
to be different they're actively looking
for something they're probably going to
either then follow up on their desktop
or follow up in person at your store or
they're probably looking for directions
or they may just call you so the
experience is a lot different on mobile
so we want to hone in on the growth of
mobile okay so to me this is one of the
more important reports in google
analytics especially under audience so
let's move on to
acquisition so acquisition reporting
tells us how the traffic was driven to
the website so if audience tells us who
is coming to the website acquisition
tells us how that traffic got to the
website and so
really what you want to do is get a
sense of what channels what marketing
channels are driving traffic so remember
we talked about organic search well
those search engines are indexing your
pages well how much of that traffic from
the search engines is actually coming to
your site and i'm a believer in if
organic search is the primary driver of
traffic then you have a pretty healthy
website because that means the search
engines are indexing your pages people
are searching for something related to
your business you're being found you're
getting clicked and that represents a
majority of the traffic so that's always
a good thing so here we could see it
broken down by channel if i go to all
traffic channels report i can see in my
dimension that organic search represents
72 percent of my traffic when this is
year to date then i can see paid search
then i can see direct which means
somebody went directly to the site i
could see referral email
social then i could see more paid search
broken out so these are the different
marketing channels now analytics allows
you to look at a specific source and
medium so the source would be the actual
website or search engine and the medium
would differentiate how that traffic
actually got to the site so if we're
talking about a search engine did they
come to the site via paid search or do
they come to the site via organic search
and so all we need to do is change our
primary dimension from default channel
grouping to source and medium and we can
see specifically the breakout of the
different sources and mediums driving
traffic to the site so here i can see
google organic at 71
and then google
cpc or cost per click at 15 16 of our
traffic so then i can look down i could
see email in here being organic i could
see some referring sites i could see
some social in terms of mobile facebook
okay so
we could see a mix of the different
sources of mediums driving traffic to
the site okay so you don't always have
to look at channel per se you can look
at it via source and medium and if
you're running google ads under
acquisition analytics has a whole
section of google ads reporting so if
you're running campaigns on google ads
remember we looked at the keyword
planner in google ads so if you're
running campaigns on google ads you can
certainly see the performance of those
campaigns just by clicking on campaigns
we can also
see
campaigns other campaigns that we're
running so remember that utm tracking
that we set up for email well we want to
be able to track the performance of
email and any other non-google campaign
with utm tracking so when we do that
we'll be able to go to campaigns
all campaigns and we'll be able to see
the campaign performance if we look at
source and medium we'll be able to see
what campaigns drove traffic to the
website so here i can see
vertical response email as a driver of
traffic so that's the campaign reporting
and then also if you have search
consoles so we looked at search console
earlier we talked about seo tools well
remember i said you can link up search
console with google analytics well
here's search console and we could see
queries devices landing pages countries
so all the performance metrics that we
could see in search console because we
have it linked up with analytics we can
see it right here so this gives us a
nice snapshot
of what keywords are driving traffic to
the site organically i could see the
impressions i could see the clicks then
i could see the click-through rate and
then the average position so in theory
the higher something ranks the more
traffic you're going to get so that's
the idea behind it we want to make sure
that we're ranking for our coveted
keywords and if we are we want to be
able to measure how many times our
listing was seen and how many times it
was clicked so that's the great thing
about you know google they have a family
of products and those products tend to
talk to one another in the form of
google search console and google ads you
can connect them directly to google
analytics so let's move from acquisition
to behavior so here in behavior we have
a number of different reports so
behavior tells us once the traffic
actually arrived at the website how are
they behaving and so
really what i would do is from there go
to site content all pages and so this
gives us an idea of how many pages were
actually viewed so site content all
pages tells us what page and how many
times it was viewed during a period of
time and again we're looking at year to
date so i can see engagement related
metrics associated with a page so this
particular page here on line one i could
see how many pages unique pages which is
equal to sessions
so i can have a session come to the
website and look at a page multiple
times in that session i could see the
average time the person has spent on a
page and i can also see the bounce rate
so a bounce rate indicates that they
arrived on the page and didn't go any
further they left the website from that
page that they arrived on and so i can
also see percentage of exits
meaning what page did people exit the
site from so these are all engagement
related metrics so here is where i want
to react and optimize my website
performance so i if i see a page now
performing well meaning it has a high
bounce rate or maybe low time on page
then i'm probably going to optimize it
meaning test it or change it to improve
performance so these are all pages but i
could certainly look at landing pages
okay so landing pages tells us the
behavior of the page when somebody
landed on it so a landing page means
that somebody came from organic search
or paid search or another channel landed
on this page so here i could see this
particular page on line one had 4
4970 sessions okay and i can also see
the performance of that page so
measuring engagements against pages is
definitely important because page isn't
performing in terms of bounce rate or
time on page then we want to be able to
make changes to that page to improve
performance okay there are some other
great reports under behavior so we want
to go to site speed we want to look at
how
fast or how slow our pages load so this
is important from an seo perspective
because if a page isn't loading very
fast then chances of it getting ranked
in google are not very good so google's
organic search basically takes page load
time seriously so if a page doesn't load
very fast then we need to be able to fix
it so we can go to page timings i can
get a good sense of the average page
load time of a particular page and what
google does here is under speed
suggestions they actually will
give me some ideas and speed suggestions
on how to address a page that's loading
very slow and so
when we load up the speed suggestions
report what google does is say hey we
know that this page is loading very slow
the average page load time is 15 seconds
here's some suggestions we're going to
give you seven suggestions so if you
click on that what's actually going to
happen is you're going to go to another
tool called page speed insights and page
speed insights is analyzing the page as
you can see here and when it's done
analyzing the page it's going to give
you some feedback on how to improve page
load performance not only for desktop
but for mobile so here i can see
if i scroll down this is desktop and
these are some of the opportunities that
i can address
when trying to improve the page load
time of that particular page so here i
could see there's some server response
time issues image sizes probably need to
be resized i can remove unused css okay
so there are a lot of different things i
can do to improve the page load time on
this particular page okay this is for
desktop i can also see mobile
so mobile a lot of the same issues so if
we address these these opportunities
then we could see a lift and page load
time we see lift and page load time
we're going to probably see a lift in
organic rankings or even user engagement
because if a page takes a long time to
load a user is probably not going to
stay on that page very long so to me
site speed is an important report under
behavior now one more report here that i
want to point out under behavior is
events and to me
events are important so if you're trying
to measure engagement on your website
you need to make sure you have event
tracking set up and when we talk about
event tracking we're talking about
measuring things that analytics doesn't
measure by default so if you have a
button on your website if you have a pdf
download if you have a submit button on
a form submission if you have a
subscribe button if you have a video if
you have an external link anything that
is going to trigger engagement on your
website you need to measure with event
tracking and event tracking is simply
set up by breaking out the event into a
category an action and a label and so
here we could see for our particular
website we have categories already set
up for event tracking so here for
example i can see on line six video i
could see how many people actually
watched our video okay so here's the
action video start okay so over this
period of time i could see i had 49
unique events 50 total so that's how
many people actually watched the video
and you can always report to label and
that'll tell you what page people
watched in this case the video so event
tracking is important because we want to
be able to measure engagement so if you
go to events
under behavior and you don't see any
events listed you probably need to get
that set up and that is set up through
google tag manager so what you want to
do is you want to be able to set up your
events through google tag manager which
is another google platform but you
certainly want to do that so that's
where you set up your events when you
set up your events for your website with
a category an action and label you'll be
able to measure those events in
analytics under behavior under events
and the important thing here is you'll
be able to measure engagement so i'll be
able to see how many people came to the
site and how many people clicked on a
button
downloaded a pdf
submitted a form
played a video did whatever we wanted
them to do so events are important so
let's move from behavior to conversions
and this is important because we want to
be able to measure conversions on a
website so analytics has four types of
conversions so if i go to admin down at
the bottom
and then i go to goals i could see that
i have four different types of goals
that i can use now right now
i have event related goals set up for
the website for this particular website
so we just talked about event tracking
so if you're measuring a button click on
your website you can certainly turn that
into a goal and so all you need to do is
tell analytics hey this is the
particular category this is the
particular action so for example if i
click on this particular goal and take a
look at it i can see that we have a
category set up that anything that
resembles donate now okay or donate go
ahead and fire this event as a
conversion okay so event is one type of
goal another type of goal is destination
so somebody goes to a specific page like
a confirmation page we can turn that
into a goal so here i could see if
somebody goes to donation dash
confirmation then analytics is going to
fire that goal as a conversion and we're
going to see a conversion against a
different metric or different dimension
like channel or audience okay so
destination is the second type of goal
the third type of goal
is duration so how long did somebody
stay on my website so in this example if
they stayed at least one minute and 30
seconds or more
then analytics is going to count that as
a goal conversion okay so duration is
the third type and then the fourth type
is pages per session okay so if i look
at this example here
if a user came to my website and looked
at more than three pages in that
particular session then analytics is
going to fire a goal conversion so four
types of goals you don't have to set up
all four different types my
recommendation is at least have one goal
set up if you're not sure what goal to
set up then at least set up a duration
or pages per session okay so at least
you can measure how long somebody stays
on your website or how many pages they
went to okay so when you actually do
have these goals set up you can go back
into conversions we can go back into
goals we can go back into overview and
we can measure our goal completions over
this period of time so here i could see
313 goal completions total with a goal
conversion rate of 1.88
and then i could see it broken down by
goal types so remember the only goals i
have available and set up are event
related goals so 69 newsletter sign ups
156 donate click buttons i have 32
contact form submissions 37 email click
completions and then 11 phone number
click completions so i can measure
engagement as a goal and so goals
generally are important to the business
so you want to make sure that if you
have a goal for your website then you
want to be able to set that up as a goal
in google analytics so that way when
you're looking at example
channels if i go back to my channels
report i can then measure
channel
by goal conversion so these are all
goals but if i want to look at for
example how many people from organic
search clicked on the donate now button
i could see that i could see year to
date 10
887 users which meant 11 000 sessions 76
clicked on that donate now button and
that comes out to 0.65
conversion rate okay so that's important
so you want to be able to measure
any dimension whether that be channel
source medium keyword campaign mobile
device could be demographic
gender or age you want to be able to
measure any dimension against the goals
you have set up so you can measure
performance and that also includes pages
or landing pages as well so that's a
quick overview of what you can expect to
see in google analytics again audience
acquisition behavior and conversions so
a lot of data in google analytics but
you want to be able to take advantage of
the data in order to improve website
performance now let's jump over to
youtube analytics because if you have
videos on youtube if you have a channel
set up some playlists you'll be able to
get some really good insights as to how
your video is performing and so here i
could see
i'm in youtube all i did was i went to
my account then i went to the beta the
studio version of youtube and then from
there i went to analytics so my account
youtube studio analytics and analytics
here is going to give me all sorts of
information about my videos okay so here
i could see over the last 28 days my
videos produced over 8 600 views my
watch time in minutes totaled over 17
and i've netted 48 subscribers and this
is an overall okay so i can actually see
when i publish videos and i can see the
date they were published and here i'm
looking at you know total views over
this particular date range i can also
see specifics on a particular video so i
could see the top video in terms of
minutes here i could see this particular
video had 602 minutes over the last 28
days so here i could see views on a
particular video so this is just an
overview i could certainly look at some
other information if i click on reach
viewers i could see the total impression
so how many times my video was viewed or
how many people looked at it okay and
then the click-through rate so
here i could see the different traffic
sources so 29 came externally okay here
i can see 25 came within youtube itself
i could see how many times a video was
viewed and played via playlist via
suggested videos so i could see
different ways in which the traffic
found my video and actually watched it
here i could see externally how people
were able to find my videos and i could
see 46 percent found it via google
search see some lots of information here
about sources of traffic how the traffic
got to these videos so i could see then
once the traffic found my videos how
many times they actually saw it and
viewed it and then watched it so that's
how many times i was able to reach
viewers via different sources and then
their reaction to that how many times i
saw it and watched it here i can click
on interest viewers so again i could see
the top videos in terms of
watch time i could see the top playlist
so here i could see my partner's
playlist was the top playlist so i can
see some interest here in terms of
average
view duration and then here we have
build an audience so we can look at
specific audiences if we have them built
in youtube to see how many people
actually watch my videos so here i can
see 88 percent of the people who watched
my videos over the last 28 days were not
even subscribed so that tells me a lot
of people are finding my videos spending
some time watching them they're not
subscribed so we're trying to get them
to subscribe to our channel so they can
watch more so a lot of information here
in youtube itself about how our videos
performed again this is good insight
because ideally what you want to do is
you really want to take a look at a
specific video see how it's performing
so if i just click on one particular
video i can actually see the audience
retention over the course of the video
itself i could see the ways in which
people found the video okay again
externally or via youtube search i could
see how many people liked it or disliked
it i could see all sorts of information
on a particular video itself or
an overview of my channel so that's all
available to you in youtube analytics
under youtube studio so take advantage
of that so if you're publishing videos
on a regular basis you wanna hone in on
how your videos are performing so if you
have any additional questions about
youtube analytics or youtube in general
take a look at our video that we created
earlier this year about how to create a
youtube channel we go into some in-depth
insights into youtube itself especially
youtube analytics so take a look at that
video and if you have any other insights
about youtube analytics or analytics in
general go ahead and put a comment below
this video now if you're running google
ads just as we did with rv rentals we
went up there and we saw we typed that
in as a query and we saw how many
advertisers there were for rv rentals
now if we are running our own campaigns
google ads actually has a good report
that i really like it's called auction
insights and so you can get to auction
insights just by clicking on campaigns
and then from campaigns click on auction
insights and what auction insights
allows us to see is what competitors or
domains are bidding on the same keywords
we are and so what google does here is
it allows us to actually see where we
stack up against our competition for all
the keywords we're bidding on and so
here i'm looking at year to date and
here we can see us and i can see our
competitors okay so i could see
impression share so for if we're talking
about one keyword every keyword has a
hundred percent impression share how
much of that impression share are you
getting and when we say impression share
meaning eyeballs when we talk about
eyeballs are we getting a majority of
the eyeballs or our competitors getting
majority of the eyeballs so we can see
our average position
i can see how often i overlap with my
competitors okay i could see how often
i'm above a particular competitor i
could see what percentage i'm at the top
of the page versus my competitors the
absolute top of page rate and then i can
see how often i outrank my competitors
and vice versa how often my competitors
outrank me so i can see
all this good insight as to what
competitors are bidding on the same
keywords i am okay so this is if you're
running google ads okay so if you're
running google ads okay you can just
click on the auction insights report you
can find that the top navigation just by
clicking on campaigns and by doing so
you'll be able to gain some insights as
to where you stack up from a paid search
perspective against your competitors so
let's turn our attention to paid
marketing tools so if you're doing some
advertising on google bing linkedin you
probably want to work within those
platforms as the tool of choice so
you know if you're doing paid search on
say google search dot com or display
you could be doing display advertising
on you know a network like adroll or
google or you could be doing social
media paid ads say on facebook so
whatever it is you're doing you probably
want to work within that platform itself
to get the ideal data that you need okay
so here are some of the tools some of
the places you can go of course if you
work in google ads you also have google
ads editor that you can leverage okay
and i'll show you that in a couple
minutes you have google ads keyword
planner of course both of these are paid
if you're running campaigns okay so bing
if you're running campaigns on bing okay
you get all this good data that you can
digest through some reporting okay you
also have some third-party tools out
there that you also have to pay for in
word stream okay so
wordstream's a third-party tool that you
can leverage bing and google
are actual advertising networks so you
would advertise on the platform itself
and get all the data you need right in
the platform and leverage a lot of the
tools that they have available in the
platform as i mentioned you could also
use google ads editor
so bing also has their own editor as
well so and as well as facebook so you
can use an editor type version and i'll
show you that here in a couple minutes
but let's talk about why we want to use
the tools in the platform itself well we
want to be able to monitor how our ads
performing so which ad receives the most
traffic as an example we want to
identify keywords that are performing
for us okay so our keywords converting
not converting now they cost us a lot of
money and not netting a high enough
return for us so we want to keep an eye
on that because we want to monitor our
cost okay across different locations and
devices not only cost but we want to
also monitor how our ads are performing
across different locations of devices
keywords across different locations and
devices so we want to be able to
measure by device okay so we also want
to analyze competitors data and as we
showed you in the competitors section
google as an example has auction
insights reporting analytics has
benchmarking so
google itself does provide some
information
in the case of auction insights as to
how
your competitors are performing against
you on google search so that's on the
paid search side then you have display
okay so
display advertisements okay you're
across a different network so there are
different types of networks out there
for example admiral okay you know
curtillo celtra is another paid version
of or paid tool you can use in wide
orbit so these are some of the paid
marketing tools you can leverage
of course i like to stay if i'm
advertising on google i like to stay on
google ads and measure my display
performance that way but if you're on ad
roll for example then you want to
leverage adroll's reporting platform and
some of the tools they have to offer so
if we look at display why do we want to
leverage some of these tools well just
like search for example where we want to
look at keyword and ad performance same
kind of concept here we want to be able
to monitor whether we have the right
keywords and right customer engagement
so when when it comes to display we want
to be able to
make sure we're choosing the right
audience of course that means looking at
not only audience insights but our
target insights as well are we reaching
the right audience when it comes to
display and google has a good breakdown
that i'm going to be able to show you
here in a couple minutes okay so we want
to improve our campaigns by monitoring
our competitors display ads as well so
there are tools available that will help
you do that and that's on the display
side and if we look at social okay why
what tools can we use on social well you
got facebook ads manager okay you got ad
espresso quiet tweepy you got all these
cool paid search tools again i usually
stick with where i'm advertising so if
i'm advertising on linkedin or twitter
i'm going to leverage that platform but
just know that there are
other tools available for you so with
social like display it's all about
targeting our audience so for these some
of the tools like on facebook we can
review and relaunch our ad campaigns
based on target audience we can measure
conversions and gain insights
in this example about facebook users how
are our users
interacting with our ads and then we
want to target people based on their
activities such as purchase intent
device usage travel
preferences etc so social allows us to
do that and then with facebook as an
example we can monitor any a b test we
run for example if we're running call to
action test we can measure the results
that write in facebook and i'm going to
show you an example of that here shortly
so let's jump right into google ads and
look at some tools available to us
from the search side of the house so if
we're running search campaigns right in
google ads we could see campaign data we
could see keyword data we could see add
data so for example if i want to see
what ads are performing i'm just going
to click on my ads and extensions okay
and here are my ads and now i can see
what ads are performing in terms of
clicks click-through rates etc and so
that way i can go ahead and pause ads
activate ads so that's right here in
the google ads uh platform itself now if
i want to look at specific keywords i
can do that so i could see what keywords
are driving traffic and clicks here i
could just sort by clicks and now i can
see not only what keywords are driving
clicks i could see
what the click-through rate is i could
see the impressions how many people
actually viewed my ad after click typing
in a keyword query that i'm bidding on i
could see
how much i've paid by keyword and more
importantly i want to be able to see
conversions or conversion rate and then
with google ads you have quality scores
so we want to be able to measure quality
score so
this is a google
ads keyword reporting and so the great
thing about
the keyword reporting is that there's
some other features available to me here
so here i can add negative keywords okay
just by clicking on negative keywords i
can also see a search terms report and
so
when it comes to search terms i can
actually see
what specific keywords people typed in
and based on the keyword that somebody
typed in as a query i can see what match
type triggered that particular ad and so
if i see a keyword query that
i don't particularly care to be shown
for or i want my ad shown for
then i can go ahead and just select it
and i can add it as a negative keyword
okay so that tool is available to you
right in google ads okay and then you
have the auction insight so we've
reviewed the auction insights when we're
looking at competitive analysis and so
here if we look at the auction insights
we'll be able to adjust our date range
and we'll be able to see
basically you know who else is bidding
on the keywords and what the impression
share is what their average position is
what the overlap rate is position above
right top of page absolute top of page
right now ranking share so once we have
google has data then they'll be able to
share that information with you okay so
that's just keywords but there's a cool
tool that i really like and i leverage
it for seo and pay-per-click and that's
google's keyword planner so if you click
on tools and then you click on keyword
planner we'll be able to
leverage the keyword planner and the
whole idea behind the keyword planner is
do we want to discover new keywords or
for the keywords we have selected we can
get volume and forecast on that so here
let's type in a keyword mail delivery
and if i click get started okay so
google's going to give me some other
keyword ideas and they're going to give
me what the average monthly searches are
for that keyword they're going to let me
know the competition they're going to
give me a range in terms of how much i
can expect to pay for that keyword so if
i happen to click on that keyword i can
add it to a plan and then once i've
added to a plan then i can go ahead and
look at that plan and
measure what kind of volume i'm going to
get and how much i can expect to pay so
now once i've added my keyword to that
plan i can go ahead and
see
how many clicks and impressions and
costs and click the rate and average
cost per click i can expect to spend so
and this is based on
a maximum cpc of two dollars so i can go
ahead and adjust my plan accordingly if
i want to in order to see basically how
much i can expect to spend so that's the
whole idea behind the keyword planner in
terms of choosing new keywords and once
you choose keywords you're interested in
bidding on you can actually do a
forecast to see exactly how much you can
expect to spend how many clicks how many
impressions you can expect to get and
if you have conversions set up how many
conversions you can expect to receive so
that's all part of google's keyword plan
that's viewing forecast as well as
choosing keywords so
there are so many
different tools and features within
google ads we need a whole whole segment
just on this so
really i'm just going to highlight some
of the more important tools and features
so i mentioned the keyword planner i
mentioned the campaigns keywords and ads
reports another thing i would look at in
google ads again we mention this as one
of our key defining why would we use it
bullet point and that's because of
devices so we mentioned devices why
would we use google ads reporting tool
because we want to look at devices and
we want to be able to see
what devices are driving traffic from
what campaign
and then the cool thing about
google ads is right in google ads
platform you can go ahead and do a bid
adjustment so if i increase my bid
adjustment for example on mobile phones
then my particular ad in this particular
campaign is going to show more than on
computer so i can always decrease it for
example do a bid adjustment on computer
and that means i'm going to show my ads
less so
i can go ahead and do bit adjustments
based on device that's the cool thing of
working right in google ads platform is
you can make adjustments right here in
the platform based on devices well you
also have locations too so we mentioned
that as one of the reasons why we want
to use some of these tools and
if i see a particular location i'm not
interested in advertising well i can
always select it and i can always just
pause it or remove it so or i can change
the bid adjustment on a location as well
so i can make a lot of different changes
right in the google ads platform for
those seasoned in
search advertising paid search
advertising especially on google ads you
can always use google ads editor all you
need to do is just do a search for
google ads editor you can download it so
basically
what google ads editor is it's a it's a
tool it's the software that you work
your ca with your campaigns on locally
so you're making changes to your
campaigns on your computer and basically
when you're done making changes you can
always
upload them to google ads to the account
on google ads in the cloud so to speak
so that's the whole idea behind google
ads editor it's a great tool for you to
use if you want to make household
changes really quick for example i'm
looking at an account with a bunch of
campaigns so now if i click on one of
those campaigns i can see the ad groups
here okay so for example i just wanted
to turn off all these ad groups i can
just highlight them all and just click
status enable to pause and i can revert
back if i want to okay so you can make
household changes so here i could see
the campaign the ad group level if i
choose an ad group then i can see some
key words and again i can make changes
at nauseum here i can copy i can paste i
can delete okay so i can make a lot of
changes really quick
right in google as editor and that's the
whole point of editor is to go ahead and
work locally while somebody else is
working locally on the same account you
could both be working simultaneously and
being more efficient on getting things
done in the campaign now if you are
working with somebody else on the
campaign you want to make sure that you
get recent changes so if i say get
recent changes to all campaigns
what google editor is going to do is
contact google ads in the cloud and
download all those changes so here i can
see the changes being download in editor
from google ads
and when it's done it's going to
highlight all the changes that have been
made and so
once i'm done reviewing those changes i
can go ahead and click done and now i
know i have the recent latest changes in
editor so now i can go ahead and
continue to make some changes and when
i'm done making changes i can go ahead
and post them so that's the beauty of
google ads editor bing has a version
facebook has a version it allows you to
again go at the keyword level the ad
group level okay you can look at ads
itself and make changes to the ads okay
you could do a lot of different things
right in editor in fact you could do
pretty much most of what you could do in
google ads you can do in google ads
editor and so that's google ads editor
to me i would recommend it if you're
experienced with google ads again it's
software you have to download it you're
going to use it on your computer as
software but when you make changes all
you need to do is post those changes or
get recent changes that have been made
on google ads and so that's google
editor ads editor in summary now let's
go back into google ads and talk about
display advertising because display is a
different network but the platform's
still the same and some of the same
tools are available from the search
network as well as for the display
network right in google ads so if i want
to take a look at a campaign and ad
group on the display network i could
just click on that ad group and i can
look at the ads that are running for
that particular ad group on the display
network so here the difference being on
the display network is you can use image
ads on the search network you can only
use text ads so
here i can look at image ads and i can
see how they're performing in fact you
could even go a step further and use
responsive display ads so google has
responsive display ads meaning it's
going to respond to what's performing
best okay and so now i can see clicks
impressions click-through rate etc right
on
on my ads and extensions report in
google ads platform now this happens to
be retargeting campaign so if we click
on audiences we'll be able to see what
audiences we're targeting here okay so
when this report loads when you run
retargeting campaigns you're targeting a
specific audience and so
we want to be able to see okay of the
audiences we have set up what audience
is performing best okay so here i can
see a breakout by audience again i could
see the same metrics i could see on the
search side i could see clicks
impressions click to rate more
importantly i want to be able to measure
conversions okay so that's the whole
idea when you're in these platforms and
you're paying for ads is you want to be
able to measure against conversions and
you can also measure against cost per
conversion conversion rate okay so those
are some key metrics to measure up
against whether it's audience keyword
ad whatever the dimension is so here on
the display network we can get a sense
of
demographics okay so unlike the search
network the display network allows us to
see demographic data and so now i could
see an age breakout or an age range
breakout that google provides us and i
can see again based on the age range
breakout which age range has the most
clicks impressions etc including
conversions so you also have the
opportunity on the display network to
add keywords you have the opportunity at
topics and you have the opportunity to
see placements or run placements so here
if i click on where ads have shown i can
actually see where my ads have shown up
for this display campaign and google ads
allows you the ability to go ahead and
you can exclude it from the ad group or
exclude a specific placement from a
campaign so you could take action on a
specific placement and i could see the
type of placement whether it's a mobile
app whether it's a site i can go ahead
and
see exactly where that placement was so
that's the
placements report you have demographics
you have audiences you have keywords you
have all these different reports
available to you on the google ads
platform so before we jump over to
social media paid search advertising i
just want to remind you we do have you
know a nice tutorial on google ads okay
so take a look at the google ads
tutorial we have set up on youtube
okay if you search for google ads
tutorial 2019 this is a good uh tutorial
on everything related to google ads so
check out this video because in today's
webinar we're just mentioning tools
across the board and if you are
advertising on google ads as most people
do then you can see just how powerful it
is and all the different features that
are available so take a look at the
video it's a nice complementary video to
this one this digital marketing tools
and
this will give you a nice and deeper
insight into everything that's available
on google ads and if you have any tools
or features on google ads whether it's
the search network or whether that's the
display network then feel free to
comment below this video happy to hear
your comments about what tools and
reports and features you specifically
use in google ads so let's move into uh
facebook ads manager and show you how
the platform looks when you're running
ads on facebook so we can look at all
the different tools and reports
available here so here we could see
if we're in the facebook ads manager we
could see our campaigns we can see our
ad sets and we can see our ads so just
like on google ads you have less side
navigation so we can drill down so if we
want to see ad sets for example we could
just click on ad sets that are showing
up in this particular account and here
we can see we have two ad sets that are
live so if i click on one of these ad
sets i'll be able to see
an actual ad that's running here and so
for the actual ad that's running i can
then see
the results of that ad and how it's
performing for example you know how many
clicks it's received what the reach is
what the impressions are so impressions
similar to google ads how many people
are actually looking at the ad and i can
see the cost per click here at one
dollar as an example and so
now i can go in and i can go ahead and
look at the ad performance and go ahead
and change out that ad if it's not
performing to my expectation so if i
click on more tools and then creatives i
can just simply click on creators and
then i can actually see the create is i
actually have running for that campaign
i selected so now i can see all the
creatives that are running and i can see
the results of those creatives so
facebook ads manager also has uh reap
different reporting so if i click on the
reports pull down menu you can see here
i could see some standard reports by add
ad set age and gender and then i can see
all reports here listed out by placement
by placement and device time of day
country etc so if we just look at age
and gender we'll be able to get a
breakout age and gender here so
you can see by campaign i'm looking at
all campaigns here and i'm looking at
just age and gender i can certainly
deselect one of these and i can look at
a specific time range so now i could see
who's looking at my ad specifically so
here i could see
35 to 44 female i could see the reach
impressions and how often they're
actually seeing my ad now this is key
for facebook because if somebody's seen
your ad
a lot they're probably going to tune out
to it so that's what makes the frequency
metric so important on facebook because
then we can go ahead and
you know turn off that particular age
and gender if we needed to and we could
see how much we spent so this just gives
you some idea of the type of reporting
that's available in facebook ads manager
now the great thing about facebook uh
reporting in ads manager is you know i
can group or ungroup uh my dimensions if
i needed to i could change the view and
arrange columns i can get rid of columns
just as you would in google ads
reporting very similar stature here so i
have a lot of flexibility here on how i
review the reports you know you got
different metrics that you can pick and
choose as well okay and you got lots of
different flexibility when you're
looking at the reports on how your
campaigns are performing now here i can
pick and choose i can choose campaign ad
set ads objective again i can choose
different demographics
so i have a lot of options available to
me in terms of how i want to you know
view the performance of my campaign view
the performance of my ad set or my ad
now remember if you're in facebook you
can always go in and edit the campaign
you can edit the ad set remember in the
ad set that's where a lot of your
decisions are going to be made including
how you want to drive the traffic okay
what your budget is okay you can
basically choose your audience here so
you're going to be able to choose what
type of campaign is going to be and
based on the campaign you're going to go
ahead and choose the kind of audience
you want to focus in on you're going to
be able to choose the location the age
range the gender
so all of this is going to be set up in
the ad set or the campaign or the ad if
you go ahead and edit it out remember
you can do a b testing as well so you
have a lot of different options and
features available to you write in ads
manager when you're managing your paid
search campaigns on facebook so if you
want some more information about
all the different features and tools and
facebook ads manager check out the
facebook ads tutorial
2019 uh webinar that we did earlier this
year in addition you can also look at
another one that we did on facebook
called facebook advertising tips and
strategies so that should give you some
sense of everything related to facebook
ads and how to take advantage of the
facebook ads manager platform so if
there's anything on social that we may
have missed or that you use feel free to
add a comment below the video we'd love
to hear your feedback okay let's talk
about some affiliate marketing tools
let's turn our attention affiliate
marketing
a lot of affiliate marketing platforms
out there
the number one probably is commission
junction also known as cj
they're an affiliate platform they have
a freemium model meaning you can have a
free trial but
basically you're gonna have to move on
and pay for the platform likewise for
house offers you have volume you really
when it comes to affiliate marketing a
lot of platforms out there click inc hey
when so a lot of these are brokers per
se and when i say brokers like for
example with cj
you as a merchant or you as a publisher
can get in touch with a merchant you as
a merchant can get in touch with a
publisher meaning cj helps bridge the
gap between
you finding somebody to build your
network with okay so
that's what really affiliate marketing
is and you really need a platform to
kind of put it all together and
it's a lot a lot of affiliate marketing
platforms we're actually going to take a
look at cj and go through some of the
features in the platform here shortly
but let's just take a look at why we
need these affiliate marketing tools
well these affiliate marketing tools
identify you know affiliates inflowers
employees other advocates you want to
partner with so again you could be on
the merchant side you could be actually
selling a product and you're going to
want somebody to help you sell that
product somebody with a website who's an
influencer who drives a lot of traffic
to their own site who you know does sell
reputable brand etc so
you need somebody to help you introduce
you to these sites okay so cj and some
of these other marketing platforms
affiliate marketing platforms do that
okay so these tools are there to
do the introductions the brokering the
relationship so the other benefit here
is you can contract with affiliates and
track the traffic and conversions well
what do i mean by that well if you do
use cj.com by no means am i only
endorsing that platform there are plenty
others out there but whatever platform
you use you're gonna want to be able to
set up terms and conditions with that
particular affiliate so
you could set up with terms and
conditions for say 10 off all sales as
an example okay well you're getting a
platform that will help you broker that
contract okay contract terms or program
terms furthermore you're gonna need a
platform to help you track hey is this
affiliate helping me drive traffic or is
this affiliate driving traffic to my
products and is this affiliate helping
me sell so
these platforms help you do just that
okay so you can gain high website
rankings with the help of your affiliate
meaning that hey your affiliate can be
promoting your product and if they're
promoting your product you have a chance
to show up via paid search organic
search off other websites so social
so you have a lot of benefits to working
with affiliate marketing in itself and
the tools available will help you gain
website rankings as one example we want
to be able to track certain metrics okay
so an affiliate marketing you have
earnings per click epc as an example
most platforms measure epc from a seven
day period to a three month period okay
you can also figure out what the actual
cost per click is just like you do on
say google search you can actually
measure that in affiliate okay you want
to eliminate fraudulent clicks
impressions and conversions so any
affiliate platform worth its weight is
going to help you understand you know
how many pressions and clicks and
conversions you're getting and help you
manage that in terms of fraudulent
clicks or hey if you're getting a lot of
impressions and no clicks that's a
problem too so
these platforms are really built on
helping you manage your relationship
with the affiliate by offering up all
sorts of reports and tools you know the
other big benefit here to affiliate
marketing tool is hey we can influence
our customers throughout their buying
journey so we could set up different
promotions based on hey did somebody go
to the website did somebody see our
product does somebody click on our
product did somebody go into the
shopping cart with our product did
somebody purchase our product so there's
all sorts of steps in the funnel so to
speak and hey you can work with an
affiliate a publisher to influence your
customers throughout that purchasing
funnel throughout that journey so let's
go ahead and log in here so when you log
in like any other digital marketing tool
any other platform you're gonna have
your own settings and whatnot so really
the whole idea behind any affiliate
marketing tool is really
there to manage your publishers who do
you want as a publisher who do you want
selling your product you obviously want
somebody who's relevant somebody who's
going to be able to sell a product
somebody who has a targeted audience
that's similar to yours okay so we go in
into cj.com we're going to log in and
here you can see a publisher's link so
we're going to click on the publishers
link and remember when you sign up
publishers you have to have program
terms and so if we click on publishers
program terms we're going to be able to
see
all the different program terms
available so here we could see
the different program turns we have set
up for certain publishers so we just
click on that we'll be able to see
that's the default program term so
remember you could set up your own
program term for any publisher so as a
best practice if you have publishers who
are actually performing well who are
selling your products maybe you want to
offer them a little bit more on the
commission side maybe you want to
sweeten the deal maybe
you know these guys these publishers get
better program terms versus say other
publishers who don't and so here we can
see the program terms basically you
could see what the terms are the action
and the different policies here so
everything you need to do to manage that
publisher in terms of payment is done
under the program terms now if the
program terms are met the publisher
actually sells your products cj is the
broker they're the ones who are going to
initiate the payment based on the
program terms so be careful on the
program terms you want to be able to set
them appropriately cj has templates cj
has some default program terms that you
can use and offer up to different
publishers so based on the program terms
that's how your publishers are going to
get paid and so here you can have as
many different program terms as you want
there's no limit here you want to be
able to align and reward program terms
again based on performance and so
here we can see what publishers are
under what program terms so again if
your publishers performing well sweeten
the deal offer them a better program
terms and so you can align publishers
with different program terms and so
that's the whole the idea behind program
terms is you want to be able to align
publishers with that so when you sign up
a publisher they're going to get a line
with a program term meaning what are
they going to get paid for selling your
product now if we want to manage by
status instead of by program terms we
could see all the different
organizations we have in our network
these are our publishers we're the
affiliate we're the ones selling the
product we want to know
who's selling who's not selling and so
we can look at all our publishers by
program terms or by status okay so
basically you can see here the term
status whether it's active or not
earnings basically what they've sold
over the last basically seven days or
three months so you could look at
basically how your publishers are
performing just by clicking on manage by
status here in cg.com so when you're
looking at reports in
cg.com or really any other affiliate
program you might see the acronym epc
this stands for earnings per click
actually it's a little misleading it's
actually earnings per 100 clicks so
basically cj calculates you know how
much your publisher is actually making
per click you know just like paid search
we're paying google x amount per click
it's the same thing here we can't or
these publishers can't make any money if
they don't generate clicks so that's why
you have an epc model or metric so to
speak so you can measure earnings per
click cj does it over seven day period
and over a three month period so you
could sort based on seven day or three
months to see who's earning the most per
click in terms of publishers now you can
select under publishers groups now you
can group your publishers okay so if you
have say a group of publishers in a
specific region like the united states
or india or if you're just focused on
the united states and say you have
publishers in different states like
texas california missouri arkansas well
you can group those publishers into
different groups and you can look at
your different group names here so here
we could see canada and so we have our
publishers grouped into
a group called canada why because
they're based in canada makes sense so
you want to be able to organize your
publishers because the whole idea behind
affiliate marketing cj is you want to be
able to get the best publishers
available for your network and so as you
get more publishers for your network
you'll be able to
basically start grouping them where it
makes sense now the example i gave you
is by geography you could do by
geography or
you could do by publisher status meaning
my best performing publishers go into a
group if they're in a group then they
get aligned with a certain program term
so you could group your publishers any
way you want by status meaning they're
selling more these are our best
performing publishers or by region or
you know by promotion i mean how you
group your publishers is totally up to
you however take advantage of the option
to create publisher groups because the
whole idea again
i'm going to repeat it is you want to
get
publishers you want to start building
your base of publishers because the more
publishers you have the more chance you
are to sell your product remember if
nobody clicks on your product then
nobody's going to buy your product so if
you have publishers who are promoting
your product for you then you have a
good opportunity to sell it so the more
publishers you have on board the better
the opportunity so now once you have
publishers you can start grouping these
publishers accordingly to whatever makes
sense it's a business decision just know
the options available in cj to group
publishers let's turn our attention to
social media marketing tools social
media always a great topic to talk about
so we're going to finish up all our
digital marketing tools with social
media we talked about seo paid
competition affiliate email you know web
analytics it's just appropriate to
finish up the social media because
social media has so many tools available
so many okay the first one i can think
about here is hootsuite hootsuite is a
great social media marketing tool to use
okay it's a freemium okay you can set up
a free trial here you
basically a base account and then uh you
can use hootsuite to do a lot of things
anything from setting up landing pages
to actually publishing content to
listening hootsuite to me is one of the
most powerful social media marketing
tools available you got buffer buffers a
paid version but you can actually set up
a low cost or free account actually on
buffer and then move to a paid account
okay you got
it's been around a long time that is
actually free and i would recommend
tweetdeck and we're gonna take a look at
that here in a couple minutes okay and
then you got sprout social sprout social
is another social marketing platform
similar to hootsuite do a lot of
reporting a lot of publishing you can a
lot of listening and so we're going to
take a look at sprout chelsea today as
well before we do that let's go over why
these tools are important to us from a
social media perspective you're pumping
out a lot of content so you need to be
able to
smartly efficiently you know schedule
and manage your post okay so you're not
just working likely with just one
platform like facebook you're probably
on a number of different platforms
depending on your business depending on
your bandwidth depending on what you're
selling your products etc your audience
obviously has a lot to do with it you
know it could be instagram pinterest you
want to be able to consolidate all that
and manage it in one place and that's
what social media marketing tools do
they allow you to manage everything in
one place so if you can manage
everything in one place then these
social media marketing platforms need to
be able to make it easy for you to add
and manage different accounts okay so a
lot of them have the ability for you to
add you know not just one twitter
account but multiple twitter accounts
and not just one social media platform
but multiple social media platforms and
a good social media marketing so worth
its weight will help you monitor the
results so monitor social media posts
that help drive leads and sales in other
words you're going to have a lot of
different metrics associated with each
social media marketing platform okay
which one is actually doing its job okay
so you want to be able to easily manage
these platforms applications and
websites very efficiently okay so
instead of having to log into each
platform is log into one place get a
sense of what's been posted what the
engagement is did they purchase etc and
what you want to do is be able to
individually customize every social
media post across different platforms so
it just makes it a lot easier to do that
in the social media marketing tools okay
you don't want to send out a blanket
message across different platforms you
want to be able to
go ahead and customize a post depending
on what that post is depending on what
the product is what time of day what
target market what target audience so
customization is a lot easier using
these social media marketing tools you
want to be able to engage with brand
advocates so listening is a good thing
with social media marketing tools using
the listening functionality so you can
actually see who is a brand advocate
who's not a brand advocate who's an
influencer who's not an influencer and
then of course you want to analyze the
behavior of your audience and optimize
individual post on real time data so if
for example you post something using one
of these social media marketing
platforms and you see it go viral then
you want to be able to react to that in
real time so you're going to be able to
see that in real time on these social
media marketing tools these platforms
like sprout social and hootsuite and
then you're going to be able to react to
that behavior and then of course
monitoring website traffic and
conversion rates that's key we always
want to monitor conversions based on our
kpis our business goals
so there are also a few important
digital marketing tools that can help
you in different ways okay so without
further ado let's jump in and take a
look at what's available in terms of
social media marketing so just a quick
reminder if you are
running
ads on facebook or you're posting on
facebook as an example or any platform
in general that platform's going to have
its own metrics if you will so for
example facebook has something called
facebook inside so you'll be able to
actually see you know what's been posted
based on you know the last seven days in
this example how many page views you're
getting engagements
recent posts so just to let you know
yes you can go into any one of these
platforms on its own and look at metrics
just like you can do if you're running
facebook ads okay you can go right into
facebook ads manager and view data there
okay so the whole point here though on
using a social media tool is that you
can measure all that in one place so if
we log into sprout social i can set up
these accounts right into sprout social
so i don't have to log in on twitter
individually or facebook individually i
can link them up all within sprout
social and then i can go to reports just
like i can with facebook insights and
then once i'm in facebook excuse me once
i'm in sprout social reporting then i
can go ahead just like i can in facebook
insights except it's all right here for
me i can jump into you know facebook and
dig a little bit deeper as to what's
going on with my account so i don't have
to log into facebook directly i can see
you know the impressions the engagement
the clicks over a period of time i can
see my audience growth i can see my
publishing behavior how often my
publishing i could see the top post
individually i could see impressions by
day you know a lot of this same
material same information is already in
facebook insights so if it's available
on facebook insights you know you're
definitely going to have it available in
a tool like sprout social so you want to
be able to just efficiently log in and
jump from one platform to the other so
here you know i can go to instagram you
know and look at instagram data or i can
look at twitter information so you want
to be able to efficiently jump from one
platform to the other using in this
example sprout social now as i mentioned
as part of one of the benefits of a
social media tool is that you can
publish content you want to be able to
publish content because you want to be
able to organize and schedule
accordingly you don't want to be
submitting and publishing content right
after one another okay you want to be
able to spread it out efficiently and
effectively and so here we could see you
know we could publish and schedule
content accordingly so all we have to do
is click compose select a profile
write whatever we need to do you can
schedule it for tomorrow at a specific
time and there you go voila scheduled so
this is on twitter okay so you know we
could choose another platform here it's
just that easy to schedule so
you want to be able to schedule
accordingly because again when you
schedule something then you want to look
at the behavior of it so it's just as
simple as going from publishing to
reporting and then based on when
something got published you could see
the reaction of it and react to it so
another thing here that i like about
it's about social hootsuite a lot of
these other platforms do it really well
you got listening tools so you can
listen in on conversations that are
being had for example
uh mail delivery you know if we do mail
delivery and twitter search we'll be
able to see what's been tweeted about
mail deliveries you know if that's the
business we're in we can refine our
search and choose a specific location a
radius to hone in if we're local okay so
this is sprout social's example of
listening here let's take a look at
another example i'm in later.com so
later very similar sprout social and
that it does a lot of the same things
you can actually schedule content on a
particular platform and one thing i like
about later here you can actually see it
visually you can see a calendar and
what's been scheduled so i could see
today i have scheduled something
scheduled at 1 15 local time and again i
have five profiles set up for this
account so i can pick and choose the
profile that i want to publish to so it
just makes it that much easier and i can
visually see it and that's important so
here i can click on media library so the
one thing about later.com is that you
know you have a library of images that
potentially you can reuse so if i click
on this image here okay i can get a
sense of when it was used and i can view
it on a calendar i can add label for it
so
that's another benefit to later is that
they have this media library here they
have conversations so i can actually
connect to a platform and listen in on
conversations that are being had similar
to the listening tool in sprout social
and they have analytics so you can
actually see
write in later.com how your particular
social media platform is performing so i
could see it here over seven days i can
see the number of followers have
increased i can see the growth rate i
can see the number of impressions that
i've received okay so i want to be able
to see how my particular platform is
performing over a period of time so i
can look at reach a lot profile views
website clicks okay so i can get a lot
of good insights here right in the
analytics platform later you can look at
specific post performance so we posted
something i could see basically how many
likes it received how many comments
impressions the reach and then if i
wanted to i can click on details and get
more specific information on it
engagement rate okay discovery actions
comments saves etc so later.com goes
into some nice detail about post
performance they even have date on
hashtags so if you use an hashtag you
can actually see how many times the
hashtags been used or saved how many
impressions it's received okay so they
really go into some nice detail here
about how your post and how your
accounts are performing and here's a
tool i really like i've been using for a
long time and that's tweetdeck so what
tweetdeck does is connect with your
twitter account so you can see in a
different visual so to speak of how your
twitter account looks in terms of your
feed here i can see this is my feed here
okay i can see some notifications i can
see specific messages then on this
column i can see activity okay so i can
add different columns here if i wanted
to and basically by adding columns you
can see i can look for what's trending
as an example so i'm going to add in a
column that says trending and so now i
can go in and see okay these are all the
different
things that are trending on twitter
so you can actually add a column and pay
attention to something really specific
okay so for example search okay so right
now i have men's health but i could type
in let's just say world cup okay so i
can see the you got the cricut world cup
you got you know the soccer football
world cup going on so you know we could
pick a particular topic to follow if we
wanted to so again here i'm following
men's health so i can now see
you know everything that's been posted
on men's health now if i click on for
example one of these hashtags here
that's trending i can actually see who's
tagging or using that hashtag friday
feeling in their tweets and so the whole
idea behind you know tweet deck it
serves up a interesting overview so to
speak of not only your account but you
know a specific topic or what's trending
or
you know other things that are being
said so if you really want to pay
attention to your brand or something
really specific like you know your
competitors or a specific product then
you can just do a search on that and so
that's the great thing about tweak deck
it allows you to kind of just look and
listen in on everything going on in
twitter now we do have a good video out
here on youtube how to start social
media marketing so if you haven't had a
chance to look at it take a look it goes
over some of these tools that we cover
today like sprout social later.com you
know facebook insights so it does cover
in more detail some of what we covered
on these social media marketing tools so
take a look at how to start social media
marketing so we covered a lot of
different marketing tools digital
marketing tools everything from seo to
email to social to paid to affiliate to
competitor but there's also a few
other digital marketing tools that you
can use in different ways like video seo
for example so vid iq you know we want
to use vid iq to get a good sense of how
particular video is performing so here
if we go into youtube
you can see vid iq is a browser
extension or browser a plug-in if you
will
so i can go and take a look at a
specific specific video and see how many
hours it's been watched how many views
minutes watch subscribers etc you know
the great thing here i can look at the
entire entire account so
i can get good insights into
my video or my entire account here just
by adding in the vid iq extension into
my chrome browser so vid iq actually
does give you some really really good
insights into not only your account but
the video and so recommend vid iq
because it's good for video seo okay
there's also tools related to
content optimization so
you know if you're doing seo and you
have a lot of content on your site well
you know what we want to be able to use
a tool
maybe a third-party tool to give some
objective reasoning as to what more we
can be doing so you got tools like seo
site checkup or site analyzer these are
pay tools but you know if you're really
heavily invested in seo then they may
pay dividends for you you want to be
able to make sure your content is fully
optimized to the fullest according to
you know google's algorithms and so you
maybe you know want to invest in that
third-party tool so these are good tools
to use for content optimization you know
there's also other key reddit but you
know there's keyboard planner uh in
google there's also a word stream
there's a lot of different keyword tools
out there so you may not have a google
ads platform and so if you don't have
google ads then you may not be able to
gain access to google's keyword planner
so having a third party keyword tool
will pay dividends as well because those
dividends pay off in the form of not
only pay-per-click but also seo and if
you're heavily invested in content
heavily invested in social then you may
want to take a look at the keyword tool
keyword it and it's primarily used for
reddit we talk about page load time so
we looked at that in google analytics we
know that it heavily impacts seo so
there are other tools available you got
a third-party tool here that's free
solarwinds pingdom you actually have
page speed insights by google so these
are free tools that you could take
advantage of in determining how you can
improve your page load time my favorite
topic conversion rate optimization so
you got a couple in here crazy egg and
target okay so i'm going to show you
another tool called hot jar so here if
you log into hotjar.com you can set up
an account it's actually free and with
the free account you can have hotjar
measure the heat map not only the heat
map but the click mapping the scrolling
of a particular page and so here you can
see we're looking at a particular page
here so hotjar allows me to
you know see on that page where people
are clicking um i can also see where
people are moving i can also see
you know the scrolling of a particular
page okay so
you can see here on the page i can see
people are moving over here to the right
that's where they're clicking mostly if
i switch over to move mode then i can
see on that particular page where people
are actually moving their mouse and then
i have my scroll analysis so i could see
you know how far down people actually
scroll on the page and so again with a
paid account you can measure up to ten
thousand page views with the free
version you can measure up to two
thousand pages and so two thousand page
views allows you to get some insight as
to what people are clicking on or where
they're moving or how they're scrolling
on a particular page and so i definitely
recommend hot jar they also do funneling
they also do forms polls lots of other
tools available in hotjar so hotjar.com
is a tool i would recommend as well
so one final tool and i'd be remiss if i
didn't mention it and that's google
optimized so google optimize is a google
platform that allows you to a b test and
so a b testing means that you have an
original page and you're changing one
element on that page to see which one
performs better and so with google
optimize it's just very easy to set up
to run and the whole point of google
optimize and a b testing is to improve
website performance so here you can see
i have an account set up and optimized
you can see we're running one test here
and we're just testing one element
versus the original so we move photos to
the top of the page the original didn't
have the photos to the top of the page
and so we can go into reporting here
google optimize does all the heavy
lifting and so here you can see
we can look at bounces or we can look at
you know basically a measure the test up
against the metric that's important to
our business and again the whole point
is to improve website performance and so
definitely take a look at google
optimize we'll have another webinar in
the future on the topic but you know to
me google optimize is free you can run
up to five tests okay and if you can run
up to five different tests and that
means you have the ability to really
improve website performance okay so
google optimize is a tool that i would
recommend today we're going to talk
about why you would want to rank using
seo and seo is search engine
optimization also known as organic
search you also may as hear us say
organic listings we're going to talk a
little bit about why you'd want to rank
your website in organic search okay what
is search engine optimization then we're
going to follow that up with how does
google rank websites so
why does it rank one website over
another and how do we get our website to
rank number one then we're going to talk
about the different types of seo or
search engine optimization techniques so
you can get your website ranked number
one and then we're gonna finish that off
with the do's and don'ts of seo so let's
get right to it and talk about why seo
so we're gonna use a basic example and
let's just say you have a blog you're a
food blogger you're passionate about
food and your niche is ice cream and
let's just say you have a lot of ice
cream recipes you want to get traffic to
your blog you want people to read your
blog and you're curious why am i not
ranking for my blog
why when people type in ice cream
recipes and say google my blog posts
don't appear at the top of organic
rankings and there's a number of reasons
why you wouldn't be ranked for your blog
post or your ice cream recipes and the
main reason would be your competitors so
there could be somebody else out there
who is also passionate about ice cream
and has been blogging a long longer than
you when they have more content and more
blog posts and more pages for google to
rank so that's usually the number one
reason the other reason is improper
usage of keywords and we're going to
talk a little bit or it's actually a lot
more about you know keyword usage in
your content so
what kind of keywords do you want to
rank for that's really what we're
talking about when we talk about usage
of keywords what keywords do you want to
rank for and how do we work those
keywords into the content another reason
is port link building practices and
really that means our other blog posts
or other websites linking to you also
are you linking to other pages on your
website and so it's all about link
building and with link building it's
internal linking so are we linking from
one blog post to another and it's
external linking are other websites of
high quality linking to us and so that's
what we talk about when we talk about
link building and then another reason is
web page load time so
you could be running your blog post on
say wordpress for example and
your blog post isn't loading fast enough
well if you look at it this way think
about it if you're google would you
really want to rank a website or blog
post in this example number one on
google rankings if that particular page
loaded very slow no you wouldn't because
when somebody clicked on that link in
organic search and went to your website
they're going to have a bad experience
because the page is going to load slow
so google doesn't want their users to
have a bad experience you don't want
your users to have a bad experience and
so that's why web page load time is a
critical factor for ranking so we need
to make sure that our web pages load
fast and then your user experience is
not good enough so
google again based on my example about
the web page load time google wants
people to have a good experience when
they go from their search engine to your
website and there's a lot at play there
specifically web page load time but also
you know google doesn't want any spam
content google doesn't want any pop-ups
or overbearing ads on the webpage they
want people who are searching for
something in particular let's just say
ice cream recipes and they want to find
a relevant website that has ice cream
recipes they want to be able to click on
that link and read some good content
about ice cream recipes it's that simple
and that's really what google's trying
to create in their environment and
that's you as an end user as a website
owner you want your users to have a good
experience and then last but not least
your website is the indexed by mistake
and really what we mean is the indexed
is google needs to be able to index all
the pages on your website so if you have
a blog with a hundred recipes you want
google to have access to all 100 recipes
so we're going to talk a little bit
later about how to get your pages ranked
or indexed on google organic search so
let's move on to what is seo so sticking
with our ice cleaning blog theme really
seo search engine optimization really is
the practice of increasing your pages
that google has indexed up the rankings
so the end result is we want all our
pages to be ranked number one for
particular keywords so if you want to be
ranked for ice cream recipes well
there's certain things you need to do so
that's generally how it works we need to
apply search engine optimization to
increase a page for keyword we want to
be found for so let me give you an
example so let's just say there's a
hundred students that participated in an
essay competition and so the competition
in this particular case is evaluated on
the basis of is the content relevant are
they using suitable titles for their
essay do they have structure when
they're participating in this essay or
talking about the essay and do they have
a suitable synopsis and is the content
neat and readable these seem all logical
for an essay competition well guess what
they seem logical for seo because that's
exactly how seo works it's exactly all
those points i just made mention about
structure logic readability organization
title all those things are what's
important in seo and so we need relevant
content we need titles for our pages
google needs to be able to see structure
we need to have synopsis of what the
page is about and that's called the meta
description and then again the content
needs to be readable and that's
important and so in order to be readable
again we're going to talk more about
site speed because site speed's
important okay and when we talk about
responsive design when i say responsive
design that means your site your page
needs a load both on desktop and also on
mobile and so all these things are
important just like an essay competition
google is the judge and they need to be
able to determine what page is best to
rank number one number two number three
etc on google search and then link
building remember i mentioned link
building a moment ago well link building
internally and externally also plays a
vital role and so we're going to talk
about that a little bit later in the
class when we talk about off-page seo
how does google rank websites and
basically google follows three basic
steps to rank a website they need to
crawl your website they need to take
what they call back to their servers and
when they take it back to their servers
your your web pages they need to
you have them available for indexing so
when somebody actually types in a
keyword into google.com it'll be
available to be found on organic search
so that's what indexing is all about and
then google's job when somebody does
type in a search query is to basically
rank the those pages that they've
indexed from number one to infinity
depending on how many pages are relevant
to that search query so really it's
about crawling indexing and ranking so
crawling is simply a process done by
which google has bots and what these
bots do is they go to your web server
and they're going to crawl every page
that they can find and how do they find
these pages well they basically follow
links you might have heard the term
spydering but that's what they call
search engine spidering so basically
what google's doing is they're building
a web so to speak all the links that
they're following and so when they can
follow all these links on your website
they're gonna be able to crawl them and
when they crawl them basically they're
going to take that content and store it
on their servers so it's available in
their index so based on this method
google finds out which websites have
relevant content and which ones don't
based on certain keywords that are typed
into google because if they can't crawl
your website you're not going to be
found and if you can't be found they're
not going to show up for relevant
keywords so we need to make sure your
site's available to be crawled and we'll
talk about that a little bit later okay
but let's show you an example so let's
just go to google search and if i type
in the keyword simply learn okay i could
see i have 1 million 10 000 results okay
and that's how many results are showing
up for simply learn okay now they may
not all be simply learned pages but
nonetheless simply learned is ranked
number one here organically and there
are 1 million 10 000 pages related to
the keyword simply learn now when it
comes to organic search we don't want to
get it confused with paid search so
anytime you see paid search you're going
to see something that says add next to
it okay so we could see that there are
paid ads here but when it comes to
organic search those are generally below
paid ads and so that's where google
counts the 1 million 10 000 results and
so that's the whole idea behind crawling
and indexing google is able to cross
simply learn's website and based on all
the pages that they gather they're going
to make those pages available in organic
search so if you type in a keyword and
your web page is not available for
indexing then you're never going to show
up for that keyword so that's why it's
important to make sure your website is
available for crawling and indexing and
so when a user types a query on search
google search the most relevant websites
that are in google's index are going
appear in the search results so in the
example i gave
was simply learn well simply learn is
the brand name of the company simply
learn so there's a lot of relevancy
there so that's why you see simply learn
show up here organically number one like
we mentioned about what is seo and why
seo we talked about that user experience
so there's a lot of factors that go into
ranking relevancy being one of them so
in the simply learn example simply learn
is relevant to a lot of the simply
learned pages because that's who they
are simply learn however
simply learn also needs to make sure
that you know for their pages the page
load time is fast meaning these pages
load very fast for the end user and
google also takes into account other
factors like how long someone is staying
on a website or are they bouncing
meaning are they going to one page that
they land on and then leaving the
website okay and so the user experience
is very very important there are other
factors also like language and location
and so for example location if you do a
search say in india the results are
going to be a little bit different than
say the results in the united states why
because google is indexing as many web
pages as they can find so if somebody's
doing a search in india
their results may be a little bit
different than the results show up in
the us because google has different bots
and these bots are crawling different
pages at different times and so google's
index is updating continuously but it's
not real time syncing so if you do a
search in india you may not see exactly
the same thing because both search
engines the google and india and the
google in the us are may not be exactly
synced up so an example would be you
know if you're looking for cafe so if
you search a cafe and say san francisco
you're going to see different results
now if you do a search for cafes in
mumbai you're going to see different
results there's going to be local search
here at the top there may be some paid
search but again you may see
different results because one location
but two google search engines in india
and united states google.com aren't
exactly synced up exactly at the same
exact time you do that search so
location is important language is
important and relevancy is important
along with user experience so all those
are important factors in how google
ranks websites okay so we're going to
talk about the types of seo now so if we
want to rank for a particular keyword on
google we're going to have to apply
search engine optimization and so
there's two strategies to search engine
optimization
on-page seo and off-page seo so first
we're going to talk about on-page seo so
on-page seo is nothing more than
optimizing your own website and so when
we say optimizing your own website
there's certain elements on your website
and on your web pages that we need to
take into account and so some of those
elements are headers meta descriptions
title tags linking so all of those
elements are something we can control as
an end user who wants to rank our web
page and our website on google and
before we do anything with our website
the first thing we need to do is
understand what keywords we want to rank
for in order to understand what keywords
we want to rank for we need to do
keyword research and if you do anything
in seo keyword research is the most
important activity that's the most
important thing you can do for seo and
why do i say it's the most important
because you need to understand if you
choose a keyword that you want to rank
for you need to understand how much
traffic you're going to get from that
keyword if you're ranked organically say
number one on google so how much traffic
will you get if you're ranked number one
on google so you need to understand what
the volume is and then number two we
need to understand what the competition
is for that keyword that you want to
rank for so if you choose a keyword and
there's not much competition for it then
chances are you can rank for that
keyword for a web page on your website
quicker than say a keyword that has a
lot of competition so we need to
understand those two basic factors
volume and competition before we choose
a keyword and it's it's simply the
practice of going through the motions of
getting your volume and getting your
competition data so you can choose the
keywords you want and then once you
choose the keywords you want then you
can go and apply on page seo you can
change the title tag the meta
descriptions the headers all those
elements can be changed but first you
need to choose your keywords and so
again the primary components we're
looking for are how much traffic you can
get or the search volume how much
competition there is for that keyword
and of course relevancy okay you need to
be able to choose a keyword that's
relevant to the web page you're trying
to rank for and so let me show you
example how to go through this so the
first thing we want to do is we want to
use a tool and the tool i would
recommend is google keyword planner and
why do i choose google keyword planner
because if we're trying to rank on
google.com or google search engine we
want to be able to get the data right
from the source so google is going to be
able to give us information about how
much volume a keyword has and how much
competition it has so let me show you an
example so if i want to use google's
keyword planner and i want to rank for
the keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist then i'm going to
type that keyword into google's keyword
planner and what google's going to do is
they're going to give me some trends
about how much volume this particular
keyword gets over the course of a year
and so for that particular keyword i can
see
that
there are trends that that appear for
both desktop and mobile so mobile is
important because people start their
search process a lot of times on their
mobile device so we want to be able to
get data from mobile as well as desktop
and so we could see a trend here that
for each particular month over the last
12 months we can see how much volume
this particular keyword how to become a
digital marketing specialist gets per
month and so on average on average over
the past 12 months i could see how to
become a digital marketing specialist is
averages 30 searches a month and this is
on google.com and so google gives us the
volume what they also give us is the
competition and so here i can see google
says for that particular keyword the
competition is medium and so in the
google's keyword planner what they also
do is give me other relevant keywords
that i might think about optimizing for
because you don't want to optimize for
just one keyword so how to become a
digital marketing specialist they're
going to also offer up other types of
keywords that are relevant so just
digital marketing specialist social
media marketing specialist so for those
keywords i can see the volume so for
example digital marketing specialist i
can see the average volume is 1000 per
month on average of the last 12 months i
can also see the competition is medium
but for some other keywords i can see
the search volume being high like
digital marketing course at 2 900 per
month but also the competition is high
and so what i would recommend as a best
practice is to collect all your relevant
keywords okay and put all your relevant
keywords in a spreadsheet and when you
put all these relevant keywords in a
spreadsheet you want to get the data on
those keywords and the data i'm
referring to is the volume and
competition so in this case we have
volume from google planner google's
keyword planner and i have competition
from google's keyword planner and so if
i go into a spreadsheet and i put all
that information in here i'm going to be
able to see the volume and competition
and so that's important however one
thing to note here is that google's
keyword planner if we go back just gives
us low medium and high and if i want to
compare numbers to numbers maybe i want
to be able to get exactly the
competition number for the keyword how
to become a digital marketing specialist
what i can do is go into google and i
can type in that keyword so if i type in
the keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist i can see there's
76 million results so i could see 76
million results 76.1 actually and for
the keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist now that's a whole
lot of results for this particular
keyword especially when the volume is
only 30 uh per month on average and so
what i want to do is get a more clear
picture of the competition and so what
you could actually do is type in the
syntax all in title and then colon and
then your keyword how to become a
digital marketing specialist and when i
do that i get a different result here i
can see only 136
listings for how to become a digital
marketing specialist but that's not just
136 that's 136 with that particular
keyword that we want to rank for
in the title tag okay so the title tag
is what you see when you type in a
keyword or search query in google search
and the title tag is what you see at the
top of every search result and so now i
can see i typed in how to become a
digital marketing specialist with the
all in title syntax and now i can see
every listing every one of these
136 results have that particular keyword
in it so i could see every one of them
how to become a digital marketing
specialist and why is that important
because now that tells me i only need to
climb over
136 listings to rank for that keyword
how to become a digital marketing
specialist and so the idea here is you
want to get your volume from google's
keyword planner but you want to get your
competition from google search and again
that's simply typing in the the syntax
all in title and then your keyword in
this example how to become a digital
marketing specialist once you get those
two numbers you're going to plug them in
to your spreadsheet and then once you do
that for number of different keyword
queries and these keyword queries again
have to be relevant once you do that
then you can go in and pick the keywords
you want to optimize for and that's
important because again if you're not
sure about a keyword then you want to do
the keyword research so you can be sure
of how much traffic you can get and how
much competition there is those are two
important three important factors in
starting the process for on-page seo so
again you want to
create content for
say a keyword like digital marketing
but digital marketing may seem a little
bit broad so you want to probably stay
away from broader keywords because
broader keywords tend to have a lot of
volume which is great but they may also
tend to have a lot of competition but
that's the whole point of doing the
keyword research maybe it doesn't maybe
there's more volume than competition
that's what you need to find out when
you do the keyword research you need to
find those keywords that are relevant to
your content that have a lot of volume
and low competition and then once we
identify those keywords then we are free
to go in and start optimizing our web
pages for those keywords and the first
place we want to start is the title tag
so if you remember my example going back
here to our search how to become a
digital marketing specialist we saw that
every one of these listings had that
keyword in the title tag and the title
tag is important because that's what
users who use google search see first
when they type in a query and get
results so they're going to see the
title tag so the title tag is the most
important element for on-page seo it's
the most important factor because that's
what people see and so ideally when we
choose our keyword we want to make sure
that keyword is in the title tag because
that's what shows up in google search
and that's what makes that particular
web page relevant for that keyword query
so the idea behind a title tag it's
between 50 and 60 characters and so we
want to make sure we stay within that
limit no more than 60 characters because
what happens if it's beyond that then
google will truncate the title tag so if
i go back to my search you can see here
on this particular title tag google
truncated it meaning they added the
ellipses after the title tag because it
exceeded the 60 character limit so you
want to stay within those character
counts and so the title tag is the first
place you should start when optimizing
your website because when we have the
right keyword
in the title tag and somebody types in
that keyword then chances are it's going
to be relevant they're going to see it
and they're going to click through to
your website and that's the whole idea
behind ranking we want to get clicks so
that's how the title tag appears so when
you optimize it you're going to update
the title tag and this is how it shows
up it's going to show up at the top of
your listing okay and it's going to be
bigger and bolder than anything else
google displays so the second thing you
want to optimize is the meta description
and the meta description is simply just
a brief description up to
155 i would say about 155 to 60 160
characters but probably no more than
that and so the meta description is
nothing more than a summary of the web
page itself so if i go back to my google
search results i see my title tag and i
see the page that this particular
listing belongs to and underneath that
is where i can see my meta description
so in this particular keyword query how
to become a digital marketing specialist
i see the meta description an ultimate
guide on how to build a career in
digital marketing and the skills
required to become a digital marketing
specialist note that it's a well-written
meta description within 155 characters
and it includes the keyword digital
marketing specialist so we're trying to
rank for how to become a digital
marketing specialist and here you can
see become a digital marketing
specialist so there's a lot of relevancy
between not only the title tag and the
keyword but the meta description and the
keyword so when you're optimizing a
keyword you want to start with the title
tag but you also want to update the meta
description because if you don't update
the meta description and you leave the
meta description blank then you're
leaving it to google to add in copy that
they deem relevant and so for on-page
seo we want to take control of the copy
and we want to optimize it for the
keywords we want to be found for so the
meta description is a powerful tool at
our disposal it gives us more characters
to work with it gives us more to talk
about so for that particular page and so
if the title tag is only 60 characters
maximum it's not a lot of information to
try and get somebody to click so the
meta description helps us in identifying
what that page is about in order to get
the click so the two working in tandem
will hopefully increase your
click-through rates so when you're found
organically we want to get the click and
then the third element that's important
is the url and url stands for uniform
resource locator and why is the url so
important because that's what people see
so if i go back to my search result how
to become a digital marketing specialist
notice that the url also includes how to
become a digital marketing specialist
article okay so it's very relevant the
url is very relevant one we can see it
in the search results but two you know
it's relevant to the keyword query and
that's important for the end user and
google google wants to know hey is this
the page that's relevant to the user's
query and if it is then this user is
likely going to have a good x user
experience after they click on the
listing so the url is an element that
helps not only with the click-through
rate but with ranking and having a poor
url structure doesn't help at all
because not only does google not
recognize the url as being relevant but
the end user
may not want to click on that page given
the the way the url looks so you want to
try and avoid a poor url structure so
the rule of thumb is this if you don't
understand what the url is then google
is likely not going to understand what
the url is and so we want to try and
keep our url structures clean and when i
say clean ideally you want to make sure
that whatever keyword you're trying to
optimize that's the keyword that's
included in the url nothing included
that is not understandable so again
going back to our example how to become
a digital marketing specialist it's very
clean the title tag is the keyword the
meta description is cleanly written has
the keyword and then the url is the
other element that the end user can see
and that url includes the keyword in it
so after we've done those three elements
the title tag the meta description and
the url then we want to start optimizing
the page itself so ideally when we say
optimize the page itself the page
remember needs to be structured and when
we say structured it needs to be
structured in terms of you know headers
and subheaders and organized in a manner
in which the end user can read the
article read the content clearly and
concisely without being confused and so
that's the job of headers they add they
add basically an organizational
structure to the content and with
headers there's a hierarchy so you have
anywhere from h1 which is the top of the
hierarchy to an h6 and so you're free to
use any one of those headers when
building on a page in order to organize
the content but ideally you probably
want to stick with an h1 or an h2
because those are at the top of the
hierarchy and what those do is they
actually stress to google that hey
this header with this particular keyword
in it is important so if you use an h6
with the keyword in it it's telling
google hey this is an h6 but it's not as
important so an h1 and an h2 tag show
importance and so let's look at an
example of what that is so here you can
see an h1 is going to be at the top of
the hierarchy so that means it's going
to be bigger and bolder then you have an
h2 which is going to be bigger and
bolder than an h3 but not as big and
bold as an h2 so with headers not only
are you organizing the content
accordingly but you're also signaling to
google how important that particular
header is and of course the header needs
to include the keyword we're trying to
rank for so let's take a look again at
that example so if we go to how to
become a digital marketing specialist if
i click on that page i can look at the
content and i can see that there are
headers in here so the headers are there
to organize the content and that's what
we want we want to be able to organize
the content and if you look at the other
example i'm showing here how to become a
digital marketing specialist a learning
path explored you can see that's an h1
but below it's a subheader the growing
digital marketing job market so that's
an h2 and so we're not stressing to
google that that's more important than
an h1 but nonetheless we're stressing at
google that it's important nonetheless
so we want to be able to use headers we
want to be able to use keywords in our
headers in order to stress to google
what's important and also to organize
the content because google likes content
organized okay the next element we want
to focus on is internal linking and so
internal linking if you remember
earlier in the presentation it's
basically links from one page on your
website to another and so here we can
see on this particular article how to
become a digital marketing specialist
there's also links to other pages on
simply learn's website and so for this
particular content it also links to seo
specialist ppc specialist social media
marketing specialist and digital
marketing specialist so the whole idea
behind internal linking is to link from
one page to another where it's relevant
and in this case it's relevant because
we're talking about how to become a
digital marketing specialist that's what
the whole content is about and so what
simply learns doing here is offering up
other pages on their website that are
relevant to becoming a digital marketing
specialist and so this is a best
practice when you're optimizing a web
page so you want to be able to
have internal linking
on your site and the whole idea behind
internal linking is it also allows users
to navigate through the site naturally
so when i say naturally they don't
always have to refer back to the top
navigation they can naturally and
seamlessly go from one relevant article
or page to another and so that's the
whole idea behind link building and
internal link building it allows google
to identify
you know pages that they want to crawl
and index because they're linked to one
another but it also helps the end user
because it allows the end user to go
from one page to another and it's
signaling to google hey this particular
page is linked to this page so we're
going to also index that page and so
that's the whole important part of
internal linking it's about the end user
experience and it's about allowing
google to find the pages on your website
so they can crawl them and index them so
you can be ranked for them and so also
in addition to
internal linking we want to be able to
use natural language and so what do i
mean by natural language or natural
language processing so what google does
is in terms of natural language
processing they're looking for the
content and the keyword it needs to be
relevant so when your website is about
digital marketing you don't necessarily
want to rank or try to rank for the
keyword digital marketing one it's too
broad two there might be some
competition but three you're probably
not going to write something as broad
like digital marketing so ideally what
you want to do is you want to choose
other relevant related keywords that's
going to be more natural and so that's
what we mean on natural language
processing we want to choose keywords
that are more natural to the content
you're writing so instead of the keyword
digital marketing maybe we want to talk
about the types of digital marketing or
digital marketing examples or what is a
digital marketing strategy or how to
become a digital marketing specialist so
those are all relevant keywords to
digital marketing and more relevant to
the content because if you try to rank
for the keyword digital marketing again
it's probably going to be a little bit
broad probably more competition and not
as relevant to your content and as a
result probably not a good user
experience so think about some other
keywords that you could optimize and
rank for and that goes back to the
keyword research that's why the keyword
research is so important because it
allows us to identify
other keywords and the natural language
process what keywords are more relevant
for the content and then another element
on page seo is the sitemap and so with
the sitemap it's basically a list of all
the pages on your website
and the whole idea of listing all the
pages on your website in one document is
it helps both users and search engines
understand the structure of your website
so there do two types of site maps one's
an html sitemap and that's designed for
humans so if you have a website with a
lot of content at the footer or the
bottom of your web page you probably
want to have a link to sitemap so if
somebody clicks on that site map they're
going to be able to see all the pages on
your website structured in an organized
manner well an xml sitemap in xml is
just a different format it's designed
for crawlers and so the whole idea
remember is google likes to crawl
content when they crawl content they
bring it back to their servers and index
it and so we want to be able to create a
sitemap for google or other search
engine crawlers and so xml is the format
so let me show you example of how that
looks so if i go to simplylearn.com
and simply type in say sitemap.xml
just as an example i'm going to get this
particular page in this particular page
displays two xml sitemaps so these site
maps are there for google to go ahead
and crawl and nothing more than a list
of all the pages on your website and so
this is a quick and easy way for google
to get a hold of all those pages so that
they can index them and that's the whole
idea behind seo you want to be able to
have google index all the content you
want to be found for for the keywords
you want to be found for so it all
starts with the site map so let's go
from on-page seo which in recap is
basically optimizing certain elements on
your website so that you are relevant
for a particular keyword and that meant
updating the title tag the meta
description the url the headers choosing
the right keywords to put into the
content having internal linking and also
updating the sitemap well those are
elements that you can do on your website
so we're going to switch gears and talk
about a different strategy off-page seo
because without on page or off page you
can't have a page ranking so the two
work together so you can do as much as
you want on on page but you still need
off page seo and you can do all the off
page seo you want but you still need on
page so both of these strategies have to
be in full effect in order for you to
rank so let's now switch gears to
off-page seo and so off-page seo is
simply the process of linking or
promoting your website using link
building and so if you remember i talked
about this earlier on there's two types
of links internal and external linking
and so for on-page seo we used internal
linking for off-page seo we're going to
talk about external linking and external
linking allows us to improve our
website's recognition or relevancy or
credibility and why do we want to
improve our relevancy and credibility
and trustworthiness and authority
because we want google to know that our
web page is trustworthy it is recognized
by other websites and it is relevant for
a particular keyword and so if we can do
that using off-page seo methods then
google's going to rank our web page for
the keyword we want to be found for so
it's really off-page seo synonymous with
link building and there's plenty of
opportunities to do link building it
just comes down to creating a strategy
so again some of the benefits to off
page well we talked about you know being
credible and trustworthiness and
relevant we need to do that in order to
rank but there's some other benefits
there so if we have a link on another
credible website then it's likely going
to increase the traffic to our own
website it also creates high domain
authority and so what i mean by high
domain authority is if we have basically
links to other web pages pointing back
to us then basically our domain
authority is going to improve and when
our domain authority improves other
websites are going to want to link to us
so the higher authoritative we are for
our website then other web pages are
going to want to link to us and so the
more external linking we have the higher
the domain authority so it all starts
with linking to
other high domain authority websites so
linking to a high domain authority
website for example having a link on
wikipedia that points back to our web
page creates high domain authority for
us and it helps drive traffic so some of
the other benefits of off page seo are
credibility so if we're linking from
wikipedia to our web page it does create
credibility for us it also helps us
increase our page rank so remember that
external linking helps build domain
authority helps build credibility
trustworthiness and it's going to in
turn help us rank for that particular
page and then certainly not last having
a good off-page seo link building
strategy increases our brand awareness
because if we're on other high
authority websites wikipedia or say a
social platform it's going to increase
our brand awareness and increasing our
brand awareness increases our
trustworthiness and so if somebody is
looking to say become a digital
marketing specialist then likely instead
of typing in digital marketing
specialists on google they may type in
our brand name in this case simply learn
and so these are all the benefits to
off-page seo so it's nothing more than
having links on other websites that are
pointing back to ours and again there's
lots of benefits it's drives helps drive
traffic and increases our authority so
those are things that we want to take
advantage of when we want to rank and
the key behind off-page seo or link
building is always going to be content
so from an on-page seo perspective
having quality content allows that
content to be optimized for relevant
keyword and ranked but also from an
off-page seo strategy having
high-quality content allows us to have
other sites and it doesn't necessarily
have to be a website it could be a
social platform or can be another
blogging platform or blogging website
linked back to ours why because the
content is original it's natural it's
well structured it reads well and so
that's the whole idea behind off page
you can't have links on other websites
if you don't have quality content so one
of the ideas behind off page seo is not
only do you want to create good content
but you probably want to
spend a lot of time or a bit of time on
others websites so remember the example
i used earlier in this presentation
about having an ice cream blog and ice
cream recipes well it probably wouldn't
be a bad idea to say spend some time on
other blogs related to desserts related
to cakes related to food in general
related to vegetables or other items
that people could link from so the whole
idea is understanding who else is out
there who has relevant content that you
could share so you could share your
content with them they can share their
content with you and generally that's
how it works naturally anyway in the web
sphere if somebody likes your content
they're going to link to it they don't
necessarily have to wait for you to ask
them but it might not be a bad idea to
understand who else is out there that
has content similar to yours so that you
can you know get a link on that
particular website or blog post and so
some other ideas behind
having external links pointing back to
your website is social media so social
media is not just facebook or twitter
but it expands beyond that there's
there's core there's medium there's all
sorts of content generated websites like
reddit so the list goes on and on you
just need to find what's relevant for
your content if it's relevant for your
content then it's worth putting or
trying to get the external link on that
social media platform and then again
going back to my ice cream blog recipes
blog post yeah if you find a particular
blog that you want to have an external
link on there's nothing wrong with
reaching out to that particular blogger
you know in some cases very flattering
but in other cases if the content is
relevant then why not it's only going to
help your end user experience if you add
somebody who has a say a blog about
cakes having their link on your blog
post so there's nothing wrong with it
because it also adds to the user
experience and if you're going to ask
somebody to put an external link on
theirs you might want to be open-minded
and make sure that you're are able and
willing to put an external link on your
blog post or website pointing to their
content that's how the web works
especially if the contents are quality
relevant and of good nature okay so
let's move on and finish up with the
do's and don'ts of seo so we talked a
lot about
why seo what is seo you know how do we
rank for seo
what is on page seo what is off page seo
and so
let's just wrap up with some of the
things you again want to do to rank your
page for a particular keyword and some
of the things you don't want to do so
the first thing on the list is optimize
for white hat techniques and what i mean
for
opting in for white hat techniques is
basically everything i just mentioned
today you want to do keyword research
you want to choose a natural language
processing form format so you could
choose keywords that are going to be
relevant natural to the content and you
don't want to opt for black cat
techniques and blad hat techniques are
probably not even worth going into
detail but one example is choosing a
keyword arbitrarily like say digital
marketing and just stuffing that keyword
into the content so that's probably not
something you want to do because again
it's not going to be good for the end
user so stay away from black hat and
focus on some of the techniques we
talked about in today's presentation the
other do we want to do is get backlinks
from relevant sites so that's off-page
seo again it's what i mentioned earlier
it's about linking your quality content
to another person's website that also
has quality content we don't want to
have a backlink from an irrelevant site
why because it's not going to be
relevant and it's also going to hurt our
authority because if it's on a site
that's not of good quality then google
is going to look at us and say well this
site is linking to your site but it's
not relevant so therefore
you know we're not going to look at you
in the same way as if you were on a
quality website we do want to use our
keywords naturally because title tags
are what people see first on organic
search but you don't want to use the
same title tag on every page of your
website so we want to stay away from
doing that so you want to have a unique
title tag
for every web page on your website and
ideally what does that mean that means
using our keyword research to choose one
or two keywords for page and optimizing
your web page for those one to two
keywords so you ideally what you want to
do is have one or two different keywords
for every page on your website we
definitely definitely definitely want to
write engaging content so the content
should be engaging remember user
experience we want users to stay on our
website we want them to enjoy the
content that they're reading and we want
them to go from one page to another
naturally we definitely don't want to
leverage or plagiarize or just copy
content from others websites because
it's not one probably going to be
relevant to what you're writing about
two it's duplicate content and it's
somebody else's so that's a black cat
technique we want to stay away from i
can't emphasize this enough we need to
do keyword research first before you do
anything else you need to find relevant
keywords and not only that you need to
understand the volume and the
competition for each of those keywords
okay you don't want to choose a keyword
that has low volume high competition you
want to choose a keyword that has high
volume low competition but above all you
want to choose keywords that are
relevant to your content we want to
avoid keyword stuffing so don't take a
keyword and just stuff it everywhere on
the page it's not going to be natural
and google's going to be able to pick up
on that so we want to maintain some
level of quality with our content and
quality with the keywords that we choose
so reminder when you have quality
content it's always going to link
internally to another page on your
website with quality content but it's
got to be natural and don't just build
site-wide backlinks meaning don't just
have an internal link to the home page
or don't have every page on your website
linking to just one page so internal
linking should be natural
naturally linking from one page to
another not only does it help google
understand and crawl all the web pages
on your website but it's good for the
end user it's good user experience and
certainly last but something i didn't
talk about does take time to rank your
content so remember the process you're
going to write your content you're going
to choose keywords you're going to
change the elements on that page for
those keywords and all the while you're
going to make sure google can crawl that
content and when they crawl they're
going to index it the process takes time
especially if you choose a keyword
that's competitive so just be patient if
you have quality content and you've
optimized for on-page seo and off-page
seo then you will rank for that keyword
and then make sure your website's user
friendly and mobile friendly so we
talked about responsive content earlier
so remember most users today start the
process of search on mobile so we want
to make sure your websites are mobile
friendly search engine optimization
starts with the keyword because we want
to be found for relevant keywords and so
the first step
and search engine optimization is always
going to be keyword research so it is
the most important step and so what is
keyword research all about well it's a
process of identifying keywords we want
to be found for on the search engines so
millions of people use search engines on
a daily basis we want to be found for
those keywords that people type in that
are relevant to the content we want to
be found so going back to the italian
restaurant example if we're writing a
blog post about italian restaurants if
somebody types in the best italian
restaurants or italian restaurants in a
specific city we want to be found for
that content if it's relevant to what we
wrote about so keyword research should
be done based on two factors really it's
based on the factor of how much traffic
or volume a particular search engine
query has and it's based on competition
and really
the underlying factor here is that all
keywords in your keyword research should
be relevant so you need to understand
what those keywords are so are they
relevant to the content that you want to
be found for if they are then really the
two factors you want to look for is the
volume how much volume or traffic each
keyword has associated with it and then
the competition how many other websites
are trying to be found for the same
keyword so those are the factors
involved with keyword research you
always want to choose relevant keywords
and then once you find or choose those
relevant keywords you want to be able to
find out exactly how much volume and how
much competitions associated with each
of those keywords and so when you look
at keywords you're always going to
choose relevant keywords but there are
two types of keywords there are short
tail keywords and there are long tail
keywords and we're going to talk about
both of these here so let's start with
short tail keywords so short tail
keywords are generic keywords generally
they're less than three words in a
keyword phrase for example italian
restaurants so
short tail keywords generally have very
high search volume that means that if
somebody types in italian restaurants
then there's going to be a large amount
of volume with that meaning that
generally a lot of people type in the
keyword italian restaurants however with
high volume always comes high
competition so
if you want to be found for italian
restaurants know that if you are ranked
number one or number two or even on page
one of google you're going to get a lot
of traffic however to get to page one of
google or even position one or two it's
going to take you a while because there
are probably a lot of websites who are
in front of you who want to be ranked
and found for the same keyword so the
whole idea with short tail keywords is
it's a lot of visibility it's a lot of
traffic a lot of volume but also a lot
of competition and generally the
underlying factor here is that if you
are ranked for very broad or short tail
keyword like italian restaurants then
chances are it's not going to be as
relevant so if you get the traffic to
your website then chances are the
conversion's not necessarily going to
happen because we don't necessarily know
the mindset of somebody typing in a very
short tail generic keyword like italian
restaurants they could be doing research
on italian restaurants they could be a
chef who's trying to get recipes for
italian food it could be a tourist
looking for italian restaurants in a
different city or it could be a person
just looking for italian restaurants
near their location or where they're
living and so there's a lot of different
factors with short tail keywords so you
just don't know because it's so generic
and because it's so generic if you do
get the traffic for that generic keyword
then the chances of the conversion are
going to be lower than say if it's a
more specific relevant keyword so let's
take an example
of a short tail keyword let's just stick
with italian restaurants so i'm going to
go to
a tool
called moz and well moz has a tool
called the keyword explorer and within
moz so if you go to moz.com and then use
their keyword explorer you can get an
idea of how much volume and competition
are associated with a particular keyword
so in this example we're using italian
restaurants it's a very broad keyword we
could see that the monthly volume
is between 70 000 and 118 000 per month
okay so that means for a particular
keyword in the united states on a search
engine you're going to get about 70 000
to 118 000 people who type in that
keyword and so if we were to look at the
difficulty of that keyword you could see
that it's fairly difficult because out
of one to 100 it's got to score 43 so
it's fairly difficult however if you
notice the click-through rate is very
high so moz estimates that we'll have a
organic click-through rate for that
keyword if we're ranked for it so
if it's relevant to us and we want to
get some visibility to our site then
yeah we want to use that generic short
tail keyword however if we're interested
in conversions then we really want to
turn our attention to longer tail
keywords however if you want the
visibility then you want to use short
tail keywords if you want the conversion
then you want to switch over to longer
tail keywords so longer tail keywords
are more specific they usually consist
of more than three keywords so italian
restaurants very generic if we add a few
more keywords that keyword phrase it
then becomes longer tail so compared to
short tail keywords longer tail keywords
are generally less competitive and the
search volume is not as high case in
point so if we go back to moz and then
we look at the keyword explorer and we'd
actually type in italian restaurants and
let's just say orlando florida
moz is going to
generate some monthly volume for us and
they're going to allow us to understand
how difficult that keyword is and so
here you could see very very little
search volume in fact so little volume
there's 11 to 50 okay so that means on
average that this keyword generates 11
to 50 queries a month so very low
compared to our short tail keyword
italian restaurants the difficulty here
didn't necessarily lessen but it is less
uh competitive so if you're interested
in conversions and you have an italian
restaurant and say orlando florida then
this is the key word you may want to use
so there's a trade-off between longer
tail and
shorter tail but when visitors land from
longer tail keywords they're usually
ready to make a purchase they're usually
more specific intent there's more intent
involved with a longer tail keyword so
best restaurants in a time in florida
branded shoes in florida something very
specific is going to generate probably a
higher conversion rate than something
more generic so that's the trade-off and
so when to use long tail keywords well
we want to use long tail keywords if
we're targeting pages with a product or
specific article so if we're interested
in that particular conversion then
longer tail keywords are likely more the
way we want to go versus something more
generic which means if you're using a
generic shorter tail keyword you're more
interested in the visibility and the
traffic not necessarily the conversion
how does a search engine work so let's
talk about that for a minute so we know
that millions of people use search
engines we know that we want to be found
on search engines but how do we actually
get our content in the search engine so
that's the important part that we need
to understand if we have our own website
we have our content so these search
engines want your content in their
search engine index so how do they get
your content well they send out bots or
files and we'll just call them spiders
so they send out these spiders to crawl
your website and the whole idea behind
using the insect spider is because we're
talking about the world wide web and so
if google for example sends a bot to
your website they're going to crawl your
website and spider your website they're
creating a web of pages so all they're
doing is following link and every page
and link that they hit they're going to
bring back to their server so these
spiders scan your websites they just
follow links and they take all the pages
and content that they're able to gather
when they hit your website and they're
going to pull all that information back
into their own index so if you think
about google they're crawling or
spidering millions and billions of
websites all those millions and millions
of websites are sitting on google
servers so when somebody does do a
search query google because they have
all these websites in their index are
able to quickly determine which website
is the most relevant for that search
engine query so that's generally how
search engines work so let's talk about
the types of seo so if we want our
website to be found on these search
engines and google or the search engines
have crawled our website then what we
want to do is we want to basically look
at it from a two-pronged perspective
it's a two-pronged strategy so the first
strategy we're going to talk about today
is on-page seo so those are on-page seos
defined as what we do on our website to
be relevant for search engine query on a
search engine so again on-page seo is
what we do to our own website off-page
seo is the other the second part of that
seo strategy and off page seo determines
what we do off our website to be
relevant for search engine query and so
off page seo generally is synonymous
with link building and we'll talk about
that a little bit more as we go forward
but really when you want to do seo when
you want to be found for
a keyword on a search engine you're
going to have to apply both on-page seo
and off-page seo so let's talk about
on-page seo
and so this is the first part of our seo
effort we want to focus on on-page seo
first and so on page seo is the method
of optimizing elements of web pages
remember these are all the items we want
to do on our website to be relevant for
certain search queries so it's basically
the idea behind this is to make our web
pages more relevant for specific search
queries on search engines and so there
are a number of different elements on
our website on a particular web page
that we want to
manipulate or optimize if you will to be
relevant for search engine query and so
let's start around the idea that you
know you there's a number of things you
can do so let's start with schema first
and so schema is nothing more than it's
a collaborative effort between bing
yahoo baidu google and the idea is
really they want to understand more
about the content of your website and so
the idea behind this is that you want to
be able to provide snippets of
information to these search engines so
they understand a little bit more about
what your web page is trying to portray
or convey so that they can find out
exactly what's relevant to that search
engine query so it's nothing more than
micro data or bits of information that
you can add to your website or web page
in order to provide a little bit more
enhanced information to the search
engines so if you think about it's
collaborating with the search engine so
the more basic information you share
with the search engines the better off
they have to understand what your web
page or website is all about and so the
more information they have the better of
an opportunity you have to be ranked for
that search engine query and so if you
have a website with reviews if you have
a website with images if you have let's
say a website with products with prices
in other words you have an e-commerce
website and you're trying to sell
products well to me you want to employ
schema because again schema is snippets
of information that are provided to the
search engine so they can better
understand so
you can certainly provide snippets of
information in the terms of images or
prices or particular products and how
much is left in stock so all this
information these bits of information
you can provide to the search engine so
that they can better understand what it
is you're trying to sell how much it
cost how much is in inventory what
people think about the product etc so if
you have a website that sell products
you probably want to employ schema and
so when you do employee schema again
snippets of information provided to the
search engines the search engines are
going to better understand and then
they're going to present that
information in the search engine results
so if you have ratings and reviews you
can provide snippets of information to
the search engines the search engines in
turn are going to present that
information in the search engine results
so if you have positive reviews then
somebody typing in in this example shoes
they're going to be able to see that you
have positive reviews for your website
so that's the whole idea behind schema
is to provide snippets of information so
again it's not just related to reviews
also for images so if you have images
you can provide snippets of information
to the search engine so they can see you
know what the shoe actually looks like
when they type in in this example puma
shoes or like i mentioned inventory
snippets of information about your
inventory the search engines are going
to provide that information search
engine results so if somebody's looking
for women's training shoes or women's
puma shoes and they see your product and
they see how this is in stock great let
me go to this website and purchase these
shoes so that's the whole idea behind
schema is making sure you present
information
critical to your website so that the
search engines better understand what
your website's about it also helps with
relevancy because the more the search
engines know about your website the more
relevant your website becomes and the
better chance you have to rank for a
particular keyword there's also some
other information here involved with
schema and those are site links so site
links additional pages on your website
okay that show up in the search engine
result and so again the more information
a search engine has about you the better
chance you have to be found the better
chance you have to get a click so site
links are just additional links on your
site that appear in search engine
results and that's all a benefactor of
having schema so here you can see in
this example we have additional web
pages that show under a certain search
engine result and so by having more
links in the search engine results you
have a better chance of getting the
click so if you want more information
about schema i would recommend going to
schema.org so when you go to schema.org
you can actually click on a link that
allows you to see all the information
you need to get started with schema.org
okay so it's got a lot of information
available to you it describes what it is
you have to do in order to
get your information
and
set for the search engines to better
understand focus on for on-page seo is
title tag and so title tag is what shows
up in the search engine results so if
you've ever done a search engine query
meaning you've gone to google typed in a
query using a keyword like italian
restaurants you're gonna see specific
search engine results and the title tag
is what appears in those search engine
results so a title tag is important
because it's the title of a web page
that appears in those results and so the
title tag is something that's important
because if we want to be found for a
specific keyword we want to make sure
that keyword is in the title tag because
that keyword is going to describe what
the page is all about and so if we want
to be found for that keyword let's just
say italian restaurants in florida for
example that's going to be part of our
title tag so when somebody types in that
particular keyword query italian
restaurants in florida then we have a
good chance of showing up because the
title tag which is the title of the page
is going to have that particular query
in it and so you can edit the title tag
and when you edit the title tag you want
to be able to put that particular
keyword in the title tag so if we do a
search on google for example so if i go
to google.com and i type in italian
restaurants in florida
here i can see under the local search
results and here i can see italian
restaurants in florida central florida
italian restaurants and miami so you can
see that these are highlighted so the
title tag is not only stands out but
allows you to
you know showcase exactly what your page
is all about and it helps with the
relevancy of that keyword query so when
you're trying to optimize your website
using the title tag for specific keyword
you want to keep in mind a couple
parameters because title tags show up in
the search engine results but
certain search engines particularly
google has character limits around the
number of characters you can use in the
title tag and so we want to keep that in
mind so
ideally we want to format our title tag
appropriately and so to me the most
optimal way to optimize a title tag
using a particular keyword that you want
to be found for is to use that keyword
in the title tag and then separate that
with your brand name so if you actually
have two keywords then you can use the
primary keyword first then the secondary
keyword and then the brand name so to me
this is the most optimal format but keep
in mind there are character limits but
if you look at this format to me it's
the most easiest format to abide by
because it makes your title tag more
relevant you don't have to worry about
necessarily fitting in excess keywords
in the title tag because again the title
tag is character limits so if we take a
look at our example in google search
results if you go over those limits and
the title tag is generally between 60
and 65 characters long and so if you go
over those limits let's just say your
title tag is more than 65 characters
google in this case is going to cut off
the characters and so here you can see
the ellipses after the title tag now if
you follow the format that you know we
at simply learn recommend you could see
if our keyword is italian restaurants in
florida and then separated by the brand
name this gives you an optimal format
for the title tag it also makes it
relevant for the keyword query so you
want to keep that title tag probably no
more than 60 characters because if you
flirt with putting more than 60
characters then the search engines are
going to cut off that title tag and then
that's not going to look good and it's
going to also become less relevant so we
want to keep the character counts in
mind so if you abide by that format of
the keyword and then maybe the secondary
keyword if you have one separated by the
brand name then you should be good to go
with making sure your title tag is
relevant for that keyword query so let's
then turn our attention to the meta
description so the meta description is
just a short description about the
content on your web page so if the title
tag is the title of the web page the
meta description describes the page okay
so it's a description about what that
page is so the meta description appears
under the title tag and then the url so
if we go back to our google search
results we look here
italian restaurants in florida
maggiano's little italy is the brand or
the restaurant we could see the url
which is underneath the title tag and
then here we could see the meta
description and so with the meta
description you have a little bit more
room to work with in terms of character
count but the meta description just like
the title tag is just as important
because one it shows up in the search
engine results two it describes what the
page is all about and three it allows
you to optimize the meta description so
the meta description becomes more
relevant for that search query that
somebody types into that particular
search engine so the optimal length for
a meta description you can go up to 300
characters but i would not even
recommend even flirting with that limit
because just like the title tag search
engines in the case of google will
actually cut off the meta description so
if we look here back at our search
results if you go over those limits
you'll see that the search engines will
cut off the copy of the meta description
with and they'll just put ellipses so we
don't necessarily want to
go over those limits so my
recommendation is to keep that meta
description probably 165
characters to no more than 200 because
we're trying to
describe not only what the page is all
about but we're also trying to optimize
that meta description so it becomes
relevant for the search engine query and
so you want to keep it short and concise
so if we look at our example here
italian restaurants in florida
maggiano's does a good job it's a book
an event space make a reservation at
maggiano's in florida to enjoy delicious
view maps menus and more so
very concise meta description it
includes their keyword query that they
want to be found for italian restaurants
in florida and so to me it's short and
concise describes what the page is all
about and
uh
allows them to fit it all in within the
character limits so here in this example
we want to be found for amazon puma
shoes so the brand here is amazon so
amazon wants to include puma shoes not
only in the title tag but they want to
try and fit that into the meta
description however the whole idea
behind the meta description more than
anything else is describe what the page
is all about okay you want to be
relevant for the search engine query but
you also want to sound natural as well
you want to be able to
really the whole idea between the title
tag and amount of description is to get
people to click on your link because
remember there are nine other listings
on the google search engine results page
for page one so we want our meta
description and our title tag to stand
out so we want it to be relevant but we
want it to stand out so it's important
you write that meta description
according to what the page is all about
but you want it to stand out uniquely
and accordingly so once you've done the
title tag and the meta description you
want to focus your attention on the
header tag and so header tags are used
on a web page to really separate out
content and so you have headers and sub
headers and so ideally you want to be
able to optimize the header tag and the
subheader and so if we think about
headers there's a hierarchy for headers
so there's between a header one and a
header six and so we'll just shorten the
word header and we'll call it an h1 so
h1 is really at the top of the hierarchy
for headers and so if we use a h1 on our
web page then what we're trying to
explain to the search engines is listen
this particular keyword phrase in our
header is is a header and we're emphasis
we're trying to emphasize what it is
we're trying to say and that's how
really the search engines interpret
headers they see an h1 h2 h3 h4 h5 and
h6 they know that if you're using an h1
you're trying to really emphasize
something so if you put that keyword in
the header tag what you're telling the
search engines is hey i'm really
emphasizing this particular keyword and
so the search engine will interpret that
as important and if you use your keyword
in that header then really what you're
saying is hey i really this keyword is
really relevant to that query so
naturally the other benefit of a header
is it really breaks up the page as well
so
the header you can use subheaders and
subheaders are nothing more than say a
lower h tag so if you have a header
that's an h1 you can use an h2 and h3 as
a subheader and so forth and so on
because what you're really trying to do
is not only organize the content on your
webpage but you're trying to emphasize
that for google so if something's an h2
or an h6 you're basically telling google
or the other search engines this is not
as important as say in h1 so if we take
a look at our example that we've been
using for italian restaurants in florida
and if we click on magianas we could see
that they're using headers so if we
click on maggiano's we could see that
this is a header here we want to bring
everyone together at maggiano's italian
restaurant in florida so they're using
that header to break up the text here
you can see they're using another header
here excellent italian food and an
excellent experience to match so that's
a header to break up the content okay
they're not using subheaders they're
used using headers but that's fine
they're really trying to emphasize the
content by putting in that header and so
headers help not only organize the
content but they help emphasize the
actual keyword it is you want google to
recognize so if we're not sure if
something is a header we could simply
just mouse over what we think is a
header and we can just right click and
if you right click on something you're
going to see a menu and if we click
inspect element then basically what that
browser in this case firefox is going to
do is show us the html of that
particular thing of that item that we
right clicked so here we could see in
this particular case this is an h2 tag
so it's an h2 so if we scroll down and
we mouse over this we could see this is
also an h2 as well so this particular
page is using h2 tags not h1 but in h2
so what they're explaining or trying to
convey to the search engines is listen
this is an h2 it's still
relevant we're still trying to put
emphasis on it but not as much so we
want to be able to use our h1s and our
h2s accordingly so remember in h1 is
you're providing the search engines with
information by telling them hey this is
the most relevant this is we're putting
emphasis on this keyword and h2 nuts as
much as an h1 and an h3 not as much as
an h2 so use your headers accordingly
not only just to break up the text not
only for styling but for emphasis for
the search engines so headers are very
important elements for on-page seo okay
let's turn our attention to the url
structure okay so url stands for uniform
resource locator and so our url is the
specific location of a web page on the
internet so basically if we're found in
the search engine results one of our web
pages are going to go along with the
title tag and the meta description in
the search engine results page so if i
go back to our search engine results for
italian restaurants in florida we could
see that the particular url in question
here is locations.maggianos.com
florida so that's the url that shows up
along with the title tag in the meta
description so if we click on that link
that's exactly where we're going to go
so url structure is important for
on-page seo so why is it important
because not only does it show people
where they're going but we have an
opportunity to
optimize that url for the search engines
to make our url more relevant for that
search query so just like the title tag
just like the meta description just like
the headers we can also manipulate the
url so if we look at a url it consists
of really the protocol and the protocol
means it's either a secure site or
non-secure site so in this example we
could see it's https and that means it's
a secure site and so ideally search
engines like web pages or websites that
are secure so after the protocol you're
going to see the domain and then after
the domain you're going to see
subdirectories okay so that's generally
the breakout with
url structures you have the protocol the
domain and subdirectories and then you
may have more subdirectories so if we go
back to the example we've been working
with if i go back to magiano's you can
see here this is a secure site
https you can see the domain in this
case it's actually a subdomain so
magianos.com is the domain but they
decided to put
locations.magianos.com and that's okay
we call that a subdomain and then here
you can see they have one particular
subdirectory after the domain and that's
florida so a well structured url not
only provides the users with information
about where they're going when they
click on your link in the search engine
results but more importantly it also
provides the search engines and some
information about what the web page is
all about so going back to our simple
example with maggiano's the search
engines know that hey if somebody clicks
on this link they're going to a page
about florida pretty simple the url
structure is pretty simple to understand
we know it's a secure site we know it's
maggianos.com and we know the subpage is
florida or the subdirectory is florida
you want to be careful like everything
else since and seo there are parameters
just like the title tag has parameters
up to 65 characters the meta description
tag has a limit of up to 165 characters
a well structured url also has character
counts but the idea here is we don't
want to get into numbers when we talk
about character counts for url structure
really the rule of thumb or the best
practice for url is to keep it short and
understandable okay if we keep it clear
and concise not only does the end user
know where they're going but the search
engines know what the page is all about
so the rule of thumb is always if you
don't understand the url or what it
means then the search engines are likely
not going to understand what the url
means we want to keep the number of
directors and subdirectories to a limit
so ideally here you can see in this
example
xyz.com if we want to optimize that url
we could put the targeted keyword in the
url if we'd like to but we want to keep
it probably to a minimum of one to two
subdirectories the shorter this the
amount of subdirectories the better off
we are because that means that not only
the end user will understand the url but
the search engines will understand the
url as well so we always want to make
sure that url is readable again for the
end user and the search engine and so in
this example you can see amazon.com
slash men's dash shoes slash sneakers
puma very easy understand as an end user
i know that i'm going to a puma page uh
for men on amazon.com now when you get
into urls with
dynamic parameters in them then ideally
you as an end user is not going to
really know where you're going to go so
in the example here the middle example i
can see that i'm going maybe to a shoes
page but i have no idea what the rest
that url means and in the other example
where you have a very low url
readability i have no idea as an end
user where i'm going to go so as an end
user i need to be able to have
confidence in knowing where i'm going to
go once i click on a link in the search
engine results so if i don't have that
confidence if i don't understand what
the url is then you then the search
engines aren't going to understand as
well and it's not going to bode well in
terms of relevancy and again the url
structure is important factor for being
relevant and if we're not relevant then
the chances of us are ranking higher is
not going to be as good because our url
is not readable so ideally what we want
to do
is make sure we're using keywords that
the end user and the search engines
understand and if we need to separate
out those keywords in the first example
we could see men's shoes we want to
separate that out with a hyphen and so
ideally if you have a url that's
readable and it's short and concise then
again your chances of ranking higher on
the search engine results page bodes
better than if you have a very long
antiquated unreadable url so let's focus
our attention on
image alt text or alt tags if you will
so alt tags or text tags as they're also
known as allow uh the search engines to
understand a little bit more about
what's on the page in terms of images so
images are a prominent part of every web
page on the internet unfortunately
images are you know usually files that
are not readable by search engines so we
want to be able to provide some
alternate text so that the search
engines understand what those images are
all about so again it gives us an
opportunity to communicate with the
search engines so that they better
understand what the image is all about
to make the page more relevant so
generally if an image fails to load on a
web page as an example well if you have
an alt tag then the alt tag is going to
show in place of the image not loading
more importantly if we have an alt tag
and the search engines have spidered our
website and somebody's actually
searching for images then the alt tag is
used as a descriptor for the image so it
also helps us get found for the images
on search engine results pages and so
like everything else we've talked about
with on-page seo there are character
limits to all tags you know generally
the rule of thumb is 125 characters for
an alt tag and the alt tag is used in
the html so we want to surround our
image with an alt tag by putting in a
descriptor and so ideally if you're
trying to be found for a particular
search engine query then you want to use
the search engine query as part of the
alt tag and so let me show you an
example here going back to maggiano's if
we look at their webpage and we actually
inspect one of their images on this
webpage if we look at for example a
pinterest or or facebook we can actually
see in this example that the image here
has an alt tag it's pinterest and so you
want to be able again to put in alt tags
for all your images so it better
communicates with the search engines
what the image is all about it also
allows the search engines to
rank images in the search engine results
based on that all text and what the
keyword query was so all tags play
an important role because again if the
image doesn't load on the web page for
some reason then the alt tag is there as
a replacement it's also there to help
the search engines rank those images and
understand the page a little bit better
so you always want to be able to put in
the keyword query that you're trying to
be found for in the alt tech and so be
as descriptive as possible you have 125
characters to use so b is descriptive
make it easy to read because again this
is what's going to show up in the search
engine results pages for images okay
let's turn our attention to internal
links so when it comes to seo internal
links also play a vital role because
basically an internal link which is a
link from one page of your website to
another page of your website um allows
google to or other search engines really
to follow the pages as they index your
entire website so it serves that purpose
of allowing search engines to index so
it definitely improves the indexing but
internal linking also has many benefits
and one of the other benefits is it
helps spreads what we call link choose
and so link juice is basically a way
another way of saying
you know this page is important because
it has links from other pages on our
website so
if we link i have a link from one page
to another and
a couple of other pages on our site
linked to that same page then search
engines tend to take notice and they
tend to note that you know if one
particular page has a number of
different links pointing to it then this
page may be important and so that's what
we mean by link jews it's a signal for
the search engines to determine what
pages on your website are important
because of the links that point to it
and so if we look at this example here
we could see that you know there's
usually a navigation on a website that
point two pages and every page on a
website tends to have a link but if more
than one page has multiple links then
again that signals to the search engines
that hey you know this particular page
seems to be important because it has a
lot of links pointing to it our
attention is site maps so sitemaps
basically allow us to list all the web
pages on our website so we could do that
in a couple of different ways but when
we do it it basically is going to and
help the search engines find our pages
easier just as i mentioned a minute ago
about internal linking when you have one
link pointing to another page on your
website it helps the search engines find
these pages quicker while sitemaps do
the same thing except sitemaps are an
entire list of links on your website and
it allows the site search engines to
find all your pages in your website
fairly easily but it also helps the end
user too so if you have a big website
like amazon has a huge website with a
lot of different products well if you're
looking for a particular product you can
do a search for it or you can look at
the site map and the sitemap will list
all the particular pages on the site and
so it's also good for the end user as
well so when we talk about the end user
and we talk about search engines they're
really two different types of site maps
you got the html version which is for
the end user that's going to be nothing
more than a link on the website usually
in the footer and so when you click on
that site map link you'll get a list of
all the links on the website okay so
that's an html sitemap then we have the
sitemap for the search engines you know
the spiders that want to crawl our site
so that's the xml sitemap and in xml is
just a different format it's just a way
to format all the links on our website
so the html site map is html written in
hypertext markup language designed for
the end user if you click on it it helps
the end user navigate the website
quickly because they can find what
they're looking for and so generally
that is an html now if we turn our
attention to the xml sitemap that's
basically designed for search engines
and thing about the search the xml site
map is we work with google to go ahead
and and and submit the sitemap to google
so google can quickly understand what
pages on our website so for example if i
went to a website let's just say
valleyfig.com
so if i went here and
if i'm a search engine i'm going to want
to know all the urls that are on this
website well as an end user i can also
just type in sitemap.xml
usually that's the xml file where all
the urls are located and here i can see
all of the urls on valleyfix.com and so
the idea behind an xml sitemap is we
want to communicate that xml file to the
search engines and so google in
particular has what they call a search
console in search console if you go to
google.com webmasters so search console
is a way to communicate with google and
one of the ways to communicate with
google is to submit a sitemap so we want
to submit our xml sitemap so if our xml
site map is located in the root
directory so after our domain
valleyfig.com
sitemap.xml we know that that file is
sitting in the root directory i can go
into search console and i can submit my
sitemap and when i submit my sitemap
then i'm basically communicating with
google telling google hey google instead
of trying to find all our web pages on
our website when you crawl the website
we're going to go ahead and submit the
sitemap to you so we're going to tell
you all the pages on our website and so
by doing that by submitting our
sitemap.xml file to google it speeds up
the process because google is able to
now understand all the pages on our
website that have been submitted and
then once we submit those pages then
google is going to quickly index a
majority of those pages if not all of
those pages and so that's the benefit of
having an xml site map for the search
engines is that we can quickly submit
that file to the search engine so our
pages get submitted and indexed quicker
so continuing on with on-page seo we now
turn our attention to page speed and so
page speed also known as page low time
of a particular page of a particular
website is important for seo why is it
important because
google has millions of users use their
search engine and google wants their
users to have a good experience and so
if google ranks websites based on
relevancy they also want to take into
account page speed because if a website
does not load fast or web page doesn't
load fast then it would be detrimental
for google to rank that page high
because what's going to happen is that
page is going to get a number of clicks
and then the user experience is not
going to be that great and so therefore
it's going to have a negative impact not
only in the end user but google as well
and so page load time then becomes
important for on-page seo so really when
it comes to page load time we really
want to pay attention to how long it
takes search engines on pages to load in
terms of seconds because if a page loads
slow then chances are the user
experience is not going to be good even
from an analytics perspective meaning if
i go to
google type in a query click on a link
and then it's that link takes me to a
website where the web page loads very
slow chances are i'm not going to spend
a lot of time waiting for that page to
load i'm going to leave that page and if
i leave the page then it's going to
cause up what they call a bounce so i'm
going to bounce from the page and that's
just not good for the entire search
ecosystem and so we want to pay close
attention to page load time because the
faster a site or page loads google's
going to recognize that and that's going
to help with ranking and so how do we
understand how our pages load well we
can look no further than web analytics
tool like google analytics for example
so if we turn our attention to google
analytics if i go to say
valleyfig.coms analytics account i can
look over the last 30 days and i can see
okay on average our page average page
load time for the entire site was 5
seconds around five seconds and ideally
we want our pages load as quick as
possible i would say the rule of thumb
on page load time is probably no more
than three to four seconds okay but
there are factors involved with page
load time so a couple of factors are the
browser that people use so some browsers
load pages differently than other
browsers the other factor involved with
browsers is the device so you could be
on a mobile device and say internet
explorer versus on a desktop using
chrome and you're going to have
variation in terms of average page load
time so definitely browser device plays
a role but also country plays a role the
infrastructure how much bandwidth is
available so you could be in say san
francisco united states and be on a
high-speed network versus another city
or another country where you're not
necessarily on the same high speed
network you're on a lower bandwidth or
lower network and that's going to affect
the page load time as well so in
analytics you can actually see the
breakdown of time per country and then
of course the page itself so when we
talk about average page load time for a
website we're talking about the average
for the entire site but we can actually
look at in google analytics the average
low time for every page on the site so
ideally if you have a particular page
you want to rank organically in the
search engines and the average page load
time is not suitable or it's very high
then you want to address what the issues
are and so the great thing about google
analytics is you actually have speed
suggestions so if i go to speed
suggestions in google analytics i'm
going to be able to see the average load
time for certain pages on the site and
then what google's going to do is
actually give me
some feedback so for example i can see
that
the home page loads about 5.59 seconds
and so if i click on page speed
suggestions then google is going to give
me suggestions on how to speed up the
page load time not only on desktop but
on mobile as well so when you click on
page speed suggestions you're actually
going to go to a tool a google tool
called page speed insights and then page
speed insights is going to allow you to
see how quick your page loads and then
it's going to be able to give you
feedback on what to do in order to speed
up the page load time not only for the
page but for the site and the great
thing again is you can see it for
desktop and you can see it from mobile
so page speed is important we want to be
able to keep our page load time low
no more than probably again three to
four seconds because if it's any more
than that google's going to take notice
the other search engines are going to
take notice and they're not going to
want to rank that particular page high
on google so some ways to increase your
page speed you always want to optimize
your images you never want to have
images that take a long time to load you
want to use a simple website design now
i know flash as an example has long been
disbanded but you don't want to use
other technology that's really going to
slow the page load time of course where
your website is hosted does matter so
the server it's hosted on could be
shared with other websites and so that
may eat into how quick the server
responds to people trying to load your
web page and so you want to keep that in
mind so server response time does play a
factor in loading and then of course
optimizing your code you want to never
have unnecessary code on your website
and when i say unnecessary code some
examples could be tracking code if
you're doing any search advertising
let's just say on facebook or bing you
try to want to minimize the amount of
extra code you put on a site because
that code has to execute and that eats
into the page load time so you want to
be cognizant of how much code you put on
your website because that will eat into
the page load time so let's talk about
featured snippets so featured snippets
is the search result that generally
shows uh up at the top of the search
engine organic results so it's
informational content and you'll see it
above organic results but you'll also
see it below search advertising and so
some of the common featured snippets you
may see are in the form of a paragraph a
table or a list and so
paragraph snippets tend to be the most
popular and let me show an example of a
featured snippet so if i go to
say google.com and type in machine
learning here you can see some paid
search ads okay and why do i know
they're paid search ads because i can
see ad next to them but if i look below
the paid search ads but above the
organic search results i see a paragraph
feature snippet and this is nothing more
than again just some an informational
content about machine learning and
really
the whole idea behind uh featured
snippets is really they're just
informational and really it's
informational and and what google likes
to do is pull content in there that
really answers a question so if your
content doesn't necessarily answer
question
then you can't expect your content to
show up as a featured snippet so the
whole idea is with the search engines is
really google searches through a number
of different sites to find content that
will best answer a user's question like
for example what is machine learning
okay so if we ask the question what is
machine learning we can expect to find a
feature snippet and so really what users
do a lot when they type in a query they
use prefixes like how does or how do or
how to or what is and so those types of
questions are normally asked as part of
the search query so if you could answer
those questions then
generally google's going to recognize
that and if it's relevant it's going to
show up as a featured snippet so the
whole idea is to really create truly
high quality content so
about feature snippets is if you have
true high quality content that answers a
question then chances are your content
may show up as a featured snippet so the
whole idea is you know work to create
high quality content that provides a
really good answer to really basic
question it could be anything what is
machine learning what is a fig you know
how to ride a bicycle how do i surf all
these are related questions that content
can answer and google wants to make sure
as part of a featured snippet that they
provide content that answers that
question and not just content the best
content that does the the best job with
the most relevant information answer
that person search query so here we can
see our three examples you have a table
format so if we want to type in aviation
jobs we can see
snippets of information about the latest
job listings for aviation you can see in
the middle screenshot what is machine
learning so that's our paragraph
featured snippet and then if you type in
something like building a fence it's
going to give you a list of you know
ways to go about building a fence so
these are all answers to questions the
query may not necessarily be in question
form but the snippet is there just in
case you want to know more information
about that particular query so generally
that's how featured snippets work and
the great thing about featured snippets
it's open to everybody the key is to
have quality content if you have quality
content that provides answers to
questions then chances are your content
can show up above organic search results
which will give you more visibility
drive a lot more traffic to your site
and quality traffic because likely it's
answering somebody's question so let's
do a a recap of everything we talked
about with on-page seo so before we move
on off page remember on-page seo is what
we do to our website to enhance our
website to be found in the search
engines for relevant keywords so it's
all about relevancy and remember before
you do anything to your website you need
to start with the basics of keyword
research you need to find keywords that
are highly relevant that have volume and
low competition and so when you can
focus on your keywords and you find out
and finalize what keywords you want to
be found for then you're going to
conduct on-page seo on-page seo consists
of number different factors some of
which we talked about today starting
with schema remember we want to have
structured data to better communicate
with the search engines what our web
pages are about then we talked about
title tags so title tags appear in
search results remember 65 characters we
want to make sure our keyword is in the
title tag followed by our brand name and
then we talked about meta descriptions
meta descriptions allow us to you know
talk specifically about what that page
is all about meta descriptions fall
under the title tag in the search
results we talked about headers h1
through h6 h1 being the biggest in the
hierarchy of headers and having an h1
tag with your keyword provides the
search engines with an identity of how
strong or how important something is on
a page it also organizes the page with
headers and subheaders and it breaks up
the content so it's easily
understandable by the end user we also
talked about alt tags so remember images
on its own are not recognized by search
engines so we want to surround those
images with alt tags with words that
help the search engines identify what
that image is they also serve a purpose
in the browser if an image doesn't load
then we can actually see what the image
is all about with the alt tag we talked
about feature snippets there are lists
okay there are paragraphs okay there are
different types of snippets and really
the whole idea again behind snippets is
answering a question with quality
content we talked about page speed
identifying how quick our pages load in
google analytics so if your pages don't
load very quickly then google actually
provides suggestions to speed up the
page load time of a particular page and
some of the culprits that you want to
look at are making sure you have images
that are good quality but also not a lot
in size you want to make sure they're
optimized you want to look at your
server response time you want to make
sure you optimize code so there's a lot
of different factors of page load time
you just want to keep an eye on what
pages are not loading quick enough and
remember we want to keep it as low as
possible but no more than three to four
seconds we talked about internal linking
internal linking to a particular page
from one page to another provides link
juice and link juice is nothing more
than an indicator for the search engines
to identify what pages tend to be more
important than another based on the
number of links pointing to that page
and then we also talked about sitemaps
so we talked about the two types of
sitemaps html and xml html is for the
end user xml is primarily for the search
engines xml generally is going to be a
file called sitemap.xml and we could
take that xml file and submit it to
google search console and so that
expedites the process of indexing your
site and helps your site not only get
index faster but will help google
understand how many pages are on your
site and then get those pages indexed so
that they can be found so that you can
generate traffic so all these are
factors with on-page seo that you want
to address before you move on to
off-page seo okay let's uh turn our
attention to off-page seo now that we
covered all the essentials for on-page
we still need to focus our attention on
off page remember earlier i mentioned
that seo is a two-pronged approach we
have to focus on on-page seo first and
then to complement
our efforts and to continue our efforts
and to continue the effort of being
relevant for certain keywords we need to
do what we call off-page seo and those
are our actions we take that don't
involve our website directly meaning
we've already updated the title tag the
meta description the alt tags the
headers etc we want to do things off our
website that's going to allow google and
other search engines to recognize that
hey we are relevant these pages are
relevant for certain keywords on our
website and so really when we talk about
off-page seo it's really the technique
of promoting your website using link
building when we say
technique of promoting our website using
link building that means establishing
links on other websites that's what we
mean by link building and so
establishing links on other websites
really
enhances our seo efforts because it
improves first and foremost it improves
the credibility of our website so
if we're on a
you know a very popular website that is
known to be reputable
then having a link pointing from that
website to ours just improves the
credibility of our own website
not necessarily in the minds of the
search engine but in the minds of the
end user uh the other benefit here is it
increases our domain authority and let's
take a minute to talk about domain
authority so domain authority is simply
just a score between one and one hundred
and so in digital marketing even
including seo as a marketing channel
everything's measurable and we want to
be able to measure everything we do
digitally and so off page seo is
measurable one of the metrics involved
with off page seo is domain authority in
other words it's a score between 1 and
100 for our domain so how does google
how does baidu how do these other search
engines see our domain how authoritative
is our domain how reputable is our
domain and so having links on other
websites pointing to our domain
increases our
reputability increases our authority and
so i'm going to show you an example so
if you remember back on on-page seo i
when we're talking about keyword
research we use a tool called moz
moz.com and i would recommend using
moz.com to measure domain authority so
if we go to moz.com and moz.com has a
tool called link explorer so if you put
in your domain using their tool link
explorer you're going to be able to see
your domain authority and domain
authority is a score between 1 and 100
and basically it's simply just scoring
your website in terms of authority how
does the search engine see your site out
on the world wide web the higher the
score the better and so
recommend using moz.com
explorer to measure to domain authority
so the more
links we have on external sites pointing
to our own site in theory the higher the
domain authority so we're going to come
back to
moz.com quite frequently as we talk
about off-page seo because we need a
tool to help manage our efforts so we're
going to come back to moz.com but let's
let's talk about some of these other
benefits to off-page seo so we know it
helps with the credibility it increases
our domain authority but what are some
of the other intangible efforts that are
also measurable well it increases our
referral traffic and by increasing our
referral traffic meaning if we're on a
reputable site that gets a lot of
traffic and there's a link pointing our
site then naturally we're probably going
to see traffic coming from that site and
we can measure that in tools like google
analytics we can measure referral
traffic and so that's an inherent
benefit to doing off-page seo because
we're trying to create the relevancy of
our own website we're trying to be found
for relevant keywords but yet at the
same time we can increase traffic to our
website and then certainly not lost in
all this is improving our page rank so
the idea here is you need on-page and
off-page seo to work together to improve
our rankings and improving our rankings
in the search engine results will
inherently increase our rankings and
drive traffic to the site from search
engines and that's ideally what we're
trying to do we're trying to accomplish
traffic from search engines by improving
our rankings but at the same time we
improve our credibility and we accrue
improve our standing in the search
engine world and we also increase
traffic to our site from all these other
websites and so there are a lot of
benefits to off-page seo um it's just
let's talk a little bit more about some
of these other benefits because
according to a backlinko a web page with
more backlinks is going to rank higher
than a page with fewer backlinks but let
me just say this with back linking
especially from sites it's all about
credibility it's all about quality over
quantity so we want to pay attention to
quality over quantity so let's hearken
back to moz.com
and here we could see
we have a domain authority of 35 but we
have a lot of links inbound links from
other websites pointing to our website
we have
575 domains out there on the internet
pointing to our domain valleyfig.com
and so if we want to take a specific
look at these domains we can just simply
click on linking domains and here we can
see all the different domains pointing
to our website now again it's about
quality not quantity so if we look at
the domain authority and that's a score
that measures the credibility of a
website we could see the domain
authority on some of these domains like
npr.org has a domain authority of 93 and
so to me
that helps boost the domain authority
for our own website our own domain it
also has the chance of driving that
traffic it also increases the
credibility but in the end having
quality links from other quality domains
is going to increase our own rank on
search engines and that's the whole idea
behind it so we could actually see
that we have quality websites of quality
domains linking to our domain now you
can also use another tool i mentioned
this earlier with on-page seo when i was
talking about site maps so if you go to
search console so that's a google tool
we can also look at
a link report and see what other
websites are linking to us so this is
google's way of communicating to us what
websites are out there linking to us and
so here i can see the top linking sites
to our website
valleyfig.com
is the crumby kitchen has
443 links pointing back to our site
cookscountry.com whole foods magazine
mayan perfect kitchen these are all
sites with links pointing back to our
site so search console is a good tool
it's a good alternative tool especially
the links report is a good alternative
tool to get an idea of the types of
sites that are linking to your site now
what you're missing here in search
console is the domain authority but you
can use the link explorer tool in
moz.com to measure the domain authority
for any domain it's just a matter of
going to the tool itself going by going
to moz.com by going to the link explorer
report and just typing in the domain and
from there you'll be able to see the
domain authority so it's all about
quality over quantity i can't stress
that enough so when it comes to off page
really it's synonymous with link
building so it's the most effective
method for off-page seo and it's simply
just getting links from other websites
to your own so it's not as easy as it
sounds especially when we're talking
about quality over quantity but building
these links to our website will help our
rankings and that's the whole idea
behind off page seo we want to be able
to link from other websites to ours so
that we can help our rankings in
addition to some of the other benefits i
just mentioned so
google recognizes backlinks as one of
their top ranking factors so in addition
to some of the on-page seo tactics that
i mentioned earlier
including title tag and meta description
and url structure and headers all those
are important but at the same time it's
a balance so google wants to know hey
yes we understand you've optimized your
title tag for keyword but how does the
rest of the internet see your website
is your website worthy enough to add a
link from a particular quality website
to your website so if there are a number
of quality links then your site must be
of quality as well and so that's the
whole idea behind link building being an
important factor because again it's
about from google's perspective it's
about the user experience they want to
make sure that sites ranked on page one
of google are quality sites quality
sites that load well that have good
content that have fresh content not just
sites that have a gazillion links
pointing to them with
you know keywords stuffed into the title
tag so it's an ecosystem google's and
other search engines want to protect
that ecosystem with quality so that's
why link building is an important factor
and so there are different types of
links so when you have a link pointing
from one website to your own okay the
link could be a follow link or no
following and the whole idea behind
follow or no follow is simply hey we
know that google and other search
engines are spidering the entire web the
whole idea is for them to collect as
many pages as they these search engines
can to bring them back to their servers
so they can serve them up in their
search engines well as google and these
other search engines spider these sites
they're following what they're doing is
they're following links that's as simple
as it gets they're following links from
one link to another so remember we
talked about internal links earlier on
on page seo internal links are just
links on your web pages pointing to
other pages on your own website well
when it comes to external links so links
pointing from one website to your
website
that website that's linking to your
website has an opportunity to say hey
google you can follow this link or don't
follow the link and so if they choose to
not follow the link meaning they put a
nofollow tag into the anchor text then
google's going to follow the link but
not recognize the link itself and what i
mean by that is hey if you have let's
just use valley fig has a link from
wikipedia if wikipedia has a link
pointing to valleyfig.com but the link
itself is nofollow then what google is
going to do is not recognize the link
itself they're not going to recognize
the link so therefore you're not going
to get credit or link juice as we say
you're not going to get any juice from
wikipedia to valley pig but if it is a
follow link then what google's going to
do is recognize the link and give you
credit for the backlink and by giving
you credit for the backlink that's going
to inherently increase your domain
authority it's also going to likely
increase your rankings so
you want to pay attention to the types
of link building that's out there no
follow and so anytime you try to
establish a link on an external website
just make sure it's a follow make sure
it's not a no follow because if it's a
no follow link then you're not going to
get the credit from the search engines
and so the whole idea behind link
building in terms of seo is to get some
credit from a quality website to your
website and so if we look here a follow
link in this example is one where the
href or the link itself doesn't have a
nofollow in it but if a hyperlink does
have a no follow in it then that means
you're not going to get the credit for
the backlink so remember no follows they
don't allow search engine crawlers to
follow the link so
if that's the case it's not going to
pass any link juice when you don't pass
quote unquote link juice you're not
going to get credit for the backlink and
so if you don't get credit for the
backlink then if we go back to our tools
that we have available for measuring off
page seo so if i go back to
let's just say moz or even let's just
say search console you know i'll be able
to see all these links here these links
that are showing up are follow links why
because google's recognizing the link if
they were no follow then we wouldn't see
the link in here so that's something to
keep in mind as well and so just keep in
mind if it is a no file you'll see in
the hypertext itself the nofollow tag
and you can always check that the html
of any particular link and so when we
talk about link building we talk about
off-page seo really we're talking about
how to get links on quality websites and
how do we do that well i've listed here
a few ways to do that so you could do
guest blogging or blogging in general is
a good off page seo slash link building
strategy and i'll talk about more that
in a minute but we can list our websites
in reputable and trustworthy directories
i mentioned wikipedia as an example even
though wikipedia may not be classified
as a directory but there are other
directories out there you could ask for
testimonials so if you're working with
clients or other websites you could ask
for testimonial or they can provide a
link pointing back from their site to
your site it's about relationships
really is what it comes down to it's
relationship building and that's what a
link is relationship building or you
could do content on social media so
these are just examples of ways to
generate links but let's go back to the
blogging part because blogging to me is
an essential part to off page seo and
why is that because any time you are
part of a blog you're generating content
and not only are you generating content
you're generating fresh content that's
likely to be interesting to the end user
and with that content yes you can
optimize that content but the beauty
about blogging is really anybody can do
it but if we want to connect blogging
with relationships if we're a food
blogger then we can write on other food
blogs as a guest writer and we can have
that blog post linked back to our own
blog as an example or we can have other
bloggers in the same industry write a
guest blog for us on their own blog and
point their link back to our site
blogging creates a lot of
opportunities for link building because
again it's a fresh canvas with
interesting content and when you have
interesting content then the opportunity
for backlinking is going to be there
because if you're writing about
something that's interesting then
naturally you're going to want to link
to something else related to that that's
interesting and so that's the
opportunity that blogging creates so
again it's vital to get links from
authoritative web pages then multiple
links from low quality web pages so
going back to the link explorer report
we want to be able to pay attention to
those domain authorities or those
websites with low domain authority and
really you should pay attention to
really quality sites okay you want to
pay attention to quality sites and so
when we talk about links there's inbound
links there's outbound links we're
interested in those inbound links we're
interested in getting links from
high quality websites pointing to our
own website and again that could be in
the form of a blog it could be social
media it could be a partner site okay
these are all inbound links they just
need to be followed make sure they're
not a no follow so it's simple just
getting a external link that's a follow
to your to your own website and so the
one thing i want to mention here though
on inbound links from external websites
and that's making sure that not
necessarily every inbound link points to
the home page we want to be able to have
links point to internal pages so let's
harken back to
search console as an example so search
console our links report
shows us
links pointing from external websites to
our own website but what are those
linked pages so if we look at some of
those linked pages here we can see the
top link pages we can see on
valleyfig.com slash recipes is the top
link page then the home page then the
about us then slash international so we
want to make sure that if we're trying
to generate backlinks from external
websites to our own website we want to
make sure that
they're pointing to interior pages not
necessarily the home page and why do i
say that because one of the benefits to
link building and off page seo is
ranking so the whole idea about ranking
is to get some of our other pages ranked
not necessarily the home page the home
page is just a doorway into your website
if we have interesting content out there
on the web
and it's a food blogger as an example
and they're talking about a particular
food item well they're going to want a
link to a page that's related to what
they're blogging about that particular
food item they don't want to link to the
home page the homepage is just a doorway
and so that's the whole idea behind link
building we want to link to multiple
pages on the site why is that because if
i take this particular page
valleyfig.com recipes and i just put
that into moz and i look at the link
explorer report for this particular page
the domain authority is still going to
be the same 35 that's what valleyfig.com
is 35 however there's also another
metric called page authority so page
authority is likewise with the domain
authority to score between one and one
hundred and so the more
external links pointing to an internal
page with high domain authority that's
likely going to increase the page
authority of that page so in other words
if we have good links from other
websites pointing to that page then it's
going to increase the page authority for
that page and ultimately the domain
authority for that page and so just like
the domain authority in this case
valleyfig every page under the domain
has a page authority score so the higher
the score the likelihood that that page
is going to rank in the search engine
results okay so that's the whole idea
behind link building is we want to
improve the authority of the pages not
just the domain but also more
importantly we also want to keep the end
user in mind so if it's from a blog or
social media the link pointing from that
blog or social media platform should
naturally point to something related to
what you're talking about not just the
home page because again the home page
more or less is the gateway into the
website so we want to get people to
where they want to go we want to
naturally create a link from good
content to some other good content so
that's the whole idea behind backlinking
so outbound links will direct a user
from our own website to another website
so
the idea here is it's okay to have
outbound links on your own website the
natural ecosystem of the world wide web
okay what i would recommend here is not
to have so many in a century located
place for example don't have one page
with nothing but external links on it
you know sprinkle these external links
these outbound links throughout your
website but also if it's not a
reciprocal link meaning if a guest
blogger is not linking to your website
but you're just linking to theirs and
they didn't ask you to then maybe
consider a nofollow tag maybe you know
ideally you want to make sure that these
links are just natural in nature so
don't just have a habit of putting
outbound links because the whole idea
behind outbound links is you want to
keep people on your website but if it's
a natural link going from one content to
another and you think the end user is
going to benefit then no problem but
just don't get in the habit of putting
external links on your website because
that means that hey
that user that's on your website may
click on that link and leave your
website and not come back so keep that
in mind as well because you don't
necessarily benefit from an seo
perspective by having outbound links on
your own website you want to do it as a
courtesy if somebody else is linking to
you you want to do it for the end user
if you feel the benefit from additional
content under the website but from an
seo perspective it doesn't necessarily
directly enhance your own website in
terms of ranking turn our attention to
duplicate content so
a lot of us have websites with a lot of
content sometimes we go ahead and take
our website and revise it create a new
one or register a new domain and put
content on that new domain and so
we may find ourselves in a situation at
one point or the other where we have two
websites with the same content or could
be the same website
with a lot of content but some of that
may be duplicate as well so we want to
try and stay away from duplicate content
but for some of us we may stumble across
it accidentally we may find ourselves
having content that's duplicated and so
we want to try and prevent that because
that's a no-no in the world of seo so
if we have duplicate content appearing
in more than one url there are ways to
rectify
not having the search engines recognize
the content twice so some examples of
duplicate content are for example a
spammer takes an article and posts the
same content on his website or like i
mentioned before you create another
website or register another domain and
have that particular
content on the old website still or
you're writing a blog post and
you tag it or categorize it and the
content shows up under the tags under
the categories and just shows up in
general so there are a lot of scenarios
where you can find yourselves with
duplicate content and so we want to
rectify that we don't want duplicate
content we want the search engines to
recognize the original source of the
content and so basically if you have two
versions of a web page you may result in
duplicate content issues another example
that would be for example if you have
products you may find that that same
product may be under two different
categories so how do we rectify that
well there are a number of different
ways and so the simple way is what they
call a 301 redirect to the original url
so if you find yourself in a situation
where you have a new website with the
same content you could simply set up a
redirect and we call it a 301 redirect
because 301 refers to
permanent so it's signifying to the
search engines that you're permanently
moving from this page to this page the
other way is through a canonical
attribute and so
the word canonical may not register with
some of you so
let's just uh take a minute to talk
about what a canonical is like basically
canonical tag it's a page level meta tag
so remember that meta tag description we
talked about in on-page seo we'll think
about this as another type of meta tag
and it's placed in that html header of
your web page so basically all it does
is by placing this meta tag it tells the
search engines which url is the original
version to be displayed in index so it's
the purpose of a canonical is to keep
the duplicate content out of the search
engine index so we want to consolidate
our page rank our page authority or
domain authority all to original content
that's the whole idea of having a
canonical and it's a quick solution so
all you need to do is add a canonical
tag to the header so let me show you an
example if you have a site let's just
use cnn as an example cnn.com has a lot
of content and sometimes given the
breadth of content that they have they
may run into duplicate content so they
simply just put a canonical tag into
their their header and so by doing that
they're able to
tell the search engines hey
this page this domain is the original if
you find yourself with multiple sites
well you can also use google search
console so remember we used google
search console in earlier examples when
we talked about
links to your site or we talked about
that site map on on-page seo if we go on
a search console we could basically say
look google because search console is a
google tool we want to confirm that this
is our domain so this is the domain you
should be focusing on so you can
leverage search console to communicate
with google regarding which site is
important which is the one that should
get indexed you can use the canonical
you can put that on any page either
website or you could set up a 301
redirect so those are the ways to fix
duplicate content issues 301s are the
easiest canonicals tend to be temporary
because they're just the page level and
then search console is a a good method
because it communicates with google
directly and it allows google to crawl
various web pages differently than if
you didn't tell them okay so if you
didn't tell them they're just going to
grab anything they can so by
communicating via the google search
console tool it allows you to tell
google this is the domain i want to
focus in on so let's talk then now about
how the google algorithms work so we'll
shift gears here and we'll talk about
how these algorithms work on google so
google uses advanced concepts retrieve
data so what they do is they're
spidering they're spidering they're
collecting web pages and they're taking
all those web pages back to their server
and anytime somebody does a query
they're delivering those web pages
within milliseconds they're delivering
results based on your query so that's in
general how it works so it uses a
combination of different algorithms to
deliver the best results they want the
best results and so some of the most
popular algorithms below are
google panda google penguin and google
rankbrain so these are all
things that google has done
to make sure that they're constantly
tweaking their search engines to deliver
the best results so let's talk about
some of these these popular algorithms
and before we talk about these popular
algorithms let's just make one thing
clear that google's always tweaking
their algorithms on their search engine
and so if you want to get an idea how
often they do it well they do it every
day they're constantly tweaking it but
they what they do is they release major
changes to their algorithm a few times a
year so if you want to get a sense of
what those changes look like well you
could go to
moz.com and you can go to google dash
algorithm-change
and you can see here that hey google
changes his search algorithm around 500
to 600 times while most of these are
minor google again rolls out major
changes like panda like penguin that
affects search results in significant
ways so you can go here and you can go
all the way back to 2000 and see some of
the algorithm changes that have occurred
over the last few years and you can see
here the last major one was done in
august of 2018 that was the metacore
update so they're constantly making
changes to their search engine to
deliver a more concise more better
ecosystem for the end user so if it's a
better search engine for the end user
and users are going to come back so the
whole idea is continuing to tweak the
system the the algorithms to better show
more accurate results and so let's take
a look at some of the the major
algorithm changes that they've done in
the past so the first is we'll talk
about google panda and panda was an
algorithm released back in 2011. so here
we are in 2019 is a few years ago but
still significant in that really this
algorithm emphasized high quality
content because before panda there was a
there's just a lot of content out there
on the internet and
there was a lot of spam content there's
a lot of duplicate content and so really
the idea behind panda is for google to
really deliver in their search engine
results pages high quality content so
what it did was it removed web pages
that had low quality or duplicate
content so that was the whole idea
behind you know the algorithm nicknamed
panda it removed low quality and
duplicate content and that kind of
cleaned things up a bit where if you did
a search query now you'd actually see
better better results and one thing
about panda is because there's so much
quality because google's indexing so
much there on the internet that it's
constantly being updated it's updated
regularly so the next one we're going to
talk about is google penguin so
penguin was released after panda and
what that focused in on was low quality
links so remember we talked about link
building we talked about quality links
over quantity so
naturally you're going to have links
naturally from all websites whether that
be high quality or low quality the whole
idea behind this algorithm is to
sever the links that are low quality and
so the idea behind that was they focused
on two areas so they focused in on link
schemes and keyword stuffing so that's
what penguin focused on was link schemes
were basically
link almost link farming where you
produced mass amounts of backlinks and
not all of them were good quality they
weren't natural links links should be
natural from one high quality site or
blog to another high quality cider blog
and by creating link schemes you created
an ecosystem where links just went to
irrelevant low quality spam related
pages and so google's penguins algorithm
update focused in on that effort to
remove or combat pages that had poor
links from being indexed in their search
engine results and then they also
combated keyword stuffing keyword
stuffing is nothing more than taking
your target a keyword and stuffing it
into the content of your page your title
tag your meta description so any sites
that were caught up doing that basically
suffer the consequences because what
penguin did was take care of sites that
basically were accused of keyword
stuffing or had characteristics of
keyword stuffing and they removed sites
that had a lot of links pointing to it
from poor quality sites and vice versa
sites that really had a lot of external
links pointing to other poor quality
sites so that's what penguin did they
took a look at those two areas i mean so
we talked about link schemes again
penguin's aim was to decrease the
ranking of web pages that created
artificially by using black hat
techniques and basically what i mean by
black cat techniques that artificially
creating length that just didn't make
sense just for the sake of getting the
backlink just for the sake of passing
link juice and so that's what a link
scheme is or was and so google basically
tweaked their algorithm to combat those
poor link schemes and so
keyword stuffing as i mentioned a minute
ago it's just repetitive usage of the
same keyword and that just basically
suffers the content is the thing that
suffers here and when the content
suffers the end user suffers so google
is all about quality content and when
you have quality content and that
quality content is indexed and users
find what they're looking for chances
are they're going to go back to the
search engine to continue to find what
they're looking for with the end result
being presented with quality content so
keyword stuffing really dilutes the
quality of the content and then let's
talk about the third algorithm which is
rankbrain so rankbrain is a processing
algorithm that uses machine learning and
what that does that machine learning
interprets search queries that users
search on google so
for example
if rankbrain sees a word or phrase it
isn't familiar with basically the
machine can make a guess as to what
words or phrases might have a similar
meaning and filter the result
accordingly so basically take these
search engine queries and present them
in a way that's logical so that the end
result can be something that's relevant
to what you're looking for and so for
example
if you're searching for online marketing
you will get results related for digital
marketing on search engine remote pages
why because rankbrain will interpret
that particular keyword and they're
trying to basically match based on all
the data they collected what words or
phrases might have a similar meaning so
online marketing digital marketing have
similar meanings now that we've talked
about some of the different algorithm
changes that google has made over the
years and continues to make let's um
segue into the types of seo and so when
we talk about the types of seo we're
really talking about
doing what's right what's expected
versus doing something that you know is
trying to cheat the system and so you
may hear the terminology black cat seo
white hat seo or gray hat seo and so the
whole idea behind these terminologies is
that hey what are we supposed to be
doing here in terms of following best
practices in order to
get our pages ranked on the search
engines for the keyword queries we
covered and so let's talk about what not
to do first and that's always black cat
techniques so i just mentioned a minute
ago with panda and penguin algorithm
updates you know penguin took into
account you know link schemes poor
linking techniques keyword stuffing so
those are considered black cat
techniques so black cat is a technique
used to improve page rank by violating
search engine rules and policies so it's
clearly google's made a clear line in
the sand they don't like link schemes
they don't like keyword stuffing so if
you take into account those practices
then you're practicing black hat
techniques to treat this cheat the
system to try and rank faster and so
some other ways of black cat or you know
redirecting
phishing
having duplicate content all these are
are things that are frowned upon by
search engines so the result of not only
algorithm changes is you could get your
website blacklisted from the search
engines if you are caught in violation
of their policies it's pretty clear-cut
so that's why the algorithms are in
place uh the algorithms try and create a
system an environment where you know
good quality content is shown so if
you're keyword stuffing you're creating
lots of duplicate content that's not in
adherence with you know google's
policies for creating good quality
content and as a result you could get
blacklisted so with black hat techniques
you run the risk of being penalized and
you don't want to be penalized by the
search engines so white hat contrarily
used to improve search engine rankings
by following those rules and policies so
in effect it's everything we talked
about today from on-page seo to off-page
seo doing the right thing with your
content in terms of organizing the
structure with headers creating very
clear and concise meta descriptions
submitting a site map all of those are
white hat techniques addressing page
load time using really relevant keywords
naturally in your content and creating
high quality content that's fresh and
interesting for the end user that's a
white hat technique that's going to get
you ranked higher and farther and with
better benefits so gray hat is just
simply a combination of black and white
it's the practice of improving by
following the policies but they
considered you know ethically dubious
and so what i mean by that is listen you
you don't want to purchase links you
want links to come across naturally you
don't want to do excessive internal
linking you don't want to have a lot of
lengths pointing to one page it's not
natural so you want to be able to do
things that
are
natural you don't want to just take
content from another side and claim it
as your own so you want to do things
that
are natural that's going to create a
good experience for the user because if
it's for the end user which it is then
generally it's going to be good for the
search engines and so let's talk about
website architecture now so
basically when i say website
architecture what i mean is we want to
give the search engines an idea of how
our website's built so website
architecture and the structure of
websites important and so every website
has a hierarchy it starts with the home
page the home page is the top page it's
the the domain it's where most people go
to find other pages of your website and
so generally you're going to have a
scenario where you're going to have a
home page with you know if you sell
products multiple categories and in
those categories you're going to have
multiple products so the generally
that's how a web architecture flows it
follows from top down and the reason for
having a good website architecture is
internal links are spread equally so you
want to make sure again not to apply a
black cat method or greyhound method of
pointing all links to one page you want
links naturally to spread throughout
your website because not just from an
seo benefit but from an end user
perspective you want users to flow
through your website naturally so if
you're planning on developing websites
from an seo perspective you know take
these things into consideration so we
want to take into account the site
architecture and navigation we want to
take into account the url remember we
talked about url structure and on-page
seo the rule of thumb is if you can read
it the search engines will read it so we
want to keep it clear and concise and
relevant to the content of that page
when we talk about responsive design
we're talking about multiple devices so
you don't build a website just for
desktop especially when mobile is being
used by a majority of the users around
the world so you want to build a website
that's both desktop friendly and mobile
friendly we also want to take into
account a robot's text file and a
robot's text file is simply just a text
file that allows the search engines to
index certain pages it tells them what
not to index and so you can always find
the robot's text file normally if you go
to a website and let's just say we go to
valleyfig.com
and then we type in robot or robots.txt
file here we can see if i type in
robots.txt file here this basically is a
file a text file that's in the root
directory and it simply just gives the
search engines an idea of what they're
allowed to index and what they're not
allowed to index so anything with a
disallow means hey search engines please
don't index these pages so that's what a
robot's text file does and every site
should have it because there are some
pages on your website then you
inherently don't want the search engines
to index and you want to optimize for
the crawlers so that means that making
sure that your pages are available and
that means also submitting a site map
remember we submit our sitemap via the
google search console so good site
architecture not only makes content easy
to find but also helps to gain traffic
because hey if your site is easy it's
well organized it's built multiple
devices the urls are easy then all
that's going to be apparent to the
search engines and when it's apparent to
the search engines it's going to get
indexed they want to get indexed then
you're going to get found and you're
going to get the traffic so it's just a
natural progression it's best practice
so some important features of good
architecture are again that url
structure code your site navigation in
css or html make it easy for the search
engines to follow build a comprehensive
structure for an internal linking
meaning they should be natural internal
links if a page is relevant to another
page then create an internal link if you
have a very big website with a lot of
content or a lot of products then create
a breadcrumb navigation okay so we're
maybe familiar with that on amazon as an
example
amazon.com has a lot of products and
if you're navigating from one product to
another in one directory or one category
to another category then amazon creates
what they call breadcrumbs to help you
navigate back to where you were quickly
so
these are all good best practices for
good site architecture good site
architecture equals search engine
results so responsive design helps to
make your website mobile friendly it
will increase the amount of time the
user spends on your website which may
improve site ranking so let's talk a
second about mobile friendliness so if i
go back to google search console there
happens to be
in search console a mobile usability
report and so if i click on that report
basically what it's going to show me is
pages that
are do not follow google's best
practices so some of google's best
practices are making sure that the text
is easy to read that clickable elements
aren't necessarily close to one another
and the viewport is set to the
appropriate device meaning the screen is
set to the appropriate device okay and
so
basically if we are found in violation
then the pages affected are going to get
flagged by google and if the page is
affected or flagged by google then those
pages won't get indexed and so we want
to keep an eye on the mobile usability
report in google search console so
remember it's better to have a good site
architecture that bots can easily index
so bots will give preference to web
pages with relevant content and in the
end it will help your website rank
better and as a side note always use a
site map to make it easy for the bots to
crawl your website so we covered that
and on page as a reminder if i go back
to search console and if i click on site
maps i can go ahead and submit my
sitemap so if i created an xml version
of my sitemap called
sitemap.xml and i submit that basically
what i'm doing is i'm saying hey google
here's my sitemap file and in that
sitemap file are all the pages on my
website that want to get indexed and
when you submit your sitemap to google
basically they're going to
discover those urls and index those urls
in their search index and that expedites
the process of getting indexed it
expedites the process of getting found
on search and it expedites the process
of getting clicks on your search results
pages and and having that traffic go to
your website where they can enjoy the
user experience and convert and remember
the robot's text file is there to allow
google and other search engines to know
what pages to crawl so good website
architecture like for example amazon
they use breadcrumbs they have a
hierarchy in terms of of categories okay
so you can see how it's evenly dispersed
on the left side on the right side a
poor website architecture is very
slanted in one direction a lot of
internal links no breadcrumbs the
navigation isn't very clear so we want
to make sure things are simple and easy
so let's turn our attention to local seo
so local seo is for those businesses who
focus on a specific market it could be
a whole state like the state of florida
in the united states it could be a
specific city in a particular state like
orlando florida or miami it really
depends on the business and who you are
trying to attract and what geo location
you are trying to attract so if you're
trying to attract a segment of audience
in a specific location then local seo
should be in your sites uh for
optimization and so when we talk about
local seo we're really talking about
optimizing your website to get traffic
from a specific location so that's what
local seo is and the idea behind local
seo is to put your particular service or
product or whatever it is you're
offering to
that particular geo market that
particular locale or that city or that
state so you want to put yourself in
front of the right audience that's the
whole idea behind local seo and so if we
focus it on google you know local
results are based on three factors and
this is according to google so it's
based on a relevancy so if somebody's
looking for a plumber and you happen to
be a plumber in that particular locale
or city or zip code then chances of you
getting found are going to be great
because of relevancy and then distance
so where that person's located based on
your address or where you're located has
a role in how you display on local seo
and then prominence so prominence is
also very important because you know how
prominent are you as a business are you
getting a lot of reviews do you have a
lot of different locations do you have
all your photos and all your information
posted so prominence does play a bit of
factor along with distance along with
relevancy on google local seo so these
factors combine to help find the best
match for your search just somebody
typing in that plumber or say that
italian restaurant or
any particular product or service is
going to find local results and you want
to be there to to meet that person when
they're looking for your product or
service so that's the whole idea behind
local seo and so one of the factors with
local seo is having consistent nap or
not and so what is an ip it's really
name address and phone number so it
sounds very simple and it is simple you
just have to be consistent so if you
have a local seo presence on say bing
search engine you want to make sure that
the name address and phone number are
can also the same name and address and
phone number on google so it's just
about consistency so that's what we want
to do we want to make sure that we're
consistent across the board because it's
important for companies that want to
rank well have some consistency and it's
important too when we talk about
consistency to actually have that
information you need obviously the name
of your company you obviously need a
phone number and you need to put your
address in there but really of all three
the phone number's just as important
because we talk about local seo we
mentioned mobile earlier we know that a
lot of people initiate their search on
mobile and so if they're looking for a
local restaurant or local cafe or that
plumber and you appear in local seo then
your phone number's going to appear with
the results and that gives an
opportunity for somebody to go ahead and
just click on that number to call it
just makes it that much easier for
somebody to get in touch with you so
consistency and having all your
information are important factors for
local seo so having an inconsistent nap
if you will is not going to bode well
for you on the local seo results okay
it's important because it offers up
legitimate legitimacy it offers up
better rankings and at the end of the
day it's going to help you get those
calls it's going to help you get traffic
to your website so for example if a
particular company that sells puma
running shoes has a yellowpages.com
listing we want to be consistent if it's
on yellowpages.com
and this is their address on their
website then you need to be consistent
with that if it's inconsistent and we're
talking about very minor details but
these minor details are important simply
just putting rd as road and then
spelling out row is going to cause some
inconsistency so consistency is very
important why because local seo is also
tied to
mapping you know google maps and so
google wants to see consistency so that
they can offer up the address and the
mapping services so that's one good
reason why it needs to be consistent
another reason is again you know so many
may want to
uh drive to your location or call your
location or see if that location is
close to them so that's why consistency
is such a key component to local seo so
in order to get started on google for
local seo what you want to do is you
want to just do a search for google my
business so google my business is the
platform in which you're going to set up
your local business and once you set up
your google my business account
whatever that account is you want to
make sure you have all the credible
information in there i can't stress that
enough you need to have that phone
number you need to have that address it
needs to be consistent but with google
my business there's a lot of things you
can do here so you can manage reviews so
if you do have a location you can go
ahead and manage those reviews that
somebody puts in for your business and
so if it's a negative review you
definitely want to respond to that
negative review if it's a positive view
you definitely want to respond to that
positive review so you can manage
reviews you can upload photos so photos
is a big component as we talked about
with all tags and images you know having
these images help appear in the local
seo results you can manage a lot of
other things your information you can
manage posts you can offer promotions
there's a lot of things you could do you
could set your business hours so the
more information you put in to google my
business the more information is gonna
can be conveyed to the end user looking
for your products and services and
google my business even goes as far as
offering up the opportunity to have a
website so if you're a business that
doesn't even have your own website you
can create a website right in google my
business and so the end result is this
if somebody's looking for let's just say
lice removal
and orlando let's just say your child
comes home from school with some lice
you need services that offer up lice
removal well you're going to be able to
see businesses listed in the atlanta
region then offer up the service you're
looking for and if you're on a mobile
phone you can go ahead and quickly you
know call that person you can go to the
website you look at the reviews so local
seos are very important to local
businesses very important and so you
want to make sure you have consistent
presence not just on google but on bing
and some of these other local platforms
like yellowpages.com for example so
being prominent across multiple
platforms is going to put yourself in
front of the right audience who's
looking for your products and services
let's talk about how to measure your seo
performance so all that hard work you've
done with on-page seo
and coupled with all the work you've
done with off-page seo are eventually
gonna net results and positive results
and we want to be able to measure that
as you're actually doing the work as
you're putting forth the effort on on
page and off page and so we want to be
able to measure that and so
you want to be able to understand what
to measure and where to measure it and
so when we talk about seo we really want
to hone in on three high-level core
metrics and that's ranking traffic and
conversion so when we talk about ranking
traffic and conversion we can break that
down into this list here what kind of
traffic are we getting from organic
search what kind of traffic are we
getting from mobile devices remember
mobile is very important because as we
talked about with on-page seo as we
talked about with local seo a lot of
searches
start with mobile devices we want to
look at keyword ranking remember keyword
research is the first step in the
seo process even before we do any work
with on page and off page you know we
want to look at the local visibility if
we have local seo results we want to
look at engagement metrics so all that
traffic we're driving from organic
search we want to be able to measure how
they're performing and behaving on our
website we also want to measure some
form of progress on off page seo and
that's in the form of backlinks so all
of these are different metrics we can
measure using different tools so let's
talk about how to go about looking at
these metrics and where to go look at
them and measure them and so
really
monitoring all this behavior will help
us understand how we're performing how
seo is performing and so really what we
want to do is start with organic traffic
and so we can look at that on a
month-to-month basis we can look at it
from a geographic perspective we can
look at it in terms of how many new
visitors were driving versus returning
and then again more importantly
conversion rate and so to me the best
place to start to look at that traffic
from organic search is google analytics
and google analytics is a free tool it's
simply there to measure website
performance so if you go into google
analytics we can actually go in and we
can look at all sorts of data based on
website behavior and so if i'm in google
analytics and i go under acquisition and
then i go under all traffic channels
over a given period of time let's just
say the last seven days for a particular
website i can see what traffic is coming
from organic search and then i could see
the amount of new users that are coming
from organic search i can also see
engagement metrics bounce rate for
example so
i want to be able to see if somebody's
typing in a query clicking on our link
in the organic search results and then
coming to our website are they actually
engaging with their website or are they
leaving the website after only visiting
the page they landed on so that's all in
these are all important metrics to
measure and i can measure all that right
here in google analytics if i wanted to
i can even take it a step further and
break that down by country so if i type
in country as a secondary dimension now
i can see what country is driving
traffic from organic search so a lot of
your organic traffic information is
going to be centrally located in google
analytics so we also talked about mobile
traffic a majority of searches take
place on mobile phones versus desktop so
google basically is reporting that
nearly 60 of searches now appear from
mobile devices and so if we go back to
google analytics we can also look at a
mobile report so if i go in google
analytics under audience under mobile
overview i can see a breakdown of the
amount of traffic coming from desktop
versus tablet versus mobile and so
you'll find as time goes on that your
mobile device is likely going to drive a
majority of the traffic from organic
search and so you can compare device
information with channel so if i just
type in channel and google analytics as
a secondary dimension and look at the
default channel groupings versus device
category i could see that you know
mobile from organic search has driven
traffic over the last seven days this is
something you want to keep an eye on
because a lot of people tend to begin
their searches on mobile devices so
mobile ranking is different than desktop
ranking because with mobile ranking it's
based on a responsive website and with
that responsive website basically
responsive being that the website's
going to adapt to the mobile device so
it's going to respond to the device that
somebody's on and so therefore the
metrics or the engagement metrics are
going to be different but if i look back
to google analytics i can see again
bounce rate i can see pages per session
average session duration so if i look at
line three i could see all the different
engagement metrics compared to those
metrics from other devices and other
channels okay so you want to be able to
do a comparison because if behavior is
not up to par engagement is not the part
on mobile then you want to do something
about that so you want to hone in on
mobile traffic specifically from organic
search because the behavior is going to
be different you know people start their
searches on mobile the site's going to
be different and so therefore it's a
different experience altogether so make
sure you track the behavior and more
importantly make sure you track that
page speed so earlier we talked about
on-page seo when we honed in on page
speed so just as a reminder if i'm back
in analytics and i go back under
behavior then if i go to site speed then
if i go to overview i'll be able to see
the average page load time on my website
i can also look at specific page timings
and i should be able to see that by
device so if i type in device category
i'm going to be able to see how each
page loads per device and so this allows
me to understand which pages are loading
fast which pages are not loading as fast
and address those pages accordingly to
improve engagement metrics so we want to
keep an eye on page speed as well as
overall user behavior from mobile
devices you can also use other tools
that are out there like agency analytics
there are plenty of tools out there i
tend to use google analytics because
primarily it's free and google analytics
is a google product so it works with
other google platforms like google
search console we want to keep an eye on
ranking so remember when we do our
keyword research we're choosing keywords
that have high relevancy high volume and
low competition so we want to be able to
track keywords that we choose that have
high relevancy high volume and low
competition and so the tool we use or at
least i recommend using is moz so i
mentioned moz earlier with on page and
off page seo so if we go into moz and we
know what keywords we're trying to rank
for we can go ahead and add them to mods
and what moz does is they actually track
where these keywords rank and so if i go
into mods and i click on rankings i'll
be able to see on a weekly basis or a
monthly basis how our keywords are
ranking and for what pages they're
ranking so for whatever keyword i choose
to to optimize for i want to make sure i
put those keywords in moz because when i
put them in moz moz is going to on a
weekly basis tell me where these
keywords rank and for what url they're
ranked for
so that way i can keep an eye on ranking
over time because in theory the higher
you rank the more traffic you're going
to get and so we want to be able to see
the trend in which keywords rank okay so
if i click on a particular keyword and
moz it's going to give me over a period
of time where that keyword is ranked be
able to see improvement in ranking for
particular keyword the whole idea behind
seo is to choose keywords that are
relevant optimize for those keywords so
that you can be ranked for those
keywords in order to get the traffic and
conversions so moz is a good platform
that helps us monitor rankings for
particular keywords now if you don't
want to use moz as an alternative you
can turn your attention to google search
console and so remember we talked about
google search console earlier when we
talked about sitemaps we also talked
about mobile usability with search
console we also talked about links to
your site with google search console so
google search console is a good tool to
help you understand how you're
performing with organic search and so
there's one tool in particular which is
performance that helps us understand
what keyword queries people are actually
typing into google search and so here i
can see the actual query and so with
this particular website valleyfig.com i
can see that dried fig recipes over the
course of the last three months had
5414 impressions that means that one of
my pages either one or multiple pages
appeared in google search engine results
5414 times and over the course of those
5414 impressions i received 1100 clicks
so google search console is going to be
able to tell me not only you know how
many impressions i received for a
particular keyword but they also are
going to tell me how many clicks and if
i wanted to add more metrics to that i
can add them like the average ranking
position for keyword the click-through
rate so i can add multiple metrics to
this report to give me an understanding
of hey are any of my targeted keywords
being used or queried and if they are
where am i ranking and i am i showing up
and am i getting clicks so search
console serves as a good alternative if
not primary tool or platform for you to
measure how your organic search results
are showing so for local visibility this
metric is important for
you know maintaining local seo so
remember on the local seo we talked
about uh google my business so if i go
back to google my business i can go into
my account and so google my business is
going to be able to show me some metrics
so if i go into google my business and
click on insights i'm going to be able
to see
a number of different metrics over the
course of a month i can see exactly you
know what queries were used by how many
users and when i appeared so i'll be
able to see how many views i receive not
only on search results but on maps then
i can also see what actions people took
when they saw my results in maps or in
search did they visit my website did
they request directions did they call so
i can actually see engagement metrics
right in google my business i could see
a breakout by zip code i could see phone
calls by day of the week i could see how
many people even viewed my photos so
there's a lot of insights into
local seo on google my business so that
gives you an idea of how you're
performing organically on local search
and remember you want to be able to use
google my business to hone in on your
specific audience so all these metrics
help you align with whether you're
getting in front of the right audience
and whether that audience is actually
behaving the way you want them to
meaning you know are they actually
contacting you are they going to your
website are they calling you so local
visibility and understanding the metrics
involve the local seo is very important
so google my business is where you want
to turn your attention so overall
engagement metrics are important they
play an important role in determining
rankings for example we talked about
bounce rate to bounce rate is the rate
at which people go from organic search
to your website
and then leave after uh seeing one page
and not going any further so if they
land on a page and then leave the
website after landing on that page it's
considered a bounce and so bounce or
bounce rate is a good indication of how
people are receiving our website or the
content that they're reading on our
website there are other metrics involved
like average session duration or pages
per visit all of these are engagement
metrics and let's not forget about page
speed so page speed is also a good
engagement metric all of these metrics
affect or determine rankings so we want
to be able to make sure that if we're in
google analytics and we're looking at
engagement metrics that our metrics are
good because if somebody comes to our
website from organic search and there's
a high bounce rate then what does that
tell us that there's a disconnect
between what that person's querying and
then the content that they're reading
and so we want to be able to address
those engagement metrics so that we can
continue to not only drive quality
traffic but keep the traffic engaged and
then in turn drive up conversions last
metric we want to look at is backlinks
so content having more backlinks from
good domains will effectively improve
your seo performance we talked about
backlinks with off-page seo and remember
quality over quantity and so we can
measure backlinks going back into moz we
can use moz's link explorer tool so
remember if i type in a domain valley
fig i can get some metrics related
off-page seo including my domain
authority but more importantly i can see
what links are pointing to my site in
this case valleyfig.com so i can see
their 575 link domains i can see there
are 7 900 inbound links and so just by
clicking on that i can get an idea of
the types of websites that are linking
to my site and their domain authority
and their spam score google search
console so if you go back into search
console you can also just click on links
and we should be able to get an idea of
you know what websites are linking to
our site and more importantly we want to
be able to see not only what sites but
what pages they're linked to remember we
want our backlinks pointing to interior
pages not necessarily the home page so
here i can see the top link page for
valleyfig.com is slash recipes so we
want links pointing to our interior
pages not necessarily the home page
that's what's going to help your
performance your rankings for all your
pages not just your home page so having
quality back links pointing to interior
pages help boost the domain authority
and the page authority for that
particular page so again using moz link
explorer tool or using the links report
and search console are good sources for
you to
identify backlinks so when we look at
these these reports we want to look at
the domain authority of these sites that
are linking ours the number of outbound
links to the site or specific pages on
our site we want to be able to look at
the ratio of link distribution you know
we want to be able to look at how many
follows and nofollow so most of this if
not all of these metrics are in moz so
if i go back to moz i can actually see
you know which one's pointing which ones
are followed the total quality of the
link that's pointing to our site again
bam so moz link explorer report tends to
give us all the information we need in
order to measure and get a sense of our
backlinks that help us with off-page seo
so there are other tools out there
there's ahrefs again search console
there's other seo platforms out there
that'll help you measure backlinks okay
now that we covered everything with
on-page seo and off-page seo and really
everything seo in general let's take a
little quiz and if you could go ahead
and just put your answers in the
comments section below so
just a little quiz here and we'll start
out with question one which the
following type of site map is
specifically designed for search spiders
so the answer is either a html sitemap
or b xml sitemap so go ahead and put
your answers in the comment section
below i'll give you just another second
to think about that okay another
question for you from a search engine
perspective which of the following link
types could cause a negative effect on
your rankings it's either a purchase
link or b no follow link so again if you
could if you know the answer or just
take an educated guess go ahead and put
the answers in the comment section below
okay next question a website's
text file serves what function is it a
tell the bots what pages should be
crawled and not crawled or b tells the
bots what links should be follow and no
follow so if you know the answer you
feel good about your answer go ahead and
put it in the comments section below
today we're going to talk about seo tips
and tricks so let's get started and
throughout this series we're going to
have a few tips to share with you and
we'll start out with tip number one opt
for smarter ways to do keyword research
and so
if you listen to any of our seo
tutorials in the past you know that
keyword research is the first step but
the most crucial step in starting seo so
when we do keyword research we want to
be able to
basically find keywords that we feel are
relevant to our business that we want to
be found on search for and so here are a
few tips that can help you do that
research in a more efficient manner the
first thing we want to do is identify a
list of keywords that are relevant so we
only want to focus on relevant keywords
for our business that's a given so what
i would suggest is as a best practice
maybe you know put down some of those
keywords in a spreadsheet so think of
them as a theme of keywords because when
you do research you're going to want to
include a theme of keywords related to
one another so you can pick the best
ones out of that theme and so as an
example
if we have a company that sells dry figs
in a spreadsheet as an example if i show
you a spreadsheet maybe we want to focus
in on just dried fig and maybe we want
to focus on dried fig recipes so go
ahead and put those in a column you know
some of these keywords that you know you
want to be found for so that's really
the first step they need to be relevant
so put them in a spreadsheet so that you
can build keywords around that list then
we want to choose keywords and when we
choose keywords we want to have some
criteria around choosing them and so we
always want to choose keywords with a
lot of volume and what i mean by volume
i mean how many people on average type
in that keyword or a related keyword per
month the second criteria is the keyword
a product fit meaning you know is the
keyword relevant you always want to stay
true to relevancy the third is
commercial intent what is the intent of
the keyword is it trying to get us a
sale is it answering a question so what
is the intent of that keyword and then
last it's difficulty so we want to
definitely take a look at how difficult
a keyword is to rank for on organic
search so that's some of the criteria
you may have some additional criteria
that you want to use but this is the
criteria basically for choosing keywords
so again we want to prefer keywords with
high volume you want to be careful of
seasonality so remember seasonality in
this example christmas tree you're only
gonna have a spike you know during the
winter or excuse me the october november
december months so be careful of
seasonality when choosing high volume
keywords and again keywords that are
relevant to your product even though it
doesn't have much search volume
relevancy always trumps uh volume or any
other metric commercial intent so we
want to
look at keywords that for example have
buy in them they may have low search
volume but if somebody's typing in that
keyword then we can insinuate that the
consumer who typed in that keyword is
ready to make the purchase so we want to
look at what the intent is of that
keyword and then again the difficulty
always opt for keywords that have low
difficulty or competition and so in
order to get these metrics we can use
third-party tools i'm going to show you
a couple of examples of third-party
tools you can use that will give you
some of this information so the first
tool i'm going to show you is google ads
keyword planner so if i'm having a
google ads account i could simply go to
tools and then choose the keyword
planner and from there i want to find
new keywords so if i choose the keyword
dried figs because that's the keyword i
put in my spreadsheet that i'm
interested in optimizing for and then
maybe drive fake recipes that was the
other keyword theme
so if i enter those two keywords in just
to begin with basically what google is
going to give me is the average search
monthly volume so here i can see dried
figs i have an average monthly search
volume 8 100. that means on average over
the last 12 months that's how many
people have typed in that keyword here i
can see a little bit of a trend i just
hover my mouse over that graph i could
see again for seasonality impact if
there is any seasonality what the volume
is on average per month then i can see
the competition is high and because this
is google ads because it's paid search
they're going to give me a sense or an
idea of what i should be bidding on that
keyword now that's another topic for
another day but it's good information to
have because if you're not ranking for a
keyword you could decide to bid on it
for paid search so don't discard the
bidding information go ahead and put it
in a spreadsheet for later use but for
now we're focused in on keywords that
are relevant how much volume how much
competition okay so once i get this
information here i can simply go back to
my spreadsheet and put that information
in there what's the volume for dried fig
what is the competition now for
competition notice that google ads gives
us a high or low now if we're trying to
measure
ratio between volume and competition we
want to get an actual sense of what that
competition is so what i always do as a
best practice is go into google search
if i go to google search and i type in
dried figs
i'm gonna see the actual volume is 34
million five hundred thousand so i can
see that's the actual search volume for
this particular keyword however if i add
a syntax called all in title before that
keyword with a colon space and then hit
enter then i could see the actual
volume reduces to 31 000 and basically
what this tells me is that 31 000
listings or results have the keyword
dried figs in the title tag so if a web
page has dried fig our targeted keyword
in the title tag then ideally we can
insinuate that that page is trying to
rank for that keyword so therefore in
order for us to rank number one on
google we have to jump over 31 000
results so we want to be able to include
this information into our keyword
analysis so if i go into our keyword
analysis here and i
go ahead and enter in that information
so what's my keyword my keyword is dried
figs
okay my volume was 8100 my competition
was 31 000 and so that gives me a ratio
of 81 divided by 31 000 if i make that
into a percentage basically 26
so that's my keyword effectiveness index
or kei or ratio between volume and
competition and so that's a way that you
can
gather information is by using google
ads enter the information into a
spreadsheet and then sort all your data
by kei you could sort it by volume you
could sort it by competition all these
metrics matter alternatively as another
tool you can use moz so moz has a
keyword explore tool okay so if i type
in the keyword dried figs i'm focusing
on the united states i could see that
moz says hey look there's anywhere
between 4 300 and 6 500 in terms of
volume out of 100 the difficulty is 41
and so i can expect a click-through rate
of you know 41
and so basically the great thing about
moz's keyword explorer tool is i can
also look at the search analysis search
engine results pages what serp stands
for and i can analyze the serp for a
particular keyword in moz so i want to
be able to understand what my
competition is doing so here i can see
if i really want to try and optimize for
that keyword
i could see what the other pages are
ranked for that keyword and then on page
one i can also
see what local results show up for that
keyword so here i can see that we have a
number of different sites listed here so
if we want to be number one these are
the sites that are basically above us
that we need to
climb over to be number one on google so
i find that the keyword explorer tool in
moz is very helpful for understanding
your competition as well as getting a
alternative check on volume and
competition or difficulty if you will
and so remember we want to identify a
list of keywords that are relevant i
can't stress that enough we want to
choose keywords based on difficulty we
want to choose keywords based on volume
on commercial intent and more important
relevancy we can also identify trends
from a site search query like amazon and
know what your competitors are ranking
for so we can also go back into moz and
we can see just by typing in some of the
keywords we're focusing on we can see if
our competitors are ranking for the same
keywords just by using that keyword
explorer tool and then another thing we
want to look at is lsi or latent
semantic indexing so that's a fancy word
which basically means we want to find
keywords related to the topic of the
page you're trying to optimize so if
there are other keywords on that page
then you could sway in that direction
and so when it comes to choosing
keywords you want to choose always a
primary and secondary keyword and so if
we go back to our spreadsheet it doesn't
necessarily always have to be just one
keyword it doesn't necessarily have to
be dried figs we could choose another
keyword that has a good volume to
competition ratio so we want to choose
keywords that are always relevant and if
we're analyzing nothing but relevant
keywords then we want to be able to
choose keywords that have a good ratio
between volume and competition so you
always want to choose at least two
keywords per page we can also stay up to
date on industry news as we'll help you
learn new jargon so it doesn't hurt to
subscribe to sites like search engine
watch or search engine land they have
lots of good tips so here i'll show you
what that one of those sites look like
if i simply just go to search engine
watch dot com i find this is a good
resource to stay up on the latest news
when it comes to search engines here we
could see
why seo and front-end developers are the
perfect search marketing team another
article about optimizing your channel
youtube channel five easy steps so
there's a lot of information here on
search engine watch that pertain to seo
and keyword research we could also look
at other third-party sites like
wikipedia reddit and core for example so
if i go to quora i can do a search for
dried figs and i could see what's being
written about that topic so that should
give me some ideas to build a keyword a
list around so for example the health
benefits of dried figs okay are dry figs
safe for diabetes best ways to eat dry
figs so those are all good keyword
themes that we could build a keyword
list around and i did that simply just
by typing in dried figs on core so
that's a a good tip for you to leverage
when you're trying to build out a
keyword list okay let's uh talk about
tip number two which is publish high
quality content to get more traffic to
your website so
it's all about content so we've already
done the keyword research we still need
to
kind of merge the two when we talk about
merging the two it's not just building
content around those keywords it's much
more than that when it comes to seo and
so that's why we always talk about high
quality content so let's talk about some
of the tips that can help you create
high quality content so
first tip is we want to be able to
publish longer and engaging content
longer and engaging content tends to
rank higher in google why because you
have more content to work with and when
you have more content to work with you
can optimize it you can structure it you
can insert different assets like videos
and images and by keeping it long you're
gonna likely keep it engaging and so
google tends to lean in favor of content
that is well organized structured and
long because it is more likely to be
engaging for the end user we definitely
want to include those target keywords so
you want to be able to
you know insert those keywords into
those meta tag descriptions into those
title tags into those alt tags but you
want to work them in naturally you don't
want to force anything content should be
naturally written because if it's
naturally written it's going to be
engaging so we want to use lsi keywords
in the content so lsi or
basically latent semantic indexing
basically just means different terms and
concepts related to your target keywords
so feel free to use terms that are
similar to what you're currently using
these keywords can definitely be used
for seo because they create more
visibility and potentially higher
rankings because it gives you an
opportunity to use keywords that are
natural and work for different
variations and let's look at example so
if you're optimizing an e-commerce
category page and your keyword is one
mix used for men so we want to use
keywords closely related to one mix used
for men for example running shoes for
men or sport running shoes for men
outdoor sport shoes or air cushion shoes
let's take a look an example of amazon
so if i go to amazon i could see the one
mix shoes for men page and if i look at
this page i can see a lot of product and
each product has basically some content
associated with it i.e the title of the
particular product and so you want to be
able to
use different descriptors for this
particular product for example men's
running shoes or breathable lightweight
gym sport shoes or lightweight casual
sneakers or walking casual sneaker all
of these are lsi related keywords
they're similar to what we're trying to
optimize for so you don't necessarily
always have to be brand heavy or stick
with one keyword you could definitely
show variation especially on the
e-commerce side if you're dealing with
different products so we want to make
the content readable with the help of
visuals subtitles and bullet points so
if you're e-commerce you want to make
sure that page is laid out properly easy
to read you hear i could see the
descriptor along with the title all kind
of merge together and so there's no
breakout of okay this is the product
name this description it's kind of one
all-in-one which i like it just makes it
more natural sounding okay and you can
see these are all broken out uh pretty
well laid out paige and amazon is more
or less you know consistent in terms of
how their pages are laid out so make it
readable add visuals add subtitles add
bullet points it helps break out a lot
of the content especially if you have a
long amount of content or a large amount
of content so the use of subtitles
bullet points and visuals will help
break it out structure it and make it
more engaging for the end user you
definitely want to write an effective
and organized content in order to reduce
the bounce rate so there is correlation
between engagement and bounce rate the
more you structure the more you add
visuals the more you add subtitles the
more engaged somebody's gonna be the
less likely they are to bounce from the
pitch we also want to share customer
reviews and ratings so
if you have a web page you sell products
even if you don't sell products it's
always good to have testimonials or some
type of customer review so if we go back
to our example
on amazon and we clicked on a product uh
one of the running shoe products we look
here we can see the image we could see
kind of the description well i may not
be so interested in buying this product
i want to know a little bit more about
it well that's where the breaking point
comes in that's where the decision
factor comes in where if i read other
reviews then i can possibly have my mind
made up to buy this product so here i
could see that not only there were
reviews but there's testimonials so i
could see that here you can see that
there's a lot of stars and you can see
the kind of the review title these
running shoes are very comfortable and
lightweight so you have a lot of
different feedback and so reading
customer reviews is always helpful
because even though you're making the
decision it kind of will help sway you
in one direction or another at least it
does for me so that's the the beauty of
a customer review and a rating we want
to be able to use those to our advantage
and then you want to be able to update
your content on a regular basis so and
that goes for testimonials and reviews
you want to make sure you're always
getting reviews if you're always getting
reviews then that's just adding to the
particular product and so if you're
always updating your content on a
regular basis as well then google's
going to be able to see that and google
likes fresh content okay we also want to
include the benefits of the product so
if you're selling a product any product
you always want to include the benefits
you want to do as much as you can to
make your product engaging to the end
user enticing so that they can buy it so
in addition to customer reviews or
adding content about the product you
want to include benefits so if we go
back to amazon here we can see amazon
lists a lot of the benefits or one mix
in this case lists a lot of the benefits
so here you can see
all the descriptors about the particular
product it's got rubber sole it's got a
breathable textile lining you get free
high quality socks with every shoe so
these are some of the features and if we
continue to scroll down we could see
some of the details about the fabric
type specifics about the fabric and a
lot of information on this product page
even a sizing chart so a lot of
different features that will help the
end user make the decision so don't hold
back add as much information as you
possibly can as much information as you
have available it doesn't hurt because
in the end what you're trying to do from
a product perspective is sell the
product and you can't really sell it
unless you have information that's going
to convince the user that this product
is what they want to buy so include the
warranty size recommendation return
policy and some offers so it should all
be listed on the page easy for the end
user to see so can't stress it enough
provide as much
product information as possible go back
here here it has a sizing chart what
colors are available again some of the
descriptors if i scroll down here i can
see
some more of the benefits you know
waffle rubber outsole soft deodorant
insole again fabric type it's got all
sorts of information it's got images
about the fabric itself the shoe itself
how it's structured so a lot of
information about this and it even does
a comparison and so there's a lot of
information about this particular
product so don't hold back add as much
as you can to convince the end user so
in the case of the one mix on amazon
you know they had a sizing chart you
know they had an faq being additional
information what other products that
customers view from one mix and then
testimonials so these are some of the
basic bits of information you want to
add on your page if you don't have
customer reviews it's okay add faq in
its place again the end result is to
convince the customer to purchase the
product and then build a comprehensive
internal linking structure of web pages
so every product page should link to
similar products so if i go back here
here i can see other products from one
mix so you should always have a linking
structure so that if the end user
doesn't want to particularly buy that
particular product then you have links
available so they can go to another page
and then add different varieties and
related short videos of the product so
if we go back to our product page you
know they have different varieties that
they're showcasing here they have the
size chart they even have a size
convertible chart so if you're dealing
with metrics you can go over to us
metrics feet vice versa you can add a
video you know show a video of if you're
selling running shoes throw a video
somebody working out you know it doesn't
have to be a full-blown commercial per
se but it could be a short 30-second
video of what the shoe looks like on
somebody else's feet so that they could
see somebody walking with those shoes on
so video doesn't have to be a big
production you can do it right from your
phone so review your content before you
publish this goes without saying you
want to do that just you make sure you
include everything possible because when
the content does get published remember
google is going to index that content
when they index it it's going to show up
in the search results so we want to make
sure we have all the information readily
available not only for the end user but
for google as well we want to be able to
analyze our meta tags in url to improve
click-through rates so this is important
because the meta tags i.e the title tag
in the meta description and the urls
what shows up in google search results
so we have title tags but first that's
the first important element that's what
shows up in the search results so what
we want to do is we want to optimize the
title tag and when we optimize it we
want to use modifiers and when i say
modifiers i mean you know feel free to
use the word best or cash back or free
shipping or discount so for example if
you're selling running shoes 25 best
sneakers or up to 70 off or free
shipping or buy shoes on discount very
action oriented but you know it includes
these modifiers that are going to help
somebody click on that link so
some tips for optimizing the title tag
in addition to modifiers we want to
watch the title length and we want to
include those target keywords in the
title tag so remember you're likely
going to have two keywords to work with
you want to have at least one of those
keywords in your title tag so with the
modifier you know up to 60 to 65
characters in length with that targeted
keyword should get you a good title tag
that's going to get somebody to click on
it so let's look at an example so if i
type in the keyword best recipes for
dried figs you know here i could scroll
down here's my title tag stands out my
url is right underneath that and
underneath the url are is the meta
description and so here i can see some
modifiers 188 best autumn dried fake
recipes or 25 fantastic fig recipes or
10 best cooking dried fig recipes so
these are all modifiers they're going to
help somebody get the click get them to
click on your link and go to your
website so when you don't hit the 65
character limit if you go over that
google's going to cut off the title text
so we want to avoid that at all possible
so the whole idea is you know like 10
best cooking dried fake recipes by emily
that's a good enticing title tag okay
takes into account a modifier includes
the targeted keyword and is under the 65
character count some additional tips for
writing meta description we always want
to provide a unique description for each
web page of the website so no duplicate
meta tag descriptions every page use
needs to be unique then we also want to
be specific about what we're offering so
if you have say you're selling
headphones and you have a particular set
of headphones from a different specific
brand include that in the meta
description if you have that particular
product from that brand on sale include
that in the meta description so you want
to be as specific as possible the whole
idea behind a meta description is to
describe the page but also to get the
end user to click on your link so here's
an example of using modifiers and
describing a page if we look at amazon
again we can see this example here and
if we look at it on google search
results so if i type in amazon bluetooth
headsets ten dollars are on sale here we
can see a lot of amazon listings in
google search here you can see the use
of modifiers in the title tag and also
in the meta description here we could
see that you know this particular
headset bluetooth headset is on sale 50
off so if something's on sale feel free
to include it be descriptive about the
page let people know where they're going
and use those modifiers don't be afraid
to use numbers in the meta description
even if it's the price itself even if
it's not on sale but it is the price
included it's not going to hurt the more
information you can include in a meta
description the better chance you have
of somebody clicking on that link use
numbers symbols you know percentages off
always help use catchy words like
discount or cashback you're competing
with other listings on the page so if
you have something on sale if it's on
clearance list that it's on clearance
here i can see they even included the
coupon code so feel free to list as much
specific information about that page as
possible the whole idea is you're
competing with your own web pages but in
other cases with competitors so the meta
description along with the title tag and
the url helps separate out you from the
rest of the listings on search engine
results and we don't want to keyword
stuff we want to keep it within 160
something characters or
65 characters because google will break
off the meta description just like they
do with the title tag and so we want
clean natural written meta descriptions
that separate you from the competition
so that means including the keywords but
making sure those keywords are naturally
included in the meta description so if i
go back again to valleyfig.com and i
could see the meta description hey
welcome to the best resource online for
dried fake recipes savory is sweet
snacks are healthy dried food recipes
we've got it all okay start cooking with
figs and so it's natural sounding it
does include the keyword it's not
keyword stuffing it's natural sounding
that's hopefully going to get that
person to click on this particular
website let's turn our attention to the
url so we want to make sure that the url
is basically taken into account best
practices so if we take a look at this
particular url here it doesn't
necessarily look as attractive as we
would like so
first of all i don't understand some of
it so that makes it unpleasant boring
and messy to say the least so you want
urls that you know basically are clean
and understandable so in other words we
want to make them seo friendly because
if they're seo friendly somebody
understands the url
then they're likely going to click on it
so the old rule of thumb is if you can
read the url then the search engines can
read the url so here are some tips for
creating friendly urls for seo make it
readable you want to include the target
keyword in the url so if it's dried figs
the oral should include dried figs if
it's dried fig recipes make sure it's
dried fig recipes now avoid using too
many subdirectories in the urls so we
want to keep it as close as possible to
the root directory and match the urls to
titles most of the time so let's go back
to our example here here we can see this
is valleyfig.com recipes not necessarily
dried fig recipes but recipes
nonetheless it's in the root directory
okay so at all cost now this is in some
cases unavoidable given that you may be
dealing with an e-commerce website
that's calling you know content from a
database so if that is the case you're
gonna have some dynamic parameters in
the url which is fine just make sure you
avoid having too many of those dynamic
parameters it's understandable that
parameters but the role of dom generally
is no more than two different parameters
in the url so prefer to create short
urls that's really the way to go the
shorter the better is the rule of thumb
and you know if you're going to break up
the url then use hyphens instead of
underscores it's just cleaner it's a
more understandable search engines tend
to read it a little bit easier if it's
hyphen so here's what a friendly url
looks like for
search you got your domain you got a
subcategory broken up with a hyphen and
then the product so that's just a clean
url for a particular ecommerce site that
has categories and subcategories so
again we got amazon.com your category
can be electronics your subcategory
could be earphones and your product
could be both earphones it's that simple
let's start with talking about rich
snippets this is tip number four so we
want to add rich snippets to improve
your website's visibility on serps so
tip number four is all about rich
snippets so let's start out by asking
ourselves what is a rich snippet so rich
snippet is simply just a term used to
describe structured data markup that you
as a website owner can add to your html
so hypertext markup language or html is
what is basically constructs a page if
we can add more information to that that
will in turn allow search engines like
google to better understand the
information that's on that web page so
the more google understands about that
web page the more they can put into the
search engine results page so rich
snippets is basically some structured
data markup that we can add to our
existing html and so if we want to add
rich snippets to search engines then how
would you prefer your products to be
displayed well if we have products then
we want to make sure that maybe we have
reviews or maybe we have so um other
information in there like
links to our site okay so there's a lot
of different types of rich snippets that
you know we can add that google can
recognize and add to the search engine
results so if you have a product then
there's a lot of things we can add like
specifically product reviews so we want
to be able to add more information to
the search engine results by working in
some rich snippets so basically the
whole idea is to set up the rich snippet
to drive targeted traffic okay so
because the more information in the serp
the more likelihood you're going to get
the click and the more likelihood that
click is specific traffic so some of the
benefits of structuring the data for
rich snippets are as i mentioned
increasing click-through rates you know
also increasing conversion rates so when
you get the traffic from organic search
to your website if somebody's looking
for specific product and you have a
number of different good reviews showing
up let's just say five stars out of five
stars and you have 100 reviews showing 5
stars then you know somebody's probably
going to send take some trust in your
brand and your conversion rate
probability is going to go higher it
also helps improve your search engine
visibility because you're adding more
information so in other words the more
google knows about your page the
likelihood it's going to rank that page
and it's more likely that that
information that's contained in that
rich snippet is going to get featured in
either the knowledge graph which is that
graph on the right side or in a featured
snippet which usually shows up at the
top of search engine results so in other
words the more information you give
google the more they can use that
information on their search results page
and there's no disagreeing that the more
information that you have in your search
engine result the likelihood of getting
more traffic increases so for rich
snippets you could always start with
images so some of the common properties
that you can add to your product page if
you have a product pages the page itself
is an image you can always start there
you can always add a description you can
always add in ratings and you can always
add in reviews so these are some of the
most common attributes you can add as a
rich snippet so if you add that google
picks it up it's going to include that
information in the search results okay
some others are offers prices
site links links to your site and
product availability so all that
information can be conveyed to google
google understands what you're trying to
pass along it's going to include that in
the search results so did you know that
according to ahrefs over
99.58 of featured pages that have
structured data already rank in the top
10 list of the google search results
page so in other words if you have rich
snippets in your page your chances of
ranking in the top 10 of a google result
is going to be very very very good okay
let's talk about tip number five
optimize your site structure for great
user experience so let's go over some of
the tips that you would do for planning
a good website for seo and so tip number
one
is you want a url structure that follows
your site's navigation hierarchy so
obviously home page interior pages so
depending on what type of site you have
obviously the navigation needs to follow
that site's navigation that's site
hierarchy and it all starts with the
home page you want to optimize your
homepage to drive traffic to your
product pages so the home page is
nothing more than a doorway into your
website and so the site's navigation
should link to all those different
products so if you have an ecommerce
site with sub categories or categories
subcategories then you want to be able
to
make sure your navigation reflects that
you want to build a comprehensive
structure for internal linking as well
because when you're from the home page
obviously you want to be able to easily
navigate to other pages however when
you're on other pages you want to be
able to have a link pointing back to
relevant pages and not necessarily on
the home page so this serves two
purposes one for the end user obviously
you want the end user to navigate
through your website seamlessly right
second for the search engines they're
following links they want to be able to
understand how your website flows and
links together so you don't want a
scenario where it's a one-way street
from the home page to interior pages you
want basically a home page to interior
interior to other relevant interior
pages and that could be a lateral or
that could be a situation where it's a
hierarchy for example home page category
subcategories sub-sub category etc you
want to be able to make sure your site
is constructed in a manner in which the
search engine can read it so css or
cascading style sheets or hypertext
markup language html are your two most
common languages that's basically what
browsers load that's what search engines
like to index it just makes it easy for
them to understand what your page is all
about remember we talked about rich
snippets in the previous tip rich
snippets are nothing more than
supplemental html to describe what the
page is all about so that the search
engines can understand that page and
include reviews or include site links in
the search engine results so this is all
based on html so the more you provide
the search engines in a more structured
manner via html the more the search
engines are going to stay on the page
adding breadcrumbs to your product pages
is also a good practice if you have an
e-commerce site and you have a category
then a sub-category then a
sub-sub-category then a product page
well it's probably not a bad idea to
make sure you have a breadcrumb so that
was that way somebody can easily go
right back from the product page to say
the category page or to the subcategory
page directly without having to hit the
back button or having to go through the
navigation some good examples i think
amazon is a good example of using
breadcrumbs giving the amount of
products they have on their site so go
check out amazon if you want a good
example for breadcrumbs and then
canonical tags we want to make good use
of canonical tags and that's in order to
avoid duplicate content so a canonical
tag is nothing more than a link element
basically or an html element that
basically prevents duplicate content
issues so in other words if we have a
canonical tag as a meta tag basically
we're telling the search engines this is
the preferred or canonical version of a
web page so use this web page so it
signals to the search engines which page
they should basically index and pay
attention to and avoid at all the other
pages that have similar content so
that's the idea behind a canonical tag
so that's a good best practice and then
optimize your site for desktop and
mobile i can't stress the mobile part
enough most users begin their journey on
mobile so
if you're not sure about
what the search engines like or don't
like you can always refer to google
search console for an example so if you
go to google search console they have a
report called mobile usability so if you
click on mobile usability you can see
what pages they like what pages they
don't like from a mobile perspective and
if you have errors they're going to tell
you what those errors are so if your
website has text that's too small to
read they're going to tell you that
these are the pages with this error and
so that allows you to go and address
those errors because from a google
perspective if you have if a page has a
mobile usability error then google will
not index that page so leverage google
search console to get a sense of what
type of errors your site has from a
mobile perspective you also want to
prefer to keep your checkout page simple
so again from an e-commerce perspective
you want to keep the checkout page as
simple as possible for obvious reasons
you want the end user to have a good
experience and you obviously want the
conversion so when i say keep a checkout
page simple really now with today's
technology you can create a one-page
checkout process you want to optimize
your sitemap so when we talk about
sitemaps we want to make sure that it's
a file and xml file that basically
includes all of our urls and we can then
turn around and give that site map to
the search engines so if you have a
sitemap in xml make sure you go to
google search console so if i go to
google search console and i click on
site maps i can just simply just tell
google where my site map is located and
when they recognize that sitemap they're
going to be able to basically index the
urls from that assignment so we can see
here how many urls they discover and how
many they index so make sure you create
the sitemap in an xml format submit the
sitemap via google search console and
then you can go back and see how many
pages they've indexed versus how many
you've submitted and you want to make
sure that sitemap is dynamic meaning
anytime you publish a url that url is
added to the sitemap fixing broken links
so broken links is not something you
want but it's something every website
has it's unavoidable you know people
publish pages all the time there's test
pages there's all sorts of reasons why
a site has broken links you want to be
able to address those and again going
back to google search console we can
basically see just by looking at some
reports what pages have broken links and
which ones don't so we could certainly
look at search console to get
information about basically what pages
are broken which ones aren't and then we
want to prefer predictive searches and
integrate product typographic errors on
your search bar so basically have a
search bar that's a best practice but
anticipate knowing what people are
typing in so that means maybe going into
google analytics and looking at the
search terms report so we can go into
analytics and look at search terms to
get a sense of what people are searching
for but you know when we talk about
integrating product typographic errors
we're talking also about fonts so we
want to make sure we're using the latest
fonts so that we don't run in any issues
on our website uh people not being able
to read based on a specific font that
you're using and then as a best practice
what i found and this is not necessarily
for everyone but using a live chat
widget sometimes helps in fact i would
even go beyond sometimes um most the
time again depending on your business
but i see most businesses now have live
chat enabled and so basically
having live chat enables somebody who
has a question to immediately reach out
to somebody versus picking up the phone
versus sending an email it's just
instantaneous gratification in some ways
so inserting live chat on a website is
more common practice than not nowadays
given it it lends to a better user
experience tip number six improve your
page speed and reduce the bounce rate so
let's talk about page speed and how page
speed correlates with higher bounce rate
if it's a high page load and so
according to crazy page speed is an
important overlooked seo tactic because
for every second delay and page load can
result in
fewer page views sixty percent decrease
in customer satisfaction
seven percent decline in conversion rate
so you know you can see here regardless
of how specific the numbers are when you
have a page that loads slow you're going
to have lower user engagement and a poor
user experience so you have to pay
attention to page speed and so since
2010 google has been using page speed as
a factor for page ranking in the search
engine results so here's some tips to
focus on making sure your pages are
optimal in terms of speed so
enable browser caching okay you can
reduce plugins if you're using wordpress
as an example you know disable plugins
you're not using getting using a simple
website design going back to tip number
five stick with css and html don't do
anything fancy in terms of technology
because it's only going to complicate
matters optimize your code minify files
meaning hey if you're not using any code
just get rid of it because code has to
execute and that slows down page load
time so if your website has numerous css
and javascripts files basically minify
and combine them and that's what we're
talking about there you know you don't
necessarily need a lot of
you know javascript on your page you can
leverage google tag manager or
you know other features that help
minimize the number of javascript files
you have and so you can also get some of
these ideas by going into google
analytics so in analytics under behavior
under site speed under page timings you
can basically see how quick each page
loads and then if you click on speed
suggestions right below page timings
what happens is google is going to
actually give you some suggested ways to
increase speed so
if we let this report load we'll be able
to see
some speed suggestions per page and so
here you can see for example the home
page has an average page load time of
4.89 seconds you can see right next to
that we have page speed suggestions
seven total so if we click on that
basically what it's going to do it's
going to launch another google product
called page speed insights and what page
speed insights is going to do is it's
going to analyze the page in question
whether that be the home page or an
interior page and what they're actually
going to do is not only analyze the
desktop version of your website but also
the mobile version and so now we can see
opportunities to improve our page speed
by making sure the images are properly
sized making sure server response time
is changed again defer unused css not
using css that's or getting rid of css
or minifying it so there's lots of
things you can do and again this is
desktop and mobile so on the mobile side
we could see some of the other issues
too that are causing high page load and
so analytics site speed reports page
speed insights are good ways to get an
idea really excellent ways to really
address page load time issues so again
these are just some of the common issues
with page load time there could be other
factors so leaning on those page speed
insights reports will definitely help
reduce page load time so
basically according to google a website
should have you know time to first bite
lesser than 200 milliseconds
milliseconds is very very fast so in
case your website is slower than 200
milliseconds such as 500 milliseconds or
more you need to improve it so you don't
even have to measure it by milliseconds
you can even go by seconds which is what
most of us count time and again you
could see that simply going into the
speed suggestions report in google
analytics so ideally in terms of seconds
you want something that's about
you know four seconds or less three
seconds or less obviously as fast as
possible so case study walmart walmart
reported the following results so
walmart experienced a 2 increasing
inversions for every 1 second of page
speed improvement so think about that
there's definitely correlation between
page load time and speed so in
conversions and user engagement so the
quicker your page loads the higher the
engagement so with that improvement they
also experienced an increment in revenue
so meaning the pages load people had a
better user experience they were able to
check out easier and that led to more
revenue so they were able to measure
revenue against milliseconds and that's
something you can certainly do in
analytics you can correlate revenue with
bounce rate you can correlate revenue
with page speed tip number seven build
quality links and increase their domain
authority of your website so google's
top three search ranking factors
includes link building so you need to
have quality links from
quality sites pointing to your site and
so that's a factor in terms of ranking
so that's falls under off page seo you
need to build
references and links on quality sites
and so building quality links to your
content can give your product or
category pages or even content or blog
posts a boost in the serps so it's all
about quality over quantity so it's
always building quality links not
quantity so let's talk about what kind
of strategies you should implement so if
you implement these strategies then
you're going to likely see a lift in the
serps so earn backlinks from relevant
and authoritative web pages so what's
authoritative well authoritative is
subjective to some degree but it's also
measurement in others so you could use
moz as a good tool to measure page
authority or domain authority so if i go
into moz moz has a page and domain
authority score between 1 and 100 and so
you can actually see
what sites have good domain or page
authority just by entering in the domain
so relevant you obviously want to rank
to something that's relevant so if
you're in the food industry something
food related you want to promote your
content regularly on social media so
social media i always consider it a
whole low hanging fruit when it comes to
backlinking you know there's so many
different social media platforms
available facebook linkedin twitter
there's so many varieties from images to
pinterest and instagram to video being
youtube so there's lots of ways to get
your content out on social media that
will allow you to not only promote your
band build a community but also
establish a reference back to that page
you can opt for guest blogging okay so
you can reach out to another blogger and
blog on that platform and it could be
reciprocal as well a blogger can
certainly you know blog on your platform
and have a link back and it works both
ways influencer marketing so influencer
marketing is working with somebody who
has a large amount of followers who can
influence those followers to you know
mention you in a hashtag link to your
particular product or brand or even
drive traffic to your site so you want
to take advantage of social media
platforms and start your own page as
well so
facebook's a good example it could be
having a youtube channel if you're into
video you can certainly set up a youtube
channel build a following around youtube
as well so always start your own page if
that's the platform of choice the last
thing you should do is set up a page on
social media and not keep it updated you
could certainly participate in forums
you can participate in other websites
like quora or reddit that's very you
know content based content driven user
driven i always recommend starting your
own blog blog is a good way to
not only generate content but it's a
good way to incorporate different types
of content so you could set up different
types of content and categories it's a
good way to incorporate different assets
like images and video it's a good way to
get users engaged by having comments or
having social share buttons it's a good
way to leverage that content onto other
social media platforms so there's lots
of benefits to blogging very few cons
the only con would be a time constraint
but it's better to have one blog post in
one month consistently than not blogging
at all so getting listed on high quality
link directories like yahoo directory is
still a way to add a link from a high
quality site and then make use of broken
link building so again on the last tip
we mentioned search console search
console certainly has reports available
for you that allow you to see what pages
on your site are no longer there and
allow you to see what pages they're
linking from okay you can also do
testimonials there's lots of ways to
generate quality links in a way you
almost have to get creative but creative
in a way that's going to generate
quality not quantity quality is the key
so even if it's one source whether that
be somebody else's blog so be it as long
as it's quality that's what counts so
let's talk about some of the key
takeaways from today's tips so remember
tip number one we want to opt for
smarter ways to do keyword research so
remember we want to look at volume we
want to look at competition we want to
create themes put them in a spreadsheet
so we want to be smarter and which in
the way in which we choose our keyword
tip number two remember publish high
quality content to get more traffic when
we say high quality content remember
break up the content use different
assets organize it structure it you know
make sure it's answering some of these
questions then we talked about in tip
number three analyzing your meta tags
and urls so we want to make sure that
title tag meta descriptions are creative
use modifiers like numbers or promotions
you know we don't want to go over
character counts we want to make them
unique and distinct so that somebody
clicks on them then we talked about rich
snippets and tip number four remember
rich snippets are just additional html
that communicates the search engines so
the search engines can understand
exactly what's on your page so if you
have recipes if you have reviews if you
have videos if you have images if you
have ratings all these things can be
added to the serps just by communicating
with the search engines vs rich snippets
tip 5 optimize your site structure we
wanna make sure that you know you have
good inbound links you wanna make sure
you incorporate breadcrumbs you wanna
make sure users can navigate your site
more easily and then in tip number six
if your pages load fast then it's going
to enhance the user experience it's
going to increase user engagement and
increase conversions and then tip number
seven we want to build quality link
quality to increase the domain authority
so remember we can use mods to measure
domain authority it's all about quality
whether that be via influencer marketing
guest blogging directories social media
setting up a social media page there's
always something you could be doing to
generate a quality link to your website
today we're going to talk about keyword
research so
what are we going to talk about when we
talk about keyword research we're going
to talk about why we would do keyword
research for seo we're going to talk
about the types of keywords that we need
to research we're going to talk about
some methodologies best practices on how
to do keyword research some alternate
suggestions we're going to talk about
keyword clustering and then we're going
to talk about some tools that you can
use to do your keyword research so let's
start with the why we would do keyword
research so jessie is planning to
publish a blog of pizza recipes so
she was doing pizza recipes step by step
piece of recipes with sausage homemade
pizza toppings pizza dough recipes thin
crust pizzas she's doing a lot of
different topics on pizza recipes well
what jessie needs to do is understand
what's going to drive traffic to these
blog posts if she's writing about you
know different topics around pizza
recipes so
she's unsure how
these blogs are going to drive traffic
so she really needs to
understand that hey you need to choose
the right keywords to drive traffic so
the question is if you're writing a blog
post about recipes with sausages is
pizza recipes with sausages or recipes
for free the best keywords to use maybe
maybe not so you need to take uh care
and choosing the key words to align with
your content so that's really the idea
why we would do keyword research because
some of the issues with keywords that
are poorly chosen are they could have
slow search volume for example you may
choose a keyboard that just a lot of
people aren't using to search for or
they can be highly competitive so if you
choose a keyword that's very broad or
popular it could be very competitive and
take you a long time to be found for
that keyword or you could just make the
mistake of choosing a keyboard that
isn't aligned with your content or you
can choose keywords but use them
incorrectly with your content so these
are some of the issues that you can
encounter if you just go about choosing
keywords randomly without due diligence
without the proper research so low
search volume will lead to less traffic
high competition you may not even rank
at all okay if somebody finds you for a
keyword that's not relevant to the topic
they're just going to leave the page and
if you're not using the right keywords
and or if you are using the right
keywords and not using them correctly in
the content then your pages may not even
be found in organic search so you really
have to take care in choosing the
keywords to me that's the most important
step with seo is keyword research so
we're going to talk about the types of
keyword research then so we have short
tail keywords and we have long tail
keywords so if you write a blog post
about pizza recipes well what are you
going to choose a short tail or long
tail so let's talk about short tail
keywords first so short tail keywords
are keywords that are usually three key
words and a phrase or shorter in some
cases it may be two key words in a
phrase or shorter so short-term keywords
usually have high search volume which
means likely means higher competition
but what it also means it could be
lower conversions because short tail
keywords like for example pizza recipes
could be considered a short chocolate
word but maybe somebody's looking for
homemade pizza recipes or pizza recipes
from their favorite italian restaurant
so
short-term keywords may not be as
relevant so if we compare with long tail
keywords chances are you're going to
have lower competition that's one of the
benefits but you're also going to have
lower search volume but with longer tail
keywords the keyword is probably going
to be more relevant with the content
you're writing about so therefore the
conversion rate's likely going to be
higher so that's really the difference
between short term keywords and long
tail keywords if you want to look at
simplistically short tail keywords are
broad in nature it's going to capture a
lot of eyeballs but those eyeballs may
look at your content is not relevant
versus long tail keywords that may be
very relevant but not as many eyeballs
on them so short tail keywords the
characteristics they're not as specific
usually they're less than three words
they have high search volume and high
competition so if you just choose pizza
recipes it could take you a while to
rank for that keyword but when you rank
you're gonna get the traffic but again
it may not convert because the keyword
is broad in nature so pizza recipes is a
short tail keyword that may not be
exactly what you're writing about in
your blog post so it may draw a lot of
traffic but the traffic may not do
anything so the longer tail keywords are
very specific they consist of more than
three words in the search query they
have relatively low search volume
competition so the chance of you ranking
higher faster for that long take a
keyword is probably going to be greater
because not many other websites are
trying to rank for that same keyword and
so the benefit of that is if you have
let's just say homemade pizza recipes
with mushrooms that's a long tinky word
but if somebody's looking for that type
of pizza recipe then you know you're
going to track the right traffic and
chances are that traffic is going to
engage or convert based on the type of
conversion you have in place so example
would be homemade pizza dough recipes
that'd be another example more than
thick key words in the phrase very
specific we're talking about homemade
pizza dough recipes so we're not talking
about just pizza recipes so it's a
little bit more
specific in nature longer tail so these
keywords are used for targeted pages
including blog posts if you're writing a
blog post specifically about pizza
recipes with homemade dough then this is
the keyword you likely would want to use
versus just pizza recipes so let's look
at an example between a
short tail keyword and a long tail
keyword and to accentuate the
differences we're going to use google's
keyword planner tool so google's keyword
planner tool is located in google ads
the google ads platform and when you're
in the google ads platform you can
simply click on tools and then keyword
planner and so what keyword planner
allows us to do is get a sense of the
type of volume that a particular keyword
has so what google's keyword planner
does is they show you the average
monthly searches this is the average
monthly search volume of a keyword over
the past 12 months and so in this
example we're going to choose pizza
recipes and homemade pizza dough recipes
so one short tail and one long tail so
we enter those keywords in we're going
to click get results and what google's
going to do is it's going to show us the
volume of those keywords so for pizza
recipe we could see the average monthly
search volume is 33 100 for pizza recipe
so note that pizza recipe and pizza
recipes are closely related keywords and
so what google does is they consider
that a close variance so meaning if
somebody types in pizza recipe then
they're also in google's eyes looking
for pizza recipes so it's a close
variance and so for the keyword pizza
recipe which is short tail we could see
on average over the past 12 months this
keyword received 33
100 queries and so if we hover over the
graph we could see basically the volume
the average volume per month so here i
could see for this particular keyword
here the volume per month is 33 1000 and
then i could see the actual volume over
the past 12 months and then for the long
tail keyword i can see homemade pizza
dough recipe again close variance
homemade pizza dough recipes i can see
over the past 12 months what the search
volume is for this on average is 2400
but i could see here in december the
volume went up to thirty six hundred but
for example in may it was nineteen
hundred so it's going to fluctuate a bit
over the past four months but on average
it's about twenty four hundred so
shorter tail a lot more volume longer
tail not as much volume but nonetheless
there is volume here and so these are
the difference between a short tail and
a longer tail and so what google's
keyword planner also does is allow us to
get a sense of what the competition is
and so here i can see the competition is
low for both of these keywords fair
enough so we now know that if we want to
optimize or choose the keyword homemade
pizza dough recipe for our blog post we
know for ranked on page one of google
even in the top spot we can expect about
2 400 search queries for that keyword
now whether you get all 2 400 clicks for
that keyword remains to be seen chances
are you're not going to get all 2400
you're going to get a lion's share of
those clicks but you're going to at
least get some volume on it so even the
longer take keywords have a lot of
promise because there is some search
volume here for this keyword how to do a
proper keyword research so we looked at
google's keyword planner tool in google
ads and we typed in two keywords and we
were able to get a sense of what the
average volume is so we definitely want
to choose keywords based on the
following factors we want to choose it
based on search volume search volume is
a good indicator of the potential
traffic we can obtain so again for the
keyword homemade pizza dough recipe we
know that it averages 2 400 a month in
search volume again we may not get all 2
400 but are we gonna get a lion share
that we also need to look at competition
and so google's keyword planner gives us
a high medium or low in terms of the
competition but if you're somebody who
wants to get a better sense of what the
competition is and you should because
competition is a key component in
choosing keywords and so what i want to
do is get a sense of how many people are
actually optimizing for that keyword so
google's keyword planner tool is going
to give me a low medium high really what
i want to do is get a better sense of
that numerically so what i can do is go
into google search and i could type in
pizza recipes and i could see there's
about 1 billion results that's a lot of
results however that means that every
potential web page out there on the
internet that mentions pizza recipes is
going to be included in this number here
and so i want to get a better sense of
who's optimizing for pizza recipes so
i'm going to put in the all entitle
syntax and so what that is going to ask
google to do is tell me all the websites
that have pizza recipes the keyword
pizza recipes in the title tag so if i
do all entitle call in space then pizza
recipes my result drops down to 336 000
so what that tells me is that there are
000 results with the keyword pizza
recipes in the title tag now if i want
to focus in on my other keyword if i
choose uh my other keyword was a longer
tail keyword homemade pizza dough recipe
so if i type that keyword in the
homemade pizza dough recipe or recipes
remember close variance and i just click
enter or type the keyword in and hit my
enter key i'm going to get 35 million
results but again is that really an
indicator of the type of competition i
have no because every listing that
matches homemade pizza dough recipes is
going to be included in the search
results so i'm going to type in my all
in title colon space and then i'm going
to get a better sense of how many
websites have the keyword homemade pizza
dough recipes in the title tag and i get
160 different results so here i can see
the first result in the title tag
homemade pizza dough recipe second one
homemade pizza dough recipe so these are
sites and web pages that have that
keyword in the title tag so now i have a
numerical number to work with and so the
thing you have to understand about seo
specifically about keyword research is
you need to do research on a few
different keywords not just one or two
so what we want to do is have a
spreadsheet the spreadsheet is going to
contain keywords that we can potentially
want to optimize for choose as keywords
to optimize for seo and so my
recommendation is you come up with a
theme first so the theme for us in this
exercise is pizza recipes and so that's
our theme so we chose the keyword pizza
recipes so the close variance here is
pizza recipe what was the volume well we
know the volume was 33 100 for pizza
recipe so what are we going to do we're
going to put that number in in our
volume column what was the competition
well if we go back and type in pizza
recipes it was 683 thousand so i'm gonna
type in 683
000. what was our next keyword well it
was pizza or homemade pizza dough
recipes so if i go back for this
particular keyword is 2 400. i'm gonna
put 2 400 in under my volume column and
then what was my competition well my
competition was i typed that keyword
back in
2160. so i'm gonna put two thousand one
hundred and sixty so now i have an idea
of what kind of volume and what kind of
competition i have now you wanna do this
for a number of different keywords and
when you do it for a number of keywords
what you do want to do is obviously
choose a relevant keyword that has high
volume and low competition so another
way of saying it is the volume or ratio
of volume to competition and so
basically what we could do is take
volume divided by competition if i make
that a percentage i can see it's 0.35
is the ratio between volume and
competition if i do the same for my
longer tail keyword 2400 divided by 2160
i can see that 111
so this just kind of proves the point
that yeah i'm still going to get some
volume but i have a better chance of
ranking for this longer teal keyword
homemade pizza dough recipes so you want
to be able to do that for a number of
keywords and examine the volume the
competition and the ratio between volume
and competition for your themed keywords
in this case pizza recipes so relevancy
you want to choose keywords that are
very relevant to the content that you're
writing and then again commercial intent
what keywords are going to drive more
conversions and revenue for the business
so when we talk about commercial intent
we're talking about you know are you
choosing keywords that are going to get
somebody to do what you want them to do
so we could say you know download pizza
dough recipes so if somebody's typing in
the keyword download pizza dough recipes
then chances are they're going to find
you come to your side and take action by
downloading that pizza dough recipe so
you want to be able to also think about
the intent of the keyword is it going to
help you drive conversions and revenue
if you're an e-commerce site so search
volume is the average monthly search
volume made for a particular keyword and
phrase so we can get that number using
google's keyword planner tool in the
google ads platform we want to target
keywords with high search volume that
will help bring traffic to the website
we want volume but we want to take into
account seasonality as well so that's
where the google keyword planner tool
comes in place because if we go back
again we can just hover over we get a
sense of any particular trend going on
or seasonality so for example if i saw
large growth in the winter months and
not much volume growth in the summer
months then that might indicate to me
that this keyword is more popular during
the winter time so pay attention to the
graphs that you know the keyword planner
tool gives you use them to your
advantage to take into account
seasonality so a good example would be
funny halloween costumes well we know
that for halloween you're going to have
a spike probably towards the end of
september all the way through october
and then it's going to drop after
october 31st which is halloween so
that's an example but in the case of
pizza recipes you know you may find that
more people are choosing to search for
pizza recipes during maybe the summer
months versus the winter months so pay
attention to seasonality it will affect
search volume so competition based on
our example it's one of the most
important key metrics you don't want to
choose a keyword that's highly
competitive because if it's competitive
then it's going to be harder to rank
number one or even on page one of google
depending on competitive it is so high
search volume low competition in other
words the ratio between the two is the
ideal combination so going back to the
spreadsheet recommend you have that
spreadsheet handy put your theme in
place okay theme pizza recipes we use
google's keyword planner tool to find
the volume we use the all in title
syntax to find the competition so we
entered both of those numbers in and we
get our ratio and so when you have these
numbers for a number of different
keywords you want to be able to choose
that ratio of high volume low
competition but always relevancy always
trumps ratio so always go with a keyword
that is going to be relevant to your
content don't choose a keyword that's
not relevant if you choose a keyword
that's not relevant it's not going to
bode well for user engagement so the
difficulty of a keyword ranges from 0 to
100 in google's keyword tool so it's
going to be easy it's going to be medium
it's going to be hard but my
recommendation is also to get the
numerical factor and that's the all in
title syntax and again relevancy is what
drives the traffic to your website and
keep the traffic there on your website
and also not only will keep the traffic
on your website but hopefully get that
traffic to engage and convert so that's
the key about relevancy you always want
to choose keywords that are relevant to
your content even if it's sacrificing
volume relevancy again trumps volume and
competition so always choose relevant
keywords first so when you do that
you're always almost guaranteeing that
at some point somebody's gonna find your
content because somebody out there might
be looking for it and if they do you're
gonna get found and then the
engagement's gonna be better so
understand your business find keywords
that are relevant to your business and
then focus on those keywords that'll
help you with getting the right traffic
to your site always keep in mind the
commercial intent so these keywords are
more specific and result in conversion
rate for example buying is a good
commercial intent keyword so if you
really want somebody to come to your
website and buy then focus on those
types of keywords in the case of the
pizza recipes maybe its download could
be our commercial intent keyword again
there may be low search volume but those
are the type of keywords you want to
focus on because that's the type of
traffic you want to drive to your site
so some other examples are commercial
intent keywords or discount deal your
coupon shipping you don't be afraid to
use some of these keywords as part of
your longer tail keyword phrase again
the volume may not be high but the
traffic quality is probably going to be
better so keyword research is the
foundation for seo so if you have chosen
your keywords properly then if you do
get ranked for those keywords then it's
going to lead to better engagement with
some conversions and so when we talk
about keywords we also want to talk
about our primary and secondary keyword
so every page should have at least a
primary keyword and then a second carry
keyword to work with so primary keywords
are really defining the nature of your
content the secondary keywords are
relevant to the primary keyword so why
do we choose a primary and secondary
keyword because you may choose a keyword
as a primary keyword that is relevant to
the content but may not necessarily rank
very high or have a lot of volume that
secondary keyword is also relevant to
the primary keyword but also relevant to
content and you may rank for that
secondary keyword so you always want to
go with two keywords versus just one
keyword you want to give your yourself a
chance to rank for at least two
different types of keywords of relevant
nature so for web page there can be
several secondary keywords but only one
primary keyword so your primary keyword
is always going to be relevant to your
content secondary keywords can be
relevant to the keyword but and you may
have multiple secondary keywords but
it's also going to be related to the
content and it gives you a better
opportunity to be found between both the
primary and secondary in search okay so
let's take a look at another example of
how to use primary keywords and
secondary keywords when choosing
keywords so if a primary keyword is
healthy diet plan remember healthy diet
plan is directly related to the content
so that's what we're talking about but
these secondary keywords are also
related to content and play off the
primary keyword and so what we want to
do is go to cool google's keyword
planner tool and get an idea of the
volume for healthy diet plan and then
also the volume and competition for some
of these secondary keywords like healthy
diet for weight loss healthy diet food
low carb diet healthy meal plans and
diet plan weight loss so if i go in to
google's keyword planner and type those
keywords in i'm going to choose get
results and now here i can see healthy
diet plan keyword i'm focusing on is my
primary keyword has an average monthly
search volume of 9900
and then some of my secondary keywords
healthy diet foods diet plan weight loss
low carb diet you know google will give
me a number of different keywords to
work with so i'm going to look at the
search volume of those as well and so
ideally what i want to do is be able to
then look at the volume and then look at
the competition so healthy diet plan i
go into my keyword analysis here that's
my theme so that's my keyword what's my
volume for healthy diet plan 9900
what's my competition so my competition
is 74
700 and that's going to give me a ratio
of volume to competition of 13 so that's
what my contents about that's a
considered a short-tail keyword because
it has a lot of competition and so my
ratio is 13
and what i want to do is i want to be
able to put these other secondary
keywords in here as well maybe even go a
little longer tail because i want to be
able to
find two key or at least two keywords i
want to be able to find my primary
keyword that's relevant to my content
and then i want to be able to find my
secondary keyword which is again related
to the primary keyword which is also
related to the content and so i want to
be able to choose two keywords basically
and i want to choose two keywords that
are relevant that have good ratio
between volume and competition so that's
the whole idea again on how to do
keyword research you want to be able to
find your keywords use the tools
available to you and get a sense of what
the volume is what the competition is
look at the ratio between the volume and
competition and then based on the
content choose that primary keyword and
then again based on the keyword you
chose choose some secondary keywords as
well because you want to be found for
not just one keyword but multiple
keywords okay let's look at some
alternative suggestions to keyword
research so for doing keyword research
we want to take into account lsi
keywords we could take into account
other platforms that host a lot of
content like quora or reddit we can use
google suggestions in the keyword search
bar we can use popular platforms like
wikipedia and we can use social media
bookmarking like reddit so there are
lots of suggestions that we can obtain
from various sources so let's start with
lsi keywords and lsi stands for latent
semantic insect indexing and so
basically what it is it's just keywords
that are linked to your primary keyword
and so when you're choosing keywords you
always want to choose that primary
keyword and then secondary keywords that
are similar to the primary keyword and
usually those are lsi or latent semantic
indexing type keywords so they're used
to drive relevant traffic to your page
so if you're focusing on one keyword we
want to have other keywords that are
similar to increase our visibility on
the search engine result pages so we
could find latent semantic indexing
right in search so if we use the term
healthy diet if we go to google search
for example if i type in healthy diet in
google search all i need to do is scroll
to the bottom of the page and i can see
searches related to healthy diet so
healthy diet menu healthy diet essay
what does a healthy diet look like
notice at the top google's also giving
me some other suggestions here so
they're saying low-fat diet veganism
gluten-free diet so there's lots of
different suggestions right in google
search bar so all of these are lsi
related keywords so if you're optimizing
a page for a healthy diet then you could
choose low-fat diet as a secondary
keyword you can use gluten-free diet as
a secondary keyword it really depends on
what the content is but you always want
to support your content with as much lsi
keywords as possible so you can be found
for as many different keywords as
possible in google search so it's
important because if you have a blog
that you know talks about python so how
do the search engines know if the
website python is about the programming
language or the snake so
google for example uses lsi keywords to
understand what the page is specifically
focusing on so if you're just focusing
on python and your content you want to
support that with lsi keywords and so
that will allow your web page to better
communicate with google also to have the
visibility to show up on search so they
can certainly improve your search
positioning and featured snippets as
well so if you have a keyword that
answers a question you could certainly
be found for feature snippet for example
maybe you know healthy diet recipes if i
type that in you can see here there's a
featured snippet so if i'm talking about
recipes that's a keyword i may want to
use and if i use that then google has an
opportunity to see what my contents
about and place my information at the
top in this featured snippet you can
also again see what some of the
questions are being asked what males are
good for weight loss what is a good
healthy diet plan all of these can be
keyword phrases that you can use so the
answers are right here in google so core
is a great platform because core is a
platform that people go and ask
questions and a community responds with
answers or responses to that particular
question or topic and so the great thing
about cora is it's a good i it's a good
place for you to go to get some ideas
about a specific topic so if we're
talking about healthy dieting so we can
find keywords with high search volume
writing core so the whole idea is you
can look at you know the top five
questions for specific topics like
healthy dieting and find relevant
keywords to healthy dieting so if you
just type in that particular keyword in
quora you're gonna probably get some
responses to questions or responses to
somebody else's question and so if we
take a look at core for example so if i
just type in healthy dieting what i'm
going to do is i'm going to get some
responses to
the topic healthy dieting so what's the
best diet for healthy living what are
the top five tips for a healthy diet
habit so all of these could be keyword
phrases that you could take away with
for your own content and so the benefit
here is you're getting kind of an idea
of what's trending what people are
talking about and if you use tips for a
healthy diet habit for example and you
optimize for that well again that could
turn around and bode well for you
because you could be featured in google
as a featured snippet at the top here
you can also turn around and use lsi
related keywords for healthy diet habits
and you can simply just look for those
lsi keywords right in google remember at
the bottom or at the top if i scroll
down i can see some related lsi keywords
at the bottom so right in google as well
you could see in the google search bar
that google provides some lsi related
keywords to your query so if i go back
here and type in healthy diet recipes i
can see here google suggesting some
other related keywords healthy diet menu
healthy diet for men healthy diet foods
healthy diet for women so these are all
lsi related keywords that you can use to
support your primary keyword and the
content you're writing about so we've
talked about lsi keywords where to find
them so they're found right here they
can be found at the top of google and
they can be found at the bottom you can
also then go to core as well and get
some ideas for the types of questions
that are being asked so if you ask a
question and use that as your keyword
phrase then again you have an
opportunity of showing up for a featured
snippet in google just by doing some
additional research within google itself
or on quora so according to google the
auto complete predictions are
automatically generated by google's
algorithm without any human intervention
it's based on a number of factors but
the primary factor is how often past
users have searched for terms so google
collects all the keyword queries that
somebody types in and they're suggesting
some of the most popular terms that
people have typed in so if i go back to
google again if i start to type in
recipes i could see some of the other
queries that somebody else has typed in
or some of the most popular queries
related to that topic so if you enter
the keyword healthy diet google's going
to suggest multiple keyword suggestions
that users have asked in the past and
you could certainly get the search
volume of those keywords just by looking
in google itself i could see for healthy
diet recipes billions of pages related
to healthy diet recipes i can also get
the search volume by going into google's
keyword planner so if i type in healthy
diet i'm going to be able to see what my
search volume is for that keyword and in
addition i can see the seasonality of
that particular keyword and in addition
to that google is going to provide some
other related keywords to my search
query so if i'm looking for healthy diet
google is going to suggest hey maybe you
should choose healthy food or healthy
eating or how to lose weight so those
are lsi related keywords that google
provides in the keyword plan which is
built into the google ads platform
another option for you is wikipedia so
wikipedia is a vast platform of content
so we could turn wikipedia into our own
assets and use it to our own advantage
by finding relevant keywords in an easy
fashion so with wikipedia we can
identify a list of keywords in the meta
description itself we could choose
keywords from the first paragraph of
wikipedia it has many relevant keywords
or we could take a look at keywords from
the wikipedia content section so we can
also see additional pages like the see
also section that gives relevant
keywords that you're looking for we can
also look at the references section as
they contain relevant keywords so we go
to wikipedia as an example and i type in
healthy diet
into wikipedia here i can get just in
the first paragraph alone i can see
some additional keywords that i might
choose to use like micronutrients i
never knew that micronutrients was
related to healthy diet but wikipedia is
providing some information about what
micronutrients is and maybe i can use
that as a keyword an lsi related keyword
to my content so if i scroll down i get
to see also section so it might give me
some information food information
consumers for example dietary guidelines
i can look at categories like dietetics
and diets i can also look at the
references section so i can also see
what information was provided like
health effects of overweight and obesity
i can look at diet and physical activity
so all of these are related to
my main keyword healthy diet so the
answers are right in here on the
platform they're just all over the page
so wikipedia has an abundance of
information you just need to know where
to look so again with wikipedia you can
look no further than the first paragraph
you look no further than the see also
section the references section category
section there's lots of information
right on the page itself to help you get
ideas for keywords so if you google your
keyword with wikipedia term in the
search query and get relevant keywords
from the title tags on the serp so you
can also do that as well so if i type in
healthy diet wikipedia in search i can
also get some information here as well
so people also search for healthy food
advantages or healthy food habits essay
or information about healthy food all of
these are related to
my keyword healthy diet so again another
bit of information for you to choose or
look to choose some additional keywords
for so reddit it's a popular community
where people post content discuss a
variety of topics so that's what reddit
is so with the help of subreddits an
individual can find relevant keywords
with with high search volume so in
reddit there's an easy way to find out
keywords they have a keyword tool called
keyword it so key wording is the average
monthly searches for a particular
keyword so if we type a word in key
reddit and choose keywords from the
auto-generated list this tool will
extract the keywords and give us those
relevant terms with search volumes so if
we go to the keyword it and show an
example of that for example healthy food
if i get keywords i can see what
keywords are relevant and the search
volume of that keyword so if i just type
in healthy food keyword tool is going to
tell me some relevant keywords and what
the volume is so if you don't have the
keyword planner tool and google ads
available to you this is a good
alternative solution to finding keywords
so it's free you just need to go to
keyword dot com type in your keyword
click get keywords and what it's going
to do is give you some relevant keywords
related to your primary keyword with the
search volume let's talk about keyword
clustering now so the whole idea about
keyword clustering is to
really take advantage of the keywords
that we're optimizing for to gain higher
ranking so if we can cluster keywords
together in a theme and
that theme of keywords is relevant to a
specific page of a website then we have
a better opportunity to rank so in other
words why do we have to target just one
keyword when we can target many so keep
in mind you know lsi keywords we want to
group a bunch of keywords together that
are similar for content so for example
after some keyword research you can
thematically group keywords into a core
topic so for example we can cluster
these group of keywords together like
for example what is seo how does seo
work intro to seo what are the basics of
seo all of those are related to the core
theme what is seo another cluster of
keywords for example could be seo
techniques seo best practices tips and
tricks website optimization on-page seo
techniques etc so those are clusters of
keywords okay that we can group together
in themes and if we group keywords
together in themes we can apply that to
a particular content on our website so
the whole idea behind clustering
keywords it's going to provide more
diversity more of an opportunity for us
to be found so that's the whole idea
behind clustering so some additional
steps remember stay up to date on
industry news to brainstorm your ideas
first and identify a list of keywords
i.e a theme of keywords that you can
cluster together and then you could
determine the keywords that your
competitors are already ranking for so
for example if we want to rank for the
keyword seo best practices for example
we can use a tool called keyword moz if
i go to keyword the keyword explorer
tool in moz and just type in seo best
practices
what it's going to do is it's going to
give me some volume related to that
particular keyword but more importantly
what it's also going to do is it's going
to show me what pages are already ranked
for that particular keyword so therefore
i can get a sense of who is already
ranking for that keyword so here i can
see mozmoz medium.com alexa.com so i can
get a sense of what web pages are ranked
for a particular keyword or group of
keywords i want to rank for myself so if
we look at tools for keyword research
look no further than moz that's the mods
of the tool i would just use but you
could also use google's keyword planner
which we used in the example so for
example if i go back to the google ads
keyword planner if you're in google ads
you click on tools you click on
cleveland planner and what keyword
planner does is it provides you for a
particular keyword the average monthly
search volume over the past 12 months it
provides you information on seasonality
so if i hover my mouse over a graph i'm
going to be able to see the volume per
month over the last 12 months what the
keyword planner also does is it provides
me some additional ideas for my
particular keyword and in addition to
that it's going to provide me some sense
of how competitive that keyword is by
telling me whether it's low medium or
high in terms of competition so there's
sem rush there's also other additional
keywords tools out there like word
stream or href or the reddit tool
keyword it and then moz is is another
tool i particularly use so if i go to
moz again here i can just type in a
keyword that i'm interested in it's
going to give me the search volume of
that keyword it's going to give me the
level of difficulty so 50 out of 100 so
it's halfway between difficulty and easy
and then it's going to give me some
additional metrics like for example what
my expected organic click-through rate
would be if i were to rank for this
keyword but more importantly what i like
about this is we could see exactly what
other sites are linked to this
particular
keyword we're interested in so here i
can look at the top 10 list so this is
moz's keyword explore tool so that's
what this tool is and it's part of
moz.com so there's a lot of tools at
your disposal i particularly use moz i
particularly use google's keyword
planner and those are the tools i use
but there are lots of tools out there
let's go with the scenario that you have
a friend named sam and he has a website
where he sells shoes but sam doesn't
understand
why his website's not ranking number one
on google and so typically
ranked number one on google there are
some factors involved and
those are factors that are going to help
sam get his website ranked number one on
google so he can sell his shoes get
traffic and convert that traffic to
conversions so there are factors
involved and so what are those factors
well it always starts with keyword
research so in order to rank for a
website where you sell shoes or
you sell products other products like
clothing or food or
your automobile website you know you're
a mechanic it doesn't matter whether
you're selling to customers or selling
to other businesses you have to start
with the keyword research and so we're
going to go into really explicit detail
on how to conduct a proper keyword
research and then the second factor
involved is high quality content so in
order to rank high on google search you
need to have high quality content so
we're going to go over what's involved
with creating high quality content then
we're going to
take that content we're going to
optimize it using on page elements and
website level factors so we're going to
take into account what's involved with
your website and what's involved with
specific pages on your website in order
to rank number one on google then we're
going to get into the off-site
engagement so when it comes to ranking
on google you need to optimize your
website and you need to do
some elements off your website you need
to be engaging off your website meaning
on other websites and so we're going to
talk about what's involved with offsite
engagement so seo being a major channel
for most companies and websites where
the opportunity to drive a lot of
traffic is there but you have to earn
that reward the reward is a lot of
traffic but you have to earn the reward
there's a lot of work involved and so
ideally what we want to do is follow
what we call the 80 20 rule when it
comes to search engine optimization and
ranking on google and what do we mean by
the 80 20 rule well 80 20 means we're
investing 20 of our effort and 80
percent of the results are obtained so
we want to invest 20 and get back 80.
that's basically what we mean by 80 20.
so for example if 20 of our targeted
keywords bring in 80 of the traffic then
that's following the 80 20 rule or 20 of
our landing pages drive 80 percent of
the overall traffic that's following the
80 20 rule or 20 of our backlinks past
80 percent of our link juice that's the
80 20 rule meaning these targeted
keywords these targeted landing pages
these trying to target backlinks using
off-site engagement we want to put in 20
of our effort on those keywords landing
pages and backlinks in return for 80
of the results so without further ado
let's get started with the keyword
research let's talk about that keyword
research for a website with shoes and it
doesn't really matter
what particular product you have if you
need to rank number one on google it all
starts with the keywords as i mentioned
before and so
in this example if you have a website
where you sell shoes for kids you're
going to want to be found for certain
keywords so the obvious keyword here
would be shoes for kids well every
keyword that you target has search
volume associated with it so that means
when we talk about search volume we're
talking about how many people on average
type in that keyword or related keyword
on google.com or google search and
there's always an average number of
searches associated with every keyword
and we call that search volume how much
search volume so obviously if we're
going to target a keyword we want to
have as much volume as possible however
there's always going to be
competition for those keywords meaning
there's always going to be other
websites who want to rank number one on
google for the same keywords and we call
that competition or difficulty so for
every keyword you're going to have
volume and you're going to have
competition or difficulty and the
difficulty ranges as well depending on
the tool you use and we'll get into that
in a minute but search volume is how
much on average people are typing in
that keyword or close variance of that
keyword and the difficulty is measured
in terms of how many other websites are
trying to rank for the same keyword and
so ideally when it comes to keyword
research we want to find that nice
balance we want high volume and we want
low competition but at the same time we
want to focus on keywords that are
highly relevant to our business so if
we're selling shoes for kids and shoes
for kids is highly relevant has high
volume and low competition then that's a
key word we want to target so we always
want to focus in on those three areas so
there's always a trade-off with keywords
so shoes for kids might have high volume
but also might have high competition or
difficulty if we look for another
keyword that's just as relevant for
example shoes for children it may still
have high search volume but the
competition or the difficulty may be
lower and if that's the case then that
may be a better keyword for us to target
instead of something highly competitive
like shoes for kids we can focus on
another relevant keyword like shoes for
children with just as much volume and
lower competition and the reason why we
want lower competition is because we
want to be able to rank for that keyword
so the higher the competition the harder
it is for us to rank number one on
google for that keyword and so the whole
idea beyond keyword research is
analyzing and choosing the best keywords
so we want to identify a list of
keywords that are always relevant we
want to choose the keyword that your
competitors are ranking for and we want
to use third-party tools to choose
keywords to identify which keywords have
low competition and what keywords have
high search volume so one thing to take
into consideration when you're doing
keyword research is that the longer the
keyword phrase or in other words long
tail keywords or keywords with three
keywords in the phrase or more you're
going to always have less competition
but there's always a trade-off with long
tail keywords meaning the longer the
keyword phrase there's going to be less
volume but the trade-off is less
competition and so what we want to do is
we want to brainstorm some ideas and
find those relevant keywords so let's
look at an example here so if we go to
google ads so google ads has a tool
called keyword planner and let's just
say i have a
a website where i'm selling dried figs
and if i'm selling dried figs i want
people to buy these dried figs however
in order to attract them i want to be
able to show them that hey we have a
bunch of recipes and if i show you a
bunch of recipes where you can use dried
figs maybe you'll buy these dried figs
to use in these recipes and so we're
going to look for keywords related to
bread recipes because if we can optimize
for our recipes page for bread then that
will attract an audience who wants to
make bread and use dried figs with those
bread recipes so that's the example i'm
going to give here and so if i look at
the keyword planner in google ads if i
just type in bread recipes what google
is going to do is they're going to give
me an average monthly search volume so i
can see the average monthly search
volume here is sixty thousand five
hundred and so in order to do keyword
research what i would recommend is keep
a spreadsheet and so the idea behind the
spreadsheet is to document the volume
and the competition you're getting for
certain keywords so if i go into a
spreadsheet here my theme of keywords is
bread recipes my keyword is bread
recipes and my volume therefore is going
to be 60 500. however if i go back into
google's keyword planner google's
telling me the competition is low so
that's great i want high volume i want
low competition but how low is low so we
want to be careful so if we're going to
put in numbers into a spreadsheet we
want to figure out what that competition
really is for the keyword bread recipes
so if i go to google and just type in
bread recipes i'm going to be able to
see 771
billion results for the keyword bread
recipes now is 771 billion are real
competition maybe maybe not what we want
to do is put in a syntax and we want to
put in the syntax all in title and then
colon space and then our keyword and the
reason why we do that in search is
because we want to be able to identify
the true competitive number or the true
number of websites who are trying to
rank for bread recipes and if we put in
the syntax all entitled colon and then
our keyword bread recipes we'll be able
to see that there are
998 000 results that's a lot lower than
771 billion so that means that 998
sites or listings have the keyword bread
recipes in the title tag and the title
tag is what shows up in the search
engine results and so if i look down and
scroll down here i can see bread recipes
on every one of these title tags so
title tag is an important element to
rank number one on google and we'll talk
about that in a few minutes but if we
understand that there are 998 000
results with bread recipes in the title
tag then this tells us that those are
the websites who are trying to rank
number one on google for that keyword
and therefore those are the websites we
need to jump over in order for our
website to rank number one on google and
so therefore i'm going to put in 998 000
in my spreadsheet as the competitive
number and so now i could see for the
keyword bread recipes i have 60 500 and
if my competition is 998 000 then my kei
or keyboard effectiveness index or in
other words the ratio of volume to
competition is six percent so that's
nothing more than volume divided by
competition so that tells me that my kei
or my ratio between volume competition
is six percent so remember we want more
volume than we want competition so any
time you do a keyword research you're
going to find a number of different
relevant keywords so if i go back into
google's keyword planner if i typed in
bread recipes you could see that google
is going to give me a number of
different keywords related to bread
recipes let's just say i have another
keyword
that i want to think about optimizing
for being ranked on google for and
that's banana bread recipe very similar
keyword as bread recipes except it's a
little longer tail now if i type in
banana bread recipe in google's keyword
planner now i can see the average
monthly search volume has actually gone
up it's
368 000. i can also see the competition
is low so those are good signs so now i
can see 368 000 i'm going to go ahead
and put that in my spreadsheet now i'm
going to go into google i'm going to put
in my syntax all in title i'm going to
put in banana bread recipe i'm going to
hit enter and now i can see i have 233
000 results with the keyword banana
bread recipe in the title tag so if i
look at the title tags i can see banana
bread recipe banana bread recipe banana
bread recipe on all the listings in the
google search results so that tells me i
have 233 000 results that i have to jump
over in order to rank number one on
google so i'm going to put 233 000 in my
spreadsheet now i can see my kei or my
volume to competition ratio is 157 158
and so to me that's a lot better number
to work with or in other words that's a
lot better keyword because it's just as
relevant and it has a higher ratio of
volume to competition so therefore
banana bread recipe is going to be a
better keyword
to optimize for in order to rank number
one on google so that's the whole idea
behind keyword research you want to
brainstorm ideas there are plenty of
tools out there so the tool i recommend
is google ads keyword planner google is
going to give you how much search volume
they're going to tell you the
competition but then you're going to go
into google search you're going to use
the syntax all in title to get a more
accurate read on the actual competitive
number and so to find out how keywords
that your competitors are ranking for
you can use those keyword tools that i
mentioned another tool that i use is
miles so moz if you go to moz.com
they have a tool called keyword explorer
so if we just type in the keyword for
example bread recipes it's going to be
able to tell us how much volume and the
difficulty so you can use other tools at
your disposal figure out the volume and
the difficulty there are plenty of tools
out there but the one thing i would just
make sure is you use everything at your
disposal so you can use social media to
find the most shared article for a
particular topic or keyword like bread
recipes you could check other platforms
that have a lot of share consistency
such as like reading and quora where you
can ask people about certain topics
using keywords to figure out how much
competition or volume there might be you
can stay up to date on industry news to
get an idea of what types of keywords
are trending but when it comes to
keywords and keyword research remember
for every web page we want to be able to
pick two keywords we want a primary and
secondary keyword so when we do keyword
research and we enter all our keywords
into our spreadsheet we want to be able
to have a number of different keywords
in this case we're focusing on the theme
bread recipes we want to have different
keywords because we want to be able to
choose a primary keyword and a secondary
keyword because we want to be able to
focus on multiple keywords for each page
because we don't want to put necessarily
all our eggs in one basket maybe we
won't want to put all our emphasis just
on one keyword to rank for we want
multiple keywords to try and rank for so
the primary key work and to find the
nature of our business the secondary
keyword could be just highly relevant to
our keyword at the end of the day we
want to choose multiple keywords to try
and rank on google for that page so for
example we have a blog and we're using
ice cream recipes and we're blogging
about ice cream recipes we can have a
primary keyword that is about ice cream
recipes or homemade ice cream recipes
we're going to always want to find out
what the volume and the competition is
our secondary keyword could be built
around other similar keywords like
low-fat ice cream recipes or fat free
ice cream recipes or low-fat homemade
ice care recipes those are complementary
keywords just like our bread recipes and
banana bread recipe so one thing we want
to do when we do keyword research is we
want to be able to target one keyword
per content when you can target many we
want to be able to target multiple
keywords not necessarily target one
keyword and so we want to be able to
cluster keywords so we don't want to
target just one we want to target
multiple keywords per page and when we
talk about clustering if we go back to
our keyword research what we're doing is
we're clustering a bunch of keywords
under the theme bread recipes and so by
looking at the volume looking at the
competition looking at the kei we can
choose different keywords for our page
and that's what we mean by clustering we
want to cluster keywords into a content
theme so why target only one keyword per
content when we can target many because
we don't want to put all our eggs in one
basket we don't want to target just one
keyword we want to target many and so
that means clustering your keywords into
a theme and choosing multiple keywords
for that particular page and when we do
that we have a better opportunity to
rank high on google search and the whole
idea behind ranking high on google
search is we can get the volume so if we
know we're ranked number one on google
search for bread recipes or banana bread
recipe we know we stand a chance of
getting a majority of the volume
associated with that keyword and if we
can get the volume and get the traffic
then we can get the conversions so let's
move on to high quality content and talk
about the impact content has on your
ability to get your website ranked
number one on google so let's just say
you have content on your website and the
content is ranking on you know page four
of google and it's that blog with ice
cream recipes and if it's just content
for the sake of content is not really
informative then it's not necessarily
gonna get good engagement in the eyes of
google you know they want to rank
content that's very informative it's
very fresh it's exciting to read it's
interesting it's going to have good
engagement so if it's a recipe or an
article about any topic if it's the
content is just not informative then
you're not going to get good engagement
and when you don't get good engagement
if people don't stay on the site to
engage in the content and they just
leave the website after landing on the
page causing a bounce then the content
is just going to continue to fall down
the rankings and we want to prevent that
we want to move up the rankings we want
to be number one on google we don't
necessarily want to
fall in the rankings for our content so
content is a key driver
in being able to rank number one on
google so if the content is on page nine
what can we do well we want to be able
to you know take that content and do
something with it we feel like we did
write engaging content so let's go ahead
and share it on social media and to me
social media is a good platform to share
your content because on social media
platforms like facebook for example
you're building a community on that
platform that community is already
interested in your content so if you're
sharing an ice cream recipe
especially in the summer time and you're
engaging with your community on that
platform then the likelihood of that
community on that platform is going to
increase engagement increased engagement
will send social signals to the search
engine that says hey this content is
good quality likewise for any other
platform most social media platforms
have engagement metrics and those
engagement metrics pass signals is it
good is it not good do we like this
content are we giving it a thumbs up are
we going to want to follow it are we
going to want to share it and so
if you share content that you feel is
engaging on social platforms then it's
going to be engaging and it's likely
going to cause an increase in engagement
for example a decrease in bounces and
once you share that quality content then
the likelihood of it moving up the
rankings even as far as number one on
google is going to be greater so you
always want to start out writing good
quality content so let's talk about good
quality content because google does take
content seriously they do take into
account what other people think of that
content so high quality content is an
important factor so how to create good
content that's always the question so
let's talk about some best practices
here remember in the last segment we
talked about keyword research so we want
to perform good keyword research why
because we want to choose keywords
remember we're choosing multiple
keywords per page one keyword could be
related to our brand one keyword could
be related to the content but another
keyword could be related to a user's
intent like recipes if you recall the
example we use with bread recipes maybe
somebody's looking to type in a keyword
that says how do i make you know a bread
or how do i make a specific type of
bread or how do i make banana bread or
what's the best recipe for banana bread
they're question related and we want to
be able to answer those questions so
that's where choosing those right
keywords that's going to respond to a
user's intent so starts with choosing
the right keywords so remember we talked
about a number of different tools when
we talked about keyword research so
there's a research tool that you can use
called
phrase.io and that will help you do
quick research on you know keywords and
trends and whatnot so if you know about
a research tool that you use for keyword
research then drop us a comment below
i'd be interested in getting your
comments about keyword research and what
research tools are out there so if you
know something better than phrase.io
drop a comment below and we'd be
interested in getting your perspective
so keyword research is key but creating
content that fulfills users requirements
so answering those questions if it's a
recipe we want to answer that question
if it's directions we want to answer
that question if they don't know how to
do something we want to answer that
question that's the whole idea behind
content content is not just to fill a
page it's to really fulfill users
requirements that's when you get good
engagement so if somebody's typing in
something on google and they're looking
for an answer your content should answer
that question but we also want to make
the content readable so in other words
you know write for your audience don't
impress anybody with
very high vocabulary type words that
somebody doesn't necessarily know the
meaning of don't use jargon don't use a
street language for example use everyday
common language that's just easily
digestible when your audience is reading
and then we want to keep that content
organized and so when we mean organized
we want to use headers and subheaders
you know break your content into
paragraphs keep the flow organized if we
can keep the flow organized then it's
going to be easier for somebody to read
and then it's okay to add resources
especially resources from credible sites
so if you can incorporate those
resources in there then it's just going
to add the credibility to your content
let the audience know that hey i've done
my research on this topic and this is
what this person has to say about it
this person who seems to be credible
okay so it only adds value to your
content so these are all tips to
remember when creating content and then
the one important tip here is we want to
use white hat techniques and when we say
white hat techniques that means you know
if we've chosen keywords that are going
to answer somebody's question we don't
want to stuff those keywords into the
content we want the content to be
naturally written so when we say op for
white hack uh techniques that's what we
mean write the content naturally keep it
organized keep it readable include
third-party sources and make sure it
answers a question so there are
different types of content so there's
content where you just write words to
install text based you could also use an
infographic an infographic is simply
just a graphic that visualizes exactly
what you're trying to explain for
example if we want to
write an article about
how to write good engaging content we
don't necessarily have to write all that
out as a text we can create an
infographic so for example here's an
infographic on 20 effective ways to
basically not bore your readers but
write engaging content so you could see
this is an infographic it's all
graphically laid out so
infographics tend to be easier to
understand because they're visual
they're easy for the end user to
comprehend because there's generally no
jargon it's usually images that are
portraying the points of what you're
trying to get across and so it tends to
break it up the monotony of just text
it's more visually appealing and it's
laid out and organized so you can see
this infographic has 20 different steps
or rules and they lay those out all here
in this infographic and the great thing
i like about infographics is you could
you could share them on social media you
can re-engage them as a post you can
save them on really any social platform
so infographics tend to tell a better
story and versus say just writing text
you can use video and images so you
don't necessarily have to lay it all out
in an infographic you can certainly
insert a video or an image into
your content especially if it's a blog
post if it's a blog post then sometimes
video and images on its own
tell the story you don't necessarily
need
text to
go ahead and tell your story a video or
an image as they say tells a thousand
words and so
images and videos are great to use in a
blog post so
using different forms of content you
know you always want to review your
content when a user dwells on your web
page for a longer time google will tend
to think okay this person's engaged so
we're going to rank that favorable so if
you're using
infographics videos and images then the
chances of somebody being more engaged
are going to increase versus just text
that's not well organized and written
out in a way that somebody doesn't
necessarily understand so be creative in
the types of content you use so longer
engaging content tends to bode well with
search engines so this is according to
hubspot so the more word count you use
the more word you use the chances of you
ranking higher are going to be better
just take into account best practices
you want to maybe break up the content
with an image organize it make it
engaging use headers so it's not
necessarily just words it's the words
and how those words are written how
they're structured the types of keywords
you're using how you're engaging with
your audience there's a lot of factors
again there's best practices we just
went over but the key is you know if you
have longer more engaging content then
it's going to bode better for you on
search engines so a couple of steps to
create high quality content so you want
to begin with a comprehensive
introduction so always introduce your
content remember the content should be
relevant to the keywords so if you're
choosing keywords in your keyword
research think about answering that
question if somebody's typing in bread
recipes maybe they're looking for banana
bread recipes how to make the best
banana bread or how to make banana bread
using dried figs we want to be able to
align our content with that keyword
naturally you want to create a title
that's worthy that's click worthy so
remember if you're in google search and
you're doing search for something simple
like bread recipes we want to
make something that's going to be
engaging for somebody to click on like
easy perfect yeast bread or easy crusty
french bread or something that's going
to be engaging you know the best bread
recipes or how to make the best homemade
bread you know something that's going to
draw somebody's attention to the title
of that blog post so we want to include
lsi keywords so what i mean by lsi
keywords in your content we mean you
know long tail keywords make it natural
headings and subheadings should consist
of keywords and variants so
if you're writing headers and subheaders
include the keyword in there and that
way
the content always stays relevant to the
audience okay shorten your sentences and
paragraphs so don't write long
paragraphs remember we want to break
this up we want to make it easy for the
end user to read and we want to
always put internal links on our blog
post why because if we have internal
links then if we have a link from one
blog post to another blog post or say
our blog post to an internal page on our
website we want to make sure that it's
relevant content that way somebody's
reading something and you have an
internal link let's just say from a
bread recipes page to a banana bread
recipes page then they may find it
interesting click on that link and go to
the banana bread recipes page so it's
keeping somebody engaged on your website
so putting in internal linking will help
keep the end user engaged because you're
offering up links that's relevant to the
content you always want to break up that
content with images okay we want to use
alt tags meaning we want to
pen the image with text so that way if
the image doesn't load then at least the
alt text will load so we can incorporate
call out boxes and more importantly we
want to update our content regularly so
we always want to
get the best recipe out there if it's
banana bread or different ways to create
banana bread or always just coming up
with ways to update the content so we
want to keep our content our blog post
fresh and then we want to include a cta
call to action if we include a call to
action then that's going to keep
somebody engaged and have them act on
your content so these are
steps to creating high quality content
and so let's look at an example here and
this is a three month old post on
buzzfeed and it's 21 pictures that
restore your faith in humanity so it has
a lot of likes a lot of tweaks and that
means it's engaged people are engaged
when reading that and so if we go and
look at it as an example we can see it
on a buzzfeed here 21 pictures that will
restore your faith in humanity so this
was written back in 2012 again a lot of
engagement but if we look at it we can
see immediately that it's taking into
account third-party sources it's got
some content it's got images it's being
broken up by images we could see there's
call to actions on there in the form of
social so people can go ahead and go
ahead and share it if they like it okay
it includes videos includes images
third-party sources so it's a good post
because listen you know it's engaging
content it's probably answering
somebody's question about humanity and
we could see clearly that look you know
there's a lot of different examples here
from a lot of different sources and we
could take action on this content so not
just video not just images but text as
well and so it's very engaging answers
questions takes into account the
different types of content available so
this is a good post in that regard so
content's updated regularly it's
engaging and it includes sources from
high authority websites some do's and
don'ts on the content so take into
account the best practices i mentioned
about creating high quality content
answer those questions that the end user
wants to hear you know because that
likely is going to be their search and
so you want to be able to respond to the
end user that's part of creating high
quality content different types of
content i.e in the form of infographics
or videos or text or images you can add
images from public domain sites you can
be relatable and use examples to clarify
points just like the buzzfeed article
simplify complex words don't use
sophisticated language talk to your
audience as if you they were standing
right in front of you and use bullet
points to exemplify your examples your
points so some do's that don'ts
obviously don't lift content we don't
want to lift content from another
website so that's plagiarism so we want
to have our own unique content we also
don't want to take images from other
websites and so if you do happen to find
an image that works for your post and
it's on somebody else's website ideally
that's not a good situation but if you
do happen to do that then always give
credit to the website okay so if you
took it from
xyz.com credit xyz.com for the image and
even put a link back but ideally you
don't want to take images from other
websites just as much as you don't want
to take copy you don't want to take
images use your own imagery and content
but if you don't have imagery then you
can always go to stock photography there
are plenty of websites out there where
you can sign up for a subscription like
adobe stock images as an example you
could sign up for an account and in some
cases you can sign up for a free account
and use stock imagery okay don't give
less information to your audience give
them to your audience what they deserve
which is the information they're looking
for they're looking for the best banana
bread recipes give them the best banana
bread recipes incorporate your own
images break it up with titles give them
a good quality piece of content that
they're going to be able to engage with
and so if you put long paragraphs in
your content then it's going to be less
engaging so try to avoid those long
paragraphs remember shorten up the
paragraphs keep the language simple add
in images answer those questions use
third-party credible sources but write
it in your own words and you should be
on your way to creating good quality
content okay so now that we've talked
about high quality content in order to
get your pages ranked high on google
search let's turn our attention to
optimizing on page elements and discuss
some website level factors that are both
going to help you rank high on google
search so
let's just do an overview of what we're
talking about when we talk about on-page
elements and website level factors so
optimizing on-page elements include a
number of different things but primarily
we're going to focus in on meta tags
also known as meta description tags
header tags also known as title tags and
urls so those are just some of the
on-page elements we want to be able to
optimize using relevant keywords in
order to rank high in google search we
also want to
take a look at some website factors that
will affect our ranking on google search
they include website architecture having
a secure website having a site map and
taking a look at page speed so all of
those are some of the
website factors we need to take into
account in order to rank high on google
search so title tag and meta description
together are considered
meta tags so both play an important role
in ranking high on google so we want to
be able to write unique title and
descriptions for each page on our
website when i say unique that means the
title and the meta description need to
be different for every page on the
website and so if you're not quite sure
what a title tag and a meta description
tag is if you go to search and just type
in any particular search query the title
tag is what's going to show up here and
bold and then the description is going
to show up below it below the url and
that's going to describe the page so
both of these meta tags are important
because it describes what your page is
all about and that's what google uses in
the search results pages so we want to
be able to pay attention to the length
of our meta tags so if we go back to our
search results pages met title tags are
generally 60 65 characters meta
description tags are generally 160
characters so anything really longer
than that then what's going to happen is
the
meta description tag or the title tag
will get truncated and so if we look
here for example we can see all of the
title tags here fit the 65 character
limit but if you run over the character
count on meta description then google is
going to truncate the copy so you want
to stay within your parameters in order
to avoid getting your content truncated
and so the other thing when we're
writing title meta description tags we
want to minimize keyword repetition so
if we're optimizing for keyword we don't
want to necessarily just plug that
keyword into the title tag and meta
description multiple times we want to
make sure our title tags and meta
descriptions are naturally written so if
somebody's typing for banana bread
recipe with dried figs you know we want
to have a nice title tag into this
description that is going to get
somebody to respond uh based on their
need and so we definitely want to avoid
keyword repetition but we want to be
able to use that keyword in the title
tag because if you remember from the
earlier segment when we did the all in
title syntax to find out exactly how
many competitors were using that
particular keyword well we obviously
want to use that keyword in the title
tag because again the title tag is an
important factor when it comes to search
engine results so we want to use the
keyword but we want to avoid stuffing or
using it repetitively in our title tag
and our meta description we want the
title tag and the meta description to
describe the page sound natural but also
be engaging because the point is we want
people to click on our link and go to
our website from search engines so title
tags with numbers tend to result in
higher click-through rates this is
according to mods so for example if you
just put in a title tag that says learn
digital marketing well that may work but
if you put a number in there like five
easy ways to learn digital marketing
that might get somebody to click on your
link and go to your website so having
questions in your meta tags can also
increase your click-through rate for
example if you just put learn the
importance of first page rankings not
too bad but again generic but if you put
it into the formal question how to rank
number one on google it's more action
oriented it's gonna get somebody to
resonate with the question that they
have and that may be their query how to
rank number one on google and so these
techniques will
help you get higher click-through rates
and so according to backlinko
title tag with a keyword can improve
site ranking so remember we want to
include that keyword in the title tag
even though we only have 65 characters
we want to include that keyword but we
want to avoid stuffing the keyword in
there we want to again make the title
tag action oriented maybe with the
number maybe as a question with the
keyword in there once naturally not easy
to do
but that's the beauty of seo if you can
follow these best practices and write a
good title tag then the chances of you
improving in your search results are
going to be greater so having only one
h1 tag in your post is going to be good
so remember when somebody clicks on a
link so let's say they do find a title
tag engaging and they click on this this
link here and they go to that website
you know you want to start out with
having that particular h1 tech because
the h1 tag especially with the keyword
in it is going to signal to google hey
we're organizing our page and because
it's an h1 tag it's important we're
structuring the page according to best
practices so having only one h1 tag in
your post is definitely helpful having
multiple tags h tags in your post help
organize the page a lot better so we
want to add that targeted keyword in
that tag and your header tag should be
relevant to the content so if we go back
to our example of the using dried figs
with banana breads well the title says
california fig banana bread and remember
the last segment when we're talking
about high quality content well look no
further than including a video
into our content so not only will this
video help keep the engagement high but
it breaks up the monotony of the page
and it's from a third party source so it
adds credibility to the page so adding a
videos based on the last segment of high
quality content definitely helps with
ranking high on google search so
following hierarchical structure that
means putting those h tags in there h2
tags help break up the content and we
want to avoid repetition of h1 tags on
your different web pages of your site
meaning don't just put the same h1 tag
with the same keyword in it and keeping
it blase we want to make those h1 tags
exciting to read but also used
appropriately to break up the content so
remember all white hat techniques we
want to avoid hidden tags we want to
avoid stuffing keywords we want things
to be natural we don't want things to be
forced and your h1 tags should be 20 to
70 characters don't make long h1 tags if
we go back to our page example a short
sweet
tag here california fake banana bread
it's relevant to the content it's short
sweet and breaks up the monotony of the
content and more importantly and again
any content you have on the page should
always answer the user's intent remember
people are using search to answer
questions find information our content
should be able to answer that for them
so
according to john muller senior
webmaster trends analyst at google
header tags would definitely help google
for rankings and the search results so
we want to use header tags so when it
comes to urls we want to use hyphens and
avoid underscores so if we look at this
url here this uses hyphens fig and
banana bread so it's all broken up with
hyphens that's a best practice remember
canonical urls a canonical url signals
to google this is the original content
so we want to use original content and
if you have multiple sources of content
out there on say different websites we
want to use a canonical tag to signal to
google this is the original content
please index this content and that
doesn't hurt to use a favicon url
meaning a small icon it helps to break
up the monotony and help your url stand
out we can add targeted keywords in the
url so again looking at the url here i
can see we're using targeted keyword as
part of the url structure vegan banana
bread and notice the h1 tag is fake
banana bread so it's all consistent and
it flows naturally urls that are no
longer existing then we want to be able
to set up a redirect for those urls
meaning a 301 redirect is a server
response for google that says hey
google this page is no longer available
but it we permanently redirected it to
this page which is now available so
that's what a 301 redirect does it helps
signal to google and all the other
search engines that if the page is no
longer there that's fine you're just
going to go to this page this is the
page that's permanently there now and
another thing we want to do here is if
you have mobile urls you want to include
those in the sitemap and we're going to
hit on that in just a minute but all
urls should be
mobile friendly as well as desktop
friendly meaning take into account those
best practices keep your url short use
hyphens put the keyword in that url and
make it easy to understand want to avoid
capital letters in the urls the urls are
case sensitive so go lower case you
should always go lower case from the url
readable urls again the rule of thumb
here is if you understand what the url
is then google is going to understand
what the url is so the shorter the url
the easier it is to read the easier it
is to read the better chance you have to
rank high on google search so according
to backlink 2 urls that are shorter
definitely definitely help you rank so
we want to be able to shorten those urls
keep them short and sweet don't make
them long and unreadable so those are
some on optimized ways or on-page
elements that help you optimize now we
want to look at some website level
factors that will help you optimize and
write client google search so good site
structure provides better crawling for
search engine bots and what do we mean
by that well we mean having your site
organized in a fashion that google's
going to be able to find all the pages
so what do we mean by that create a
logical hierarchy structure so if you're
selling shoes you know you're going to
have a home page break the structure up
into men's shoes women's shoes
children's shoes then under men's shoes
you could have it by brand it could be
nike puma adidas on the women's side it
could be nike puma adidas on the child
side it could be nike puma adidas and so
you want to keep the structure flow in a
hierarchy do we want to balance the
amount of subcategories within each
category so the men's if it has nike
puma adidas the women should have nike
puma adidas and so you want to code your
site navigation and css or html meaning
we want to be able to use something that
google is going to be able to index so
most sites are built in html and that's
what google likes to index they like to
index something that they could take
back to their servers and then more
importantly build a comprehensive
structure for internal linking so
internal links mean that if you're on a
site you should have natural links
pointing to other pages on your website
so to keep the flow going and we don't
want to have unnatural inbound things
you always want to have natural internal
links to keep the flow of the user going
from one page to the other so here i can
see as an example all the ingredients in
this recipe well this has an internal
link to another page on our site and
this happens to link to a page where
somebody can buy the ingredients so it's
a natural internal link so john doherty
of credo has claimed that one of the
biggest changes that he can make in
fixing the credo website is architecture
so for example in credo john dougherty
has increased the organic sessions by 74
and pages by per session by 41
just by changing the site architecture
so you'd be surprised by changing the
site architecture what that will do to
engagement and so let's turn our
attention to secure versus non-secure so
what we mean by that is securing your
site we want to make it sure that
compliant with certain protocols and so
if we go back here we can see that this
particular site is compliant it is
secure
https means it has a secure license
meaning the site is secure so google
likes secure versus non-secure so
non-secure would be http so we want
https
as our protocol and what that means is
just enabling ssl certificates and that
means when you enable an ssl certificate
that means your domain or your protocol
is going to be turned to https so google
prefers sites that are secure versus
non-secure so if you use hsts
as a protocol that adds an extra layer
of security over the https and hsts
prevents cookie hijacking so adding
multiple layers of security always helps
in my opinion if you have an http
website a non-secure website you should
look into
buying an ssl certificate getting your
sites flipped over to https
because what's going to happen is your
url structure is going to change when
your url structure changes google's
going to recognize that because they're
going to index your site and when they
index your site they're going to see
those secure urls and that's going to
work favorably in your favor and help
you rank higher on google search so
websites using secure or
https have a higher chance of ranking
higher so https is a ranking signal
because google indexes those pages so
let's also talk about sitemaps so
sitemap is one of the most important
ways to improve your website ranking why
well because sitemaps are a way to
organize all your urls into one file so
we're basically going to
prioritize all our web pages in a
sitemap so if you go to any particular
website and you type in sitemap xml
you're likely going to see all the pages
on your website so usually the site map
is located in the root directory so if i
type in
sitemap.xml i'm going to be able to see
all the pages in my root directory and i
can also prioritize them i can also
alert google as to how often they change
and every page is going to have a date
stamp associated with it so google can
actually see how often it changes so
remember we want our content to be
updated frequently so content's not
updated frequently or it's not fresh
then google is going to see that site
that date stamp that last modification
down so we want to be able to make sure
content is updated frequently we want to
let google know that we change it
frequently and we want to be able to
prioritize our pages let google know hey
these pages are important to us so all
that can be set up in a sitemap we want
to be able to add canonical versions of
urls in the sitemap so we want to be
able to add all our original urls in our
sitemap and so we always want to build
dynamic urls sitemaps for larger
websites and what i mean by dynamic urls
that means that if i look at this
sitemap and we're always adding content
let's just say in the form of a blog
well guess what we want those pages to
be added to the site map as they're
published so as we add pages to the blog
or to the site then they should
automatically be added to the site map
and so in effect what's going to happen
is we're going to be able to see
the site map grow with more urls when
the sitemap grows with more urls then
that means then google is going to index
more pages they're going to index more
fresh pages so they're going to be able
to get those pages that are just
published quicker so that's the whole
idea behind dynamic sitemaps is we want
to be able to capture all the urls just
as they're published and we want to be
able to maintain our maps and so i would
always recommend a dynamic sitemap but
you can always create your own sitemap
just by going to a tool called xml
sitemap so if i just type in xml
sitemaps
into google search here i could see xml
sitemaps generator and i can be able if
i have a small website just create a
free and simple
sitemap on my own when xml sitemaps
creates it or your platform creates a
dynamic sitemap either way the sitemap's
going to sit in the root directory and
then what we want to do in turn is let
google know where that sitemap is so in
search console we want to be able to
submit the sitemap so you're going to
add the sitemap you're going to let
google know where it is it should be in
the root directory and it should be
called
sitemap.xml and when you do that google
is going to be able to take those urls
and index them so we could see we
submitted 528 urls google index 521 so
one thing about urls here is when we
create a site map we're putting all our
urls in there we do not add no index
urls in your sitemap and what that means
is that any url we don't want google to
index we're just going to exclude from
the sitemap okay so we want google to
take all the urls we want indexed and
put them in the sitemap so according to
edgy using sitemaps for seo can increase
your website's visibility and help you
get indexed why because what you're in
fact doing is taking all your urls that
you want indexed you're telling google
how often they're modified you're
telling google which ones are important
and you're submitting that to google and
so google's going to be able to take all
these urls quicker index them quicker
and when they're indexed quicker you can
get ranked quicker and when you get rank
quicker you can get traffic quicker so
that's the whole idea behind site maps
so let's turn our attention to page
speed now so when the last factors for
our website besides architecture making
it secure and adding site maps is we
want to take a look at how quick our
pages load here are some tips in order
to optimize page speed because ideally
the quicker a page loads the more
engaged the user is going to be if it
takes a longer time for the page to load
all the elements of that page then
what's going to happen is the user is
going to get impatient maybe leave the
website all together or go to another
page and so we want to be able to
optimize images so any image that's of
large size in terms of megabytes we want
to be able to optimize that to compress
the image so that's one way to speed up
page speed we want to use a simple
website design you know html with css or
cascading style sheets just a simple
design with simple hierarchy and website
navigation structure so nothing fancy
nothing complex just a simple website
design with optimized images we want to
leverage browser caching and we want to
upgrade the server response time meaning
all your files are sitting on the server
so when somebody goes to web page the
server is serving up all of those files
the images the text etc and so we want
the server to respond as quick as
possible so when it comes to page speed
we can look at the factors affecting
page speed in google analytics so if i
go to google analytics and i go under
behavior and i go under site speed and i
go to overview i'm going to be able to
see what my average load time is for my
site and ideally we want our pages to
load as quick as possible so that means
anything under four seconds anything
four seconds or higher and it's likely
the end user is going to leave the page
there's a correlation be between page
load time and bounce rate and so what
google actually does is give you speed
suggestions so if we do have a page that
loads slow we can just go to speed
suggestions and google analytics and we
go to speed suggestions then google is
going to be able to tell us hey this
particular page load fast this potential
page loads slow and if it loaded slow
why is it loading slow so here we could
see the home page of the example is
loaded on average of 7 seconds well if
we look here they're going to give us
some suggestions so if i click on this
page speed suggestions it's going to
load a report and a tool called page
speed insights and basically what it's
then going to do after it's done running
is this going to tell me all the ways in
which i can optimize my pages not only
for
desktop but also for mobile so here i
can see for desktop or for mobile i can
look at some ways in which i can
optimize it to increase page speed for
example sizing my images properly server
response time reducing my server
response time avoiding multiple page
redirects so there's a lot of
opportunities that we can do to speed up
page load time and all that's found in
page speed insights and all that's found
within google analytics so remember
optimizing code minimizing redirects
optimizing your images upgrading your
server response and all of those are
factors and so again you can go into
analytics page speed insights and you
can see exactly what google is
recognizing as what's lowering or
slowing down your page load time so
google takes site speed as one of the
most important ranking factors why
because they're going to rank pages not
only with high quality content that are
relevant to the keyword queries but they
want those pages to have a good user
experience so if somebody clicks on the
page then the user should be able to see
that content fairly quickly and so
that's why it's such an important factor
so the quicker your pages load the
chances of you ranking higher are going
to be better so according to web
performance today walmart as an example
experienced decline in conversions so
what they did was looked at their page
speed and when they looked at their page
speed you'd be surprised what that did
just increasing it from one to four
seconds or decreasing it basically
increase conversion so there's always
going to be a correlation between how
quick a page loads and how engaged the
user is because if it's users engaged
they're going to stay on the site and if
they stay on the site then their chances
of converting are going to be higher so
just even one to two seconds increase in
page load is low time will make a world
of difference in terms of engagement and
conversions let's turn our attention to
off-site engagement so previously we
talked about on-page elements and
website factors that affect our rankings
for search results but we also need to
turn our attention away from our website
meaning what we do on our website and
turn our attention what we can do for
our website off our website and onto
other websites so that's off-site
engagement and so let's look at an
example so that ice cream recipes blog
so
we did everything we possibly could we
updated the meta tags the title tag the
meta description we added h1 tags we'd
made sure the site architecture was
sound we submitted a site map we we made
sure the page load was good and fast so
we did all the things we're supposed to
do on our web page but we're still not
ranking well what do we need to do well
we need to turn our attention away from
our website into other websites we call
this off site or off page seo and we
need to basically generate links from
high quality sites back to our site so
if we've done everything we can on our
own website and we're still not ranking
where we want to be well then we need to
turn our attention to other websites and
so if we turn our attention other
websites and other websites that are
relevant other websites that are of
quality other websites that have high
domain authority
then we're going to see an increase in
rankings so it's just a matter of
getting quality links from quality
websites that are relevant that's what's
going to move the needle on search after
we've taken care of all the on-page
elements so more backlinks from high
domain authority results in higher
rankings seo is a combination between
what we do on our website meaning
optimizing the page and making sure our
website has good site architecture and
follows the best practices in terms of
site maps and page load then we need to
turn our attention to the backlinking to
improve our domain authority so
according to backlinko analysis offsite
engagement is one of the most important
elements for ranking number one in
google so you can't just focus your
attention on updating the title tag and
making sure the pages load fast you have
to turn your attention as well to
getting back links from high quality
sites that's off-site engagement and so
gaining links back links from multiple
danes is vital it's vital because they
bring referring traffic to your site
they bring credibility to your site but
more importantly google's going to
recognize the relationship between these
sites and your website and if these
sites that have backlinks or links
pointing to your site and if they're of
high quality then we call that passing
link choose so it's going to bring
quality to you in terms of organic
search so if we look at an example
if i do a search for banana bread recipe
there are 241 billion results for banana
bread recipe why did this particular
page from simply recipes rank number one
well we can turn our attention to moz
and maz has a report called link
explorer and so ma's link explorer
report helps us identify our own page
authority our own domain authority and
how many links we have from other
quality websites so if i put that
particular url into link explorer and
notice the url
here is short even though it uses an
underscore when it shows a hyphen it's
still ranked number one and why because
off page elements help this page rank
number one why their page authority out
of 100 is 58 their domain authority out
of 100 is 82. and what does that mean
well that means that they have a lot of
good links from other domains of high
quality they have 824 linking domains to
this one domain they have 3 600 inbound
links and they're ranking for a lot of
different keywords so if we scroll down
we're going to be able to see kind of a
breakout the quality of websites that
are linking to them so they have 19
domains with a domain authority of 91 to
100 linking to them they have 15 domains
between the range of 81 and 90. so what
does that tell me between 15 and 19
that's 34 particular domains that are
very high quality linking to them and so
we can see the breakout of the linking
domains we could see the top file links
to the site and we could see the page
authority so the link explorer report
gives us an overview of what pages are
linking to ours and it also gives us an
idea of what our own page authority and
domain authority are because domain
authority and page authority both need
to be high in order for us to rank on
google search in order for it to get
high we need links from high quality
sites so that's the whole idea behind
off-site engagement so some of the
offside engagements are influencer
marketing meaning is there somebody out
there on social who has a huge following
but not only do they have a huge
following but are they relevant to our
product for example usain bolt who's a
famous sprinter if we're selling shoes
and we're selling nike shoes maybe usain
bolt can reference us on twitter or
facebook that's influencer marketing
getting people to
influencing people to buy our product we
can engage with audiences on multiple
social media platforms like facebook and
twitter meaning if we're running a
promotion on those running shoes then we
can promote that on facebook okay we can
promote that on twitter we can also
bookmark our webpage on popular
bookmarking sites like stumbleupon we
can also put our content on discussion
forums like reddit we can join high pr
quality
q and a sites excuse me and post answers
to questions related to our business
like cora.com so we can engage in
sharing our content and answering
questions so there's lots of ways to get
links to your website if you have a blog
post as an example you can
make sure that maybe that content is
shared on a similar blog post so if you
have an ice cream recipe blog post well
maybe you can look at a dessert blog
post and share your content on that
particular blog post and have a backlink
pointing from that blog post to yours as
an example and you can reciprocate so
the whole idea of content is sharing the
content but at the same time of sharing
it you're producing backlinks and
backlinks help domain authority so not
only do they help domain authority but
they improve the search rankings so in
google's eyes the higher your domain
authority higher the page authority in
google's eyes that means your page is
important it's credible and we're going
to prove it in the search engine
rankings it increases brand visibility
if we have our content on a
highly engageable website a highly
popular website or blog it's not it's
going to lift our brand visibility if we
have usain bolt who's very famous
sprinter do some influence in marketing
for us then that's going to increase our
brand visibility so anytime we can
associate with something that has some
influence or some clout or high domain
authority then it's only going to
increase our brand awareness and
visibility so again it's going to
increase our domain authority because of
the association of passing link juice
from one domain to another it's going to
then as a result increase referral
traffic because if we're on a high
quality website that gets a lot of
traffic then the chances of some of that
traffic go on our site is going to be
great and again it improves the
credibility and trust of our website and
that's what we want we want google to
trust us and a way to build trust is by
associating our website with other
websites of high equal or higher quality
so when we talk about offsite engagement
we want to do some guest posts on
relevant websites so if you have that
ice cream blog go to another blog like
the dessert blog and do a guest post so
not only that will that improve your
brand awareness but
it'll generate a backlink and maybe
drive some referral traffic you can
participate in forums and blog
discussions like core.com or reddit get
your content out there start a
discussion about a specific topic to
engage users build brand awareness and
generate that backlink you can always
you know put your
your site on a directory like yelp for
example or yahoo directory you could
prefer testimonial link building meaning
if you serve products or offer up a
service well somebody could provide a
testimony on their website or you could
just earn backlinks from relevant
authoritative web pages like we
mentioned quora or wikipedia there's
plenty out there so the idea is to
associate yourself with high quality
websites but do it naturally you don't
want to force anything so if you're
selling a specific service or selling a
specific product look for like mining
services or products that complement
what you do and that'll create the
natural environment natural ecosystem
that will eventually give you the
benefits that you need to rank higher in
the search results pages so we don't
want to purchase any links we don't want
to cloak content we don't want to just
inject links on sites that aren't
relevant we don't want to just have
site-wide links all over the place
pointing to the same page and we
certainly don't want to be on
low-quality websites or directories it's
all about quality not quantity with
off-site engagement so having off-site
engagement complements what you do on
your website for on-site together both
of those efforts will get you higher
search engine results in this video
we'll learn about google ads google
display network google analytics how to
set up goals in google ads how to set up
event tracking in google ads and google
data studio we'll also be talking about
how to start with social media marketing
facebook advertising tips and strategies
how to rank youtube videos how to create
a youtube channel how to increase
youtube subscribers youtube ads how to
increase followers on instagram and how
to increase twitter followers when
you're setting up your brand and you
need to make sure it reaches the right
audience and provide the best results
there's really only one place to turn to
it's one of the largest online
advertising platforms really in the
world and that's on google and so today
we're going to talk about how to
advertise on google and let's get right
to it and talk about google ads and
its effect with advertising so we're
going to start out with what are google
ads well google ads used to be called
google adwords and it's been around a
good while almost 20 years now so really
google has grown at a really rapid pace
it's become one of google's main sources
of revenue uh you could say probably in
the 90 percentile of its revenue comes
from google ads and when we say google
ads we mean people who pay for
advertising on google.com so google ads
really what it does is it provides
services that fall under the category of
ppc which stands for pay-per-click you
may also may hear google ads or ppc
referred to as cost per click or cpc or
sponsored search really what it comes
down to it's a model so when you
advertise on google.com and somebody
clicks on your ad basically you're
paying google for they click okay so
it's just really a business model where
an advertiser pays google to have their
advertisement on google.com but they
only pay google when they get the click
so that's really in a nutshell how it
works for advertisers if i want to
advertise my business i can go to google
ads and say google place my ad on
google.com and then my ad does get shown
on google.com somebody clicks on it it's
just as simple as i pay google a fee so
google ads is just an online advertising
platform developed by google with which
advertisers can pay to display ads they
can offer up their services there's
video involved there's obviously
mobile's involved so you got all the
necessary devices and platforms
available in google's ecosystem so for
example if i go to google search even if
i type in you know what is google ads
here i can see a total of 1.8 billion
results for what are google ads as my
search query so in search you got a lot
of different things going on here you
have organic results you have videos
that are being pulled from youtube you
got a knowledge graph here you got
feature snippets you got an organic
listing but really at the top this is
what we're going to focus on today we're
going to talk about sponsored search so
you can see here for this particular
keyword query that i typed in what are
google ads really two sponsored search
or pay-per-click ads appeared now if i
happen to click on any one of these two
and go to that particular advertisements
website they're gonna pay google a
specific cost per click so that's how it
looks on google.com it really depends on
your query and what ads show up but the
great thing about your google ads is
they make it known for the user who's
doing the search query what the ad is so
here i can easily pick out what's an ad
a sponsored search or pay-per-click ad
and what's not because if it's a
pay-per-click ad or an advertiser
advertising on google.com i'm going to
be able to see this little box here that
says add next to the listing and so by
displaying that little logo their ad
it's letting the end user know the
person who's searching know that hey
this is an advertiser who is advertising
their product or service on google.com
okay so that's how you can differentiate
between paid search and organic search
organic search here or even down here
doesn't have that little ad box next to
the listing so you know if it doesn't
have a little ad box you know it's a
paid search ad now why do we want to
advertise on google ads because it
increases visibility to high quality
audience so
what i mean by that is you know search
is really a great place to advertise
because you're meeting the consumer
halfway meaning somebody's typing
something in and your ad is there to
help them find what they're looking for
so google ads advertises your product or
service to the relevant audience to
ensure the users perform the action
required of them so it's really a great
way to get quality audience to your
website because if somebody types in
something and you happen to offer what
they're looking for basically your ads
gonna show up somebody clicks on it you
pay google for the click and you get
quality traffic in return so the other
great benefit to being on google ads is
increases brand awareness so it's a
great way to get your product and brand
out there google has a vast network uh
also known as the display network but
even on google.com the search network
itself the search engine itself millions
of people use it every day fact here in
the united states it's been said or
studied that you know people over the
age of 18 use search at least once a day
at least once a day here in the united
states so you can figure that's millions
and millions of people so it's a great
way to get your brand in front of a
large captive audience okay so top of
mind awareness refers to a brand of
product being the first one that comes
to a customer's mind when thinking about
a particular industry or category so it
really does provide top of mind
awareness another benefit to being on
google ads is retargeting so when we say
the word retargeting in marketing that
means you know showing our ad to
somebody who's already been to our
website so we can use google's display
network or we can run remarketing lists
for search ads right on google.com to
ensure that we're targeting those folks
who have already been to our website and
have not performed a function that we
want them to perform such as converting
or buying something or downloading
something or subscribing to a newsletter
or visiting a certain page okay so if
somebody doesn't do what we want them to
do it's okay maybe they're ready to
commit to our product or service and
that's why google offers up retargeting
so it allows us to reach that audience a
second time so they're going to be
familiar with their product they're
going to be familiar their website
because they've been there and so we can
offer up a very unique specific ad to
that audience so that's a really good
benefit to being on google ads so some
other benefits here increased
intelligence so you know we can
certainly get data about who is coming
to our audience so we can look at what
device what you know browser etc so we
can really gain some information about
who's coming to the website we could
certainly
measure our performance so with google
we're paying cost per click and so based
on that model you know we can certainly
measure what keywords what ads are
generating traffic to the website and
how much we're paying for that okay and
if that traffic turns out to be a lead
we can measure that against that
specific keyword or ad or campaign so we
can certainly measure our performance
all the way down the keyboard level and
can we measure up against how many
conversions or what we're paying for
those conversions so google ads is a
very highly quantitative approach to
advertising because there's lots of
numbers involved and you're constantly
collecting information about your
advertising on google.com and its
network and another benefit really is
its high flexibility so google ads has a
number of different options so we can
customize our ads based on an audience
based on a keyword based on a specific
website based on retargeting so we
really have a lot of options not to
mention the number of options in terms
of the ad format text ads dynamic
responsive ads video ads display ads so
google ads has
very
flexible options in terms of advertising
and we're going to talk about some of
those as we move along here today so
another big benefit here and this is
what i always suggest is if you're not
ranking organically then you might want
to consider google ads because as we
shown here in our example if i go back
to our example a couple minutes ago you
know if you want to bid on the keyword
what are google ads why would you bid on
that well it's relevant to your business
maybe you're in the digital marketing
industry and you want to help folks who
need help and advertising on google ads
but what if you want to be found for
that organically well if you're not
found for it organically then you can
bid on it so it definitely is a good
option if you're not ranking for
particular keyword organically so it
serves as almost an option i always say
that you know search is like a fruit
bowl okay you have apples and oranges in
that fruit bowl well the orange is
organic search and the apple is paid
search they're different approaches but
they share the same fruit bowl the same
real estate so you can really really
help yourself by using google ads to
complement what you're doing organically
so if you're not ranked organically for
keyword you can certainly use google ads
if you are ranked for specific keywords
and it's a highly competitive industry
then you can use google ads to help you
leverage the amount of clicks you get
from that ad so it's okay to be
organically listed and have a paid
search listing at the same time so if we
go back to our example here we could see
wordstream.com has a paid ad and here we
can see just two spots below organically
they're showing up with an organic
listing so you could certainly be in
both positions to try and maximize your
clicks so it's definitely a good
strategy to run with google ads on top
of everything we mentioned in terms of
measurement flexibility google ads does
offer up a really good incentive to
advertise and let's not lose focus that
again search is really the only medium
in which you're meeting somebody halfway
based on what they're looking for and
when i say halfway meaning your ad is
going to appear for somebody who's
looking for something whether that be
food a cafe a plumber a doctor
or directions search is there to serve
that that person needs there's no other
advertisement platform or another
channel out there in terms of
advertising that reacts the same way
whether that be tv or radio or email
marketing or affiliate marketing search
is unique in that regard so search
engine results pages are the pages that
are displayed by search engines in
response to an ad so that's serp and so
you could certainly you know be listed
in the serps or also known as organic
search but the great thing is google ads
is there to help you get your brand or
product in front of that user looking
for a specific need or service so let's
shift focus now and talk about the
various formats in google ads on google
search we have text ads so text ads are
the only ad format on google search and
so here you can see in this example you
have a headline so not only do you have
one headline you have three headlines in
one ad so jbl headphones one headline
wide range of headphones second headline
amazon.in third headline so you have
three headlines and the great thing
about google ads with with this text
format is that you can have up to two
descriptions of 90 characters so the
headlines are up to 30 characters the
descriptions are up to 90 characters and
so you can really write some specific
information about your ad about your
product about your service okay and the
ad is also going to contain what we call
ad extensions so here you can see
shop by category in-ear headphones on
ear headphones those are all site link
extensions meaning they're going to link
to something on your website and so the
purpose of the extension is to help get
the click so the reason why you're
running google ads is to get the click
you want to generate the click you want
to get that traffic to your website so
by writing three headlines and writing
to description lines and adding
extensions to your ad i'll help you get
that click yes you're gonna pay google
for the click but that's the whole
purpose is to generate the click from
search because remember search is there
to respond to somebody's need or query
and so if you get the click on your ad
chances are it's going to be a highly
relevant visitor to your website so
google offers up a lot of opportunity
for you to write a lot of information in
your text ad on google for google.com so
google also has other formats and so
they also have responsive display ads so
when we say responsive we mean google
can serve up a specific image from your
website based on what somebody's looking
for based on the page that they went to
so these ads are responsive they adjust
their size appearance and format
depending on the space available so
responsive can also be text text and or
image and so the whole point of response
is if you have a large website let's
just say with a lot of different
products and categories like amazon well
it's hard to write static ads for
thousands of particular categories and
products so why not let google do the
heavy lifting why not let google serve
up the images and ads based on what
somebody looked at on your website and
so that's the whole idea behind
responsive ads is it allows google to
you know show the particular ad that's
most relevant to that user so it's a
really a great option when you're
advertising on google you have image ads
as well so image ads are as we mentioned
part of responsive or they can just be
static and so here you can see an
example from slack okay you can see just
an image app but the great thing about
image ads is you have a lot of different
size options so 468 by 60 250 by 250 160
by 600 all these are pixel sizes so you
have a lot of different size variations
when you run image ads okay so you don't
have to run a small image ad let's just
say in comparison to facebook where you
have a thumbnail okay and one size for a
particular image ad on facebook first
says google you have multiple multiple
sizes that you can choose from in terms
of running image ads so image ads are
really a great option if you're going to
advertise on google okay you also have
app promotional ads these ads are used
to drive app downloads and engagement so
here you can see an example for uber so
that's another option too if you have an
app and you really want to drive
engagement for that app and then you
also have video so google owns youtube
so you can run advertisements video
advertisements on youtube so they could
be standalone or they can be inserted
into other streaming video content as
say a pre-roll meaning people are going
to look at your ad before actually
watching the actual video they went to
youtube for so you have a lot of
different options with video
advertisements on youtube so the other
ad format you have on google are
shopping ads and shopping ads are really
a great way to get your product in front
of the right user so somebody's looking
for shoes or running shoes it's an
opportunity for you to run shopping ads
so you could put that particular shoe
with a description with the price with
your brand name in front of that user
and so with a cost per click model if a
user clicks on your shopping ad then
chances are they're probably going to
convert because they could see the
product they could see the price they
could see the product name they can see
the brand and so it's an opportunity for
you to really drive high quality traffic
to your site with the opportunity to
convert somebody at a very high rate so
shopping ads are really good because it
prevents unwanted clicks if somebody
clicks on that ad they're definitely
interested so let's take a look on
search to see how that looks so if i go
to google search and i just type in
running shoes so my search results are
going to list not only some paid ads but
a lot of different options on shopping
ads so here i could certainly scroll
around and see all the different brand
names i could see the price point if i
hover over it i can actually see you
know some other information about it
like reviews
return policy so if i actually click on
this ad chances are i'm going to buy it
otherwise why would i click on the ad as
an end user and so that's the great
thing about shopping ads it gives you
the advertiser an opportunity to really
get your products in front of people who
are looking for your product or service
and given that you're listing the price
if they like the price and they click on
your ad they're probably going to go
ahead and follow through with the
conversion so it doesn't necessarily
have to be running shoes it could be
anything that you have to offer a user
so running shopping ads on google is a
good strategy if you have products okay
so you can showcase these the shopping
ads on google search by certainly
really giving google access to your
product inventory connecting in some
reviews connecting in some information
connecting in the pricing points and
voila it's really very fairly easy to
set up google shopping ads within google
search and the great thing about
shopping ads is it also appears under
images and also pairs under shopping so
if i'm on google search you know i can
go to shopping or i can go to images and
i'll see those same image ads show up
here at the top and i will certainly see
those under shopping as well so shopping
ads allow you to really showcase your
products on google search to those
looking for that particular product so
it's really a great option with google
you also have call ads so when we say
call ads really call only ads are great
for mobile so when you run
advertisements on google if you have a
phone number associated with your
business you can certainly add that
phone number to the ad so if somebody's
searching on their mobile device and
your ad is displayed along with your
number they click on your number they're
actually going to call your business and
google can track that they can track how
many people click on your number and
even turn that into a conversion for you
so if you have a phone number associated
with your business it's wise to go ahead
and set up you know what we call a call
extension as part of the app because if
somebody sees that ad with that phone
number on mobile it allows them to
easily just click on the number and call
your business and so google can track
calls as well so keep that in mind if
you have a phone number and you want to
associate that phone number with an ad
okay so let's move over to where is
google showing your ads i showed you an
example of google search so we looked at
text ads we looked at shopping ads on
google search network so google search
network really allows you to advertise
on google search so with google search
if i go back to google search and i go
to all i typed in running shoes okay
here i can see shopping ads here i can
see a couple of text ads so you have the
opportunity if you're running only text
ads to show at the top and if you're not
at the top then google will place you at
the bottom so really depends on the
keyword that somebody's querying in
google search so it really depends on
how many people are advertising and so
what google does if i didn't have any
shopping ads here google will list a
maximum of four text ads at the top and
at the bottom any other ads that weren't
shown at the top will get placed at the
bottom so ideally if you're running text
ads on google you want to make sure
you're always at the top and i would say
between positions one and three you
always want to make sure you're at the
top okay so you can certainly measure
that remember google had has measured
performance so you can measure
everything about your ad so if you're
going to advertise on google with a text
ad you want to make sure you're always
at the top so let's have a look at the
different types of search networks that
google ads is affiliated with so
the first is google search okay so let's
focus on google search and so basically
when we say google search or search
sites we really mean google.com or all
google search engines for that matter so
if you want to advertise to a mass
audience you want to probably start with
google.com because again millions of
people use it on a daily basis and so if
you're advertising on google.com your
ads will appear basically below or above
the search results on a google search so
if somebody searches for something
depending on the search query they're
going to see results now depending on
the device also so they could be on
mobile or on desktop they could see
sponsored ads or paid ads they could see
local listings and they could see
organic search results so for example
this is what an ad would look like so
let me show you what that looks like on
google search so if we go
for example to
google.com and type in the keyword
classes on digital marketing we could
see some search ads here these ads
appear above
some featured snippets and the organic
search results okay so
depending on a lot of different factors
again i've mentioned this throughout the
webinar there are a lot of factors in
showing up in the top position second
position third position and so forth
okay if i scroll all the way to the
bottom you may even see ads down here
depending on how many people are
actually bidding on the keyword phrase
classes on digital marketing so we could
see simply learn here in the second
position why because again i can see the
logo add here okay so i can see simply
learn using three headlines i can see
simply learn using their two description
lines here and i could see simply learn
using some other extensions with the ad
now all of this is geared towards
getting the click so when you're on
google search the whole idea is
somebody's looking for something you're
offering that up and so it doesn't even
matter if you're in the top position
ideally you want to be in these top
three positions in order to get the
click okay so that's the whole idea
behind being on google search if you're
on google search you have the
opportunity
to be at the very top of the search
result or in the top three above local
listings and above organic results now
if i change my search query and typed in
coffee in san francisco my search
results are going to be completely
different i'm going to see local
listings here okay so this is tied to
google my business not google ads okay
so this is completely different so don't
don't mix this up with running ads on
google search so google my business is
tied to local listings or google maps
and again with desktop which is what i'm
showing you the search result on you're
going to see likely google local
listings above organic results okay and
if i go back to my previous query of
classes on digital marketing i'm going
to be able to see paid search results
above local and organic listings so in
other words if you're running ads ads
are going to trump any other type of
result on google search if you can be in
positions one through three now in
addition to google.com google also has
something called google search partners
so if you set up an account and you set
up a campaign in google ads you have the
option to choose google search as your
network and then as an alternative or an
additional option you can advertise on
google search partners sites and so some
of their search partners can range so
basically these are sites that have
partnered up with google that's allowing
google to
show ads on their site so the sites can
range anywhere between youtube to amazon
to new york times let's take a look at
an example it could even be another
search engine so if i go to say ask.com
and type in classes on digital marketing
it's a completely different search
engine but i can see the same ad for
simply learn so i can see same i could
see a different headline here actually
but i can see the description and i can
see some site link extensions and so
notice the ad is still at the top in
this case it's in position one and i can
see multiple companies running
advertisements why because they could
see ad next to it and i could see those
over
over organic listings so these are
google search partner listings so you
can opt in to be on other partner sites
that google or other sites that google
has partnered up with so you have
options outside of google search and
that option is display network so
display network allows you to advertise
elsewhere which is outside of google
search and if you're going to advertise
on google's display network you have
more ad formats available to you
including image and including video for
example your ad can be found on a
specific
website if you choose to advertise on
the new york times.com or webmd or
marriott.com you could certainly do that
okay you just need to tell google hey
this is the site i want to advertise on
so some of the advantages of being on
the display network so if you don't want
to advertise on google search okay
google.com you can certainly go to
display and on the display if you're
running display ads or or even video ads
you're going to grab the attention of
potential customers because of the
format of the ad okay so putting your
ads in front of people early on in the
buying cycle can have a very positive
effect so you're basically reaching out
to a large number of people on google's
display network and giving them an
opportunity to see who you are as a
brand and giving them an opportunity to
see what your product is all about so
for me the display network is a good
opportunity to get your product and
service in front of a lot of people
because the way the display network
works is it's a millions of websites who
want to have advertising on their site
and so you can really pick and choose a
specific site where your audience is
going to be and get your ad in front of
that audience so you can really retarget
to potential customers so
retargeting as we said earlier is really
reaching out to people who have already
been to your website and didn't perform
a particular function that you wanted
them to perform meaning somebody came to
your website from paid search on
google.com
and they went to page a and then they
left so you really wanted them to go to
page b add a product to a shopping cart
and check out and purchase that product
however if they didn't do that you could
certainly run ads knowing that they've
been to page a and page b and you can
offer up that specific ad to that person
who's been to your website and so that's
what retargeting really is all about and
you can retarget on google's display
network so remarketing your product to
people who previously visited your your
website or even your app allows you to
really get your ad in front of a
qualified audience and so you could take
advantage of analytics so google's ads
has all the information you need so
let's actually take a look at some of
these options in google ads for the
display network so if i actually go to
google ads and i actually go to display
campaigns i can see i have a lot of
different options available to me so if
i click on keywords for example okay i
can choose keywords for my display
campaign so what google does if you
choose keywords basically what they're
doing is they're going to contextually
place your ad based on the keyword okay
so that's an option for you if you're
not sure what websites to be on with the
display network you can certainly just
add keywords and based on those keywords
google will place your ad on websites
that they deem relevant to the keywords
you choose so you can also choose
demographics so on the splake network
you can say hey google i only want to
advertise to say 18 to 24 year olds or
25 to 34 year olds and so based on that
google is going to place your ads on
websites related to that age demographic
you're interested in on the display
network you can also choose topics so if
there's a specific topic that you want
your ad to be associated with you can
certainly do that so google has a number
of different topics at their disposal so
here if i just choose a particular ad
group now i have specific topics that i
can choose from arts and entertainment
food and drink to news to pets and
animals and so under each one of these
topics i can get really specific so if i
go under science i can see subcategories
under the topic science i can see
chemistry and physics and scientific
institutions and equipment so i can
really pick and choose specific topics
where i want my ads to be shown as i
mentioned already you can pick and
choose specific placements okay so if
you have a specific website that you
want your ad to be shown on you can
certainly let google know okay you can
also advertise on gmail you can also
advertise on youtube so you can really
pick and choose where you want your ads
to be shown so you have all these
different options available to you to me
one of the best options for advertising
on the display network because when you
tell google you have a specific audience
you want to target and that audience
could be somebody who went to a specific
page or somebody who went to your
website and didn't convert you can
associate that audience with the
campaign and when you associate that
audience with a campaign you can
retarget them with an ad so the display
campaign is very powerful with google
because you have all these different
options available to you so with google
ads you can also determine how well
you're reaching your goals which
websites you're running your ads on
which ads are bringing in clicks and
which site gives you maximum value for
the minimum cost so you can see all that
in google ads so when i actually pick
and choose how i want to target i can
certainly measure that so for example
audiences or demographics for example if
i go back to demographics i have all
this data that google's collected on my
advertising so i can see for example by
age range based on my campaign how many
clicks how many impressions impressions
are how many times my ads been seen
click-through rate meaning the rate at
which people see my ad and are clicking
on my ad how much i'm paying per click
cpc is cost per click total cost and
conversions how many conversions am i
getting so i could see all this data
available to me in google ads so it's a
very powerful platform for measuring
performance okay let's talk about how
you can create a google ad okay so first
thing you want to do is you want to set
up your campaign and you want to align
and go with that campaign just like we
talked with ads related to facebook you
always want to align a goal with your
campaign just like we talked about there
we want to do the same thing here on
google so we have a number of different
options at our disposal so when you run
a campaign why are you running the
campaign so if you're in just to drive
traffic or you're trying to generate
brand awareness okay great you can still
set up that campaign you're just going
to choose the display network okay the
display network allows you to get your
ad out there on millions of websites so
that people can actually see what your
brand product or service is all about
now if you're into direct response
meaning you're in it for sales and leads
then you probably want to choose
potentially google search partners as a
network okay not display but google
search and the partner sites okay on
google search so by choosing google
search as your network it's director
response so somebody's typing in a
keyword query and you're responding so
that's the whole idea behind google
search is we want to meet somebody
halfway we want to be able to offer up
the product or service they're looking
for so if sales and leads are what your
campaign goal is all about then you want
to go search network with the option to
choose google search partners okay again
if you're into you know driving brand
awareness or product and brand
consideration then maybe you should
choose the display network the bottom
line is you need to figure out what the
goal is of the campaign that's the very
most important very first step and most
important step is to figure out
what the goal is of the campaign and
once you've decided that then it's on to
setting up the campaign and in google
you're always going to have at least
one ad group and what makes up an ad
group keywords and ads so ideally when
you set up a campaign on google search
network you're going to choose keywords
and those keywords should be tightly
knitted or tightly themed or in other
words be all relevant to one another in
an ad group so that's what an ad group
is keywords that are relevant to one
another okay in that ad group you're
also going to have an ad so when you
choose your keywords you're gonna write
an ad for those keywords so step three
is after you set up the ad group and
choose your keywords you're going to
create an ad so let's take a look at how
that looks in google ads so if i go to
google ads i can see i already have an
account set up i have a couple campaigns
so let's just say i have this campaign
set up here i'm just going to call it
industrial campaign okay and if i choose
industrial campaign okay i'm going to
then be asked to set up an ad group now
if i set up an ad group already in that
ad group should be keywords and ads okay
so remember when you set up an ad group
you want to choose your keywords first
paying this keyword should be all
related to one another so for example i
could see an ad group here called fig
concentrate well if i click on this ad
group and i look at the keywords they
should all be related to fig concentrate
so here we go we can see a few key words
in this ad group in fact i have 10 of
them all related to fig concentrate so
it's very very important from a quality
score perspective if you remember when
we're talking about quality score
quality score is based on
landing page experience expected click
through and the add relevancy to the
keyword so if you can choose a ad group
and have all your keywords related to
one another like i do here with fig
concentrate then it's easier to write an
ad okay so here i have 10 keywords all
related to fig concentrate so now if i
go to ads and extensions in the google
ads platform we can see here i already
have a couple of ads going okay so
ideally if i wanted to i can run more
than just two ads as a best practice as
a best practice you want to have at
least two ads why because these two ads
are going to be served up against each
other and ideally the whole idea of
running more than one ad is what google
can do is start serving up the ad that
is performing better in terms of
click-through rate or in terms of
conversions okay so it doesn't hurt to
even add one or two more ads so here i'm
going to go ahead and add one more ad
here okay if i click on that plus button
i have a bunch of options here i'm going
to go ahead and choose text ad because
i'm running this campaign on the search
network and my goal is to get sales not
lead sales so i want sales i want
somebody to click on my ad go to my
website and purchase some fake
concentrate so that's my goal and so if
i'm on the search network i can only
have text ads so i'm going to choose
text at and once i choose text ad then i
have the option now to go through
and create a new ad okay so what google
actually does is they populate the ad
from previous ads and so this gives me
an opportunity to tweak one of the ads i
already have in place so here you can
see i have a final url and that's the
url that the traffic is going to go to
when they click on your ad okay so if
somebody clicks on the ad that's the
page they're going to go to call that
the final url now i have an option to
create up to three headlines so here i
can see headline one up to 30 characters
i have my brand name headline two i have
something related to the keyword i'm
bidding on so what am i talking about
fake concentrate okay again up to 30
characters now that includes spaces so
if you happen to go over 30 characters
your ad is not going to get approved so
here you can see 32 over 30. i'm two
characters over
if i just get rid of that the ad is okay
so you got to be careful to stay within
the boundaries of the character limits
including spaces so here i got headline
two is fig concentrate now i'm going to
write headline three this is new so this
is recently implemented by google and i
highly recommend that all the fields
available to you you use because the
more information you can put in an ad
the better it is for not only your ad
but for the end user because if
somebody's searching and looking for
fake concentrate and you provide them as
with as much information as possible
then the chances of them clicking on
your ad are going to be greater and
that's what we want if we're going to
advertise we want to advertise so that
people can see our ad and click on our
ad that's the whole point isn't it to
get people to click on our ad because
they're looking for something that we're
offering in this example fit concentrate
so
here i have headline three i'm gonna go
ahead and put something in the headline
three maybe a promotion let's just say
i'm offering up 20
so i can say up to 20 off through
april and may now you see i'm running
into character count so i'm just gonna
go ahead and keep it at april so up to
20 off through april now i can create
another ad and maybe change the headline
to say up to 20 off through may so you
want to take advantage of all three
headlines now notice when i added the
headline here i can see a preview of it
on mobile
and i can see a preview of it on desktop
now underneath that i have what they
call the display path so what google
does is they take your domain in this
case valleyfig.com and you can basically
customize that domain with what they
call a path so you have path one path
two and the whole point of this is for
you to
customize it based on the keywords you
were bidding on so i'm bidding on fake
concentrate i'm going to put fake
concentrate in here now remember when
somebody actually clicks on my ad
they're not going to go to valleyfig.com
concentrate they're going to go to the
url up here under final url so you want
to make sure you put a path in here
ideally what i would do is put in
something related to the keyword i'm
bidding on in this case fit concentrate
now i have an opportunity to add a new
description a second description this is
new and i have up to 90 characters so i
can go ahead and add some content so
remember with description 2 i have up to
90 characters so i'm just gonna go ahead
and borrow some copy from the website if
i'm not actually sure what to write and
so here you can see fit concentrate is a
natural product containing no
preservatives or additives so that's my
second description so now i can go ahead
and save and create extensions so i'm
just going to go ahead and push the
button save and create extensions and
when i do that i'm going to be prompted
to go ahead and create some ad
extensions and so ad extensions allow me
to add in links site links underneath
the ad just like you see here so when
you've added your site link extensions
and other extensions you save it you'll
be able to see your new ad here here we
can see the ad we created okay notice
it's got the three headlines notice it's
got the two descriptions and if i want
to edit i can just click edit add and go
ahead and edit it if i don't want to
edit it then i don't have to i can
always go back so you can always edit it
ad after it's been created okay if not
no big deal notice when you actually
create your ad in some cases google is
going to review it to make sure it fits
within google's guidelines and policies
uh but once it's approved you'll see it
under uh you'll see approved under the
status column and that's pretty much how
you would go ahead and create a text app
okay so when it does get approved it's
going to be in the rotation with the
other two ads and so what google's going
to do is serve up each ad equally and
then eventually the ad that is
performing best will get served up more
and that way you're putting your best ad
always in front of the user who's
looking for the product and service
you're offering so now let's talk about
the metrics so associated with these
keywords these ads these ad groups and
campaigns so there are a lot of metrics
in google ads a lot of metrics and we're
not even going to cover most of these
metrics we're just going to cover what i
deem the most common the most important
metrics to get you going so if you find
yourself advertising whether that be on
google search network or google's
display network you're going to have
some common metrics and here are the
metrics that we're going to focus on
today so you have impressions cost
clicks average cpc
conversions cost per conversion ctr or
click the array and quality score so
let's go through these metrics here and
talk about what they are so impressions
really it's the number of times your ads
been shown on that particular network
whether it's google search or display
and so an impression is just how many
times somebody actually seen your ad
okay whether they actually physically
seen it or not if your ad is showing up
on that network then an impression is
gonna get counted so here if we're
looking at ads we can see we have over a
period of time certain amount of
impressions okay so that's how many
times this particular ad has been shown
so this particular ad here the first one
at the top has been shown
557 times over this period of time which
is year to date okay so that's an
impression how many times your ads been
shown so if we talk about cost cost
refers to the amount of money we've
spent so any your ad gets clicked you're
going to pay google x amount so if i go
back to google ads i can see what my
total cost is and not only can i see
what my total cost is i can see what my
average cost per click is and so there's
a lot of factors that go into what you
actually pay and some of these factors
are who else is advertising where you're
advertising what network you're
advertising on what time of day what
particular keyword and so there's a lot
of factors and so here i can see on
average year to date i've spent 1.80 per
click on this particular ad for a total
of 32.33
so i can really
see how much i've actually spent and so
clicks is just refers to
how many times somebody clicked on your
ad so if your ads been shown you need an
impression and when somebody sees your
ad they're going to click on your ad so
the whole idea is to get the click
remember you want to be in positions one
through three so i want to make sure
that my average position is between one
and three and so if you're looking in
google ads at metrics and you don't see
average position well you can always add
that as a column so if i click on
columns here and then i go to
competitive metrics and i click on
average position and i'm going to move
average position all the way to the top
here so if i click move average position
all the way at the top i'm going to be
able to see what my average position is
over that particular period of time so
here i can see i'm in positions one
through three and that's where you wanna
be you wanna be in positions one through
three so if you're in positions one
through three that means you're at the
top if you're on google search or that
means you're in a problem position on
the display network so if your ad is
shown meaning this gets an impression
then likely somebody's gonna click on
that ad and somebody clicks on that ad
it's going to generate a click which in
turn is going to generate cost and so
ideally what you want to do is you want
to measure the rate at which people
click on your ad based on how many times
it was shown so here i can see 28 clicks
over
3549 impressions that's a 0.79
click-through rate so ideally the higher
the click-through rate the better the at
and the higher the clicker rate the
chances are you're going to get more
traffic to your site so we want to be
able to measure clicks and we want to be
able to measure click through rate and
we also want to measure cost per click
which is really the total cost divided
by the number of clicks so if i go back
to google ads here i can see you know
17.57
over 28 clicks that averages out to
about 63 cents per click so that's how i
get cost per click now your class per
click is going to vary a little bit okay
so it's going to vary based on keyword
it's going to be based on where you're
advertising what position etc so there's
a lot of factors involved with cost per
click but that's how you would actually
calculate it but google ads actually
does the calculation for you for
collector rate and cost per click but in
case you want to know you can always
divide clicks into cost okay so
conversions probably one of the most
important metrics you're going to use in
google ads because you're paying google
and if you're paying google for
advertising you want to make sure you're
getting return on your investment so
conversions are added when a user clicks
on your ad and performs an action that
you've defined such as purchasing
something downloading something viewing
something signing up for a newsletter
etc so you want to make sure that if
you're in google ads that you're
measuring conversions and so you simply
want to go to tools so if you go to
tools and then click on conversions you
want to make sure that you're running
conversions ideally what you want to do
is you want to run conversions from
google analytics but you can certainly
set up conversions within google ads as
well notice i also have call from ads as
set up as a conversion so you have an
opportunity in google ads to add a
number of different conversions and the
more conversions you add really the
better off you are because you want to
measure up all your campaigns against
conversions if i go back to campaigns i
want to be able to see what campaigns
are driving conversions and if i can
measure that and i have a campaign
that's really driving conversions that
i'm going to continue to advertise on
google okay so here over this particular
period of time i can see one campaign
has driven nine conversions at 128.67
cost per conversion and so how do i get
cost per conversion well i get my total
cost divided by the number of
conversions and then i could see my
conversion rate the rate at which people
convert so really if i have 241 clicks
and nine conversions that's nine divided
by 241 that's 3.77
conversion rate so i can measure
conversion rate cost per conversion and
conversion just by setting up
conversions in google ads and so ideally
if you're going to pay google for
advertising you want to be able to
measure return on investment via
conversions so again see cost per
conversion is just really the the total
cost divided by the number of
conversions and then click the rate
again just as a reminder the total
clicks divided by the total number of
impressions and then one other metric
we're going to talk about here today is
quality scores so quality score is
really google's way of measuring how
well
your keywords are are compared to the ad
associated with it the expected
click-through rate and the landing page
so quality score is the backbone of
google ads so if i go back to google ads
and i click on keywords quality score
something you want to measure and if you
don't have it in your columns you could
certainly just click on columns and add
it and so here i can see my quality
score and quantity score is a
measurement between 1 and 10. and so if
you have a good quality score google's
gonna score you higher because your
keyword is relevant to your ad it's
relevant to the landing page and you
have a good expected click-through rate
if you don't have a good quality score
google's gonna let you know why you
don't have a good quality score so again
your three categories that make up
quality score are landing page
experience which means really google
looking at the landing page you're
sending people to and they're seeing if
the page loads well fast does it have
ads does that have good content is it
good landing page will the end user have
a good experience they also look at the
ad relevance okay is the ad relevant to
the keyword and they'll also look at the
expected click-through rate okay so
based on other advertisers and their
click-through rate are you achieving the
same click-through rate and so those
three factors make up quality score
quality score is a metric assigned to
keywords so if you don't have a good
quality score you need to fix it because
the repercussion is you're going to have
to pay more so having a good quality
score likely means you're going to pay
less per click so you want to make sure
that if you bid on a keyword that the
keyword goes to a relevant landing page
the ad itself is relevant and you're
getting a good click-through rate so
quality score is the backbone of google
ads and how it works so you want to make
sure you have a good quality score so
optimizing your ads so what if you don't
have a good quality score what if you're
not getting conversions well there's
things you can do so remember we want to
make sure that we're adding extensions
whether that be call site link review
app add extensions to your ads because
it's going to increase the click-through
rate so you can also
really hone your ad copy if you're
selling products and you're running
promotion maybe you want to add in a
little sense of urgency to help people
you know realize hey if this this
promotion's ending maybe i want to click
on the ad and take action okay with
google ads you can always run a b
testing on ads and so what you could do
is run two ads in one ad group and see
what ad is performing best in terms of
click to rate or conversion rate and
whatever ad is running better you can
always run that ad and then continue
more testing so that way you're always
putting your best forward in terms of
advertising and the ad copy whether that
be text or display you always want to
use call to action you want to get
people to click on your ad when somebody
clicks on your ad it's going to improve
click through rate click to rate
improves quality score so as i mentioned
several times already you want to make
sure your ads are placed at the top
between positions one and three on
google search so you can measure ad
position in google ads and if you're not
rank between one and three you want to
increase your bid okay you can also
optimize for local search so local is an
ad extension that you can add to your ad
you can also advertise at a time when
your audience is online or you can
advertise on during business hours only
so you can adjust when you advertise on
google ensure some of your ads you know
capitalize on some particular events
that are related to your industry so you
can capitalize on that okay you can
certainly ask google to accelerate your
ads okay or you can do standard delivery
so google can spread out your clicks and
show your ads throughout the day google
search is all about keywords so you want
to be able to pick and choose the right
keywords first you can also add negative
keywords so
if you're bidding on a specific industry
let's just say you have software and you
want somebody to sign up for your
particular piece of software uh but you
don't offer a free trial then maybe you
want to add free as a negative keyword
so if you don't offer anything for free
free should be a negative keyword so if
somebody actually does type in looking
for free software
then your ads not going to show up so
that's the whole idea behind negative
keywords okay you can use dynamic
keyword insertion into your ads meaning
you can ask google hey i want to
dynamically insert a keyword into my ad
that somebody uses to make your ad more
relevant so relevancy increases
click-through rate and improves quality
score so as you can see there's a lot of
things you can do here's some more
things you can use branded keywords you
can use particular match types in google
so let's talk about match types for a
second so you have different match types
if i go back to google ads here i could
see my keywords that i'm bidding on so
by default if you actually bid on a
keyword it's going to be broad match and
so if i've been on the keyword medical
computer if somebody typed in something
related to medical and included the
keyword medical but not computer then my
ad may show up however i can make an
exact match so somebody can type in
exactly only medical computers so if i
click edit and i can change the match
type for that particular keyword to
exact then that means that somebody that
types in only medical computer my ad is
going to show up i can basically do
phrase match so somebody types in
looking for
something that's going to
help me with medical computers okay
that's a long tail phrase work keyword
query but the keyword medical computer
is in that order so my ad is gonna show
up okay so with phrase match your ad is
going to show when somebody types in
that keyword you're bidding on in that
order you also have broad match
modifiers so if you have a plus sign in
front of the keyword then that means
that somebody actually has to use that
keyword in the query in order for your
ad to show up okay so you could change
the match type of any keyword so if you
use an exacto phrase then chances are
you're going to have lower volume of
queries but probably higher relevancy if
you use a broad match then your ad could
show up for any combination of search
queries so you really want to be careful
on the match type that you choose so
keep an eye on quality score remember
google has quality score between one and
ten the higher quality score the better
you are so really if you have a quality
score i would say anything below four
you probably want to pause the keyword
okay so you can measure quality score at
the keyword level so if i go back to
google ads and i have keywords that are
say three chances are i'm going to have
to pay more for the click and it might
not be worth it so i may want to end up
pausing that keyword and try other
keywords that are more relevant that i
can send traffic to a more relevant
landing page or i can have an ad that's
more relevant to that keyword in order
to help with the quality score okay you
can ensure that your landing pages are
mobile friendly so that's another thing
you want to keep in mind that most
people start their search on mobile so
you certainly want to make sure that
your landing pages are optimized because
if somebody starts to search on mobile
likes your products or service chances
are they're coming back via desktop or
even going into the store most searches
start on mobile so you want to make sure
those pages are optimized and there's
plenty more things you could do to
optimize your ads you want to make sure
you group and organize your keywords
into relevant ad groups why because you
can write relevant ads for those
keywords so if i go back to google ads i
want to make sure if i go to ad groups
that the keywords in that ad group are
all relative to one another so what's my
ad group name well if it's medical pc if
i click on medical pc i want to make
sure the keywords in that ad group are
all relative to medical pc i want to
structure my campaigns and ad groups to
target more ads effectively so you want
to be able to you know organize your
campaigns and ad groups and the rule of
thumb here is you should organize your
campaigns and ad groups based on the
site architecture of your site so the
way your website is laid out in the
navigation is how you should likely
structure your campaigns and ad groups
focus on your budget okay so you want to
put more budget to campaigns that are
converting okay you can use automatic
bidding for ads to maximize results so
meaning that google has what they call
artificial intelligence so google can do
a lot of the bidding and a lot of the
managing for you that's really a great
benefit to running your ads on google so
their machines are learning behavior
from your keywords that you're bidding
on and so ideally when they learn what's
converting they're going to bid more and
try and help you get the conversion for
the keywords that have historically
converted and so ideally you can use
some of the automated bidding features
that google ads has to offer in order to
improve performance and today we're
going to talk about google display
network so thanks for joining and let's
get started so i want you to
imagine
having the world at your fingertips
especially when it comes to advertising
imagine having the entire world at your
fingertips for advertising so just
imagine you have the ability to
advertise your brand to any website in
the world can you imagine that well
imagine having
that entirety at your fingertips the
entire world so it's not really an
imagination so no need to imagine
anymore because google ads has come to
the rescue so no need to imagine the
world is at your fingertips and why is
it at your fingertips because of google
and specifically google display network
okay so we're gonna talk about what the
google display network is so let's start
out by asking the question or answering
the question what is the google display
network so google has two networks
basically one the search network one the
display network so you as an advertiser
if you want to advertise on google you
have a choice can i go with google
search or can i go with the display
network well the search network is for
google search only so if you want to
advertise when somebody types in a
keyword query and you want your ad to
show up that's the search network so it
looks something like this somebody types
in a keyword data science and lo and
behold ads show up and here you can see
the first ad from simply learn why did
that ad show up because simply learn was
bidding on the keyword data science and
so that's how the search network works
you bid on keywords somebody types on
those keywords and your ads show up in
the search engine results at the top
above organic listings so that's the
search network and it just simply
comprises of ads that respond to what
people are querying okay the display
network is a little bit different so
that's the search network today we're
going to talk about the display network
okay the display network is a little bit
different so imagine you're on the
lookout for a new shoe on amazon as an
example but you don't have end up buying
the shoe you're looking at shoes you
don't buy it well you might have noticed
in the past you've done something like
that whether it be shoes or shirts or
coats or belts or cars or radios or
headphones or phones it doesn't really
matter you might have been looking at
something and then notice an ad show up
it might have been exactly that same
product or might have been something
similar to the product you were looking
at but on the same website so why does
that happen well it happens because
google's display network specifically
remarketing which we'll talk about so on
google's display network you have the
option to advertise that somebody's been
on your website so that's one of the
powers and one of the features of
google's display network and that's
remarketing or retargeting somebody
that's looked at your product so let's
take a little bit of a deeper dive into
how the display network works so if
you're a customer you go to a website
and
you leave that website again from a
remarketing perspective your product can
appear on another site okay so that's
remarketing so you can retarget that
person who's been to your site so that's
again one great example of how to use
display network in google terms we call
it remarketing and again somebody goes
to your website they leave in this
example not buying something it could be
a technology company where we want
somebody to watch a video or download a
pdf okay whatever they do that that you
want them to do but they don't actually
do it then you can go back and retarget
them so if they actually go to a page
and look at your product but don't buy
that product then you have the
opportunity to advertise to them again
so the whole idea is if you advertise
them again
wow that person can say okay i remember
that i was in still interested in that
product let me go back and purchase that
product so they go back to the site and
make the purchase so that's again the
power of the display network you can
reach people who have been to your site
before so let's take another look here
so retargeting evolves around adding a
piece of code or pixel on your website
which uses browser cookies to add
website visitors to your audience so let
me just summarize that for you so if you
want to use display network and you want
to target people who have been to your
website well you need to add a simple
script or pixel if you will to your
website that's all and so when somebody
comes to your website they're going to
get cookied and that cookie is stored in
their browser and so that's an important
piece of the whole process because
that's how google determines who that
visitor is so without that cookie then
google won't know to show their ad your
ad to them again so that's the first
piece in all this so when somebody does
get cookie they're going to be added to
that audience and so when we say
audience we mean you as an advertiser
defining who you want to retarget to so
in this example we're talking about
people who have looked at a product and
didn't purchase that could be a whole
audience in itself people who look at a
product and don't purchase it could be
everyone who comes to your website it
could be only returning users it could
be only new users you defund the
audience but however you define that
audience they're going to get cookied
and placed on a list and when they're
placed in that list they're going to get
shown the ad again so past visitors will
see your product ads when they're
browsing the web watching videos on
youtube going through news sites and so
on so if that's your audience list past
visitors that's where they're going to
be able to see your ad because google's
displayed network is much more than just
websites it's also youtube
it's also news feeds it's also social
networking sites so there's a lot
involved with google's display network
so the network involves several websites
that are partnering up with google along
with the likes of youtube along with the
likes on millions of other websites in
fact these websites together tally up to
more than 2 million that encompasses
more than 90 of the internet so you can
imagine google's display network is just
made up of a bunch of websites including
youtube okay so you have the opportunity
to really reach somebody that's been to
your website before so again if they're
past visitors and they looked at a
product and they didn't purchase it you
have an opportunity to really put your
ad in front of them on a lot of
different websites so that's just an
intro about the display network
remarketing is just one benefit but
let's take a step back so we dove into
the deep end with remarketing let's just
separate out the two again just so
you're clear on what the display network
is versus the search network well let's
go
through some of the differences so
display network on the left search
network on the right so the display
network as we just discussed is great
for retargeting people who have been to
your website whether they're new users
returning users users who looked at a
product users who added a product to
your cart users who looked at a specific
page whatever that behavior is you're
defining that now the search network is
usually for top of funnel why do we say
top of funnel because users are actively
searching for something they're looking
for a product they're being active so
they're going to search and seeing who
has that product okay the display
network we know remarketing is a benefit
but usually it's bottom of funnel like
brand awareness so if nobody knows who
your brand is or what your brand is or
what you have to offer what your
services are then the display network
remember made up of millions of websites
you have the opportunity to put your ad
out there okay so display bottom of
funnel search network top of funnel
somebody actively looking for something
let's take a look at some other
differences here so display network
easier to advertise products that don't
satisfy an immediate need this is true
because again if you have a new product
you want to get that product out there
you want people to just know about it
some people may not be ready to buy that
product but at least they're going to
know what the products about on the
search network on the other hand if
somebody's looking for something like a
particular product that you're offering
then they could type in a keyword that
describes that product and wham your ad
can appear at the top okay remember top
of funnel so products and services
usually fulfill a particular requirement
now the display network can be used to
familiarize users to your brand so again
going back to remarketing somebody comes
to your website they really don't know
who you are well you can reach back out
to them on the display network with
another ad retargeting and that's how
you get users familiar with your brand
where on the search network users are
showing ads based on what they search
for so
it doesn't really matter if they know
your brand or not hey
if they're looking for something and
they're ready to buy and you have that
product at the right price then the
chance of them converting are pretty
good so you're at the right place at the
right time where the display network's
all about familiarity retargeting to
people with your brand getting your
brand out there getting your product out
there in front of millions of people now
on the display network users are shown
these ads in over a million different
websites so with the display network you
have the opportunity to kind of hone in
and pick and choose those websites we're
on the search network users are shown
ads in google apps and on the search
engines so you have the opportunity to
place your ads not just on desktop
search but also on mobile and also on
apps whereas again the display network
is made up of much more it's made up of
websites youtube apps etc okay the
display network has a multitude of
different formats okay when we say
different formats we mean text ads image
ads rich media ads meaning ads that have
some functionality to it like movement
okay and then video ads where the search
network is really only text ads and i
say really only text ads well you can
have image ads those are called shopping
ads but mainly it's text ads where
display network you have an option
between text image rich media or video
edit so you can see the differences here
really there are big differences between
the two networks where search you're
just really responding what somebody's
looking for they're really active and
ready to go display hey you're trying to
reach out to these people you're trying
to introduce them to something and in
some cases with remarketing you're
reaching out to them again okay you're
trying to get them familiar with your
product and brand and you're trying to
do that via video via rich media via a
regular image ad via text ad so you're
trying to do it in a multitude of
formats so again bottom of funnel for
display top of funnel for search now
we've already mentioned display ads can
be found in a number of different
formats so that's important to know so
for example text ads so we know what a
text ad looks like on the search network
very similar on the display network so
you have a headline you have some text
you have a url so that's a text ad so
text ads on display are very similar to
how they look on search rich media ads
so these type of ads enable more user
engagement with videos animation
text combinations and more so you
usually have some movement going on here
with rich media ads some animation
something that you're going to likely
engage with okay so with display you
have the opportunity to serve up rich
media ads the whole idea is you want to
really grab somebody's attention because
display is bottom of funnel we're trying
to introduce our brand to somebody so
putting something engaging in front of
them is going to get them to take notice
of your product and brand okay we have
regular image ads so these ads let you
use relevant images layouts and
different backgrounds and colors so you
can use a static image with some
messaging with it again there are some
best practices involved here with image
edge you really you're trying to
introduce your product and brand to
somebody you want to make it stand out
and pop and then of course video ads so
video ads are served up on youtube and
across a multitude of websites on
google's display network remember
google's display network is made up of
millions of sites some sites allow for
video advertising so it's not just
limited to youtube it can be used for a
multitude of sites across the display
network so that's an intro to the
display network those are the
differences between search and display
now let's go through the steps of how to
set up a
campaign in google ads using the display
network as our option so here i am i'm
in google ads i'm in an account
and i want to set up a campaign on the
display network so you can see here if
i'm in google ads i've selected display
campaigns i can already see i have some
display network campaigns set up in fact
they're all remarketing campaigns and so
remarketing remember is targeting
somebody who fits a list or description
okay so it could be somebody looking at
a particular product they get cookie
meaning that text file is going to sit
on their browser and then they're going
to see your ad the next time they're on
google's display network wherever site
they may be so we're reaching out to
somebody who fits a particular
description okay so if we're going to
set up a display campaign
meaning a campaign on google's display
network we want to go to campaigns and
we want to click on the plus button here
and we're just going to say new campaign
now we have the opportunity now to pick
and choose what our goal is for that
campaign and so most of the time with
display you're going to choose brand
awareness and reach okay so here you can
see the campaign types for brand
awareness and reach display and video
usually when it comes to sales or leads
or even just driving traffic
okay you might go with the search
network but if you're just really trying
to just promote your brand you may go
with display because remember you have
the option to get your ad in front of
millions of websites we're gonna choose
brand awareness and reach okay and we're
going to choose the campaign type so
here you have display we want to run
different kinds of ads or we can run
just video okay we want to run if we're
running video we can reach and engage
viewers on youtube and across the web
meaning other websites okay let's choose
display here so
we're going to go ahead and just put our
website in there so our businesses
website
and when that loads up we're going to
have a number of different options
available to us so here we can name our
campaign okay so here you can see brand
awareness and reach is the name of our
campaign and for now we're just gonna
protest now we have the opportunity to
choose our location here we're going to
choose the united states we have just
like a search campaign we also have
languages and options so with search you
have locations and languages same thing
on display so we're going to target
english as our language and what are we
trying to do what are we focusing on
well we want to get a product out there
so we're going to choose impressions
viewable impressions that's really what
we want to focus on we want people to
see our ad okay so an impression is the
number of times somebody sees your ad
okay so we have viewable impressions
that's what we want people to do we want
them to see our ad and if you take a
peek over here on the right side you can
see your targetings reach so we can
reach over 10 billion plus in
impressions meaning that's a lot of
eyeballs the number of people looking at
our ad right now is over 10 billion plus
okay so that's just gives you the scope
and some idea of how big google's
display network is so just like search
we could set a budget i'm just going to
choose a hundred dollars for now and i
can choose how to deliver that budget
just like on search i have standard
accelerated i can ask google to speed up
the spend or i could just do regular
standard which means they're going to
spend my budget evenly over a period of
time over the course of the day now
remember with display network we have
different options on ad types we have
text ads rich media ads regular image
ads and video so we can rotate our ads
how we like so we could say hey look i
want to run my best performing ads okay
so that means i want google to optimize
for me meaning if i have an ad that's
performing better than some others then
i'm going to let google run that one
more and that's the one i would
recommend but you do have other options
here you can just have them rotate
evenly you can say hey optimize for
conversions but it's really remember our
goal here for the display is to get
impressions eyeballs we're not
interested in top of funnel conversions
in here we could say rotate evenly and
that's not supported for display so
really our best option here is prefer
best performing ads we want our best
performing ads to run okay we have an
option to schedule them we have an
option to start and okay and we have an
option to set a cap how many times we
want somebody to look at that ad so we
can limit how many times our ad is shown
to the same user okay so we're gonna let
google optimize how often your ads are
shown however we do have the option to
set that limit okay so we could set the
limit to x times per day for the entire
campaign or it could be for a particular
ad or aggro okay so we could set the
limit ourselves and we can let google
optimize for us here we have some
exclusions okay and then we have the
opportunity to set up our ad group now
the ad group is the same as the search
network the ad group on display is where
your settings are going to be your ads
are going to be located in your ad group
and now the important part we want to
get to audiences so if we're remarketing
we're going to choose our audience and
if we're not remarketing we still have
the opportunity to choose our audience
so if i'm a tech company and i just type
in tech then google is going to give me
some options here so here i can choose
some tech companies technology cli
products new inventions etc or i can
choose some ideas that google has in
mind for audiences like they have an
in-market audience so this is based on
network systems and services network
management so the bottom line is google
is giving me suggestions on who i can
target my ad to okay that's what really
what this is choosing your audience now
you don't have to choose anything here
in fact you can just clear all and be
done with it now you can go down to
demographics now i can pick and choose
based on gender i can pick and choose
based on age parental status and
household income really depending on who
you're advertising to that's really what
it comes down to it okay so you have
demographics and you have audiences
audiences are really for remarketing so
again you can go with some of google's
recommended audiences or you can create
your own audience and we're going to
talk about that here in a minute but
this is all part of the setup for the
campaign so i'm saying hey these are the
demographics and these are the audiences
but if you're not remarketing you don't
necessarily have to go with an audience
okay once that's done you can set up a
bid just like you want on the search
network and then you have the option to
choose your ad so that's part of the
campaign setup so when you actually
choose your ad again you have different
options image ad okay rich media ad
video or text once you choose your ad
then you pretty much have your campaign
set up now we're gonna tweak it after we
set it up but that's pretty much the
steps in terms of setting up a display
campaign very similar to search in fact
minor differences really are choosing
your audience and choosing the ad type
that's really the main differences
between setting up a campaign on display
and setting up a campaign on search the
main differences now there are other
subtle differences but those are the
main ones so we talked about remarketing
to people who have been on our website
so going and showing our ad to somebody
who fits a particular description
meaning they looked at a product or they
looked at a particular page so if you're
going to retarget the people then as a
best practice i would set up the
audience in google analytics so google
analytics talks to google ads in fact
you can link up the two in analytics so
regardless of whether you're creating a
display campaign or search campaign you
want to link up analytics with google
ads so you can see we've done that here
okay now that we've linked the two up we
could set up an audience in google
analytics for use on a remarketing
campaign on google's display network so
here you can see i have audiences set up
if you want to just create a new
audience you can do that so if i click
new audience here here i can choose
choose returning users or new users
these are audiences that google has set
up by default i can create a new one if
i want so i could say hey i want to
target you know 18 to 24 year old males
who
speak english for example and
who came from mobile so if i go here
technology i'm going to say including
mobile so that could be my audience so
anybody who fits that description of 18
to 24 year old coming to my website from
mobile who speaks english i'm going to
retarget them and you can go ahead and
save this so if i go ahead and click
apply i'm going to name my audience 18
24 year old male english mobile one
thing about remarketing on the display
network is you can choose how long
somebody stays on your list meaning how
long is that cookie gonna live so
depending on your funnel if they're
buying a car the funnel may be
six months long if they're buying a pair
of shoes the funnel may be seven days
long maybe even shorter so really
depends on your business the default is
30 days so if you go at 30 days and that
means any 18 to 24 year old male who
speaks english and comes from mobile is
going to get cookied and that cookie is
going to live for 30 days so if i click
next step i can go ahead and publish it
i can say i want this to be available
in my google ads account so i'm gonna go
ahead and pick my account and it'll be
available in that account so i'll choose
my account and then go ahead and click
publish so now this audience list is
gonna be available for me to use in my
display campaign when i go to choose my
audience so if i go back to google ads
so google ads and google analytics talk
to one another why because they're
linked and so now when i go to actually
set up my ad group and i'm choosing
remarketing i can go ahead and choose
that audience list so for example this
campaign that's already set up i can go
ahead and choose to set up another ad
group with that particular audience list
so if i choose new ad group and now i'm
going to search for the audience i just
set up so here you go i just did a
search and here's my audience i'm going
to select my audience and i'm going to
now use this audience in my ad group for
my remarketing campaign so now all i
need to do is align the right ad with
this audience so that's how remarketing
works you choose your audience list you
set up your ads remember you have
different ad formats video rich media
image and text and the whole idea beyond
remarketing is you know who your
audience is you know what you want to
say to them so your ads should really
encompass that message the message of
what you want to say to that particular
group in this case 18 to 24 year old
male who speak english who came to your
site from mobile so if you don't really
want to retarget somebody who's been to
your website you could certainly still
use the display network to your
advantage remember bottom of the funnel
the goal of our campaign is just get our
ad out there so that people recognize
our brand our services our product so
when you actually go to set up an ad
group you don't have to choose an
audience to retarget to you do have
other options so if i look at this ad
group here you can see i have image ads
already set up so where do i want these
image ads to appear so i do have options
available to me in the display network
so if i choose keywords then that means
if i go ahead and add a keyword then
what google is going to do is
contextually place my image ad on a
website that fits the description or
matches that keyword so if i add one or
two or three keywords then what google
is going to do is going to look at that
keyword and it's going to map
a website on the display network using
those keywords so that's keywords now
you got to be careful here because it's
a broad way of advertising meaning your
ads could appear on sites that you don't
necessarily deem relevant to those
keywords so you're allowing google to
match the website with the keywords you
choose so that's choosing keywords
audiences again audiences are there if
you want to retarget so if you're
retargeting you can set up your audience
in analytics in fact that's the best
practice so again if i go back to
analytics and i go back to admin under
my property audiences i can go ahead and
choose my audience to be used in google
ads so that's using audiences on a
display campaign on google's display
network when we're setting up our
campaign we had an option to choose
demographics so we can exclude a
demographic if we wanted to we can
always go back and exclude a demographic
just by removing them from the ad group
notice if we choose all demographics we
can actually then see over a period of
time in google ads how many people based
on this particular age group or gender
or parental status or household income
saw our ad but not only saw our ad that
would be impressions but clicked on our
ad and how much they spent per click and
how many conversions so you have all
that data available to you in the
display network okay so that's
demographics i can also use topics so i
can take i can choose a particular topic
to advertise on so if i choose topics i
can choose a particular keyword find a
particular topic or i can drill down on
google's topic categories and
subcategories so here you can see
online communities if i choose that one
i could see there are other
subcategories under online communities
okay i can choose the whole category of
science or i can drill down to see what
subcategories are under science so i can
do that for any one of these topic
categories and if i choose a category
notice that's where google is going to
place my ad whatever i select again
notice upper right here i can take a
sneak peek at how many eyeballs
google is expecting to see my ad so here
by choosing astronomy and science i have
310 million impressions that's how many
potential eyeballs can look at my ad so
if you're setting up a display network
campaign you can choose keywords you can
choose demographics or you can choose
topics now if you decide not to go with
the topic then your last option here is
placements so i can pick and choose a
specific placement if there's a
particular website that i want to
advertise on let's just say
newyorktimes.com or or
latimes.com or webmd.com
remember there are over two million
websites on google's display network so
i can pick and choose specifically where
i want my ads to be displayed now when
you're done choosing your audience or
your keywords or your demographics your
topics or your specific placements you
can always then go to your placements
and then click on where ads showed and
so now over this particular time frame
i'm going to be able to see where my ads
have been shown and so now i can see my
ads have been shown my mobile apps and
on particular websites
now if you don't like any of the
particular websites that your ad is
showing on you can always select it and
you can always exclude it can exclude it
from the ad group or the campaign okay
so that's how you manage where your ads
are showing up on google's display
network again you can go ahead and go to
where ads are shown under placements and
over that particular period of time
google's going to show you where your
ads have been shown and if you don't
like that placement then you can always
just exclude it or if you don't like the
performance meaning you're not getting
many impressions or you're not getting
many clicks or the click-through rate's
very low you can go ahead and exclude it
so this is an opportunity for you the
advertiser to take control over
where your ads are shown so in summary
when you set up a display campaign on
google's display network you have
options if you're remarketing you're
going to choose your audience going to
choose your audience using a list you
created in google analytics if you're on
the display network not remarketing you
have the option you can choose a keyword
and have google place your ad on a
website that fits the description of
that keyword you could choose specific
demographics you could choose a topic or
subtopic category or you could choose a
specific placement okay those are all
the options available to you when you
run your ad on google's display network
now let's go back and take a look at
some of the advantages of the google
display network so i just went over with
you how to actually create a campaign in
an ad group i
actually went over how to set up a
marketing campaign and set up a
marketing list and analytics and i went
over all the differences between the
search network and display but let's
really hone in on those advantages here
so with the display network we can
provide advanced targeting meaning i can
particularly point to a specific website
that i want to advertise on so that's
what i mean by advanced targeting or if
i don't want to advertise to 18 to 24
year olds or 25 to 34 year olds i can
exclude them or i can really pick and
choose a specific audience that i want
to remarket to so those are all examples
of advanced targeting and that's all
done within analytics or google ads so
advanced targeting enables you to target
the people that didn't engage with
previous campaigns and get in front of
people with look look-alike audiences
that can be created based on the
audience you usually advertise to so
in other words we can really hone in and
pick and choose who we want to advertise
to another advantage is relatively low
starting cost so what we mean by low
starting cost is normally on the search
network you're bidding on keywords and
some keywords can be very competitive
whereas on the display network you can
pick and choose who you want to
advertise to and pick and choose where
you want to advertise so you can really
advertise on websites that get a lot of
traffic may not have a lot of
competition and therefore may not cost
as much so if you compare it to
traditional forms of advertising like tv
or radio display advertising reaching a
large broader audience is a lot cheaper
okay you can do advanced tracking
meaning when we talk about perform
advanced tracking we're talking about
again remarketing we can really pick and
choose who we want to remarket to and
cookie them and pick and choose how long
they are going to be cooking so we talk
about advanced tracking that's what
we're really talking about so we can
also talk about how many times our ad is
shown to somebody we really can pick and
choose how many times we want somebody
actually see our ad on a site based on
performance okay let's take a look at
some other advantages the ability to
advertise your brand to a broader
audience and google has over two million
websites so we can pick and choose where
really where we want our ads to show up
again it can be by topic it could be
contextually via keywords or it can be
specific websites so we can create
demand for our product and what we mean
by that we can create really cool ads
remember rich media ads video ads these
are all engaging type of ads those are
ad types on the display network we
create engaging type of ads it's going
to appeal to somebody and they're going
to engage so we have that opportunity
just based on the different ad types of
course increasing web traffic we can't
say that enough if you're advertising on
google's display network you have the
opportunity to get your ad in front of
millions of people getting from our ads
in front of millions of people we have
the opportunity to get a lot of clicks
and we do have that wide range of
formats search network only has text ads
here we have text we have rich media we
have image we have video so all these
types of ad formats allow us to really
get our ads out there in a number of
different ways again we're marketing our
products and services of the big big big
advantage using google's display network
that's how we started today's webinar we
started talking about remarketing
because it's such a key feature so if
somebody comes to our website and
doesn't do it we want them to do we can
cookie them and we can retarget them
with a more specific ad tailor to that
audience and today we're going to talk
about google analytics i'm very excited
to be with you today because google
analytics is one of my favorite google
platforms and my favorite topics so
let's talk about
what we're going to cover today and
we're going to start out with how to set
up a google analytics account and so
we're going to talk about everything
that entails including creating your
google analytics account we're going to
talk about setting up a property in your
account and what a property is we're
going to talk about setting up a
reporting view in your property and
we're going to talk about installing the
tracking code so those are the series of
steps we're going to go through today in
terms of setting up a google analytics
account so let's get right to it and so
really the prerequisite here when it
comes to setting up a google analytics
account is to have a google login and id
so when you actually go to google
analytics you need to be able to sign up
or sign in and so
once you actually sign in then you're
going to go walk through a series of
steps but really that's really all you
need to get the account going is a
google id and login so if you have a
gmail account or an other email account
that you use for other google products
then you're good to go that's all you
need to do so when you actually go to
sign up for google analytics you're
going to be asked to set up a new
account and these are the series of
steps you're going to walk through or go
through to set up a new google analytics
account so you're going to choose an
account name and then you're going to
choose a property name okay so the
account name can be anything you want it
to be the name your company your name
whatever you want to name it the
property name is really the website name
so what website are we talking about so
here i'm going to set up a fictitious
website name for now it's called demo
simply learn so the url for this website
demo simply learn is going to be
demo.simplylearn.com
so that's the property when we talk
about properties and analytics we're
really talking about what websites we
want to measure and then you're going to
be asked to choose an industry category
and so for simply learn we're in jobs
and education but you have a number of
different industries that you could
choose from this is important go ahead
and choose the
most relevant industry that your
particular business is associated with
okay and i'm gonna talk about why that's
important here in a minute and then
you're gonna choose your time zone and
the time zone is also important because
that's when the day starts in analytics
and the day ends based on that time zone
so the data that google analytics
collects starts and ends with that time
zone so very important to choose the
time zone your business is located in
okay and then you have some additional
options here okay so you have some
settings and so the first setting is to
allow google products and services so if
you opt into this then basically what
google's going to do is share some
products and services with you via email
i would go ahead and opt into that
that's of course recommended by google
it doesn't hurt to hear from google on
related products and services that may
enhance your business the second is
benchmarking so benchmarking to me is
something you should opt into so going
back to that industry and category we
chose jobs and education so by opting
into benchmarking basically what google
is going to do is share your data that
it collects on your website in this case
demo.simplylearn.com
it's going to share that data
anonymously
with others in the industry in this case
jobs and education and because you've
opted in it's going to do the same exact
thing for you it's going to share
anonymous data on other websites in the
same industry and the benefit of that is
we get to see
what other websites or how other
websites are performing compared to ours
what's the benchmark in our industry and
so the benchmarking to me is important
and i'm gonna go over that in a few
minutes when we go over the different
reports but to me i would always opt
into benchmarking because this is the
only report google provides in analytics
about how others in your industry is
performing versus your website okay so
it's a way to compare your website
performance against others in the same
industry the other options here
technical support and account specialist
i would also recommend you opt into
those because then it allows you to
basically
google allow google access to your
account and they'll be able to help you
if you occur or run into any issues so
these are the options in setting up a
google analytics account it's very
simple very easy to do you're just
entering in a few fields note that we
talking about a website right now so i'm
talking about demo.simplylearn.com
but just know that if you want to track
a mobile app google analytics will allow
you to do that as well you just choose
the option mobile app so we're tracking
a website we want to know how users
behave when they get to my website and
that's what google analytics is going to
allow us to measure and look at we just
need to do a couple more steps in the
process so once we fill out these fields
here we're going to click get tracking
id now i'm going to accept the terms of
service i'm going to accept another
terms and service in relation to data
protection i'm going to click accept
once i accept i'm going to be able to
get some tracking code the tracking id
is the id associated with your account
and so
this number is going to be associated
with your account so your account id
starts with ua and it's going to be this
number here now the dash one is the
property you set up so in this case i
set up demo.simplylearn.com
if i wanted to track multiple websites
under that same account then i can
certainly set up multiple properties
just know that every property i set up
in that account is going to have a dash
1-2-3-4
etc depending on how many properties i
set up so by default i set up one
property so my first property id is dash
one if i set up a second property the
same account number is just gonna have a
dash two and that's important because
that id that account and property id is
going to be associated with that
particular property or website so again
once you finish setting up the account
settings then you're going to be asked
to add some tracking code to your site
and that tracking code is going to be
related to the account and the property
so notice my tracking id up here notice
the tracking id and the snippet of code
now this snippet of code needs to go on
every page of your website that you want
to track and you don't have to put it on
every page but if you want to track
website behavior on every page your
website then it needs to go on every
page of your website so if you're using
a you know platform like drupal or
joomla or even more popular platform
like wordpress adding the tracking code
site-wide is as easy as maybe adding a
google analytics plug-in to wordpress
for example and then just simply plug in
in the id now there's an alternative to
adding the google analytics tracking
code to your site and that's google tag
manager so google tag manager is the way
i would recommend going so if you're not
familiar with google tag manager i would
recommend watching the
youtube video we have on google tag
manager you can just go to youtube type
in simply learn google tag manager and
this will give you a nice overview of
what google tag manager is and how it
works but basically this is the way i
would go and i would recommend that in
addition having google analytics you set
up a google tag manager account and then
that way you can put the tracking code
in google tag manager so if i go to
google tag manager and i just go into an
account on tag manager i can just simply
put in the google analytics id right
into tag manager and so if i have it in
tag manager then tag manager is going to
be the place that holds the code and
fires page view when somebody comes to
my website so that way i don't have to
add the tracking code to my website if i
do it in tag manager so that's the
recommended method for me is to add the
google analytics id associated with tag
manager if you can associate it with tag
manager then that's the easier route to
go versus putting code on your website
okay so again take a look at the video
we have on youtube for google tag
manager that's the route i would go now
once you do get the tracking code on
your website whether that be through
google tag manager or through a plugin
or you know just simply adding the
script to your site to pages on your
site then what's going to happen is
you're going to start collecting data so
that's ideally the way it works you need
to add this code to your website now if
you're not ready to do that and you
simply want to
basically understand how google
analytics works then i would recommend
getting access to google analytics demo
account and so if you just type in and
search google analytics demo account
basically what you're going to do you're
going to choose the first listing there
and you're going to go to demo account
so if you have a google analytics or
google login then all you need to do is
click on access demo account and so what
google's going to do is put this demo
account into your account and so it's
going to look something like this so if
i click on demo account here it's going
to add to my google analytics account so
i'm going to have then access to the
demo account from google and google
analytics so i would recommend going
this route here if you're not familiar
you're not sure what you're getting
yourself into so think of the demo
account as kind of a test drive you're
test driving google analytics before you
even add any code to your website so
again all you need is a google account
and if you have a google account and you
add the demo account to your google
analytics account you're going to be
able to see how analytics works okay and
so that's what i would also recommend so
if you're not ready to start adding code
to your website then what you can do
is just simply add the demo account and
then once you add the demo account
you're free to peruse around google
analytics to see the different types
reports it has to offer now when you do
actually set up a google analytics
account you're going to have some
settings that you're going to want to
pay attention to so when you set up the
account you have the account name and
then you have a property so under each
property you have by default you're
going to have one view and so here you
can see this view here so if we look at
the account we set up we set up a demo
simply learn account property is demo
simply learned so that's associated with
the website we're going to track and
then again by default under each
property you're going to have a view and
so by default the name of the view is
going to be called all website data and
so in that view is where all your
analytics data is going to be stored so
you can see my screen here there's a lot
of different settings you have you have
settings under the account you have
settings under the property and you have
settings under the view so we're going
to talk more about these settings in
future webinars for advanced google
analytics users but for now know that
there's a bunch of settings that you
have that you can play around with when
it comes to google analytics anything
from adding users to your google
analytics account your google analytics
property review you can actually set up
goals you can set up filters you can set
up segments you can link up google ads
you can
you know set up remarketing lists
there's a lot you can do in terms of the
settings as it relates to google
analytics but so no those settings are
there they're located right down here
and this little sprocket icon that's the
admin icon so if you need to get to
these settings at any time you can
simply just click on the sprocket or the
admin icon and then you'll be prompted
to choose any one of these settings here
that you want to edit or alter so now
let's take a look at some google
analytics reports so once you've
actually set up your account you have a
number of different reports that you
have available to you in google
analytics so we're going to take a look
at you know customized reports we're
going to look at real time audience
reports acquisition behavior and
conversion so these are all the
different reporting buckets if you will
that you have available to you in google
analytics so if i'm an admin and i'm
looking at the google demo account let's
start out by looking at real time so if
i click on the real time report
and i just click on overview so
basically what this is going to do is
show me at this point in time how many
users i actually have active on the
website okay so that's why they call it
real time reporting because it allows
you to see the behavior of users who are
currently on your website and so this is
the overview report under real time and
you can see here i can see that 79
percent of my users are coming from
desktop 18
20 are coming from mobile and then
approximately three percent are coming
from tablet here i can see how they
actually came to the website so this is
the referring source if they came from
say search or social i can see the
source there and i can see what pages
they're active on and then here i can
see what locations where they're located
and so if i want to see a breakdown of
everything in the overview i can
certainly do that if i go to locations
under real time i could see a majority
of my users are coming from the united
states okay where are they coming from
i'll just click on traffic sources and
here i could see the different sources
and mediums medium is the means in which
the traffic was driven so if it's google
it's either paid search or organic
search so i can see here it's organic
then i can actually see what contents
they're looking at on my website so i
could see currently have three active
users on the home page two active users
on the google's women's white tee page
so forth and so on now most importantly
if you have event tracking set up so if
you taking a look at our google tag
manager webinar you know that you could
set up event tracking in google
analytics to measure engagement on your
website whether that be a form
submission or somebody clicking on the
play button of a video so if i click on
events i'll be able to see
what events are firing so here i can see
we have event tracking set up and i can
see how many different events are firing
on my website in real time so here i can
see e-commerce somebody clicking on the
quick view click some a couple of users
clicking on add to cart a couple of
users clicking on the promotion click
and as these events are fired you're
going to be able to see them highlighted
so if something gets fired it's going to
get highlighted and i could see
that these are the current events that i
have currently firing on the website and
that's what's currently fire now if i
want to look at the events that have
happened in the last 30 minutes i can
just click on this link here last 30
minutes and it's going to give me an
overview of the events that have
happened over the past 30 minutes okay
so that's event tracking and then more
importantly we can also look at what
conversions are happening in real time
just by clicking on conversions and so
now i can see
i had one active user who entered the
checkout so that's goal number four so
in analytics you can have up to 20 goals
and so here i can see we have goal
number four has already had one active
user and so if i look at the last 30
minutes i can see i still have only one
goal over the last 30 minutes and that
was somebody who entered the checkout so
that's real time reporting in summary it
just gives you an idea of what's
currently happening on your website and
so for me ideally if i'm launching a
campaign or let's just say you do a new
website redesign and you want to see how
users performing and behaving then real
time is a good option for you so you can
see how things are happening in real
time now let's jump down to audience
reporting so if i click on audiences
it's just right underneath real time i'm
going to see a number of different
reports available to me under audience
and so let's click on the audience
overview report so
audience reporting basically allows us
to get a sense of who is coming to our
website when i say who is coming to our
website it doesn't necessarily have to
be a specific person in fact google
doesn't allow personally identifiable
information in google analytics personal
identifiable information such as a
specific name a social security number
credit card information etc however we
could still paint a nice picture on who
is coming to our website meaning what
country
city or state did they come from what
language what device did they get to our
website from how old were they okay were
they male or female or other what
interest did they have what browser did
they use so we can paint a nice picture
based on all this information that
google analytics is providing us under
audience so if i go to audience overview
here i can see i have all these
different options available to me to get
a basic understanding of who is coming
to our website so for example i could
see a majority of the people coming to
our website speak english and are from
the united states okay in fact that
represents 61
of the users and so google analytics
does a great job of giving me an overall
percentage so
if i have a 100 of the users i could see
61 percent of those users represented
english speaking users from the united
states seven percent represented
english-speaking users from great
britain and so when it comes to
analytics we have users and users are
broken down into two categories they're
either returning or they're new so when
you add the google analytics tracking
script to your website what's going to
happen is if a user or when a user goes
to your website they're going to get
cookied if it's the first time they've
been to your website what google
analytics is going to do is store a
cookie in the browser so when that same
user comes back another day in the same
browser analytics is going to recognize
that that cookie is in the browser and
so then analytics is going to categorize
that user as a returning user okay so
that's how analytics is able to
differentiate new versus returning so if
that user doesn't have a cookie in the
browser then analytics is going to
recognize that store the cookie and then
count that user as a new user and so
when you're looking in analytics you're
going to be able to see a breakdown of
new versus returning so here i can see
over three quarters of my traffic over
the past week here i can see april 6
through april 12th three over three
quarters are new users to the website
here i could see about 23 24
are returning users okay so i can get a
good breakdown of what type of users are
coming am i driving new traffic am i
driving traffic that's been to my
website before what language are they
speaking okay i can also paint a bigger
picture how old are they are they what
gender are they do they come from mobile
so let's take a look at some of these
different reports under audience and so
if i skip down now to demographics i can
click on overview and when that report
loads i can see now under demographics
overview i can see the breakout of age
ranges and so here i can see the
majority of the traffic coming to my
site again over the past week now if i
want to change this date range i could
simply do that i can change the date
range just by clicking on the date range
and then maybe going say the last 30
days and i can even compare it to the
previous period or the previous year i'm
going to choose the last 30 days i'm
going to click apply now i'm looking at
data over the last 30 days and again you
can change the date range to any range
you want you can only go back as far as
when you actually created the google
analytics account you can't go prior to
that so here i'm looking at the last 30
days and i can see almost 47
of my users were in their age range of
25 to 34. now when it comes to gender i
can see
66 percent represent males so i can get
a breakout of gender and age as well as
interest i can click on interest and
look at the overview there and see what
the interest is of the users who are
coming to my site based on in-market
segments or affinity i can also choose
language and location so if i want to
know exactly where my users are located
when they're coming to my website